THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
DOCTOR QUIRK NOTICES THE ABSENCE
OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. ACOSTA
AGUIAR-CURRY ALLEN ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW. BLOOM.
BONTA. BROUGH.
BURKE CABALLERO. CALDERON
CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU. CHAVEZ
CHEN. DAVID CHIU. CHOI KANSEN
CHU.
COOLEY.
COOPER. CUNNINGHAM.
DALLEY.
DALY. EGGMAN FLORA.
FONG.
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA. GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GRAY.
GRAYSON
HARPER HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE KILEY LACKEY
LEVINE LIMON ALONE. LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY. MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
QUIRK QUIRK SILVA. REYES
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
STEINORTH STONE.
THURMOND.
TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER. WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER
MEMBERS THERE ARE OVER THREE
HUNDRED BILLS THAT.
NEED TO BE DISPENSED WITH PLEASE
REPORT TO THE FLOOR IMMEDIATELY
SO WE MAY BEGAN THE BUSINESS OF
THE DAY MEMBERS PLEASE REPORT TO
THE FLOOR IMMEDIATELY
A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND BOB OSHITA REVEREND
OSHITA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
WHEN THE ASSEMBLY DESIGNATED
THIS MONTH THAT ME AS LUPUS
AWARENESS MONTH.
IT BROUGHT TO MIND A
CONVERSATION THAT I HAD THIRTY
FIVE YEARS AGO.
A CONVERSATION THAT HAS NEVER
LEFT ME.
I HAD HEARD MY OLD COLLEGE
CLASSMATES WIFE HAD BEEN
DIAGNOSED WITH LUPUS.
I RESEARCHED THIS ILLNESS THAT I
KNEW LITTLE ABOUT.
AFTER LEARNING HOW DEVASTATING
THIS AUTOIMMUNE DISEASE COULD BE.
I CALLED THEM.
I WILL ALWAYS REMEMBER OUR
CONVERSATION. WHEN I ASKED HOW
THEY WERE DOING.
AFTER A THOUGHTFUL PAUSE MY
FRIEND SAID SOFTLY.
WE REALIZE NOW.
THAT IT DAVE WITHOUT PAIN IS A
PRIVILEGE.
HIS HAUNTING REACH YOUR WORDS
HAVE NEVER LEFT ME.
AND I FOUND THAT THROUGH THE
YEARS.
IN THE MOMENTS WHEN I REALIZE
THEY'VE BEEN TAKING MY HEALTH IN
MY LIFE FOR GRANTED.
THE WISDOM THAT LUPUS BROAD INTO
THEIR LIVES COMES QUICKLY TO
MIND.
A DAY WITHOUT PAIN IS A
PRIVILEGE.
HOW FORTUNATE WE ARE TO AWAKEN
TO A PAIN FREE DAY?
TODAY. LET US TRY TO EMBRACE
THIS MORNING WITH GRATITUDE.
IF WE CAN PLANT THE SEED OF
WISDOM IN OUR HEARTS THAT A DAY
WITHOUT PAIN IS A PRIVILEGE.
WE WILL BEGIN TO LIVE WITH A
DEEPENING GRATITUDE FOUR DAYS OF
HELL.
IN A DEEPENING DEEPENING EMPATHY
FOR THOSE IN DURING HEALTH
ADVERSITIES.
NOW MORE ME. WITH KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE BEYOND.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAVEZ AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE MISTER.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN HONOR IN OUR
COUNTRY.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE.
NATION.
IT IS.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY MAY
SIXTEENTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN BEE
SEMI MEDICINE NAM. HONORABLE
CECILIA AGUIAR-CURRY ASSEMBLY
ETCETERA CALDERON MOVES AND
MISTER DALLI SECONDS OF THE
READING OF PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION REFERENCE
OF BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THERE
ARE NO ABSENCES
FOR THE DAY
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
PERMIT THE BUDGET CONFEREES.
SOME MEMBERS TING ARAMBULA BLOOM
CHáVEZ AND OBERNOLTE TO ADD
THEIR VOTES
TO ROLL CALL VOTES TAKEN ON THIS
DAY AS IF PRESIDENT WHILE THEY
ATTEND BUDGET CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST.
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER TO
THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO COMMITTEE.
S. B. TO SEMI FOR GLAZER FROM
THE GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
AS WE SEVENTY TWO SKINNER FROM
THE AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE AND SB SEVEN
NINETY TWO WILK FROM THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MEMBERS PLEASE COME TO THE FLOOR
THIS IS SECOND READING.
CLERK.
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY ONE TWENTY
FIVE.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE.
YOU'RE GOING TO PASS AND RETAIN.
HIS
CONCURRENCE PASS RETAIN FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO.
ON RECONSIDERATION FILE ITEMS
FIVE THROUGH ELEVEN WILL BE
CONTINUED.
WE ARE MOVING TO THE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FILE.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS AND RETAIN.
OUR FILE ITEMS THIRTEEN.
THROUGH TWENTY.
FOR.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE.
PASS RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS TWENTY
SIX AND TWENTY SEVEN.
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
TWENTY EIGHT.
PASS AND RETAIN A FILE ITEMS
TWENTY NINE THROUGH THIRTY TWO.
WHEN A PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM.
THIRTY THREE.
PAST A RETAINER FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY FOUR.
WHEN TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY FIVE.
AND THIRTY SIX
.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM.
THIRTY SEVEN.
THIS IS A C. ARE.
ONE NINETY ONE BY MS LOW MOAN
THE COOKERY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE NINETY ONE BY SOME A MEMBER
LIMON AND OTHERS RELATIVE
CALIFORNIA NONPROFITS DAY.
MS LOAN YOU MAY OPEN. I THINK
YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ACR
NINETEENTH ONE NINETY ONE
DECLARES JUNE SIXTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AS CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT
STAY IN RECOGNITION OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS.
TO THE ECONOMY AND WELL BEING OF
OUR STATE.
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE STRONG ECONOMIC
POWERS BE RANKED AS THE FOURTH
LARGEST INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYEE NEARLY ONE MILLION
PEOPLE IN OUR STATES AND
GENERATE. TWO HUNDRED EIGHT
BILLION IN ANNUAL REVENUE.
CALIFORNIA'S NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS ARE ALSO NATIONAL
AND INTERNATIONAL GROUND
BREAKERS IN THE ENVIRONMENT
SCIENCE SAFETY NET INNOVATION
CIVIL RIGHTS THE ARTS AND
OF OUR DEMOCRATIC IDEALS.
RE RELY ON NONPROFITS TO FILL
THE GAPS IN SERVICE WHEN
GOVERNMENT AND TING ENTITIES
CANNOT. BE SURE PEOPLE DO NOT GO
HUNGRY WATCH OUR CHILDREN AFTER
SCHOOL.
HE'LL COMMUNITY DIVIDES AND
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED ASSISTANCE
AFTER NATURAL DISASTERS.
THERE ARE MANY REASONS WHY NOW
IS AN EXCITING YET CHALLENGING
TIME TO BE IN NONPROFIT IN
CALIFORNIA.
JOINING WITH ME AT TODAY IS JAN
MATSU OKAY CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFITS AND
JEFF GREEN CEO OF SANTA BARBARA
CITY COLLEGE FOUNDATION AND
CHAIR OF THE BOARD. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFITS IN SUPPORT OF ACR ONE
NINETY ONE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS EMMA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE RESOLUTION IS THE MOMENT
YOU LIKE FIRST ROLE FOR CO
AUTHORS.
MS A MONITOR QUESTION THAT THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION CLERK
LOCAL ROLL-ON BUSINESSES FOR CO
AUTHORS CO AUTHORS AND ACR.
ONE NINETY ONE.
S. CO AUTHORS.
ADDING ON THE RESOLUTION.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE THEIR SIXTY TWO CO
AUTHORS ADDED AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT. THAT
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEMS THIRTY EIGHT.
AND THIRTY NINE.
PASTOR. OF FILE ITEMS
FORTY FORTY ONE AND FORTY TWO.
I BRINGS US FILE ITEM FORTY
THREE THIS IS AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY
FOUR BY MR MCCARTY THE CORPORATE.
SOME PEOPLE SEVENTEEN FIFTY FOUR
BY SOME REMEMBER MCCARTY AND
OTHERS AND I DURING THE EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION.
MR MCCARTY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER SPEAKER I
HAVE BEFORE US THE PRE QUE FOR
ALL ACTIVE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THIS MEASURE WILL ENSURE THAT
ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE FOUR YEAR
OLDS HAVE ACCESS TO OUR
CALIFORNIA. STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM.
WE KNOW THAT QUALITY PRE K.
PROGRAMS ARE HIGHLY EFFECTIVE IN
PROMOTING BRAIN DEVELOPMENT
ACADEMIC SUCCESS FIGHTING
POVERTY IN KEEPING KIDS OUT OF
TROUBLE.
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF LOW INCOME INCOME
ELIGIBLE. KIDS ARE WITHOUT
ACCESS TO OUR PRE K. PROGRAMS.
PRE K. PROGRAMS.
LEAD TO INCREASED HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION RATES.
AT RISK KIDS WHO ATTEND
PRESCHOOL ARE TWENTY NINE
PERCENT MORE LIKELY TO HAVE A
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA.
FURTHER AT RISK KIDS WHO ATTEND
PRE K. PROGRAMS ARE FORTY SIX
PERCENT LESS LIKELY TO END UP IN
OUR. JUVENILE JUSTICE AND PRISON
SYSTEM NOW IS THE TIME TO MAKE
WISE INVESTMENTS AND EXPAND OUR
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM TO
ENSURE THAT ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE
CHILDREN HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SEAT. ASK YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MR MCCARTY MISS
FRIEDMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY AS I JOINT AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL.
AS THE MOTHER OF A FOUR SOON TO
BE FIVE YEAR OLD I KNOW
PERSONALLY HOW IMPORTANT CREE
QUE IS AND THE FACT THAT SO MANY
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR FREE CARE UNABLE TO
ATTEND. A IS SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED TO FIX
IT'S NOT FAIR TO THOSE CHILDREN
WHO ARE ENTERING KINDERGARTEN TO
NOT NOT ENTER IS PREPARED AS
OTHER STUDENTS. SO IT'S ALSO NOT
FAIR FOR THOSE PARENTS TO NOT
HAVE THE BENEFIT OF.
PRE K. FOR THEIR CHILDREN WHICH
SOMETIMES PREVENTS THEM FROM
BEING ABLE TO GO TO WORK.
AND TO BE PRODUCTIVE IN OUR
SOCIETY SO WE NEED TO DO MORE
FOR ALL OF OUR KIDS IN
CALIFORNIA AND I URGE EIGHT AYE
VOTE ON THIS. ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MS FRIEDMAN MIS
AGUIAR-CURRY.
MONNING MISTER SPEAKER I WANT TO
COMMEND.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM SACRAMENTO
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD. AND
OF THE IMPORTANCE OF PRE SCHOOL
WHICH I TRULY BELIEVE IN BUT I
DON'T WANT ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
TO FORGET. THAT WE NEED
ADDITIONAL SLOTS FOR OUR ZERO TO
THREE YEAR OLDS I DO NOT NEED TO
HAVE THEM LEFT BEHIND. SO PLEASE
KEEP THAT IN MIND AS WE ARE
GOING FORWARD AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
THANK YOU MS AGUIAR-CURRY SEEN
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUR VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE.
AND TELL YOU ABOUT.
EYES FORTY SEVEN KNOWS NINE THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY.
NOW FILE AND FORTY FOUR.
WE ARE.
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
FORTY SIX.
A. B. NINETEEN TWELVE COOKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN TWELVE BY
SOME A MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC AGENCIES
MAKING A PREPARATION THEREFORE.
MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE RISE
TO PRESENT SOME OF BILL NINETEEN
TWELVE.
LAST YEAR A. JPA CALLED ALLEY
WORKS DISSOLVED WHICH RESULTED
IN A SIXTY THREE PERCENT.
CUT TO THE PENSIONS OF OVER TWO
HUNDRED OF THE JP EIGHT
EMPLOYEES.
AND RETIREES AFTER THE JP A LOST
ITS SOURCE OF FUNDING AND CITIES.
THAT.
WAS CREATED BY THE JP A FAILED
TO BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE JPA
SUCCESSES AND FAILURES.
THE STATE AUDITOR FOUND THAT
EMPLOYEES AND RETIREES OF
ANOTHER JP I. CAUGHT SOUTH
ORANGE COUNTY WASTE WATER
AUTHORITY COULD ALSO SEE THE
SAME PROBLEM.
THERE'S ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY ONE OTHER JPA THAT
CONTRACT WITH CALPERS.
AND MANY IN OTHER PENSION SYSTEM
WHICH COULD HAPPEN AGAIN WHICH
RESULT. IN HARM THE RETIREMENT
SECURITY OF ABOUT LEAST TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND JPA EMPLOYEES AND
RETIREES.
MEMBERS THIS BILL IS ABOUT
PROTECTING THE RETIREMENT
SECURITY OF EMPLOYEES.
AND RETIREES WHO WORK AT JP
HAYES AND IT DOES NOT APPLY.
JOINT AND SEVERAL LIABILITY
RETROACTIVELY AS CLAIMED BY THE
OPPONENTS.
I RESPECT THE OUTRIGHT VOTE.
THEY REYES RODRIGUEZ SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
QUIRK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
IS ADDED VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
MISTER RODRIGUEZ MOVES A CALL
EVERYBODY PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN WE'RE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT.
AB NINETEEN EIGHTEEN.
BY MISTER EDUARDO GARCIA THE
CLERK READ ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN BY SOME A
MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO OUTDOOR
RECREATION.
MR GARCIA.
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES AB
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN WILL ESTABLISH
THE OFFICE OF SUSTAINABLE
OUTDOOR RECREATION. FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA'S OUTDOOR RECREATION
ECONOMY IS THE LARGEST IN THE
UNITED STATES GENERATING OVER
NINETY TWO BILLION AND ECONOMIC
STIMULUS AND CREATING MORE THAN
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND. DIRECT
JOBS.
SPECIFICALLY THIS OFFICE WILL
HELP PLAN AND IMPLEMENT
COORDINATED STRATEGIES TO
DEVELOP JOBS AND ECONOMIC GROWTH
IN THE OUTDOOR RECREATION
INDUSTRY.
DEVELOP STRATEGIES CONCERNING
OUTDOOR RECREATION AMENITIES AND
EXPERIENCES AND TO SERVE AS A
CENTRAL POINT OF CONTACT.
AMONGST A MULTITUDE ACTORS.
INVOLVED IN THIS SECTOR
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GARCIA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM QUIRK OF THE ROLE. ON
MEMBERS.
IS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE TO ROLL AND TALLY THE
VOTES.
I SIXTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS I'M GOING TO MOVE BACK
IN THE FILE THE FILE ITEM NUMBER
FORTY ONE.
THAT IS A. B. THIRTY TO FORTY
NINE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM FORTY ONE AB
THIRTY TWO.
FORTY NINE.
COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TO FORTY
NINE BY THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY AND ACTUALLY TWO
ATTORNEYS MISTER STONE EMAIL BUT.
I THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THIS IS THE ANNUAL BAR
DO SPILL THAT GOES TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE EVERY YEAR.
IF YOU BEN.
WATCHING THIS BILL THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS WE'VE HAD A HECK OF
A FIGHT ABOUT REFORMING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BAR THIS BILL
FURTHER IMPLEMENTS THOSE REFORMS.
AS WELL AS LOOKING AT DEEPER
INTO ISSUES OF ATTORNEY
DISCIPLINE AND ENSURING THAT THE
BAR IS FUNCTIONING FOR ITS
PRIMARY PURPOSE WHICH IS
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THERE'S AN ADDITIONAL PROVISION
IN HERE THAT I WANT TO POINT OUT
TO YOU AND THAT IS AN AUDIT
PROVISION. IT'S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THE BAR IS
GOING TO BE COMING BACK TO US
NEXT YEAR ASKING FOR AN INCREASE.
AND THE DUES THAT THEY CHARGE
ATTORNEYS AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE ADEQUATE
INFORMATION BEFORE US IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT WE.
HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE TO TO WEIGH
IN ONE WAY OR THE OTHER ON THE
INCREASE ARGUES THAT WE EXPECT
TO BE PROPOSED NEXT YEAR SO
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PROVISION OF
IT. THE REST OF IT IS IS REALLY
WORKING THROUGH THE FUNCTION OF
THE BAR AND ENSURING THAT
THEY'RE BEING RESPONSIBLE.
LOOKING AT DIVERSITY ENSURING
THAT THAT ATTORNEYS ARE
PROVIDING THE SERVICES
ESPECIALLY IN UNDERSERVED AREAS
THAT THEY NEED TO SO THIS IS A
THE LOT OF THE WORK AND I WANT
TO THANK THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHO HAVE BEEN VERY VERY
ENGAGED. IN THIS BILL AS IT HAS
MOVED THROUGH AND VERY VERY
ENGAGED IN THE BAR DISCUSSIONS
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTES.
THANK YOU MICHELLE. SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLIP LIBERAL. MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE THOUGH.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE ANTI VOTE I SIXTY
SEVEN.
KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY NINE.
THAT IS AB NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN
BY MISTER SANTIAGO THE
CARBURETOR. ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER SANTIAGO AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT.
PICTURE SANTIAGO THINKING WAS
SPEAKER AB NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN
WERE STANDARDIZE AND CLARIFIES
EXISTING LINE PACKING PUBLIC
SECTOR EMPLOYEES. EMPLOYER
REALIZATIONS WITH REGARD
EXISTING PAYROLL DEDUCTION
DUTIES.
AB NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN BROUGH
REVISING RECAST.
STATUES AFFECTING PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES WITH REGARDS TO
PAYROLL DEDUCTIONS TO STANDARD
THE PROCESSES REQUIREMENTS FOR
BOTH EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES
ORGANIZATIONS.
NOTHING IN A. B. NINETEEN THIRTY
SEVEN DEPARTURE FROM CURRENT LAW
AND PRACTICES IN THIS CONSISTENT
A BASIC PHILOSOPHY STRUCTURE. OF
COLLECTING BARGAINING STATUES
AND THE POLICIES IN CALIFORNIA.
CURRENTLY THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
MISTER HARPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS.
EUGENE UNION AGENCY FEES VIOLATE
THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
RIGHTS OF WORKERS I BELIEVE THE
U. S. SUPREME COURT WILL AGREE
WITH ME WHEN THEY DID GIVE THE
RULING. IN THE CASE OF JANICE
PURSES ASKED ME.
IN ANTICIPATION OF THEIR LOSS
UNIONS ARE PUTTING FORTH
LEGISLATION LIKE THIS BILL TO
MAKE IT TOUGHER FOR HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIANS TO OPT OUT OF
PAYING DUES. AND AVOID PAYING
AGENCY FEES
UNDER A. B. NINETEEN THIRTY
SEVEN WORKERS WOULD HAVE TO
SUBMIT A CANCELLATION REQUEST.
OF THE AUTO DEDUCTION OF THEIR
DUES TO A UNION NOT THEIR
EMPLOYER.
THIS WOULD MAKE IT EASIER FOR
UNIONS TO NOT AYE THOSE REQUESTS
AND KEEP ON COLLECTING THOSE
DUES KEEPING THE PIPELINE
FLOWING.
THE UNIONS UNDERSTAND THAT IF
WORKERS OPT OUT OF DUES THEN THE
RESULTS OF JANET'S WILL ALLOW
WORKERS TO AVOID AGENCY FEES.
AND HER THE POLITICAL POWER OF
UNIONS.
WE NEED TO STOP PUTTING UP
ROADBLOCKS
THE DELAY THE INEVITABLE.
RULING OF JANICE VERSUS ASKED ME.
AND QUIT VIOLATING THE FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHTS
OF MILLIONS OF WORKERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I URGE YOU ALL TO VOTE NO ON
THIS BILL.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
OUR DEBATE.
OR SANTIAGO YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH.
I THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER WHILE
APPRECIATE ALL THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE THEM TO BE VERY
CLEAR. THAT THIS SEEKS TO
STANDARDIZE AND CLARIFY EXISTING
LAW THAT IMPACTS PUBLIC SECTOR
EMPLOYEES AND ORGANIZATIONS.
AS IT RELATES TO CURRENTLY THE
WAY THEY DO PAYROLL DEDUCTIONS.
OUT WE ARE NOT TRYING TO AFFECT.
ANY DECISIONS ANYWHERE AND QUITE
FRANKLY WE COULDN'T EVEN IF WE
WANTED TO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
WITH THAT CLERK LIBERAL. MEMBERS.
HE'S ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE.
UNTIL I OF OF. I FORTY FIVE.
KNOWS TWENTY THREE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE GONNA BACK IN THE
FILE.
TAKE UP FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
EIGHT.
THAT IS AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FOR
THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY EIGHT
ABA. EIGHTY FOUR BY MISTER
CALDERON.
COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR BUY SOME THE AMBER CALDERON
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO FOOD
FACILITIES MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
MEMBERS ARE KEEP THIS BRIEF THIS
IS MY STRAWS UPON REQUEST BILL.
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS THAT
WHEN YOU GO TO A DINING
RESTAURANT.
AND YOU WANT A STRAW YOU CAN
HAVE IT YOU JUST HAVE TO ASK FOR
IT. THAT'S IT MUCH LIKE WE DO
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WHEN YOU WANT SOME WATER AND YOU
GO TO A DINING RESTAURANT. YOU
WANT A GLASS OF WATER YOU JUST
HAVE TO REQUEST IT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE DID.
I'M WE PUT IN A PLACE BECAUSE
WE'RE GOING TO THE DROUGHT.
SINGLE USE PLASTIC IS A MAJOR
DETRIMENT TO OUR OCEAN.
LANDFILLS WATERWAYS ARE ALL OVER
THE WORLD THE E. WAS ACTUALLY
TAKEN ACTION VERY RECENTLY THE
BAND THE SINGLE USE CLASSICS
LIKE STRAWS. AND CUTLERY BECAUSE
OF THEIR DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS ON
THE ENVIRONMENT WE JUST HAD A
WHALE.
AGAIN WASH UP ON TO OUR BEACHES
HERE IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WITH
A STOMACH FULL OF PLASTIC OUT
AND IT DIED BECAUSE A LOT OF THE
RESULT OF ALL THAT PLASTIC. IN
ITS STOMACH BY THE YEAR TWENTY
FIFTY THERE'S GOING TO BE MORE
PLASTIC IN THE OCEAN THEN THERE
ARE FISH BY WEIGHT.
REGARDLESS IF I YOU THINK IT'S A
SILLY IDEA OR NOT OR OR MAYBE A
NON ISSUE OR NOT IT IS A REAL
ISSUE THAT IS AFFECTING. ALL THE
ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH WE LIVE AND
WE HAVE THE WORLD THE MAJORITY
OF THE WORLD THAT RECEIVES ITS
FOOD. FROM THE OCEAN ARE AND WE
HAVE THESE FISH ADDS HIS MEET
THESE THESE MARINE LIFE THAT ARE
TAKING IN THE PLASTIC IN THE
CLASS AGAIN AND WE IN TURN. EAT
THOSE FISH THAT HAVE IN JUST
ABOUT PLASTIC IT IS A BIG ISSUE
IT'S A SMALL STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND WHERE WE ARE. IT
RAISES A LOT AWARENESS A LOT OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE STARTIN TO
I CATCH ON IT AND IMPLEMENT A
FEW OF THEIR OWN POLICIES ON
SINGLE USE PLASTIC ITEMS LIKE
CUTLERY STRAWS ON THE ROUND. UP
BUT THIS IS A GREAT POLICY THERE
IS NO OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
THE PLASTIC INDUSTRY IS NOT
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. THE
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION IS NOT
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL IT'S A GOOD
BILL THAT DOES. GOOD THINGS ARE
WITH NO OPPOSITION SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FOUR.
THEY WAS CALDERON MISTER BLOOM
CORRECTNESS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR THIS BILL IS ABOUT CHANGING
THE BEHAVIOR OF NOT ONLY
CONSUMERS BUT. RESTAURANTS AND
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE YOU BEEN TO
A RESTAURANT EVERY SINGLE DRINK.
COMES BACK WITH A NEW STRAW.
THIS S THE OUT WASTEFUL IT'S
UNNECESSARY WE USE OVER FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION EVERY DAY IN
AMERICA AND MOST OF THOSE AND UP.
IN THE OCEAN OR IN LANDFILL
POLLUTING THE WATER AND KILLING
MARINE LIFE WHEN THEY ARE IN THE
OCEAN. IT'S ESTIMATED THAT
SEVENTY ONE PERCENT OF SEA BIRDS
AND THIRTY PERCENT OF TURTLES
HAVE BEEN FOUND WITH PLASTICS IN
THEIR STOMACHS. THINK ABOUT
THOSE STATISTICS
WHEN THEY INGEST PLASTIC MARINE
LIFE HAS A FIFTY PERCENT
MORTALITY RATE.
CONTRARY TO WHAT YOU MIGHT THINK.
PLASTIC STRAWS ARE NOT ROUTINELY
RECYCLED AS MUCH YOUR THEIR
THEIR TO LIGHT WEIGHT TO MAKE IT
THROUGH TO ME CANTICLE RECYCLING
SHORTER. DROP THROUGH THE
SORTING SCREENS AND MIX WITH
OTHER MATERIALS THAT ARE TOO
SMALL TO SEPARATE AND SO THEY
END UP CONTAMINATING RECYCLING
LOADS OR GETTING DISPOSED OF AS
GARBAGE.
IF WE DON'T ACT NOW BY THE YEAR
TWENTY FIFTY.
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN AND PREDICTED.
THAT THERE WILL BE MORE PLASTIC
IN THE OCEAN THEN FINISH.
THIS BILL ALONG WITH OTHER
PLASTIC MARINE DEBRIS BILLS WE
HAVE BEFORE US ARE HELPING US TO
CURB. OUR ADDICTION TO SINGLE
USE PLASTICS.
AND HELP US MOVE TOWARD USING
THINGS THAT ARE MORE SUSTAINABLE
AND LESS DAMAGING I ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THINGS BLOOM SHARPER HERE
RECOMMENDS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS LITTERING IS A
HUGE PROBLEM IN THIS STATE. BUT
RATHER THAN GO AFTER THE
OFFENDERS A. B. EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR PLACES THE BLAME ON
RESTAURANTS.
THIS IS ANOTHER REASON WHY
CALIFORNIA IS MAKING IT HARDER.
FOR BUSINESSES TO OPERATE HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
MOST OF THESE RESTAURANTS SERVE
BEER WINE COFFEE WHICH DO NOT
REQUIRE A STRAW TO DRINK.
THE REAL PROBLEM IS WHEN
CUSTOMERS GET FAST FOOD AND DUMP
THEIR TRASH.
ON THE GROUND AT A PARK. AND THE
BEACH OR LONG A HIKING TRAIL.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL PROVIDES
AN EXEMPTION FOR THOSE TYPES OF
RESTAURANTS AND DOES NOT PUNISH
THE OFFENDERS.
IF WE REALLY WANT TO CLEAN UP
OUR OCEANS IN OUTDOOR AREAS THEN
WE NEED TO CRIMINALIZE THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
TRASHING OUR STATE. THE
LITERATURES AND NOT.
THE INNOCENT RESTAURANT OWNERS.
I BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL IS
INDEED A SLIPPERY SLOPE.
THE WAY THIS BILL WAS ORIGINALLY
WRITTEN.
WAS RIDICULOUS AND I THINK THIS
IS JUST AN INCREMENTAL A STEP
TOWARDS THAT.
THIS REMINDS ME OF WHAT I WAS ON
THE HUNTINGTON BEACH CITY
COUNCIL.
AND IF IT WASN'T ONE THING IT
WAS ANOTHER WAS THE BAND OF THE
MONTH CLUB AND THEY ALWAYS ADD
SOME BECAUSE SOMETHING TO BAN
EVERY SINGLE YEAR THEY WOULD
TRAVEL FROM SAN DIEGO TO SANTA
MONICA ALONG THE COASTAL CITIES.
AND WHETHER THEY WERE PEDDLING A
PLASTIC BAG BAN OR WHETHER THEY
WERE PEDDLING A STYROFOAM BAN OR
WHETHER THEY'RE PEDDLING THIS
KIND OF LEGISLATION. THAT IS
WHAT THEY WERE TRYING TO DO TO
JUSTIFY THEIR POLITICAL ACTIVISM.
LET'S SAY NO TO THIS NANNY STATE
BILL AND VOTE AGAINST A. B.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FOUR.
MR LOW YOUR RECOMMENDS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I APPRECIATE THE
OF THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE FOR.
CHIU FACTOR YESTERDAY I WAS
ADDS MOURNS JUST DOWN THE STREET
WITH A FEW MEMBERS AND WE ASKED
OF THE SERVER ABOUT HER
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS BILL BECAUSE
WE SAW. THAT SHE INDEED DID NOT
PROVIDE ANY STRAWS AND THE FACT
SHE SAID SHE WAS VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF SUCH MEASURES THESE ARE
PRETTY CONSISTENT WITH THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT I'VE HAD WITH
THE NUMBER OF CONSTITUENTS. AND
WITH RESPECT TO SOME PREVIOUS
COMMENTS MADE FROM SOME OF OUR
OTHER COLLEAGUES THERE STILL
PROVIDE SOME.
PROTECTIONS IN OPTIONS IN PLACE
FOR.
THIS OPTION TO OCCUR AND
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
MISINFORMATION ON THIS BILL BUT.
AT HAND THAT PROVIDES OPTIONS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
MISTER CALDERON YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION AND
THE SENTIMENTS SHARED I
ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUE FROM
HUNTINGTON BEACH IF YOU'D LIKE
TO DO A BAN ON ALL PLASTIC
STRAWS INCLUDING FROM.
IT'S A FAST FOOD RESTAURANTS I I
WOULD SUPPORT THAT EFFORT IN
BACK IN ONE HUNDRED PERCENT I'M
GLAD HE'S PASSING ABOUT THAT
ISSUE WOULD LIKE TO WORK ON IT.
BUT.
THIS IS IN A BAND WE'RE NOT
BANNING ANYTHING. YOU WANT TO SO
YOU CAN HAVE A STRAW YOU JUST
GOTTA ASK FOR IT ONLY FOR DINING
RESTAURANTS IT'S A SMALL STEP.
IS MEANT TO BE A MEASURED STEP
THAT'S WHY THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION AND QUITE FRANKLY AS
THE RESTAURANTS ASSOCIATION HAS
POINTED OUT. IT'S GOING TO HELP
THEM SAVE MONEY.
EVEN IF IT'S A LITTLE BIT AND
STILL SAVE MONEY AND IT IS AN
ADDED COST.
AND I MAKES A BIG DIFFERENCE AND
IT'S GOING TO LEAD TO BETTER
LONG TERM CHANGE AND HOPEFULLY
BETTER DECISIONS AROUND THIS
ISSUE SO I APPRECIATE THE TIME.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
WITH THAT CLARK LOW THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
IS OUT OF THAT ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE AND TALBOT
EYES FORTY FIVE.
KNOWS SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS BACK IN FILE ORDER.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY.
AB NINETEEN THIRTY NINE BY MR
STEINORTH THE CORPORATE RATE.
AT SOME LEVEL NINETEEN THIRTY
NINE BY SOME A MEMBER STEINORTH
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
CRIME VICTIMS MAKING A
PREPARATION THEREFORE. MISTER
STEINORTH THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB NINETEEN THIRTY NINE
WILL HELP SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE REMOVE THEMSELVES FROM
ABUSIVE SITUATIONS WHILE
MAINTAINING THE SAFETY OF THEIR
PETS.
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT OVER
FORTY NINE PERCENT OF FEMALE
FEMALE SURVIVORS THEM DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE REPORTED THREATS OR
HARM TO THEIR PATS.
THIS FEAR OF ABUSE TO VICTIMS
PAD IS BECAUSE UP TO FORTY EIGHT
PERCENT OF SURVIVORS TO DELAY
LEAVING AN ABUSIVE ENVIRONMENT.
DUE TO THESE CONCERNS
AB NINETEEN THIRTY NINE SIX TO
REMEDY THIS OBSTACLE BY ALLOWING
SURVIVORS TO HAVE THEIR PET
BOARDED REIMBURSEMENT WHILE THE
FLEEING ABUSIVE ENVIRONMENT.
THIS BILL HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
IS RECEIVE NO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
DAVIS STEINORTH.
MS MELENDEZ YOU'RE RIGHT NEXT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
WHILE I CERTAINLY.
AGREE.
WITH THE AUTHOR STATED INTENT
THAT THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
VICTIMS.
DON'T HAVE TO ALSO WORRY ABOUT
THEIR PETS.
HERE IS THE ISSUE WITH THIS
BILL.
THIS VICTIMS COMPENSATION FUND
HAS BEEN DWINDLING VERY QUICKLY
OVER THE YEARS THAT IS DOWN NOW
TO ONE OF ITS LOWEST POINTS. IN
THE PAST.
TEN TWENTY YEARS IT'S DOWN TO.
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
IT'S HARDLY ANYTHING.
THIS MONEY GOES FOR VICTIMS SO
THAT THEY CAN GET TO MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
IN SOME CASES THEY CAN GET
ALARM SYSTEM PUT IN THEIR HOMES
BECAUSE THEY'RE FEARFUL OF THEIR
SAFETY IN THE LIVES OF THEIR
CHILDREN.
IT ALLOWS THEM TO GO SEEK THE
HELP THAT THEY'RE GOING TO NEED
SOMETIMES VERY SEVERE CASES.
SO WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A
FUND THAT HAS. MINIMAL RESOURCES
RIGHT NOW IN IS WINDING DOWN
VERY QUICKLY AND THERE'S NO
AVENUE HERE TO REPLACE THAT
FUNDING.
FOR ME I CAN'T JUSTIFY VOTING
THOUGH I LOVE.
PETS AS WE ALL DUE AND I
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE
I CAN'T VOTE TO.
TO FIND THE BOARDING OF.
ONE WOMAN'S PAT AND THE
TELENOVELA WOMEN THAT THERE
ISN'T ENOUGH FUNDING FOR HER TO
GET THE SERVICES THAT SHE NEEDS.
THAT JUST THAT DOESN'T SEEM
RIGHT TO ME SO ICE THAT I GET
THE IDEA BUT NONE OF US SHOULD
EVER TELL.
I DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVOR OR
WORD IS AN ASSAULT SURVIVOR WERE
THERE ANY TYPE OF VICTIM THAT'S.
SEEKING THESE FUNDS.
THAT THEY'RE IN SECOND PLACE
BECAUSE THEY'RE COMPETING FOR
THAT BINDING. WITH SOMEONE
ELSE'S PACKED SO AM. I WILL NOT
BE VOTING FOR THIS BILL.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
THANK YOU I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND IT YOU KNOW WE WE
MADE SOME CAREFUL DETERMINATIONS
AS WE PASS THIS APPROPRIATIONS
BECAUSE. I THINK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LIKE ALL SORTS RIGHT THE
FUND IS DEPLETING AND IT'S VERY
HARD TO TO PASS THESE BILLS AND
SOME OF YOU MAY HAVE HAD BILLS
THAT WERE HELD BECAUSE THIS FUND
IS DEPLETING. BUT THE
RESEARCHERS SO CLEAR THAT IN
PARTICULAR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
VICTIMS.
THEIR PETS ARE USED AGAINST
THEM IN A WAY THAT AND. THAT THE
REST OF US CAN'T QUITE
UNDERSTAND IT IT'S A POWER
STRUGGLE AND THERE IS EVIDENCE
TO SUGGEST THIS IS RELATIVELY
INEXPENSIVE WAY OF MAKING
VICTIMS HOLE. AND SO WE THOUGHT
IT WAS A WORTHWHILE BILL TO PASS
OUT AND WE THOUGHT THAT IT WAS
ONE ON ONE A VERY VERY NARROW
ONES THAT WE WE SHOULD CONTINUE
MOVING FORWARD I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER
SEEN NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
ON THE ITEM MISTER STEINORTH YOU
MAY CLOSE YES I I DO AGREE THAT
WE DO NEED TO COMPENSATE TO THE
VICTIMS COMPENSATION FUND WE
NEED TO I'M REINVEST INTO THAT
FIND AND AND I COURSE AND
CONCERNED ABOUT THE DWINDLING
NUMBERS THAT ARE THERE AS WELL.
BUT WHAT CONCERNS ME OR THE
AMOUNT OF VICTIMS ACTUALLY STAY
IN ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIPS BECAUSE
OF THEIR RELATIONSHIP WITH THEIR
PAT. AND IF THIS SMALL STAB WILL
HELP FORTY EIGHT PERCENT OF THE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE CHOSEN TO STAY
IN ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIPS GET OUT
AND SEEK SAFETY AND CARE FOR
THEMSELVES AND FOR THE PAT. I
THINK THAT'S A GREAT INVESTMENT.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK
DRIVE OUT.
WITHOUT THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROWLAND TIED OF AND I
SIXTY SIX KNOWS ONE. THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE UP THE BUDGET CONFEREES
BILLS AT THE A COUPLE OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE.
BUDGET CONFERENCE COMMITTEE SO
WE MAY DISPENSE WITH THOSE ITEMS
ARE GOING TO START WITH.
THE BUDGET CHAIRMAN STIR TANG TO
TAKE UP.
A NUMBER OF HIS ITEMS MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO.
MOVE BACK IN THE FILE THE FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY SIX.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY SIX IS
AB TWENTY NINE FORTY TWO BY
MISTER TING THE CORPORATE RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE FORTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO RECALL OF
SENTENCING. MISTER TING.
THANK YOU BUT SPEAKER AB TWENTY
NINE FORTY TWO PROVIDES
PROSECUTORS ANOTHER TOOL. IN THE
TOOLBOX TO REDUCE CENTERS FOR
DEFENDANT THAT HAVE THE
POTENTIAL FOR REHABILITATION THE
BILL ALLOWS PROSECUTORS THE
DISCRETION TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR RECALL IR
RE SENSING OF DEFENDANTS.
PROVIDED THAT THE DEFENDANT'S
BEHAVIOR IS NOT A THREAT TO
PUBLIC SAFETY AND THAT THERE'S
EVIDENCE.
ALL OF THEIR REHABILITATION.
AGAIN THIS IS JUST ANOTHER TOOL
IN THE TOOLBOX OF PROSECUTORS
USE THEIR DISCRETION AROUND
DEFENDANTS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISS TING. SAYING NO
MEMBERS TO GET RECOGNITION.
QUIRK LIBERAL. I'M.
THERE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS BUT IT'S OUT OF THE
MISTER TAME MOVES CALL.
MEMBERS RUMORED TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
TWO SEVENTEEN.
IT'S FILE ITEM TO SEVENTEEN.
AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY.
COOPERATE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY BY SEN EMERGING AND OTHER
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE LAND USE.
RESEARCHING. THANK YOU BUT
SPEAKER AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY
IS A BILL THAT REMOVES BARRIERS
TO THE WIDESPREAD ADOPTION OF
EXCEPT THREE DWELLING UNITS. AS
LOW COST ENERGY EFFICIENT AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AS WE'VE SEEN
WE HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ACCESS RECALLING UNITS ARE GREAT
WAYS FOR PEOPLE TO BUILD UNITS
IN THEIR BACKYARDS IN THEIR
GARAGES SO THAT RELATIVES FAMILY
MEMBERS OR EVEN UP POTENTIAL
TENANTS CAN USE THOSE UNITS FOR
THE FUTURE.
AS WE'VE SEEN UNFORTUNATELY.
WE HAVE TAKEN GREAT EFFORTS TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR HOMEOWNERS IN
PROCTOR'S TO DEVELOP. ACCEPTS
REDRAWING UNITS UNFORTUNATELY
CITIES HAVE STEPPED IN TO MAKE
IT EVEN HARDER AT SOME POINTS
WE'RE PASSING LEGISLATION TO GET
FURTHER STREAMLINE IT. REALLY OR
DRIVE OUT SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO BUILD A CHEAP
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UP AND DOWN
OUR STATE.
THANK YOU MISS TANK.
SEEING THAT NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
CLERK LOGAN ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
THE SIDE OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
MISS YOUR TING THE
STAYING WITH MISTER TANG MEMBERS
THIS IS FILE ITEM THREE TEN.
FILE ITEM THREE TEN.
A. B. 23-14 CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL 23-14 I ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING AND ACTUALLY THE
DOMESTIC WORKERS
MISTER TING IMAGEN OPEN.
I THINK YOU MIGHT SPEAKER AB
TWENTY THREE FOURTEEN
ESTABLISHES AND MAINTAINS A
DOMESTIC WORK.
WORK FORCE INVENT AN ATARI
DOMESTIC WORK ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAM WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT.
CLEARLY DOMESTIC WORKERS ARE
ONE OF OUR LARGEST GROUP OF.
EMPLOYEES UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE
THEY TEND TO WORK IN PEOPLE'S
HOMES OF THEIR IN THE.
GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT
UNFORTUNATELY OFTENTIMES WORKING
SHADOWS.
THEY FACE AT TIMES.
UNFAIR.
EMPLOYMENT ACTION AGAINST THEM
THAT THEY DON'T ALWAYS GET PAID
THEIR FAIR WAGES.
THIS IS NOW REALLY CALLING TO
ATTENTION THOSE ISSUES IN ASKING
THE DEPARTMENT OF. LABOR INSTEAD
IS A FORCED ME TO REALLY TAKE A
CLOSER LOOK TO ONE EDUCATE
EMPLOYERS BUT ALSO EDUCATE
EMPLOYEES ABOUT WHAT THEIR
RIGHTS ARE WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK TRIBAL.
THINGS TANK SEEN NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
LOCAL PEROT. ON THE ROAD TO
SARAJEVO ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THIS OUT OF THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF BOTH
THE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW ABOUT ICE
FIFTY TWO KNOWS TWELVE. THAT
MEASURE PASSES AND. FINALLY FOR
MISTER TANG WILL GO TO FILE ITEM
THREE THIRTEEN.
FILE ITEM THREE THIRTEEN IS AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY FIVE
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE THIRTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE. MR JING.
I THINK IT SPEAKER AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY FIVE CREATES THE
HEALTHY STORES REFRIGERATION
GRANT PROGRAM. WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE TO HELP CORNER
STORES ANOTHER SMALL SCALE
STORES.
BUT THE LIMITED SELECTION OF
FOOD PRODUCTS PURCHASE ENERGY
EFFICIENT REFRIGERATION I DO
APPRECIATE THE LIVELY DEBATE WE
HAD IN THE. ASSEMBLY AG
COMMITTEE A LOT BECAUSE OF THAT
DEBATE WE ARE AMENDING THE BILL
TO MAKE IT ELIGIBLE FOR EVERY
COUNTY.
WE STARTED IT AS A PILOT AND
THERE WAS SO MUCH INTEREST IN
THE COMMITTEE WE EXPANDED IT TO
ALLOW EVERY COUNTY TO NOW OUR
PARTICIPATE. NOT WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DRIVER.
THEY COMMISSION TANK.
SEE NO DISCUSSION MADE ON THIS
ITEM.
CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON.
WHO'S THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS CENTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE ANTI THAT
ICE FIFTY.
KNOWS FOURTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT TO WE ARE GOING TO MOVE. TO
ALLOW DOCTOR ARAMBULA TO TAKE UP
HIS ITEMS.
BEGINNING WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO TWENTY TWO.
THAT IS AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY
FIVE COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE SIXTY
FIVE BY SOME THE MEMBER ARAMBULA
AND ACTUALLY A MEDICAL. DOCTOR
ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I HAVE ALWAYS BELIEVED THAT
HEALTHCARE IS A HUMAN RIGHT.
IT IS BECAUSE OF THIS BELIEF
THAT I BECAME A DOCTOR.
SO THAT I COULD CARE FOR THE
RESIDENTS ALL OF THE RESIDENTS
OF MY COMMUNITY.
AS THE DOCTOR I SAW THE
CHALLENGES THAT MANY
CALIFORNIANS FACE TRYING TO GET
GOOD MEDICAL CARE.
I ALSO SAW MANY OF THE
LIMITATIONS OF OUR CURRENT
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO ARE MOST
VULNERABLE WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE WITHOUT
INSURANCE ARE LESS LIKELY TO GET
THE MEDICAL CARE THAT THEY NEED.
THE FEDERAL INSTITUTE OF
MEDICINE PUT IT SUCCINCTLY.
UNINSURED PEOPLE ARE MORE LIKELY
TO RECEIVED TOO LITTLE CARE AND
RECEIVE IT TOO LATE.
AS A RESULT THEY OUR SECKER AND
DIE SOONER.
I'VE SEEN THIS FIRSTHAND.
I WAS ON THE FRONT LINES OF
HEALTH CARE AND FEEL THE URGENCY
TO FIX OUR BROKEN CURRENT
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY FIVE SEEKS
TO EXPAND MEDICAL COVERAGE TO
INCOME ELIGIBLE UNDOCUMENTED
YOUNG ADULTS AGES NINETEEN
THROUGH TWENTY FIVE.
SIMPLY PUT.
THIS BILL REMOVES A BARRIER TO
HELP ACCESS DO TO IMMIGRATION
STATUS THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS UNJUSTLY IMPOSED.
AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY FIVE WILL
BRING CALIFORNIA ONE STEP CLOSER
TO ENSURING THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIAN HAS COMPREHENSIVE.
AFFORDABLE ACCESSIBLE HEALTH
COVERAGE.
IN OUR RECENTLY CONCLUDED SELECT
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS AND UNIVERSAL
COVERAGE.
WITH CHAIRMAN WHAT AND I JUST
FINISHED
HEALTH CARE EXPERTS REITERATED
SEVERAL TIMES THAT ARE SHORT
TERM STEP TOWARDS UNIVERSAL
COVERAGE. IS TO WORK WITH THEM
CALIFORNIANS.
CURRENT FRAGMENTED FINANCING
SYSTEM AND IMPROVE COVERAGE TO
EXPAND MEDICAL COVERAGE TO THE
UNINSURED.
NEARLY SIXTY PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIANS REMAINING UNINSURED
POPULATION WHICH IS NEARLY THREE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS IS
UNDOCUMENTED.
ACCORDING TO THE UC REPORT
RELEASED AT THE END OF OUR
SELECT COMMITTEE.
EXPANDING ELIGIBILITY TO MEDI
CAL.
TO THIS POPULATION WOULD LIKELY
MAKE SUBSTANTIAL INROADS TOWARD
UNIVERSAL COVERAGE.
TWO YOU TO ARE UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS BEING UNABLE TO
ACCESS HEALTH INSURANCE AND THE
COMPOUNDING FEARS AND CHILLING
AFFECTS.
CREATED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. THEIR QUALITY OF
LIFE IS NEGATIVELY IMPACTED AN
ADDITIONAL TRAUMAS ARE CREATING
AN URGENCY TO ENSURE THEY ARE
PROTECTED AND INSURED.
INSTEAD OF BEING ABLE TO RECEIVE
CARE IN A TIMELY MANNER.
TO PREVENT ILLNESSES FROM
DETERIORATING MANY UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS ONLY ACCESS HEALTH
CARE IN THE EMERGENCY ROOM.
WHERE MANY TIMES PHYSICIANS LIKE
MYSELF OR NO LONGER ABLE TO HELP
DUE TO THE EXACERBATION OF THEIR
ILLNESS?
I'VE SEEN COUNTLESS CASES
IN MY EMERGENCY ROOM IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN OUR COUNTRY'S
BREAD BASKET.
WHERE FARMWORKERS WHO HELP? TO
PRODUCE THE FRUIT AND VEGETABLES
THAT FILL OUR TABLES.
ARE UNABLE TO DO THE SAME FOR
THEIR OWN FAMILIES DUE TO THEIR
DIRE HEALTH CIRCUMSTANCES.
NOT ONLY IS THIS CURRENT STATE
OF AFFAIRS DETRIMENTAL TO THESE
INDIVIDUALS. BUT IT ALSO
INCREASES THE DEMAND ON
EMERGENCY ROOM SERVICES AND
INCREASES COSTS IN OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM OVERALL. IN A MANNER
THAT COULD BE PREVENTED.
WE CAN DO BETTER.
THIS LEGISLATION BUILDS UPON THE
WORK THAT THIS LEGISLATURE HAS
DONE WITH HEALTH FOR ALL KIDS
WHICH WAS CHAMPIONED BY SENATOR
LOTT ON. WHO I AM PROUD TO BE
WORKING WITH THIS YEAR TO EXPAND
TO ALL LOW INCOME? UNDOCUMENTED
YOUNG ADULTS.
THIS BILL INSURERS THAT FULL
SCOPE MEDICAL CONTINUES
TO BE AVAILABLE TO LOW INCOME
YOUNG ADULTS AS THEY AGE OUT OF
ELIGIBILITY. DUE HEALTH FOR ALL
KIDS WHEN THEY TURN NINETEEN.
UNDOCUMENTED YOUNG ADULTS.
CALIFORNIANS FACE BARRIERS.
OF NOT HAVING HEALTH CARE WILL
ALSO CARING FOR THEIR AGING
PARENTS WHO HAVE WORKED HARD TO
PROVIDE FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
FELLOW MEMBERS WE INVEST IN THE
HEALTH OF OUR STATE WHEN WE
INVEST IN HEALTH COVERAGE FOR
LOW INCOME UNDOCUMENTED YOUNG
ADULTS. WHO ARE A FUNDAMENTAL
PART OF OUR WORK FORCE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES?
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA MISTER
HARPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS.
YEAH.
CALIFORNIANS ARE STRUGGLING WITH
HIGH HOUSING COSTS.
THE HIGHEST GAS PRICES IN THE
NATION.
AS WELL AS EXPENSIVE WATER AND
ELECTRICITY RATES.
IN ADDITION OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM
RANKING IS DISMAL.
AND OUR STATES INFRASTRUCTURE
CONTINUES TOLL ROAD.
THE HARD WORKING CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA.
SHOULD NOT FOOT THE BILL FOR
ILLEGAL ALIENS IN THIS SITUATION.
THE LAST THING WE SHOULD BE
DOING.
IT'S PUTTING OTHERS
BEFORE OUR OWN CITIZENS.
THEY'RE ARE MORE THAN ONE
MILLION CALIFORNIA CITIZENS WHO
CANNOT AFFORD HEALTH CARE WITHIN
OUR STATE.
HOW YOU TELL AN AMERICAN CITIZEN?
THE TAXPAYER FUNDS THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN USED.
FOR THEM.
TO RECEIVE CARE.
WILL GO TOWARDS THE CARE.
OF AN ILLEGAL ALIEN.
MY COLLEAGUES.
THIS BILL.
WILL SERVE AS YET ANOTHER MAGNET.
A BEACON ATTRACTING.
ILLEGAL ALIENS
FROM THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
I REQUEST THAT EVERYONE JOIN ME
IN PUTTING CALIFORNIANS FIRST.
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO
VOTE ON THIS BILL.
SEEING KNOW ADDITIONAL.
DISCUSSION.
DEBATE ON THE ITEM DOCTOR
ARAMBULA YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH.
HEALTHCARE IS A HUMAN RIGHTS AND
OUT SUCH I HOPE WE RECOGNIZE
THAT ARE UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD BE TREATED
WITH THE SAME DIGNITY. AND BE
GIVEN THIS RIGHT STARTING WITH
ARE UNDOCUMENTED YOUNG ADULTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
WITHOUT CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE
DESIRE TO THOUGH?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA MOVES A CALL
.
WE'RE STAYING STAYING WITH
DOCTOR ARAMBULA. MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM THREE
OH SEVEN.
FILE ITEM THREE OF SEVEN WITCHES
AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY FIVE IN
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY TO SEVENTY
FIVE BY SOME THE MEMBER ARAMBULA
AND ACTUALLY THE MEDI CAL.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ALL
TRYING KEEP THE BRIEFS AND SOME
MEMBERS ARE OFF THE FLOOR.
AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY FIVE
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO
ESTABLISH A QUALITY ASSESSMENT A
PERFORMANCE IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM.
TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES PROVIDED BY
MANAGED CARE PLANS AND TO REDUCE
HEALTH DISPARITIES.
THIS BILL WILL ESTABLISH A NEW
MINIMUM PERFORMANCE LEVEL SET TO
THE BOTTOM QUARTILE OF MEDICAID
PLANS PERFORMANCE NATIONWIDE.
PACIFIC STANDARDS WILL BE
DETERMINED BY STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS THAT DRIVES QUALITY AND
REDUCES HEALTH DISPARITIES.
FURTHERMORE THIS BILL WILL
ESTABLISH A FINANCIAL INCENTIVE
PROGRAM TO REWARD MANAGED CARE
PLANS THAT MEET PERFORMANCE
TARGETS THAT EXCEED THE NEW
MINIMUM PERFORMANCE LEVEL AND
ALSO INCLUDE A DEFINITION OF
HEALTH DISPARITIES.
DH THE S. WILL DEVELOP A PLAN
FOR THIS INCENTIVE PROGRAM WITH
IMPLEMENTATION SUBJECT TO
LEGISLATIVE APPROPRIATION OF
FUNDS.
WITH THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
QUALITY ASSESSMENTS AND
PERFORMANCE IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM
I HOPE WE CAN REDUCE THE HEALTH
DISPARITIES WITHIN COMMUNITIES
AND RAISE THE QUALITY OF OUR
HEALTHCARE. IN ORDER TO BUILD
HEALTHIER COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA SEEING
THEIR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
THE SAD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE
.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA. DOCTOR ARAMBULA
MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK
IN THE FILE.
TO ALLOW MISTER ARAMBULA TO TAKE
UP.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE NINETY NINE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE NINETY
NINE AB TWENTY FORTY THREE
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FORTY THREE
BY SOME THE RIVER ARAMBULA AND
ACTUALLY TO FOSTER YOUTH DOCTOR
RAM LET YOU MAKE AN OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
THIS BILL HAS SUPORT ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE.
AB TWENTY FORTY THREE
ESTABLISHES THE FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE SYSTEM FOR FOSTER YOUTH
IN CARE GIVERS.
STATEWIDE TOLL FREE HOTLINE
AVAILABLE TWENTY FOUR HOURS A
DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK FOR
CAREGIVERS AND FOSTER YOUTH WHO
ARE EXPERIENCING EMOTIONAL
BEHAVIORAL OR OTHER DIFFICULTIES.
AND NEED IMMEDIATE HELP.
THE HOTLINE WILL BE STAFFED WITH
OPERATORS TRAINED IN CONFLICT
RESOLUTION AND DE ESCALATION TO
HELP TO DIFFUSE THE SITUATION.
AND DETERMINE WHETHER A MOLD. IN
HOME SUPPORT IS NEEDED.
COUNTIES WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
FOLLOW UP WITH A.
NO WILD RESPONSE TEAM TO PROVIDE
FACE TO FACE IN HOME RESPONSE TO
HELP STABILIZE THE LIVING
SITUATION AND ASSESS THE
CAREGIVER AND CHILD'S NEEDS.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED STRONG
BIPARTISAN BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTES
TODAY.
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
I'M.
A DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE WRONG TYPE OF
AN ICE FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
AND THE LAST ITEM FOR MISSED HER
DOCTOR ARAMBULA WILL BE FILE
ITEM TO FORTY FIVE FILE ITEM TO
FORTY FIVE IS AB THIRTY TWO
EIGHTEEN COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TWO
EIGHTEEN BY SOME THE MEMBER
ARAMBULA AND ACTUALLY THE STATE
PARKS DOCTOR ARAMBULA. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER.
TODAY I PRESENT A. B. THIRTY TWO
EIGHTEEN WHICH ENJOYS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
AB THIRTY TO EIGHTEEN WOULD
ALLOW THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
CONSERVANCY THE ABILITY TO ENTER
INTO A MANAGEMENT AGREEMENT.
WITH THE STATE PARKS AND WOULD
PROVIDE FOR OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE OF THE TRAILS AND
SPACE THAT THE PARKWAY HAS
ACQUIRED.
IT IS NO SECRET THAT THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY IS SEVERELY
UNDERSERVED AND FALLS FAR BEHIND
IN RATES OF PARKS PER CAPITA.
NOT ONLY NATIONWIDE BUT
STATEWIDE AS WELL.
THIS LACK OF GREEN SPACE AFFECTS
MEMBERS OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THE MOST.
AS A PHYSICIAN I KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF SPENDING TIME
OUTDOORS.
DIABETES HYPERTENSION OBESITY.
THESE COULD ALL BE ALLEVIATED BY
SIMPLY SPENDING MORE TIME
OUTDOORS
IF ONLY WE COULD PROVIDE A SAFE
AND AVAILABLE RECREATIONAL AREA
FOR ALL TO ENJOY. THANK YOU AND
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
THEY DUCKED ARAMBULA MISTER
BIGELOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. I WANT TO COMPLIMENT THE
AUTHOR ON HIS ACTIONS AND HIS
EFFORTS
TO BRING THE DIFFERENT PARTIES
AND AND STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER
THIS WAS A CONTENTIOUS ISSUE
WHEN IT WAS FIRST INTRODUCED.
BUT BECAUSE OF HIS EFFORTS AND
THE COMBINED EFFORTS OF ALL
PARTIES THIS IS NOW SUPPORTABLE
MAJOR AT THE LOCAL LEVEL BOTH
MYSELF AND THE GOOD MEMBER FROM
FRESNO.
I REPRESENT THE DIRECT AREA THAT
IS IMPACTED BY THIS PARTICULAR
BILL WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
AGAIN AND I AYE ENCOURAGING AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MUCH BIGELOW MUCH
PATTERSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
BECOME MEMBERS LIKE TO.
RISE TO JOIN IN THE CALL FOR
SUPPORT OF THIS UP. AS A FORMER
MAYOR FRESNO NOW REPRESENTING UP
A BIG SWATH OF THAT RIVER THIS
HAS BEEN SOMETHING THAT SO MANY
OF US WOULD WORKING ON A LONG
LONG TIME. LOT OF UP.
LOCAL ISSUES AND A LOT OF OUR
PEOPLE INVOLVED IN IT AND I WANT
TO COMMEND THE. MY COLLEAGUE
FROM FRESNO FOR WORKING THROUGH
THIS WE WERE ALL AT THE TABLE.
THIS IS A VERY VERY GOOD BILL
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND WE
WANT TO GET ON TO SOMETHING THAT.
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO GET
ACCOMPLISHED FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS PATTERSON DOCTOR
ARAMBULA YOU MAY CLOSE FEW WHICH
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
CLICK CLUB THE ROLE ON MEMBERS
SO.
IT IS OUT OF LOVE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS.
THIS OUT OF VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND HOW IT AYE SIXTY
FOUR KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS THAT OBJECTION WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO ALLOW MISTER
BLOOM TO TAKE UP AN ITEM THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO TWO FIVE.
FILE ITEM TO TWENTY FIVE WHICH
IS A. B..
TWENTY NINE NINETY EIGHT.
KERKORIAN.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE NINETY
EIGHT BY SOME REMEMBER BLOOM AND
ACTUALLY TO BUSINESS SCHOOL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
THIS BILL SEEKS TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS BY
PROHIBITING THE SALE OF JUVENILE
PRODUCTS MATTRESSES AND
UPHOLSTERED. OR RE UPHOLSTERED
FURNITURE THAT CONTAIN TOXIC
FLAME RETARDANT CHEMICALS.
EVERY DAY CALIFORNIANS ARE
EXPOSED TO THESE CHEMICALS AND
OVER TIME THE ACCUMULATED OUR
BODIES AND IN THE ENVIRONMENT.
CAUSING A VARIETY OF ADVERSE
HEALTH EFFECTS INCLUDING
ENDOCRINE AND THYROID
DESTRUCTION CANCER AND HARMFUL
NEUROLOGICAL IMPACTS.
CHILDREN AND FIREFIGHTERS ARE
OFTEN EXPOSED TO THESE CHEMICALS
IN THEIR DERIVATIVES AT EVEN
HIGHER RATES THAN THE GENERAL
PUBLIC.
INFANTS ARE OFTEN EXPOSED TO
THESE CHEMICALS THROUGH
CONTAMINATED DUST AND BREAST
MILK. AND BEEN FOUND TO HAVE
THESE CHEMICALS IN THEIR BODIES
AT THREE DIFFERENT LEVELS THAT
ARE THREE TO FIVE TIMES THE
LEVELS IN THEIR MOMS.
FIREFIGHTERS ARE EXPOSED TO
FLAME RETARDANTS THROUGH THEIR
WORK PROTECTING THE PUBLIC.
AND WHEN FLAME RETARDANT
CHEMICALS BURNED. THEY RELEASE
CARCINOGENIC SUBSTANCES THAT ARE
INHALED BY FIREFIGHTERS AND EVEN
LINGER ON THEIR PROTECTIVE
CLOTHING LONG AFTER THEY LEAVE
THE SITE OF A FIRE.
AS A RESULT WE'RE SEEING HIGHER
RATES OF CANCER AMONG
FIREFIGHTERS THAN EVER BEFORE.
NOW HERE'S THE THING.
IN ADDITION TO BEING TOXIC THESE
CHEMICALS ARE COMPLETELY
UNNECESSARY TO MEET FLAMMABILITY
STANDARDS.
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN WE AS A STATE
UPDATED R. FLAMMABILITY STANDARD
AND THE PRODUCTS AFFECTED BY
THIS BILL DO NOT NEED FOR NEED
FLAME RETARDANTS. IN ORDER TO
MEET THAT REVISED STANDARD.
AND THIS IS WHY MANY
MANUFACTURERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE ARE VOLUNTARILY PHASING
THEM OUT HOWEVER MANY OTHERS.
TEN YOU TO USE THESE PRODUCTS
AND THEREFORE A RESTRICTION ON
THE SALE OF SPECIFIC PRODUCTS.
ATTAINING THESE CHEMICALS IS
NECESSARY.
AB TWENTY NINE NINETY EIGHT
PRIORITIZE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF CALIFORNIANS BY PHASING THESE
CHEMICALS OUT FOR GOOD AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOW.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLOCK CLUB THEY'RE ALL.
SORRY ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE
.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE.
I FORTY SIX KNOWS TEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS BACK IN FILE ORDER.
WE LEFT OFF AND FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTY TWO.
THAT IS AB NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE
BY MR SANTIAGO OPERATE. ASSEMBLY
BILL NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE BY
SELLING MEMBER SANTIAGO AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE MENTAL
HEALTH. MISTER SANTIAGO.
FIGURES SPEAKER.
AB NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE WILL
EXPAND THE DISH DEFINITION OF
GRAVE OF THE DISABLED TO INCLUDE
MEDICAL TREATMENT WITH THE
INABILITY OR FAILURE TO RECEIVE
MEDICAL TREATMENT. WILL RESULT
IN DETERIORATING PHYSICAL
CONDITION OR DEATH.
THIS IS A BILL THAT WE TOOK UP
BECAUSE IT IMPACTS
MY DISTRICT LIKE I'M SURE
IMPACTS MANY OF YOURS.
WHERE YOU HAVE A HOMELESS PERSON?
AND YOU KNOW THAT THEY
ABSOLUTELY NEED SOME MEDICAL
ATTENTION AND THERE IS NOTHING
WE CAN DO CURRENTLY UNDER THE
LAW TO GIVE THAT PERSON. A
MEDICAL ATTENTION.
NOT CERTAINLY WERE WILL AND
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
ADVOCATES IN THE INTENTION IS
NOT.
TO JUST PICK UP PEOPLE THE
INTENTION IS TO DO THE MORE
HUMANE THING.
AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY ALONE
THAT WAS CLOSE TO EIGHT HUNDRED.
AYE PEOPLE WHO DIED ON THE
STREETS LAST YEAR.
AND WHILE WE DON'T KNOW THE
EXACT NUMBER OF THOSE WHO DIED.
FOR MEDICAL NECESSITY
IMMEDIATELY THAT COULD HAVE BEEN
PART OF PREVENTED WE DO KNOW
THAT THIS BILL WILL HELP US TO
IDENTIFY FURTHER FOR DID ONLINE
FOLKS WHO HAVE.
MEDICAL NEED.
AND FOR ONE REASON OTHER CAN'T
RECEIVE IT.
IT'S JUST A MORE HUMANE THING TO
DO.
PICK SOMEBODY AND GIVE THEM
ALTHOUGH SERVICES THAT THEY NEED.
CURRENTLY.
YOU CAN SEE CONSERVATORSHIP.
IF SOMEBODY.
CANNOT HOPE.
CLOTHE THEMSELVES FEED
THEMSELVES OR HOW THE HOUSE
THEMSELVES.
BUT THE THRESHOLD IS SO HIGH.
THAT WE BELIEVE THE MORE HUMANE
THING TO DO WHEN SOMEBODY HAVE.
NECESSITY.
IS TO GIVE THEM THOSE SERVICES.
AND THAT'S WHY WE DECIDED TO
TAKE UP THIS BILL.
SPECIALLY TAKE A LOOK SOME OF
OUR DISTRICTS AND.
SACRAMENTO CLOSED DE EIGHT NINE
THOUSAND PEOPLE LIVE ON THE
STREETS IN MY DISTRICT ALONE IN
A FEW SQUARE BLOCKS SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN EIGHT AND TEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE AND MOST OF THEM HAVE.
MISTER A MEDICAL NECESSITY.
I AND.
A WE TOOK THE THE APPROACH TO DO
A BIPARTISAN BILL.
I BECAUSE WE FELT THAT THAT WAS
THE BEST WAY TO GET A BETTER
PRODUCT OUT OF THIS.
I THINK YOU MEMBERS.
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THE US ON TIAGO DR CHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I WRITE TODAY'S A PROUD WHEN
AUTHOR OF AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
ONE.
MAKING A CHANGE THE DEFINITION
OF GRAVELY DISABLED AS NECESSARY.
BECAUSE THOSE WHO SUFFER FROM
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS ARE OFTEN
A DANGER TO THEMSELVES.
AND SOMETIMES TO OTHERS.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE WHEN
INDIVIDUALS AND CAPABLE OF
UNDERSTANDING NATIVE IMPACTS.
OTHER ILLNESS.
UNDER EXISTING CALIFORNIA LAWS
SERIOUSLY MENTALLY ILL
INDIVIDUALS ARE FALLING THROUGH
THE CRACKS SOCIETY.
INSTEAD OF RECEIVING SUPPORT
TREATMENT AND ASSISTANCE THEY'RE
BEING JAILED HOSPITALIZE HOPE
FOR SHORT AMOUNTS OF TIME
RELEASE BACK ONTO THE STREETS
WITHOUT ADEQUATE CARE.
THE FILM THE WHOLE SYSTEM
CALIFORNIA COULD BE SEEN ALL
OVER THE STATE.
AND WOW THE MOST VULNERABLE TO
LANGUAGE ON OUR STREETS WITHOUT
A LIFETIME.
IS INHUMANE AND WE CANNOT ACCEPT
THIS IS A VIABLE OPTION.
WHEN LOOKING CHANGE IN
DEFINITION OF GRAVELY DISABLED
WE NEED TO BALANCE INDIVIDUAL
CIVIL LIBERTIES THE SAFETY OF
PEOPLE. THOSE WITH MENTAL
CONDITIONS
RENDER THEM UNABLE TO MAKE
DECISIONS
REGARDING MENTAL HEALTH AND
PHYSICAL HEALTH.
BY ADDING THE DEFINITION OF
MEDICAL TREATMENT TO THE
DEFINITION OF GRAVELY DISABLED
IT WILL ALLOW THE STATE TO STOP
A FAMILY GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT
NEED OUR HELP. THEY NEED A
RESOURCES AND OF COURSE NEITHER
TREATMENT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHEN MISS
FRIEDMAN HERE RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU.
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY IS A JOINT
AUTHOR OF NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE.
AND I'M IS WHAT I TELL YOU A
BRIEF STORY ABOUT.
WHEN I REALIZED THE IMPORTANCE
OF THIS BILL. WHO A FEW OF US
HAD THE JOINT AUTHORS TOOK A
TOUR OF SKID ROW IN LOS ANGELES
A FEW WEEKS AGO? I WAS SPEAKING
TO THE WOMAN WHO OVER HER RUNS A
FRONTLINE EMERGENCY SHELTER WHO
DEALS WITH THE HOMELESS
POPULATION EVERYDAY.
AND WHAT YOU TOLD ME WAS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
COME WHO WHO THEY SEE ON THE
STREETS.
BUT THEIR NOT REALLY ABLE TO
PROTECT NOW THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO
MEET THE DEFINITION RIGHT NOW A
PEOPLE THAT. ARE NOT ELIGIBLE
FOR CONSERVATORSHIP.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE CLOTHING ON
THEIR BACK EVEN IF IT'S ONLY A
COUPLE PIECES OF NEWSPAPER AND
THEY'RE ABLE TO FEED THEMSELVES
EVEN IF IT'S FROM SCRAPS THEY
FIND LYING ON THE SIDEWALK.
AND THEY'RE NOT.
STANDING IN FRONT OF TRAFFIC AND
THEY'RE NOT WAVING A KNIFE SO
THEY'RE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR SEVENTY
TWO HOUR HOLD.
BUT BECAUSE OF CO MORBIDITIES
DIABETES
OTHER ISSUES.
THEY KNOW THAT WITHOUT
INTERVENTION.
THOSE PEOPLE WILL BE DEAD IN A
MATTER OF MONTHS THEY KNOW IT
THEY SAID THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO
WALK AROUND AND POINT PEOPLE OUT
AND SAY THIS PEOPLE WILL BE DEAD
VOTE WILL DIE.
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT.
NO WHERE THEY ARE THEY CERTAINLY.
ARE NOT.
MENTALLY.
SUFFICIENT TO BE ABLE TO CHOOSE
WHETHER OR NOT TO TREAT A
MEDICAL.
CONDITION THAT THEY MIGHT HAVE.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO BECAUSE OF
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS.
CANNOT SURVIVE.
EVEN.
THEY CAN'T SURVIVE ON THE
STREETS.
BUT BECAUSE. OF THE WAY THE LAWS
ARE WRITTEN THEY ALSO CAN BE
PLACED A CONSERVATORSHIP THEY
CANNOT BE COMPELLED TO TAKE
MEDICATION THAT WOULD EXTEND
THEIR LIVES.
IT IS NOT HUMANE.
TOO DAMN THESE PEOPLE TO DIE
SLOWLY ON THE STREETS IN FRONT
OF US THAT'S NOT HUMANE.
IT'S NOT HUMANE TO SAY THAT
UNTIL THEY COMMIT A CRIME AND WE
CAN LOCK THEM UP THEY CAN'T GET
HELP.
AND YET BECAUSE OF THE WAY THE
LAWS ARE WRITTEN THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT HAPPENS.
WE. THE AUTHORS UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS THAT SOME OF THE
OPPONENTS HAVE MADE AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO WORKING ON
ADDRESSING THOSE AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD. BUT DOING NOTHING
IS NOT AN OPTION.
SAYING THAT UNLESS SOMEONE IS AN
IMMEDIATE DANGER THEY CANNOT. BE
HELD A CONSERVATORSHIP IS NOT AN
OPTION PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
ILLNESSES THAT ARE THIS SEVERE
ARE AS SEVERELY DISABLED TO
SOMEBODY WITH A PHYSICAL
HANDICAP AND GET THE LAW DOES
NOT TREAT THEM THAT WAY.
IF YOU TALK TO ANY OF THE
FRONTLINE.
EMPLOYEES AT THE SHELTER THEY
WILL TELL YOU THAT THERE IS A
NEED FOR THIS BILL TO BE ABLE TO
GET PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS AND
SAVE LIVES AND I URGE YOU. TO
DOCTOR EGGMAN YOUR READINESS.
I THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS OF I JUST RISE TO TO
RAISE AN ISSUE AS MY COLLEAGUE
ROSE ON.
PREDATED ALSO TALK ABOUT A
BILLION DOLLARS FOR BABIES I
JUST RAISE THE ISSUE THAT WE AYE
I APPRECIATE EXPANDING
CATEGORIES OF HOW WE.
CAN INSTITUTIONALIZE PEOPLE BUT
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD LOSE
SIGHT OF THE FACT THAT WE DON'T
DO ENOUGH FUNDING FOR MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH PSYCHIATRIC BEDS WHEN
PEOPLE DO HAVE ACUTE. ISSUES AND
SO WHAT WE CAN.
FEEL GOOD ABOUT TAKING CARE OF
EXPANDING HOW YOU CAN TAKE
SOMEBODY'S RIGHTS AWAY I THINK
MORE IMPORTANTLY WE NEED TO
BUILD A PROACTIVE AND THINK
ABOUT HOW DO WE PROVIDE MORE
MENTAL HEALTH SO PEOPLE DON'T
FIND THEMSELVES IN THIS
CONDITION.
MR ACOSTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'LL BE
BRIEF FILE I ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN NINETY
SEVENTY ONE WE HAVE AN ACUTE.
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS AND
HOMELESSNESS ISSUE IN.
THE STATE AND PARTICULAR IN LA
COUNTY. WHICH I PART OF MY
DISTRICT.
WE HAVE.
ISSUES THERE AND WE REALLY NEED
TO MAKE SURE WE CAN GET THESE
FOLKS OF THAT THE CARE THAT THEY
NEED. ARE SO I DO OBVIOUSLY
RISING SPORT RIGHT TO SEVENTY
ONE ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER COST AND SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
SANTIAGO YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH.
THANK YOU FOR SPEAKER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
CLERK LIBERAL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW THE VOTE
EYES FIFTY NINE DOES ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES PASS RETAIN ON
FILE ITEM FIFTY THREE.
FILE ITEM FIFTY FOURS AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTY FIVE AYE MR ACOSTA
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE THIRTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ACOSTA
AND ACTUALLY THE VEHICLES MISTER
COSTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
FIVE IS A SIMPLE STRAIGHTFORWARD
BILL THAT AUTHORIZES THE
PERSONALIZATION OF GOLD STAR
FAMILY LICENSE PLATES SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN CALIFORNIA'S
ISSUED UPON REQUEST A
SPECIALIZEDLICENSE PLATE. FOR
QUALIFIED GOLD STAR FAMILY
MEMBERS EASIER IMMEDIATE FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO HAVE LOST A LOVED
ONE IN THE LINE OF DUTY WHILE
SERVING TO PROTECT OUR COUNTRY.
GOLD STAR FAMILY MEMBERS ACROSS
THE STATE WOULD LIKE THE
OPPORTUNITY.
CREATE PERSONALIZED SPECIALIZED
LICENSE PLATE IS DEDICATED TO
THE LOVE ONES WHO WERE TAKEN TO
EARLY WHILE SERVING OUR GREAT
COUNTRY.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CASA SI NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CORPORAL
OPEN THE RIGHT.
THIS OUT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THIS ARAB VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE ANTI THAT
I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS.
FIFTY FIVE FIFTY SIX AND FIFTY
SEVEN PASS TO RETAIN OR FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT.
THAT IS AB TWENTY TWO OUT TO BY
MR GRAY CORPORATION ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY TO GO TO BUY
SOMETHING MEMBER GRAY AND
ACTUALLY TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA MAKING A PREPARATION
THERE FOR. MISTER RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TWENTY TO OUT TO APPROPRIATES
MONEY TO THE REGENTS OF THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA FOR THE
CREATION. CONSTRUCTION AND
ESTABLISHMENT OF A UCSF MEDICAL
SCHOOL BRANCH CAMPUS IN
PARTNERSHIP REDUCE THE MERCED
AND UCSF FRESNO.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN THE STATE
BUDGET DIRECTED THE UC TO
COMPLETE AN ANALYSIS OF THE
PROCESS TO CREATE A MEDICAL
SCHOOL AT THE MERCED CAMPUS.
THE UC RECENTLY RELEASED THEIR
COMPLETED ANALYSIS.
WHICH PROVIDES AN OVERVIEW OF
THE HEALTH NEEDS OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AND ECONOMIC
ANALYSIS OF THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY MEDICAL SCHOOL BRANCH
CAMPUS.
THE INADEQUACIES OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY'S HEALTHCARE
INFRASTRUCTURE WELL DOCUMENTED.
AS THE UC REPORT HIGHLIGHTS THE
BALLOT IS ONE OF THE FASTEST
GROWING. POOREST AND LEAST
HEALTHY REGIONS OF THE STATE.
AND HAS A LONG STANDING SHORTAGE
OF PHYSICIANS AND OTHER
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS.
YOU SEE REPORTER IS THE ONLY THE
LATEST IN A TWO DECADE EFFORT TO
LEVERAGE THE ASSISTANCE FOR THE
BUILD OUT OF MEDICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE VALLEY.
A FULLY INDEPENDENT MEDICAL
SCHOOL YOU SEE MERCED WAS BEING
DISCUSSED BEFORE THE
UNDERGRADUATE CAMPUS EVEN BEGAN
CONSTRUCTION.
THIS TALISMAN OF A MEDICAL
SCHOOL BRANCH CAMPUS IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY WILL ALLOW THE
TRAINING OF MEDICAL STUDENTS WHO
WERE BORN AND RAISED IN THE
REGION. IN WHO HAVE ROOTS THAT
WILL ENCOURAGE THEM TO PRACTICE
MEDICINE CLOSE TO HOME.
THIS STEP PRIOR THE CONSTRUCTION
OF A FULLY INDEPENDENT MEDICAL
SCHOOL PROVIDE IMMEDIATE RETURNS
BY FUNNELING DOCTORS INTO THE
REGION WHILE PROVIDING TIME FOR
THE UC TO DEVELOP A TRULY
COMPELLING AND INNOVATIVE
PROPOSAL. FOR A FULL UC MERCED
MEDICAL SCHOOL.
IN ORDER ADVANCE THIS CONCEPT
THE LEGISLATURE MUST PROVIDE
FINANCIAL CERTAINTY A VARIABLE
WHICH INITIALLY STALLED THE
ACCREDITATION OF THE UC
RIVERSIDE MEDICALS.
AB TWENTY TO GO TO SEEKS TO
PROVIDE THIS FINANCIAL CERTAINTY
THAT CONTINUES TO BE A WORK IN
PROGRESS.
DIFFICULT AS IT MIGHT BE WE MUST
CONTINUE TO MOVE THIS DISCUSSION
FORWARD IS THE VALLEY HAS TO BE
A VICTIM.
OF DELAYS FOR TOO LONG.
THIS BILL SUPPORT BY MERCED
COUNTY THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS AND
MEMBERS I WOULD ASK THE QUESTION
AT A TIME OF RECORD SURPLUS IF
WE CAN'T MAKE THIS INVESTMENT
VALLEY NOW. I DON'T KNOW WHEN WE
CAN MAKE IT WITH THAT THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION OF RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
IT WAS GREAT MISSION MEDINA
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AS THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE AREA THAT
HAD THOUGH LAST MEDICAL SCHOOL I
RISE IN SUPPORT. OF AB TWENTY
ZERO TWO AND URGE MY COLLEAGUES
TO VOTE IN FAVOR. A
ACKNOWLEDGING THE SHORTAGE OF
DOCTORS AND INLAND CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MR MEDINA AND WITHOUT
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
SORRY TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER
DECIDE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
S. TAKES FIFTY FOUR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
.
MISTER BRECHT LIVES A CALL.
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM FIFTY
NINE.
AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTEEN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVENTEEN
BY SOME A MEMBER BURKE AND
ACTUALLY TO TAXATION TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
MISS BURKE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTEEN
WHICH ENACTS THE BIDDY MASON
GOLDEN STATE CREDIT. THROAT
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AND IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIANS TO
MITIGATE THE IMPACT OF THE NEW
FEDERAL TAX LAW.
BRIDGET BIDDY MASON WAS BORN A
SLAVE WHO WON HER FREEDOM SHE
WENT ON TO SUCCESSFULLY SERVE AS
A PROMINENT MIDWIFE AND NURSE
ASSISTING IN HUNDREDS OF BIRTH
TO MOTHERS OF EVERY WALK OF LIFE.
AND SHE WAS THE FOUNDER OF THE
FIRST AFRICAN METHODIST
EPISCOPAL CHURCH.
CONGRESS FOR OVER A HUNDRED
YEARS IN REFLECTION OF FEDERAL
IS PRINCIPLES HAS RECOGNIZED TAX
DEDUCTIONS FOR CHARITABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS UNFORTUNATELY THE
NEW FEDERAL TAX LAW WILL CAP THE
STATE AND LOCAL TAX DEDUCTION
AND RAISE THE STANDARD
DEDUCTIONS RESULTING ANY
PROJECTED SEVENTEEN BILLION
DOLLAR. DROP IN CHARITABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS.
AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTEEN CREATES
A CONTRIBUTING SON SYSTEM WHICH
BRINGS A THREEFOLD BENEFIT TO
SCHOOLS AND NONPROFITS THE STATE
AND CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS WHILE
ALLOWING DONATING. TAXPAYERS TO
CHOOSE WHICH NON PROFITS AND
SCHOOLS ARE DONATIONS GO TOWARDS
PROMOTING CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
ENCOURAGING THE CONTINUED
SUPPORT OF NONPROFITS I THINK
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I.
THANK YOU MS BURG SCENE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ON
THEM VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW IT EYES
FORTY NINE.
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM SIXTY.
IS AB TWENTY TO THIRTY FIVE
COOPERATE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
TO THIRTY FIVE BY SEVEN MEMBER
QUIRK SILVA AND ACTUALLY THE
COUNTY COMMUNITY SCHOOLS. THIS
QUIRK SILVA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY TO THIRTY FIVE
IS A COMMON SENSE FIX TO THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
FOR COUNTY COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
THIS BILL WILL RESTORE THE
SIMPLE POLICY THAT FUNDING
FOLLOWS STUDENTS
STUDENTS ARE REFERRED TO THE
SCHOOLS BY THEIR ORIGINAL
DISTRICTS FOR ABOUT VARIETY OF
REASONS. BUT THEY ARE OFTEN AT
RISK IN DANGER OF FAILING TO
GRADUATE. OR BEHIND IN CREDITS
LOCAL EFFORTS TO RESOLVE
SITUATIONS WHERE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HOUSE ON THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF EDUCATING THE
STUDENTS BUT NOT THE FUNDING
REQUIRED THIS ADDITIONAL
STATUARY STATUTORY AUTHORITY.
IT HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND NO OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU MISS QUIRK SILVA SEE
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
COURT CLUB THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. RESIGNED A VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSER ROLLING TIED
ABOUT ICE FIFTY EIGHT. KNOWS
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM SIXTY ONE IS AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY EIGHT CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIFTY EIGHT
BY FAMILY MEMBER CABALLERO AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
MISS CABALLERO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT.
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY EIGHT WHICH
WOULD PROVIDE THE LOCAL AGENCY
FORMATION COMMISSIONS OR LAUGHED
GOES WITH A ONE TIME SMALL
INFUSION OF GRANT MONIES TO
FOCUS EFFORTS ON STREAMLINING
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND IMPROVING
EFFICIENCY AND DELIVERY SERVICE.
CONSISTENT WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION MADE IN THE TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN THAT'LL
HOOVER COMMISSION REPORT THERE
IS A NEED FOR LAB GOES TO CAN.
CONDUCT MORE IN DEPTH STUDIES OF
LOCAL AGENCY SERVICE PROVIDERS
THAT COULD RESULT IN MORE
OPTIONS FOR GREATER EFFICIENCIES
ELIMINATION OF NON FUNCTIONING
ORGANIZATIONS OR RE ORGANIZATION
EFFORTS.
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY EIGHT.
BOB WOULD PROVIDE LAUGHED GOES
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS KNOWN
SERVICE AND GOVERNANCE CONCERNS
THAT COULD POTENTIALLY SAVE
CALIFORNIA'S.
TAXPAYERS MONEY THE GRANT FUNDS
WOULD BE USED CAN DUCK SPECIAL
STUDIES. AND TO POTENTIALLY
INITIATE ACTIONS BIT BASED ON
THOSE STUDIES THATREMOVER
REDUCED LOCAL COSTS
THE GRANT PROGRAM WHICH SUNSET
ON DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY.
TWENTY THREE THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CABALLERO SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK LOCAL THEY'RE ALL. VOTE.
THOSE ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS REYES ART ABOUT
CLERK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
AYE AYES FORTY THREE KNOWS
EIGHTEEN. THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO IS AB TWENTY
TO SEVENTY ONE CLERK READ AS A
LEGAL TWENTY SEVENTY ONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA AND
ACTING SCHOOL FOOD AUTHORITIES
MISS QUIRK SILVA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY
ONE WILL HELP REAP DUES FOOD
WASTE IN OUR K. TWELVE SCHOOLS
BY EXPANDING EXISTING GRANT
OPPORTUNITIES. NOW AVAILABLE
THROUGH THE NATIONAL SCHOOL
LUNCH PROGRAM EQUIPMENT
ASSISTANCE GRANTS
THIS COMPETITIVE GRANT IS
AVAILABLE TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT WISH TO PURCHASE COMMERCIAL
GRADE EQUIPMENT. TO STORE IN
PREP FRESH NUTRITIOUS MEALS FOR
STUDENTS.
SOME OF US REMEMBER WHEN SCHOOL
WAS THAT FROM WHEN OUR SCHOOLS
ACTUALLY PREPARED SCHOOL UP
BILLS ON CAMPUS THAT WAS QUITE
AWHILE AGO. BY ALLOWING AN
INCREASE IN THE GRANT AMOUNT
AVAILABLE IN PROVIDING SCHOOL
FOOD AUTHORITIES THE FLEXIBILITY
TO COMBINE GRANTS TO CREATE A
CENTRALIZED FOOD PREPARATION
SPACE WE EMPOWER SCHOOL DIST
BRICKS TO. FIND CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS TO CURBING FOOD WASTE
IN OUR K. TWELVE SCHOOLS THIS
GRANT ALSO ENCOURAGE ENCOURAGES
HEALTHY COOKING AND COULD LEAD
TO A REDUCTION IN OBESITY FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THEY WAS QUIRK SILVA SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK LIBERAL.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ADDED VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE ANTI ABOUT ICE FORTY
FIVE. KNOWS SEVEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES WERE TO PASS RETAIN FILE
ITEM SIXTY THREE PALLIDUM SIXTY
FOURS AB TWENTY THREE FIFTEEN.
CORKERY.
AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY THREE
FIFTEEN BY FAMILY MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA AND ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE
HEALTH.
MISS QUIRK SILVA YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY THREE FIFTEEN
WOULD INSTRUCT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IN
CONJUNCTION WITH D. H. C. S. AND
APPROPRIATE STAKEHOLDERS TO
DEVELOP GUIDELINES AND BEST
PRACTICES. FOR MENTAL AND
BEHAVIORAL TELL A HELL HEALTH
DELIVERY IN CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
AGAIN THESE ARE GUIDELINES ONLY
BY CREATING A STATE PARTNERSHIP
TO EXPLORE THE GUIDELINES
NECESSARY. TO IMPLEMENT THIS
TECHNOLOGY IN OUR K. TWELVE
CAMPUSES AB TWENTY THREE FIFTEEN
IS A GREAT STEP FORWARD TOWARDS
MAKING SURE THAT OUR YOUTH HAVE
ACCESS TO QUALIFIED
PROFESSIONALS WHEN THERE IS A
CRISIS ON CAMPUS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS QUIRK SILVA
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THE.
CLERK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND HOW YOU VOTE
EYES FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM SIXTY
FIVE TO SEVENTY PASS RETAIN FILE
ITEM SEVENTY ONE IS AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY EIGHT.
I MISTER GIBSON AND WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY TWO IS AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY THREE.
BY MISTER EDUARDO GARCIA.
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY THREE BY
FAMILY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA AND
OTHERS AND EXPLAINED AIR
POLLUTION. MISTER GARCIA.
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY THREE DIRECTS AIR
DISTRICTS TO PROACTIVELY WORK
WITH SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
TO IDENTIFY WHAT INTERVENTIONS
MAY BE AVAILABLE TO REDUCE
POLLUTION EXPOSURE IN.
PRIORITY HEAVILY POLLUTED BURDEN
COMMUNITIES IDENTIFY THROUGH THE
IMPLEMENTATION.
OF AB SIX ONE SEVEN.
ANY FUNDING RECEIVED FOR AB SIX
ONE SEVEN IMPLEMENTATION CAN BE
USED FOR THOSE MITIGATION
MEASURES INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO AIR. FILTRATION
SYSTEMS
AND VEGETATIVE BARRIERS THIS
BILL DOESN'T CREATE ANY FUNDING
MANDATES
SIMPLY OPEN THE DOOR TO
POTENTIAL FUNDING IF ITS LOCAL
PRIORITY.
AS WE WORK TO ACHIEVE OTHER
STAPLES RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISS GARCIA SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLUB LOVE THE ROLL-ON DIED VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I FIFTY FIVE.
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
EVERYONE MOVE BACK FILE ITEM
SEVENTY ONE.
TO MR GIBSON THIS IS AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY EIGHT THE CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR FORTY
EIGHT BY SOME A MEMBER GIPSON
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
JUVENILES.
MISTER GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR SPEAKING
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR FORTY
EIGHT. OF WHICH WILL ENSURE THAT
YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE AND YOUTH
INTO AND OUT OF. LOCAL JUVENILE
DETENTION CENTER FACILITIES HAVE
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET LASHER
THIS BODY PASSED.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT ELEVEN
WHICH EXPANDED WHICH WAS
EXPANDED VERSION THE GOVERNOR
VETOED THAT PARTICULAR BILL AND
WE NARROWED IT IS THE BILL WE
HAVE BEFORE US TODAY. ON THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION
AND.
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ASK FOR YOUR.
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GIPSON SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CLERK
LIBERAL.
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR GIPSON.
MISTER GIPSON MOVES A CALL.
BACK IN FILE ORDER SEVENTY THREE
FILE ITEM SEVENTY THREE IS AB
TWENTY FOUR SIX
THREE.
ASSEMBLY ALL TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
THREE BY SOME THE MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT MISS QUIRK
SILVA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
THREE ESTABLISHES THE SMALL
BUSINESS ASSISTANCE. ASSISTANCE
ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM WHICH WOULD
BE ADMINISTERED BY GOBIZ BOTH
THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEES HAVE APPROVED
SEVENTEEN MILLION FOR THIS
PROGRAM WHICH WILL FUND
BUSINESSES ASSISTANT SERVICES
FOR OUR SMALL BUSINESSES. AS WE
KNOW. OUR SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
THE HEART OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND
I AM PROUD TO HAVE RECEIVED OVER
FOUR HUNDRED LETTERS OF SUPPORT
AND EVEN MORE PROUD TO BE
WORKING JOINTLY TO AUTHOR THIS
BILL WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES. A WE HAVE A JOINTLY
PRESENTED THIS TO OUR COMMITTEES
WITH A COMPLETE SUPPORT AND WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AS WELL.
MR MOUNTAINOUS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKERAND
MEMBERS ALONGSIDE MY COLLEAGUE
FROM NORTH ORANGE COUNTY WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON EXPANDING
RESOURCES. FOR OUR SMALL
BUSINESS COMMUNITY FOR SOMETIME.
AS MENTIONED BEFORE THIS BILL
SETS A FRAMEWORK FOR PROVIDING
CRITICAL RESOURCES TO CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESSES THROUGH
PARTNERSHIP AGREEMENTS WHAT
FEDERALLY DESIGNATED SMALL
BUSINESS TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CENTERS.
THE INLAND EMPIRE TRULY AND
ECONOMIC FORCE IS ONE OF THE
FASTEST GROWING REGIONS WITH
OVER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND SMALL
BUSINESSES. AND I KNOW THAT THE
UNIQUE CHALLENGES OF THE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER OUR SHARED
EXPERIENCE THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY THREE THE STATE WILL
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT OUR SMALL
BUSINESS COMMUNITY NOR SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THREE AIBO.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE CLERK LOVE IN THE ROLE.
ON THIS OUT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TYLER NICE
FIFTY NINE.
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM SEVENTY FOURS AB TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTY NINE BY MISTER
VOEPEL PURPLE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOEPEL AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION MISTER
VOEPEL.
MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES
I RISE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY NINE WHICH ESTABLISHES A
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID PILOT
PROGRAM. TO EXAMINE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF AN INCOME CHAIR
AGREEMENT AS A FUNDING SOURCE
FOR STUDENTS EARNING HER
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN OUR UC AND
CSU SYSTEM.
COMMENCING WHAT THE TWENTY
TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY FIRST
YEAR.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE CS USE
TO TAKE PART IN THIS BILL AND
WOULD ASK UC'S TO PARTICIPATE.
PARTICIPATION WILL BE BASED ON
THE LEVEL OF PRIVATE. INVESTMENT.
IN INCOME SHARED AGREEMENT IS
NOT ALONE OR OTHER DEBT
INSTRUMENT IN INCOME SHARED
AGREEMENT REPRESENTS A STUDENTS
OBLIGATION TO MAKE PAYMENTS
LINKED TO A SPECIFIC PERCENTAGE.
OF THE STUDENTS FUTURE EARNED
INCOME.
THE INCOME SHARED AGREEMENT
MONTHLY PAYMENTS ARE ADJUSTED
ACCORDING TO THE STUDENTS
POSTGRADUATE INCOME AND DID NOT
BEGIN UNTIL THE STUDENT IS
EMPLOYED. EARNING THE MINIMUM
SALARY OF.
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THIS IS VERY VERY SUCCESSFUL IN
OTHER STATES AND ESPECIALLY
PURDUE UNIVERSITY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER VOEPEL SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLICK LOCAL ON MEMBERS.
HIS ART ABOUT A MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF AND I SIXTY
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY FIVE IS AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY ONE COOPERATE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
ONE BY SOME A MEMBER OF THE
PALIN OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
STATE EMPLOYEES. MISSED VOEPEL
YOU MAY GET OPEN. MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY I HAVE THE
PLEASURE OF PRESENTING AB TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY ONE.
A BILL THAT WOULD IMPLEMENT A
PILOT PROGRAM AUTHORIZE IN A
STATE AGENCY TO ADOPT THE INFANT
AT WORK PROGRAM.
THE INFANT AT WORK PROGRAM
ALLOWS EMPLOYEES OF THE AGENCY
WHO ARE NEW PARENTS OR
CAREGIVERS TO BRING THE INFANT
AID SIX WEEKS TO SIX MONTHS OR
UNTIL CRAWLING. TO THE WORKPLACE
SIMILAR PILOT PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
ADOPTED ANOTHER STATES AFTER IT
WAS FOUND THAT THE PILOT PROGRAM
INCREASED PARENT INFANT FUNDING
EASIER BREASTFEEDING AND
ACCESSIBILITY FOR MOTHERS.
OVERALL REDUCED HEALTH CARE
COSTS FOR BABIES AND INCREASED
EMPLOYEE MORALE AND PARA
PRODUCTIVITY.
FOR THESE REASONS MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THIS IS
SUPPORT SUPPORT MS BAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER BECAUSE
IT'S A GOOD BILL TO STE DOUBLE
SUPPORT THANK YOU TO THE.
ARE GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AREA.
THIS IS IMPORTANT FOR US TO DO
IT'S ACTUALLY NOT ALLOWED UNDER
CURRENT LAW FOR THIS TO HAPPEN
IN CALIFORNIA IT'S SOMETHING WE
SHOULD DO. I JUST RECENTLY HAD
ONE OF OUR OWN DISTRICT OFFICE
STAFF WHO IS A A NEW MOM OF HER
CHILD CARE FELL THROUGH FOR THE
MORNING AND SHE NEEDED TO BRING
HER CHILD TO WORK IT WORKED OUT
FINE WE SHOULD MAKE THIS
POSSIBLE FOR ALL STATE EMPLOYEES.
THANK YOU I URGE AN AYE VOTE A
DOUBLE SUPPORT SUPPORT THANK YOU
MS BAKER.
OUR CLUB NARAL.
ALL MEMBERS.
OUR TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE AROUND TOWN
ABOUT AYE SIXTY ONE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL. ON FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
SIX THIS IS AB TWENTY NINE FORTY
TWO MISTER TANKER PROPOSED.
ALL MEMBERS.
VOTE.
VOTERS ARE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES
FORTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY FOUR THAT
MEASURE PASSES WERE ALSO GOING
TO LIFT THE CALL.
ON FILE ITEM NUMBER TO SEVENTEEN
THAT IS AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY
THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DECIDE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLLING TIED ABOUT AYE
AYES FORTY THREE NOS THIRTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
VIOLATE I'M SEVENTY SIX THROUGH
SEVENTY EIGHT PASS AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS I AM AFRAID TO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM FORTY SIX THIS
IS AB NINETEEN TWELVE BY MISTER
RODRIGUEZ CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
WELL CLOSER ALL TIME ABOUT AYE
AYES FORTY ONE. KNOWS TWENTY.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
AND I'M TO RELIVE THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM TO TWENTY TWO THIS IS
AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY FIVE DOCTOR
REMEMBER THE CLERK WILL POST.
OUR MEMBERS VOTER TO SARAH VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLAND TALENT OF.
I FORTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY FOUR
THAT MEASURE PASSES WERE ALSO
GOING TO LIFT THE CALL ON FILE
ITEM THREE OF SEVEN MAYBE TWENTY
TO SEVENTY FIVE ALSO DOCTOR
ARAMBULA CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS THERE TO VOTE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL ANTI ABOUT EYES FORTY
TWO NOS NINETEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
AND. WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM FIFTY EIGHT
THIS'S AB TWENTY TWO OH TO BY MR
GRAY CORPORATE.
POST.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE VOTE.
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW YOU VOTE. I FIFTY EIGHT.
KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
THIRTY MINUTE RECESS UNDER CALL
OF THE SPEAKER THERE WILL BE.
LUNCH FOR THE DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS
OF THE LOUNGE LUNCH FOR THE
REPUBLICAN MATT.
THE RULES COMMITTEE.
PLEASE RETURN TO THE FLOOR
PROMPTLY AT TWELVE THIRTY WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE UP BUSINESS.
RIGHT AT TWELVE THIRTY.
THIS IS RECESS UNDER CALL
MEMBERS IT'S TWELVE THIRTY.
WE'RE BACK IN SESSION PLEASE
RETURN TO THE FLOOR.
SO WE MAY TAKE UP BUSINESS
RETURN OF THE FLOOR.
LOTS OF BUSINESS BEFORE THE
ASSEMBLY TODAY
MEMBERS PLEASE RETURN TO THE
FLOOR SO WE MAY RESUME BUSINESS
BEFORE THE HOUSE
WE ARE BACK.
FILE.
MR MCCARTY WILL BE TAKING OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY NINE
THIS IS A BE.
TWENTY FIVE FORTY SEVEN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE FORTY
SEVEN BY SOME THE MEMBER MCCARTY
AND ACTUALLY NEW TEACHERS MR
MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
MEASURE WOULD CREATE THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHER CORPS PROGRAM
WE KNOW ABOUT THE TEACHER
SHORTAGE PUTTING OUR STATE FOR
MANY YEARS.
TO DEAL WITH THIS PROBLEM TOO
MANY SCHOOLS OFTEN RESORT TO
HIRING STAFF THAT ARE UNPREPARED
TO MEET THE CHALLENGES OF THE
CLASSROOM IN FACT TODAY ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THERE OVER SIX
THOUSAND. EMERGENCY CREDENTIAL
TEASED TEACHERS.
WE ALSO KNOW THE RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT UNDERPREPARED TEACHERS ARE
MORE LIKELY TO LEAVE THE
PROFESSION THEIR FIRST.
A FEW YEARS.
OFF EXPERIENCING FRUSTRATION
AND LOCKED LACK OF JOB
SATISFACTION.
THIS MEASURE WILL HELP PROVIDE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH MATCHING
GRANTS TO CREATE MAINTAIN OR
EXPAND.
EACH YEAR RESIDENCY PROGRAMS.
THESE PROGRAMS OFFER STRONG
CLINICAL PREPARATION AN EARLY
TEACHERS SUCCEED AND HOPEFULLY
STICK WITH THE PROFESSION.
I PASSED OUT OF COMMITTEE WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND ASK FOR
SUPPORT AGAIN TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MCCARTY SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SEE FIVE NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES PASSWORD PASS TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEM EIGHTY.
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM EIGHTY
ONE.
FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO.
IS AB TWENTY FIVE PART ME AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT.
BY MEASURE DAVID CHIU CORKERY.
AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY EIGHT BY SOME A MEMBER
DAVID CHIU AND OTHERS THAT
CLAIMED INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
MISTER DAVID CHIU.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE
THIS LEGISLATURE PASSED A LAW
CREATING AN INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICT ALONG THE
PORT OF SAN FRANCISCO. DEFINE
IMPROVEMENTS FOR AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE THIS BILL WOULD
AMEND THE I FD TO REBUILD THE
SAN FRANCISCO SEA WALL AND
PROTECT OUR SHORELINE. BUILT
OVER A CENTURY AGO OUR SEA WALL
IS CRITICAL LOCAL REGIONAL AND
STATE INFRASTRUCTURE. IT
PROTECTS OVER A HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS OF ECONOMIC ACTIVITY IN
ASSETS
IS SIGNIFICANTLY DETERIORATING
AND HIGHLY VULNERABLE TO
EARTHQUAKE AND SEA LEVEL RISE.
IT'S WHERE MILLIONS LIVE WORK
AND PLAY INCLUDING TWENTY FOUR
MILLION VISITORS TO CALIFORNIA
EVERY YEAR. THE SEA WALL ALSO
PROTECTS CRITICAL UTILITY
NETWORKS AND REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR THE BAY AREA. THIS IS PART
OF A BROADER PLAN FOR FUNDING
FROM LOCAL FEDERAL AND PRIVATE
SECTOR SOURCES ON BEHALF OF MY
CITY IN THE BAY AREA. I WANT TO
THANK THE BROAD SUPPORT OF ALL
STAKEHOLDERS THE STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN ALL
COMMITTEES AND THE ZERO NO VOTES
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
NAMES CHIU SAY NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CAR CLUB IN THE ROLL-ON.
WHOSE HARD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED THE SENATE OF
THOSE.
CLERK WILL CLOSER ROLE AND
TALBOT AYE SIXTY ONE. NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
EIGHTY THREE IS AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVEN NINE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY NINE BY SOME A MEMBER
BURKE AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
THE MEDICAL MISS BURKE. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS IN SHARING OUR CHILDREN
ARE COVERED WITH ADEQUATE HEALTH
INSURANCE BUT UNFORTUNATELY.
OVER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND STILL
REMAIN UNINSURED. OVER NINETY
THOUSAND OF THOSE UNINSURED ARE
ALREADY ENROLLED IN THE
SUPPLEMENTAL NUTRITION PROGRAM
FOR WOMEN INFANTS AND CHILDREN
KNOWN AS WICK. WICK AND MEDI CAL
HAVE THE SAME ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY NINE ESTABLISHES AN
EXPRESS LANE ELIGIBILITY PATHWAY
FOR. FROM WEEK TO MEDI CAL AND
WOULD ALLOW CHILDREN APPLYING TO
THE WICK PROGRAM TO SUBMIT A
SINGLE APPLICATION TO
SIMULTANEOUSLY ATTAIN EXPRESSLY
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM.
ADDITIONALLY THERE ARE ROUGHLY
THIRTEEN THOUSAND PREGNANT WOMEN
WHO ARE ON WEIGHT BUT NOT ROLL
THE MEDI CAL DESPITE THEIR
ELIGIBILITY. AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY NINE ENSURES THAT
PREGNANT WOMEN ENROLLED IN LAKE
WOULD BE PRESUMPTIVELY AND
ROLLED INTO MEDI CAL WHICH WOULD
PROVIDE TEMPORARY BUT IT. MEDIA
COVERAGE WHILE THEY COMPLETE THE
APPLICATION PROCESS
STREAMLINED APPLICATION AROMA
PROCESS FOR MEDI CAL AND WAKE IS
A CRITICAL STRATEGY FOR
INCREASING A MOMENT OF UNINSURED
ELIGIBLE CHILDREN AND PREGNANT
WOMEN INTO THESE PROGRAMS.
LINKING APPLICATION AND
ELIGIBILITY TO TERM TERMINATIONS
FOR THESE PROGRAMS WILL FOSTER
BOTH SOUND NUTRITION AND HEALTH
FOR CHILDREN AND PREGNANT WOMEN
IN CALIFORNIA.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I
WILL.
THERE WAS BURKE SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE CORE CLUB
NARAL.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLLING TIED
ABOUT AYE SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
EIGHTY FOURS AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
WILL TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY BY
FAMILY MEMBER CUNNINGHAM
ACTUALLY THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
MEASURE CUNNINGHAM.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY WILL CLARIFY THE STANDARD
FOR GOOD CAUSE FOR OBTAINING A
CONTINUANCE OF THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION HEARING.
THIS WILL PROVIDE MORE
FLEXIBILITY.
IT STILL TAKES SETTLEMENTAND
GET KIDS THE SERVICES THEY NEED.
IT WAS PASSED OUT OF BOTH
COMMITTEES UNANIMOUSLY AND
SUPPORTED BY THE DISABILITY
RIGHTS ADVOCATE.
ADVOCATES I'D APPRECIATE AND I
BOTH THANK YOU.
NAMES CUNNINGHAM.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
WILL OPEN ROLL-ON.
WHO'S OUT ABOUT ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THEM.
ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE AROUND TIED
ABOUT AYE SIXTY EIGHT KNOW ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
EIGHTY FIVE IS. AB TWENTY SIX OH
ONE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY SIX OH ONE
BY SOME A MEMBER WEBER AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE
INSTRUCTION. DOCTOR WEBER YES
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT TO YOU AB TWENTY
SIX OH ONE. WHICH EXTENDS A
CALIFORNIA HEALTHY YOUTH ACTS
COMPREHENSIVE SEX HEHE SEXUAL
HELP HEALTH EDUCATION AND HIV
PREVENTION TO CHARTER SCHOOLS.
AB TWENTY SIX A ONE ENSURES A
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOL
STUDENTS RECEIVE COMPREHENSIVE
SEXUAL HEALTH EDUCATION AND HIV
PREVENTION EDUCATION LEASE ONCE
IN MIDDLE SCHOOL AND HIGH SCHOOL.
THIS BILL MERELY SETS OF
FOUNDATIONAL BASELINE FOR SEXUAL
HEALTH EDUCATION IN CHARTER
SCHOOLS WHILE MAINTAINING
SIGNIFICANT FLEXIBILITY FOR
CHARTERS TO DECIDE WHAT
CURRICULUM THEY ADOPT. WHAT
SPECIFIC GRADE TO PROVIDE
INSTRUCTION AT OTHER CURRICULA
ELEMENTS?
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT ANY
PARENT CAN OPT THEIR CHART
STUDENT OUT OF THE SEXUAL EDGY
HEALTH EDUCATION PROGRAM.
AS CALIFORNIA SEEKS TO ADDRESS
SEXUAL HARASSMENT ABUSE
COMPREHENSIVE SEX SEXUAL HEALTH
EDUCATION WITH ITS FOCUS ON
HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS CONSENT.
AND CHALLENGING NEGATIVE GENDER
STEREOTYPES IS THE CENTRAL FOR
PREVENTING THESE NEGATIVE.
BEHAVIORS BEFORE THEY START AB
TWENTY SIX OH WANNA SPONSORED
NATURALLY BY THE ACLU IN ACT FOR
WOMEN AND GIRLS BUT IS ALSO
SPONSORED BY THIS OF CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION. THE PTA THE
CTA AND A HOST OF OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS OVER SIXTY
ORGANIZATION SUPPORT THIS EFFORT.
THERE HAS BEEN NO OPPOSITION TO
THIS AND HAS BEEN BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. I'M.
LARA VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE TOWN
OF A NICE FORTY SEVEN DOES
FOURTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM EIGHTY SIXES AB TWENTY
SIX TO. BY MR MCCARTY.
KERKORIAN AS A LEGAL TWENTY SIX
OH TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY
AND EXPLAIN TO HOMELESS YOUTH MR
MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER WE HAVE
A HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IN OUR. IN
OUR GREAT STATE TO WE ALSO HAVE
IT OF COURSE HERE IN MY HOME
DISTRICT OF SACRAMENTO THIS IS A
DISTRICT BILL CREATING THE
HOMELESS YOUTH EMERGENCY SERVICE
PROJECT IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO
ORGANIZATION SUPPORTING THE
RAPIDLY EXPANDING POPULATION OF
HOMELESS LGBT YOUTH IN THE AREA.
HOW WE KNOW RESEARCH SHOWS THAT?
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE NOT OFTEN
ADDRESSED IN OUR TRADITIONAL
HOMELESS PROGRAMS AND THAT THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW SACRAMENTO TO
JOINT. FIVE OTHER COUNTIES
ACROSS THE STATE DEALING WITH
OUR EMERGENCY.
DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS AMONG START LGBT
YOU THANK YOU.
THEY WAS MCCARTY DOCTOR WEBER.
MICROPHONE VERY GET SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WELL EPIDURAL. MEMBERS THE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
PERCENT OF THEM.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF
ON I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES WERE TO PASS
TEMPORARILY FILE ITEM EIGHTY
SEVEN.
FILE ITEMS EIGHTY EIGHT AND
EIGHTY EIGHTY DYING PASS AND
RETAIN WHERE FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINETY.
THAT IS AB TWENTY SIX FIFTEEN BY
MS.
CARILLO.
WE CAN PASS TEMPORARILY.
ONE ALSO PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINETY ONE.
EVER IS WHEN YOU GO BACK TO FILE
ITEM NINETY. THAT'S AB TWENTY
SIX FIFTEEN BY MISS CARILLO
INCORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY WHAT'S MY SIX FIFTEEN
BY FAMILY MEMBER CARILLO AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY STATE
HIGHWAYS THIS CARILLO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTEEN A BILL THAT
WOULD HELP MAXIMIZE SAFE AND
CONVENIENT ACCESS FOR BICYCLES.
AND PEDESTRIANS TO CALIFORNIA
PARKS
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO NUMEROUS
PARKS THAT A FOR FUN AND
ENRICHING EXPERIENCE TO THOSE
WHO CAN MAKE USE OF THEM. IN
SOME CASES BEAST PICTURESQUE
PARKS ARE WITHIN SIGHT OF MANY
RESIDENTS BUT JUST OUT OF REACH.
THESE PARKS AND HAVE ACCESS
ISSUES ARE PHYSICAL BARRIERS
NEAR THEM SUCH AS ROADWAYS ARE
UNSAFE TERRAIN THAT MAKE IT
HAZARDOUS FOR PEOPLE TO ENTER
THEM ON FOOT OR BY WRITING BIKES.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION OR CALTRANS IS
CHARGED WITH COORDINATING A
DEVELOPING TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING AND POLICY. HOWEVER
ISSUES RELATING TO SAVE PARK
ACCESS ARE NOT OFTEN CONSIDERED
WHEN PLANNING AND POLICY MAKING
FOR TRANSPORTATIONPROJECTS
OCCUR.
AB TWENTY SIX FIFTEEN WILL
MANDATE THAT CALTRANS
COLLABORATE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF PARKS AND RECREATION. AND
OFFER PUBLIC ENTITIES THAT TO
FACILITATE GREATER COMMUNICATION.
AND COORDINATION THAT EMPHASIZES
THE CONCERNS OF SAFE PEDESTRIAN
AND BICYCLE ACCESS TO PARKS FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS.
NO ONE SHOULD BE DENIED ACCESS
TO A SAFE.
A SAFE FUN PARK EXPERIENCE OUR
PARKS ARE PRECIOUS RESOURCES TO
OUR STATE AND OUR RESIDENTS. AND
WE MUST DO ALL WE CAN TO MAKE
SURE EVERYONE. CAN ENJOY THEM.
THIS IS A BILL THAT HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND ZERO NO
VOTES
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
TAKING HIS CRISTINA DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CORP LOVE THE
ROLL-ON VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE TO ROLAND TYPE
BUT I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
WE PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
NINETY ONE FILE ITEM NINETY TWO
IS AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY EIGHT BY
MISTER RODRIGUEZ COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX TWENTY
EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ
AND ACTUALLY THE STATE EMPLOYEES
MISS RODRIGUEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TO THAT PRESENTING AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY EIGHT. WHICH
IS SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION.
THIS MEASURE IS INTENDED TO
MEMORIALIZE THE CCP ALWAYS
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING.
THESE AGREEMENTS ARE NEEDED TO
ENSURE THAT A RETIRED
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
OF ADEQUATE HEALTH BENEFITS
AFTER THEIR SERVICE OUR SECTOR
AFTER AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS RODRIGUEZ SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ADAM
CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON.
IS THERE TO VOTE ON THE
IT'S VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE ANTI
ABOUT ICE FORTY SIX KNOWS ELEVEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM
NINETY THREE IS AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY FIVE BY DOCTOR WEBER
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX THIRTY FIVE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER WEBER AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO EDUCATION
FINANCE. DOCTOR WEBER YES MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT TO YOU AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY FIVE THE LC FF LOWEST
PERFORMING SUBGROUP BILL.
AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY FIVE WILL
CREATE A NEW SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT
CATEGORY IN THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA FOR THE LOWEST
PERFORMING SUB GROUP OF STUDENTS
NOT CURRENTLY RECEIVING A
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT.
SOME OF YOU WHO ARE HERE THE FEW
WHO WERE HERE FIVE YEARS AGO
KNOW THAT THIS BILL TO THE
CONCEPT OF LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA WAS IMPLEMENTED.
PUT TWO THINGS ONE TO GET RID
OF THE.
CATEGORICAL IS AND THE OTHER
PIECE WAS TO RECOGNIZE THE FACT
THAT SOME STUDENTS REQUIRE MORE
RESOURCES IN ORDER TO BABY
CLOTHES ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
AT THE TIME IN OUR BEST WAS AND
WE THOUGHT THAT THOSE STUDENT
WITH FALL INTO CERTAIN
CATEGORIES OF EITHER BEING
LANGUAGE BILINGUAL. POVERTY OR
FOSTER CARE HOMELESS KIDS AND AS
A RESULT WE SUPPOSE WE CREATED A
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT PROGRAM FOR
THOSE STUDENTS.
AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY FIVE
TACKLES A FLAW THAT WE FOUND
THAT HAS BEEN DISCOVERED IN THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
SINCE IT WAS INSTITUTED TWENTY
THIRTEEN. IN AN EFFORT TO TARGET
RESOURCES TO THE HIGHEST NEED
STUDENTS IN THE STATE.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS IN THE STATE.
TWO ONE IN SIXTY ARE RECEIVING A
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT BECAUSE THEY
ARE LOW INCOME ELL ARE HOMELESS
A FOSTER YOUTH. HOWEVER THERE'S
A SUB GROUP THAT'S A LITTLE.
CLOSE TO A HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS WOULD NOT RECEIVING A
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT I NEED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND FIND
THEMSELVES IN THE LOWEST
CATEGORY OF ACHIEVEMENT IN STATE.
IN ORDER TO SUPPORT THE ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE AND CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP IT BECOMES
NECESSARY THAT WE LOOK AT OUR
SUBGROUP FUNDING. AND THAT WE
CREATED ADDITIONAL CATEGORY.
THIS IS THE ONLY GROUP OF
STUDENTS PERFORMING BELOW THE
STATE AVERAGE THAT ARE NOT
ALREADY RECEIVING A SUPPLEMENTAL
GRANT.
IN ADDITION AFRICAN MEN STUDENTS
HAVE THE LOWEST HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION RATE OF ANY STUDENT
GROUP AT SEVENTY TWO POINT NINE
PERCENT AND ALSO THE HIGHEST
SUSPENSION RATE AT NINE POINT
EIGHT PERCENT.
WITH THREE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS IN NEW PROP DIE NAY
FUNDING THIS YEAR NOW IS THE
TIME TO FIX THIS EDUCATIONAL IN
EQUITY. AND FULFILL THE PROMISE
OF THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA TO TARGET RESOURCES THE
STUDENTS THAT ARE MOST IN NEED.
THIS BILL RECEIVE UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. IT IS A
HIGH PRIORITY OF THE LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS AND IS ENDORSED BY
NUMEROUS EDUCATIONAL
ORGANIZATION AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
DON'T WEBER MISTER HOLDEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND I'D
LIKE TO. JOIN IN SUPPORT WITH
THAT OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO. AND THIS VERY IMPORTANT
BILL AS CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I RISE
IN SUPPORT. OF ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX THIRTY FIVE AS IT IS
OUR TOP PRIORITY FOR THE CAUCUS
THIS YEAR. CURRENTLY AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS ARE THE LOWEST
PERFORMING SUBGROUP DUE TO YEARS
OF DETRIMENTAL POLICIES.
EVEN THOUGH THE SUBGROUP
INCLUDES PEOPLE'S AT ALL INCOME
LEVELS IT SCORES ARE BELOW THE
SCORES OF ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED PUPILS WHICH
SUGGEST THAT POVERTY ALONE DOES
NOT EXPLAIN. THIS OUTCOME.
ABOUT NINETY TWO THOUSAND BLACK
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
NEITHER LOW INCOME NOR ENGLISH
LEARNERS AND THEREFORE DO NOT
GENERATE SUPPLEMENTAL LC FFL LCF
F. FUNDING.
WE CONSTANTLY TALK ABOUT
COLLECTING DATA AND USING DATA
INFORM MATHIS.
WE HAVE THE DATA THAT SHOWS WHEN
ADJUSTING FOR INCOME AFRICAN
AMERICANS ARE STILL THE LOWEST
PERFORMING SUB GROUP. THAT DOES%
NOT RECEIVE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THEIR LCF F..
WE SHOULD DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO ENSURE THE GROUPS WE KNOW ARE
FALLING BEHIND HAVE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTS. TO IMPROVE ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE AND ULTIMATELY
IMPROVE LIFE OUTCOMES.
RATHER THAN INVESTING IN PRISONS
CALIFORNIA SHOULD DEDICATE MORE
FUNDS TO EDUCATION BY USING DATA
WE ALREADY HAVE IDENTIFIED LOW
PERFORMING STE SUBGROUPS AND
DIRECT ADDITIONAL FUNDING. AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THESE REASONS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ABOUT.
AIMS HOLDEN MISS THEM ON.
THANK YOU SPEAKER I RISE IN ALSO
IN SUPPORTER.
TO COLLEAGUES WHO ARE BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AS SOMEONE WHO WAS
A BOARD MEMBER WHEN THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FOR IT FORMULA
ROLLED OUT. I UNDERSTOOD THAT
THE IDEA WAS NOT JUST TO HELP
ALL STUDENTS BUT PARTICULARLY
ALL SUBGROUPS AND WE WERE ABLE
TO DO THAT FOR ENGLISH LEARNERS
FOSTER YOUTH. AND A LOW INCOME
STUDENTS HOWEVER THERE IS STILL
A GAP AND THIS BILL MEET ME AIMS
TO ADDRESS THAT GAP OF ENSURING
THAT OUR STUDENTS WHO ARE IN
SCHOOLS WHO ARE AFRICAN AMERICAN.
HAVE THE ABILITY TO ALSO BENEFIT
THERE IS SUB GROUP THAT IS
STRUGGLING TO PERFORM AND
BECAUSE THE RESOURCES ARE NOT
THERE SO I STAND IN SOLIDARITY
AND I HOPE THAT WE WILL ALTHOUGH
I FOR THIS BILL.
MISTER THURMOND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT. OF
AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY FIVE AND
LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FOR
SAN DIEGO FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON
THIS MEASURE. I'M HONORED TO BE
A CO AUTHOR A I BELIEVE THAT
THIS BILL IS VERY MUCH IN THE
SPIRIT OF WHAT THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA WAS ALL ABOUT.
AT TO PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CREATE EQUITY AND TO SUPPORT ALL
STUDENTS ALL STUDENTS CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL. UP BUT LCF AFTER
SUPPOSED TO SUPPORT ALL STUDENTS
WHO MAY HAVE BEAT DISADVANTAGE
FOR WHATEVER REASON I CAN'T
THINK OF ANYTHING. THAT CREATES
MORE DISADVANTAGED AND THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP IN THE FACTORS
THAT CONTRIBUTE TO IT FOR
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND OTHER
STUDENTS. AND THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO PROVIDE
CRITICAL RESOURCES THAT HELP TO
CLOSE THAT GAP I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY SIX THIRTY FIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER THURMAN SEE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENT ON THE BILL
DOCTOR WEBER YOU MAY CLOSE IF
YOU WISH
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR SUPPORT IN
THIS BILL AND PARTICULARLY FOR
THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS IN
THE OTHER CAUCUSES FOR. LOOKING
AT THIS AS REALLY AN ISSUE OF
EQUITY AND AT A SUBSIDY. WE
BELIEVE VERY STRONGLY IN ALL OF
US WHO I THINK IN THIS HOUSE
THAT IT EDUCATION IS TRULY
AMERICAN EQUALIZER. AND WHEN WE
FIND A GROUP THAT IS STRUGGLING
ON THE BOTTOM AND WE CAN
IDENTIFY THAT IS POOR OR
WHATEVER THE AS WE'VE BEEN MUST
TARGET RESOURCES. TO HELP THAT
GROUP TO SUCCEED I THINK ALL OF
US IN THIS SO LEASE I ALWAYS
FEEL A LOT LESS WHEN I LOOK AT
IT ACHIEVEMENT AND I REALIZE
THAT WOULD NOT DOING THE BEST
THAT WE CAN FOR ALL OF OUR
CHILDREN. THIS IS SOMETHING WE
DISCOVERED AFTER FIVE YEARS OF
IMPLEMENTATION THAT WE MUST
ADDRESS IF WE DO NOT ADDRESS
THAT WE WILL NEVER CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP. THAT IS CLEAR
AND SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOU I BOTH AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY
FIVE ON BEHALF OF ALL THE
CHILDREN WHO STRUGGLING AT THE
BOTTOM. AS WE MAKE EVERY EFFORT
POSSIBLE TO BRING THEM UP AND
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ENJOYED WHAT
CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS OFFERED IT
THE BEST EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM IN
THE NATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
RESPECTFULLY
S. B. I BOTH THE TWENTY SIX
THIRTY FIVE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER WITH THAT
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
THOUGH.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY VOTE I
SEVENTY. NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES WERE TO PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEM NINETY FOUR.
FILE ITEM NINETY FIVE IS AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT BY MISTER
CALDERON CROCKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX FIFTY
EIGHT BY FAMILY MEMBER CALDERON
AND ACTUALLY DEL TRONIC RECORDS.
THIS CALDERON. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY ABLE TO ESTABLISH A
BLOCKCHAIN WORKING GROUP TO
STUDY THE USES OF RISKS AND
BENEFITS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
LEGAL IMPLICATIONS OF THE USE. A
BLOCKCHAIN THE BLOCKCHAIN IS A
TYPE OF DISTRIBUTED LEDGER THAT
CONTINUOUSLY UPDATED IT IS
UPDATED. DIGITAL RECORDS AS A
COMPLEX ENGINEERING TECHNOLOGY
IT IS IMPORTANT TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND THE LEGAL
IMPLICATIONS AND THE POTENTIAL
CONSEQUENCES OF STATE OR LOCAL
REGULATION OF BLOCKCHAIN.
THE WORKING GROUP WILL REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE ON THE POTENTIAL
USES REX RISKS AND BENEFITS OF
THE USE A BLOCKCHAIN TECHNOLOGY
BY STATE GOVERNMENT IN
CALIFORNIA BASED BUSINESSES. THE
WORKING GROUP WILL ALSO
RECOMMEND AMENDMENTS TO CODE
SECTIONS IN ORDER TO FOSTER
INNOVATION AND CALIFORNIA WITH
BLOCKCHAIN THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
IT WAS CALDERON SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS OUR DEVOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE THE ROLE. AND
TALLY THE VOTES.
I SIXTY FIVE DOES ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM NINETY
SIX THAT IS AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY
THREE BY MS FRIEDMAN COVERING.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX SIXTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
THE TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
MS FRIEDMAN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS PRIOR TO TWO
THOUSAND SIX A CHANGE IN
OWNERSHIP BETWEEN DOMESTIC
PARTNERS WAS NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
THE SAME PROPERTY TAX EXCLUSION.
THAT APPLIED TO MARRIED COUPLES
THANKFULLY SUBSEQUENT
LEGISLATION FIX THIS DISCREPANCY
FOR DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIPS
REGISTERED AT THE STATE LEVEL.
HOWEVER FOR COUPLES WHO HAD
REGISTERED THE DOMESTIC
PARTNERSHIP WITH THEIR LOCAL
COUNTY OR CITY AND NOT AT THE
STATE LEVEL. THE SAME EXCLUSION
HAS NOT BEEN AVAILABLE. AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTY THREE WILL
CREATE PARITY THE LAW FOR ALL
REGISTERED DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIPS
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY
ORIGINALLY REGISTERED.
THE PROCESS WILL BE ALIGNED WITH
WHAT'S CURRENTLY IN PLACE FOR
OTHER DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIPS
INCLUDING THE INFORMATION
REQUIRED FOR THE APPLICATION.
NO ONE SHOULD BE AT RISK OF
LOSING THEIR HOME AS THE RESULT
OF THE DEATH OF THEIR PARTNER.
AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY THREE CLOSES
IN UNINTENDED LOOPHOLES AND
ENSURES THAT ALL COUPLES HAVE
EQUAL ACCESS TO BENEFITS
INCLUDING TAX RELIEF I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I WROTE.
THANK YOU MS FREEMAN SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE BILL
CLERK WILL OPEN ALL. MEMBERS
DECIDE ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ROLE ANTI THE
EYES SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS I'M
PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL.
ON FILE ITEM SEVENTY ONE THAT'S
MR GIBSON'S AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
EIGHT THE CLERK WILL POSE.
MEMBERS. WHO WISH TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WISH TO VOTE.
CLARK WILL. CLOSE THE ROLE ANTI
ABOUT ICE FORTY FOUR NOSE TWENTY
TWO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE
GOING TO ALLOW THE ASSISTANT
SPEAKER PRO TEM TO TAKE UP THE
REMAINDER OF HER BILLS ON THE
FILE.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE ALL FOR THAT'S
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTEEN BY MS
FRIEDMAN.
COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TONY TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTEEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN ACTUALLY MEDI CAL.
THIS FRIEDMAN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS.
EVEN HIS FAMILY'S TRANSITION OUT
OF CAL WORKS AS THEIR INCOME
GROWS FROM EMPLOYMENT. ACCESSING
RETAINING MEANINGFUL HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE CAN BE A CONSIDERABLE
CHALLENGE.
THE CHEAP IS COVERED CALIFORNIA
PLAN HAS AN INDIVIDUAL
DEDUCTIBLE OF SIXTY THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS AND A FAMILY
DEDUCTIBLE OF TWELVE THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS. THE MAXIMUM
CASH ASSISTANCE FOR A FAMILY
UNDER CAO WORKS IS JUST SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN DOLLARS A
MONTH.
AND PROGRAM RESTRICTIONS MEAN
THAT A FAMILY CANNOT HAVE MORE
THAN TWENTY TO. A TWO THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS IN THE
BANK ACCOUNT.
EVEN WITH THE TAX SUBSIDIES AND
COST SHARING REDUCTIONS
AVAILABLE TO HELP THROUGH COVER
CALIFORNIA THE MATH JUST DOESN'T
WORK FOR THESE FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS.
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTEEN
ALLIANCE THE CALIFORNIA POLICY
WITH WHAT'S ALLOWABLE UNDER
FEDERAL LAW. INSTEAD OF THE
EXILE EXISTING SIX MONTH WINDOW
FOR TRANSITIONAL MEDICAL
COVERAGE AN OPTION FOR AN
ADDITIONAL SIX MONTH EXTENSION
IF THE FAMILY MEETS INCOME
REQUIREMENTS. FAMILIES LEAVING
HOW WORKS WOULD HAVE TWELVE
MONTHS OF TRANSITIONAL MEDIC
MEDIC CAO COVERAGE.
KEEPING CALIFORNIANS HEALTHY
DEPENDS UPON ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE QUALITY HEALTHCARE.
FOR FAMILY STILL STRUGGLING TO
MAKE ENDS MEET AFTER LEAVING HOW
WORKS MEDI CAL PROVIDES A SAFETY
NET OF A HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
NEIGHBORS FRIEDMAN SENIOR
DISCUSSION OF IT ON THE ITEM.
CLERK IN THE WORLD. MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS ADDED VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE AND HOW
ABOUT AYE AYES FORTY EIGHT. NO
SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WHO ARE IN A MOOD TO
FILE ITEM ONE FOURTEEN AB TWENTY
EIGHT.
TO. CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY A A TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND EXPLAIN TO
INSURANCE MISTREATMENT THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS. I'M
PROUD TO PRESENT AB TWENTY EIGHT
OH TO WHICH WOULD REQUIRE AN
INSURER IN COOPERATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES. TO IDENTIFY INSURANCE
CLAIMANTS TO A PASTOR CHILD
SUPPORT INTERCEPT THEIR
INSURANCE PAYMENTS AND DIVERT
THAT INCOME TO THE CHILDREN WHO
HAVE NOT RECEIVED THE CRITICAL
INCOME AT THE RELY ON.
MANY FAMILIES TO RECEIVE CHILD
SUPPORT OFTEN DEPEND ON THIS
INCOME TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
RECENT ESTIMATES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES SHOW THEIR
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND OPEN CHILD
SUPPORT CASES WITH PASTOR
BALANCES.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
TOTAL AMOUNT OWED AND PAST DUE
CHILD SUPPORT WAS SEVENTEEN
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
OF THE SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE
BILLION OWED LAST YEAR
CALIFORNIA INTERCEPTED ONLY
NINETEEN MILLION DOLLARS THROUGH
VARIOUS CHILD SUPPORT INTERCEPT
PROGRAMS.
SEVEN OTHER STATES CURRENTLY
OPERATES SUCCESSFUL MANDATORY
INTERCEPT PROGRAMS.
WHEN TEXAS FIRST IMPLEMENTED
THEIR STATEWIDE INSURANCE
INTERCEPT PROGRAM IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE THEY SAW AN
INITIAL A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FOUR PERCENT INCREASE IN CHILD
SUPPORT COLLECTIONS. I COLLECTED
AROUND SIXTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS LAST YEAR ALONE.
AB TWENTY EIGHT OH TWO IS
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT
CHILDREN WHO DEPEND ON CHILD
SUPPORT AS A SOURCE OF INCOME
RECEIVE WHAT THEY DESERVE.
I'VE WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE
INSURANCE AND JUDICIARY
COMMITTEES ON THE LANGUAGE AND
PRINT.
THIS BILL IS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND DOES NOT HAVE ANY
REGISTERED OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THE IMAGE FRIEDMAN. SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
FOR.
IT IS THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY VOTE I
SIXTY TWO. KNOWS TO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
FOLLOW ADAM ONE THIRTY ONE AB
TWENTY NINE ELEVEN ARE PORTRAYED.
AS SOME LITTLE TWENTY NINE
ELEVEN BY SOME REMEMBER FRIEDMAN
AND ACTUALLY THE FIRE SAFETY
MISS FRIEDMAN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS IT'S BECOMING
INCREASINGLY CLEAR OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS THAT CALIFORNIA'S
WILDFIRE SEASON IS NOW YEAR
ROUND BATTLE. AND IN OUR CURRENT
POLICIES NEED TO BE REEVALUATED.
AB TWENTY NINE ELEVEN IS AN
EFFORT TO ENSURE THAT CITIES
FOUND WITHIN HIGH FIRED HAZARD
SEVERITY ZONES.
AND STATE RESPONSIBILITY AREAS
SUCH AS MINE HAVE THE TOOLS THEY
NEED TO PREVENT AND REDUCE THE
RISK OF WILDFIRES. AB TWENTY
NINE ELEVEN SEEKS TO PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR FIRE SAFETY
PLANNING EFFORTS IN LOCAL CITIES
AND COUNTIES.
STRENGTHENED DEFENSIBLE SPACE
REQUIREMENTS I CLARIFIED
VEGETATION CLEARANCE
REQUIREMENTS AROUND UTILITY
LINES ALL WHILE PROMOTING
HABITAT RESTORATION.
GIVEN THE DEVASTATION OF THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WILDFIRE
SEASON IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE
RE EVALUATED UPDATE OUR CURRENT
FIRE SAFETY MEASURES I CURRENTLY.
I'VE RECURSOS RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS FRIEDMAN SENIOR
DISCLOSURE DEBATE.
CLERK LOVE THE ROLL-ON VOTERS
OUT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE ANTI WHITE
EYES FORTY SEVEN KNOWS ELEVEN
THAT MEASURE
HOUSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
ONE. A. B. THIRTY TWO ó SIX
COOPERATE ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
TWO A SIX BY THROWING UP
FRIEDMAN AND ACTUALLY THE WATER
CONSERVATION. WAS FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB THIRTY TWO OH SIX ALLOWS THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION TO
ADOPT REGULATIONS TO ESTABLISH
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS FOR NEW
WATER METERS.
IT WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THE STATE
WATER BOARD RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD TO ADOPT PROTOCOLS FOR THE
REGULAR SAMPLING AND TESTING OF
INSTALLED WATER METERS DURING
THE BOARDS EXISTING REGULATORY
PROCESS. FOR DEVELOPING WATER
LOSS PERFORMANCE STANDARDS UNDER
S. B. FIVE FIVE FIVE.
ACCORDING TO WATER AUDITS FILED
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES.
IT TURNS OUT THAT TWO THIRDS OF
ALL WATER SYSTEMS CONDUCT NO
REGULAR TESTING OR SAMPLING TO
DETERMINE THE ACCURACY OF THEIR
INSTALL METERS AND IF ANY OF YOU
EVER SERVED IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT
YOU KNOW THE COMPLAINTS FROM
CITIZENS OVER. MAN ABOUT
FUNCTION MALFUNCTIONING WATER
METERS IS PRETTY COMMON.
IN FACT JUST LAST MONTH THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO REPORTED MORE THAN
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
OVER CHARGES DUE TO THREE
HUNDRED FORTY THREE MIS READ
METERS. THE CITY HAS NOW
PURCHASE A FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR DIGITAL TESTING BRANCH
A TOAST CUSTOMER METERS AND ARE
WAVING THE SIXTY SIX DOLLAR FEE
TO HAVE METERS TESTED.
CUSTOMERS SHOULD HAVE CONFIDENCE
THAT THEIR METERS ARE ACCURATE
AND THAT THEY ARE CORRECTLY
CHARGE FOR THEIR WATER USAGE. A.
B. THIRTY TWO OH SIX WOULD
ENSURE THAT NEW METERS ARE MORE
ACCURATE AND THAT EXISTING
METERS ARE TESTED SUFFICIENTLY
THERE'S NO PROTOCOL REQUIRE
MIGHT. REQUIREMENTS RIGHT NOW
FOR WATER METER EFFICIENCY UNITS
HIGH TIDE THAT WE ADDED SOME I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
MISTER GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
WHAT WE SHOULD BE FOCUSING ON
IS INCREASING THE AMOUNT OF
WATER METERS?
WHERE THEY'RE WHERE THEY'RE
CURRENTLY ARE NINE?
THIS WOULD INCREASE IN THIS
ULTIMATELY IS GOING TO LEAD TO A
NEW STANDARD THAT WOULD MAKE
OBSOLETE. WATER METERS THAT ARE
ALREADY THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
INSTALLED.
THROUGHOUT URBAN COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
THEREBY INCREASING COSTS WHEN
THEY HAVE TO REPLACE THOSE.
ALREADY WORKING METERS WITH THIS
NEW TECHNOLOGY STANDARD THIS
GOING TO BE ESTABLISHED AGAIN BY
AN UNELECTED. OF. THAT'S GONNA
DETERMINE THAT FOR EVERYBODY
AGAIN.
WHEN THIS HAPPENS IN THE
INCREASE HAPPENS IN YOUR WATER
DISTRICT IN YOUR RATES ARE GOING
UP BECAUSE WATER METERS HAVE TO
BE REPLACED.
THIS IS THE LEGISLATION.
AND OTHER OTHER BILLS LIKE IT.
HOW THEY'VE ALREADY PASSES HERE
THAT IS GOING TO INCREASE THOSE
COSTS?
WERE ALL ACROSS UP AND DOWN THE
STATE DOING MORE MORE.
TO CONSERVE OUR WATER IN IN
DIFFERENT AREAS THEY'RE DOING
DIFFERENT THINGS BASED ON THEIR
LOCAL NEEDS BASED ON THE
FEASIBILITY. AND FINANCIAL
ABILITY TO DO IT.
THIS BILL DOESN'T TAKE THAT
INTO ACCOUNT AND AGAIN TO GIVE
THE POWER. TO AN UNELECTED
BUREAUCRACY TO MAKE THESE
DECISIONS FOR YOU AND FOR YOUR
CONSUMERS
IT'S GOING TO INCREASE COSTS. IN
AN UNNECESSARY FASHION AND SO
I'D ASK FOR OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
MS FREEMAN YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU THIS BILL IS ONLY AND I
REPEAT ONLY A FAX
FUTURE WATER METERS. AND REALLY
WE SHOULD BE IN A POSITION IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
SIMPLY REQUIRE. THAT
MANUFACTURERS.
PRODUCE EFFECTIVE WATER METERS I
DON'T OVER OR UNDER BILL OUR
CUSTOMERS I THINK THAT THAT'S
REALLY A VERY REASONABLE
STANDARD. I DON'T SEE HOW THAT
WOULD INCREASE COSTS BUT YOU
KNOW IT DOES INCREASE COSTS FOR
UTILITIES WHEN YOU FIND OUT THAT
YOU HAVE UNDER BILL CUSTOMERS
FOR YEARS BECAUSE OF A
MALFUNCTIONING METER.
OR WHEN YOU FIND OUT THAT.
YOU MAY PEOPLE PAY WHO CAN'T
AFFORD TO PAY BECAUSE THEY'VE
BEEN OVER BEING BEING OVER
BILLED FOR YEARS AND NOBODY
NOTICED BECAUSE NOBODY TESTED
THOSE METERS AND THOSE METERS
HAD NO BASIC STANDARDS. TO EVEN
SHOW THAT THEY WERE EFFECTIVE.
THIS WILL STOP THE OVERBILLING
AND UNDER BILLING OF OUR
CUSTOMERS AND JUST AS WE HAVE
STANDARDS FOR MANY OTHER
PRODUCTS THAT WE SAW IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WHEN IT'S
SOMETHING AS FUNDAMENTAL AS WERE
BILLING PEOPLE BASED ON THOSE
PRODUCTS WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
SET STANDARDS FOR EFFICIENCY.
SO WITHOUT THIS IS A GOOD FOR
PROTECTING OUR CONSUMERS AND OUR
RATEPAYERS AND I WOULD URGE AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. NAME WAS
REMOVED WITH ACT CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
TO VOTE ON.
VOTERS ARE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLLED HOW THE VOTE FOR
EYES FORTY EIGHT KNOWS TWENTY
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS REWARDED WOULD FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO FORTY NINE. AB TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY NINE COOKERY.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
MISS FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ONE OF THE BIGGEST BARRIERS FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES SEEKING
TO OBTAIN AND MAINTAIN HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE IS AFFORDABILITY.
THROUGH COVER CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
TAX CREDITS IN PLACE TO HELP
COVER THE COST OF PREMIUMS FOR
THOSE MAKING LESS THAN FOUR
HUNDRED PERCENT OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LIMIT. OR F. P. L..
HOWEVER FOR INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES WHOSE INCOME EXCEEDS
FOUR HUNDRED PERCENT OF THE FPL.
THEY'RE COMPLETELY ON THEIR OWN
KEEP IN MIND FOUR HUNDRED
PERCENT OF FPL IS FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR AN INDIVIDUAL. AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE CREATES A
REFUNDABLE TAX CREDIT FOR THOSE
WITH INCOMES BETWEEN FOUR
HUNDRED AND SIX HUNDRED PERCENT
OF THE FPL. TO HELP COVER THE
COST OF THEIR PREMIUMS.
CREDIT IS EQUAL TO THE COST OF
HEALTH INSURANCE PREMIUMS FOR
THE LOWEST COST BRONZE PLAN FOR
THE INDIVIDUAL THAT EXCEEDS A
PERCENTOF THEIR MODIFIED GROWS
IN A GROSS INCOME.
ESSENTIALLY THE BILL ENSURES
THAT NO CALIFORNIANS SPENDS MORE
THAN A PERCENT OF THEIR INCOME
ON HEALTH INSURANCE PREMIUMS.
TOO MANY OF OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE
FACING THE IMPOSSIBLE CHOICE A
PAIN FOR HOUSING TRANSPORTATION
GROCERIES CHILDCARE UTILITIES.
OR PAYING FOR HEALTH INSURANCE
THE RESEARCH IS CLEAR IMPROVING
AFFORDABILITY WILL INCREASE
ENROLLMENT AND COULD MOVE US
CLOSER TO UNIVERSAL COVERAGE.
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE HAS A
BROAD COALITION OF SUPPORT THERE
IS NO OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
PREVIOUS REMAIN WITH THAT.
CLERK OF THE ROLL-ON.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE THERE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO GO.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE ANTI VOTE AYE
SIXTY EIGHT.
NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES AND
FINALLY MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM THREE EIGHTEEN.
FOR MS FRIEDMAN'S LAST ITEM THIS
IS AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY HARMING
TWENTY SIX.
TWENTY THREE SIXTY THREE OPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE SIXTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY NO
TRAFFIC THE.
MISS FRIEDMAN YOU MAKE AN OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I PRESENT AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
THREE AND A AND AN EFFORT TO
ADDRESS INJURIES AND FATALITIES
AS A RESULT OF INCREASED
SPEEDING ACROSS THE STATE. THE
ISSUE OF TRAFFIC RELATED
INJURIES BEGAN FOR ME LIVING IN
GLENDALE A CITY OF TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND IN AN AREA WHERE FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO LIVES WERE
LOST BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE.
AND TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN TO
TRAFFIC RELATED COLLISIONS.
GLENDALE IMPLEMENTED A BICYCLE
OR A MASTER BY A BICYCLE MASTER
PLAN AND IS INVESTED IN ST
ENGINEERING IN ORDER TO SLOW THE
FLOW OF TRAFFIC. AND ENSURE
PEDESTRIAN AND BICYCLE SAFETY.
YEP THE SPEED LIMITS BASED ON
THE AVERAGE EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT
OF SURVIVORS SPEEDS CONTINUES TO
RISE DESPITE THE WISHES OF THE
COMMUNITY.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY THREE
CREATES A VISION ZERO TASK FORCE
TO REVIEW THIS METHODOLOGY TO
REPORT AND RECOMMEND BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE HOW FATALITIES AS A
RESULT OF VISION OF VEHICLE
RELATED COLLISIONS CAN BE
REDUCED TO ZERO.
CITIES SUCH AS SACRAMENTO SAN
JOSE FREMONT SANDIEGO LOS
ANGELES SAN FRANCISCO SANTA
BARBARA MONTEREY AND MORE MORE
ARE MEMBERS OF THE VISION ZERO
NETWORK.
THESE LOCALS UTILIZE A THREE
PRONGED APPROACH OF ENGINEERING
EDUCATION AND ENFORCEMENT TO
ELIMINATE INJURIES AND DEATHS AS
A RESULT OF TRAFFIC RELATED. A
COLLISIONS
WE HAVE RECEIVED UNSOLICITED
OUTPOURING OF SUPPORT FROM LOCAL
COMMUNITIES ALL ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WHO ARE THEMSELVES
TRYING TO ADDRESS AN ISSUE TO OF
INCREASED SPEEDING AT ITS
IMPACTS ON SAFETY IN THEIR
CITIES.
THE VISION ZERO TASK FORCE WILL
BE COMPRISED OF REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
OTHER ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BICYCLE SAFETY
ORGANIZATIONS ROAD SAFETY
ORGANIZATIONS LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS AND MANY MORE
STAKEHOLDERS.
AT THE HEART OF THIS EFFORT IS
USING DATA TO IDENTIFY WHERE
SAFETY IS PROBLEMATIC. AND HOW
WE CAN BEST A DIRECT A REDUCE
SEVERE INJURIES AND FATALITIES
AS A RESULT OF ALL SPEEDING
VEHICLES.
I AM QUITE INVITE ALL OF YOU TO
JOIN ME IN THIS EFFORT AND WORK
WITH ME TO REDUCE FATALITIES AND
INJURIES JUDO CRAFT TRAFFIC
RELATED POSITION COLLISIONS TO
ZERO IN CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I BOTH.
THANK YOU.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THOSE ROLL TIDE VOTE I SIXTY
NINE KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS BACK IN FILE ORDER OVER
BE TAKING A FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINETY SEVEN.
THAT IS AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTY
SIX CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX SEVENTY
SIX BY FAMILY MEMBER GIPSON AND
ACTUALLY THE WAY MASTERS. MISTER
GIPSON.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY
SIX OF SEVENTY SIX WHICH EXTENDS
A SUNSET ON A PROGRAM. THAT
ENSURES A JUNK DEALERS AND
RECYCLERS HAVE LEGITIMATE
BUSINESS LICENSE WHAT OPERATING
CALIFORNIA THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION HAVE RECEIVED BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AND I VOTE.
THEY WAS GIPSON SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS THOUGH.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF AND I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM NINETY EIGHT IS A BE.
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TWO CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE AND
ACTUALLY THE HEALING ARTS. MS
BURKE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I PRESENT TO YOU TODAY
AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TWO
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIVES FOR THE
THIRTY YEAR.
PEOPLE HAVE ASKED ME WHY I'M SO
COMMITTED TO THIS ISSUE AND I
CAN ONLY SAY THIS.
HOW DO YOU SHOW RESPECT FOR THE
PERSON WHO GAVE HER BODY SO THAT
YOU COULD HAVE THE GREATEST GIFT
OF LIFE?
TO BE A PARENT.
YOU MAKE SURE SHE ALWAYS HAS A
CHOICE WHEN IT COMES TO HER BODY.
AND HOW SHE CONTINUES TO GIVE
THAT GIFT.
MY SERGEI USED A MIDWIFE FOR ALL
OF HER PREGNANCIES AND I CAN
TELL YOU.
THAT IT WAS AN EXTRAORDINARY
EXPERIENCE.
BUT WE'VE ALSO RESET TIPPING
POINT IN CALIFORNIA.
RISING HEALTHCARE COSTS CONTINUE
TO BURDEN WORKING PEOPLE.
ACCESS TO QUALITY CARE IS NOT A
REALITY FOR ALL OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND WE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
SHORTAGE OF HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS.
I SPENT A MAJORITY OF MY TIME IN
THE LEGISLATOR LEGISLATURE
FIGHTING TO ALLOW CERTIFIED
NURSE MIDWIVES TO USE THEIR
SKILLS TALENTS AND TRAINING TO
MAKE OUR SKILLS OURS SERVES.
OUR SYSTEM BETTER.
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT NOTE IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN AB THIRTEEN
KNOWING IT WAS APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR TO REMOVE PHYSICIAN
SUPERVISION OF LICENSED NURSE
MIDWIVES.
UNLIKELY SINCE MIDWIVES
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIVES ARE
REQUIRED TO COMPLETE A GRADUATE
LEVEL OF EDUCATION IN ORDER TO
QUALIFY FOR LICENSURE IN YET ARE
STILL SUBJECT TO VISION
SUPERVISION TO PRACTICE.
CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRES C. N.
N.'S TO PRACTICE UNDER
SUPERVISION OF A PHYSICIAN BUT.
BUT SPECIFIES IT THE SUPERVISION
REQUIREMENT SHALL NOT BE
CONSTRUED TO REQUIRE THAT HIS
PHYSICAL PRESENCE OF THE
POSITION.
I WANT TO REITERATE THIS THE
POSITION IS NOT PHYSICALLY
PRESENT DURING THE BIRTH UNDER
CURRENT LAW.
ALTHOUGH THE SUPERVISION
REQUIREMENTS HEATHER C. N. N.'S
TO PRACTICE ONLY WHERE POSITION
CONSUMER BUYS IT DOES NOT
CONSIST OF ACTUAL OVERSIGHT OF
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY. INSPECTION.
BICU CHARTS CLOSE SIGNATURES
OF PRESCRIPTIONS DIRECT CARE
PATIENTS OR EVALUATION OF CNN
PATIENTS AT ANY POINT DURING THE
PREGNANCY OR WHILE WOMEN CARE.
WE HAVE NEARLY TWELVE HUNDRED
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIVES
PRACTICING IN CALIFORNIA I'M
ALMOST OTHER STATES ALLOW
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIVES TO
PRACTICE INDEPENDENTLY. WERE
ONLY ONE OF SIX STATES THAT
STILL REQUIRES PHYSICIAN
SUPERVISION.
AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TO CREATE
THE LEVEL OF PARITY IN THE LONG
BETWEEN ALLEN'S AND CNN'S BY
REMOVING THE PHYSICIAN
SUPERVISION REQUIREMENT FOR
CNN'S ALLOWING THEM TO PRACTICE
INDEPENDENTLY WITH THEIR SCOPE
OF PRACTICE.
IN ADDITION AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
TO SPECIFY THAT ASEAN M. SHALL
CONDUCT WITH AN IS IF NECESSARY
CO MANAGER REFERRED TO OR
TRANSFER CARE TO A PHYSICIAN OR
SURGEON.
IN ANY OF THE FOLLOWING
SITUATIONS THE CONDITION IS
BEYOND THE CNM SCOPE OF PRACTICE
BASED ON EDUCATION AND
PREPARATION IF THERE IS EVIDENCE
THAT A CONDITION OR DISEASE
LIKELY JEOPARDIZE THE HEALTH OR
LIFE OF A NEWBORN OUR MOTHER.
THAN ASSESSOR NEST THE SUSSER
YOU THE SUBSIDIES ARE THE
RESOURCES AND PERSONNEL ARE NOT
AVAILABLE IN THE SETTING OF CARE.
FURTHERMORE I CAN SAY WITH LIST
LEGISLATIVE FRAMEWORK THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION A
COG.
AND THE US.
OSTEOPATHIC PHYSICIANS AND
SURGEONS SURGEONS HAVE REMOVED
THEIR OPPOSITION WITH TO THIS
BILL. I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR PATIENTS
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS AND
THEIR COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH ME
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS BURKE.
SHALOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AYE RISE TO I
THINK THE AUTHOR. OF FROM MARINA
DEL REY FOR HER COURAGE OF THIS
HAS BEEN A LONG TIME COMING AND
THAT'S WE SOLVE THIS MEASURE
COME BEFORE THE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE YOU SAW
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE. OF THE
DILIGENT EFFORTS AND ENGAGING
WITH ALL KEY STAKEHOLDERS IN
SUPPORT AND AND AND THE
OPPOSITION AND TRYING TO FIND A
COMMON SOLUTION.
VERY APPARENT AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK COLLEAGUES TO JOIN IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
THEY COMMISSION LOW MS
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO SIX EIGHT TWO.
I WAS BORN AT HOME.
ON THE KITCHEN TABLE.
AND IT WAS THE DECISION OF MY
MOTHER TO DO SO.
I WAS BORN UNDER THE SUPERVISED
CARE OF A NURSE MIDWIFE AND
OTHERS.
NOW THE JURY MAY BE OUT WITH
THIS GROUP BUT I THINK I TURNED
OUT OKAY.
MOTHERS HAVE THE RIGHT.
TO DECIDE HOW AND WHERE TO GIVE
BIRTH TO THEIR CHILDREN.
AND NOT ALL DECIDE THAT THEY
WANT TO DO IT.
UNDER THE BRIGHT LIGHTS OF A
HOSPITAL WITH MEDICATION.
THIS BILL KEEPS THE DECISION.
IN THE HANDS OF THE MOTHER.
AND THE FATHER.
AND THE MOTHER ABOUT HOW AND
WHERE TO GIVES BIRTH TO THEIR
CHILD.
I STAND WITH MY COLLEAGUE AND
ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT AB TWO SIX
EIGHT TWO.
DOCTOR QUIRK.
YES MY DAUGHTER RECENTLY GAVE ME
A WONDERFUL GRANDCHILD.
SHE WAS DEDICATED TO HAVING THE
BIRTH AT HOME WITH A MIDWIFE.
AFTER TWO DAYS OF LABOR.
THE NURSE MIDWIFE DECIDED IT WAS
TIME FOR MY DAUGHTER TO GO TO
THE HOSPITAL SHE DID THAT
WITHOUT SUPERVISION FROM A
POSITION I DON'T THINK SHE
NEEDED IT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
ON THE ITEM IS BURKE YOU MAY
CLOSE IF YOU WISH I JUST THINK
AGAIN MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
CONTINUED SUPPORT WITH THIS.
THANK YOU MISS BURKE WITH THAT
CLERK WILL OPEN THE RIGHT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE AND TELL
YOU THOUGH.
I SIXTY EIGHT.
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM.
NINETY NINE IS AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN CORKERY. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SIX EIGHTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE SMALL
BUSINESS ADVOCACY.
MISS QUIRK SILVA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
SEVEN INTEGRATES THE SMALL
BUSINESS ADVOCATE WITHIN THE
STATE'S EXISTING DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY ACTIVITIES.
CURRENTLY THE ADVOCATES ROLE IS
LIMITED TO POSTING DISASTER
RELATED INFORMATION ON A WEBSITE
AND CONDUCTING A PUBLIC MEETING
TO SHARE BEST PRACTICES FOR.
SMALL BUSINESS DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS.
WHEN THE WILDFIRES HIT IN
NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
LAST FALL HOWEVER THE ADVOCATE.
AND HIS TEAM SAW THAT THEY COULD
PLAY A MORE MEANINGFUL ROLE THEY
SPENT DAYS IN ALL THREE DISASTER
REGION SUPPORTING LOCAL EFFORTS
AND ADDRESSING SMALL BUSINESS
NEEDS. AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
SEVEN UPGRADES THE ROLE OF THE
ADVOCATE TO ASSIST IN EMERGENCY
RECOVERY IMPOSSIBLY RESPONSE AS
WELL AS PREPAREDNESS I AM
JOINTLY AUTHORING THIS BILL WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW MOAN. WHOSE
DISTRICT SUFFERED GREATLY IN
LAST YEAR'S FIRES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THE IMAGE QUIRK SILVA SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK LOGAN ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONE HUNDRED IT'S AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY ONE CORPORATION AT SOME
LEVEL TWENTY SIX NINETY ONE
PRICE FAMILY MEMBER JONES SAWYER
ACTUALLY TO PEOPLE HEALTH.
MISTER JONES SAWYER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY SIX NINETY ONE.
WHICH ESTABLISHED THE TRAUMA
INFORMED SCHOOLS INITIATIVE
WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION TO ADDRESS THE
IMPACT OF ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES ACES ON THE
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES A
CALIFORNIA PUPILS.
FOR MANY STUDENTS WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED DRAMATIC EVENTS.
SCHOOL SETTING CAN FEEL LIKE A
BATTLEGROUND IN WHICH THEIR
ASSUMPTIONS OF THE WORLD. AS A
DANGEROUS PLACE SABOTAGE ABILITY
TO REMAIN CALM. AND REGULATE
THEIR BEHAVIOR IN THE CLASSROOM
DETERMINE FORM SCHOOL INITIATIVE
WILL ALLOW CALIFORNIA CREATE
SCHOOL ENVIRONMENTS WOULD WHERE
OUR CHILDREN CAN FEEL SAFE.
AB TWENTY SIX NINETY ONE HAS HAD
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN NO NO VOTES
IN THE POLICY COMMITTEES MEMBERS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THE IMAGE JONES SAWYER SEE NO
DISCUSSION OF A CLERK WELCOME
THE ROLL-ON.
I'M SORRY ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY
ONE NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM ONE ONE PASS RETAIN.
PASSING TEMPORARILY AND FILE
ITEM ONE OR TWO.
FILE ITEM ONE OF THREE.
IS AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTEEN
COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTEEN BY FAMILY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ AND ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT. MISS
RODRIGUEZ.
YOUR CHAIR MEMBERS AB TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTEEN IS AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE. IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
WORKPLACE SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
THIS BILL WE'RE CREATE A
CENTRALIZED SYSTEM FOR REPORTING
AND TRACKING OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT COMPLAINTS AT STATE
AGENCIES AND REQUIRE REPORT TO
BE MADE. AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC
AND LEGISLATURE
THE REPORT WILL INCLUDE A NUMBER.
THE NUMBERS OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
COMPLAINTS RECEIVED AND THE
AMOUNT SPENT.
TO SETTLE CLAIMS.
TRANSPARENCY CREATED BY THIS
LEGISLATION ONE ABLE THE STATE
TO IDENTIFY PATTERNS OF
MISCONDUCT AND ELIMINATE ABUSE
IN A IN. AND INAPPROPRIATE
BEHAVIOR.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
MISS MELENDEZ.
THINK MISTER SPEAKER I I HAVE A
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR A FIGHT.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
DISC THIS.
DOES THIS INCLUDE THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AS FAR AS THE REPORT.
NO JUST AGENCIES.
SEEN NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON
THE BILL.
THIS RODRIGUEZ YOU MAY BECAUSE
WE WISH.
ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
CLICK LEVINE ROLL-ON.
WE SAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS TIRED OF VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW THE VOTE
I FIFTY THREE KNOWS ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'VE DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM
ONE ALL FOUR. FILE ITEM ONE OF
FIVE IS AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
TO COOPERATE.
AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MEDINA AND OTHERS ACTUALLY TO
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID. MR MEDINA.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY TO WILL
REAUTHORIZE A CRITICAL STATE
SPONSORED. EDUCATION BENEFIT.
CURRENTLY AFFORDED TO CALIFORNIA
SERVICE MEMBERS.
AND RECONSTITUTED AS THE
CALIFORNIA MILITARY DEPARTMENT
GI BILL.
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY TWO
EXPANDS CURRENT PROGRAM
ELIGIBILITY. AND REMOVES THE
PROGRAM SUNSET DATE.
CURRENTLY SET TO END IN TWENTY
NINETEEN.
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY TWO HELPS
INSURE CALIFORNIA ATTRACTS AND
RETAINS HIGH QUALITY SERVICE
MEMBERS.
WHO SUPPORT THE STATE BY
PROVIDING EMERGENCY RESPONSES
FOR WILDFIRES FLOODS EARTHQUAKES
AND SEARCH AND RESCUE MISSIONS?
THIS LEGISLATION WOULD PROVIDE
NEEDED IMPROVEMENTS THAT WILL
BENEFIT SERVICE MEMBERS FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES OR
OPPOSITION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS MEDINA SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE BILL.
CAR CLUB THE ROLE. I'M.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
BUT IS THERE TO VOTE.
OR WELL CLOSER ALL ANTI VOTE AYE
SIXTY ONE. NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE OF SIX IS AB
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN
COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES
AND ACTUALLY THE COURT REPORTERS.
MS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN PROVIDES A MUCH NEEDED
INCREASE.
THE COURT REPORTERS FEE FOR
TRANSCRIPTION OF RECORDS.
THE YOU SUPPORT REPORTERS
CONTINUES TO BE THE MOST
EFFICIENT AND COST EFFECTIVE
METHOD TO MAKE AN ACCURATE AND
COMPLETE. VERBATIM RECORD OF
COURT PROCEEDINGS.
AN ACCURATE RECORD IS ESSENTIAL
TO ANY APPEAL.
COURT REPORTERS ARE HIGHLY
SKILLED INDIVIDUALS WERE
PREDOMINANTLY WOMEN AND GET PAID
EIGHTY THREE CENTS PER ONE
HUNDRED WORDS TRANSIT
TRANSCRIBED.
THIS FEE SET BY STATUTE HAS NOT
BEEN INCREASED SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN
ESTABLISHES AN INCREMENTAL PAY
INCREASED APPROPRIATELY
COMPENSATE COURT REPORTERS FOR
THEIR AFTER HOURS WORK ON
TRANSCRIPTS.
INCREASING IT FROM THE CURRENT
EIGHTY THREE CENTS AND WERE
USING A TO THE ONE DOLLAR ONE
THIRTEEN MARK BY TWENTY TWENTY
THREE.
THIS SMALL INCREMENTAL
TRANSCRIPT FEE. INCREASE WILL
HELP ENSURE THAT A GREAT GREAT.
THAT THERE IS GREATER PAY EQUITY
FOR COURT REPORTERS MOST OF WHOM
WERE WOMEN WHO PERFORM AN
IMPERATIVE JOB FOR OUR COURT
SYSTEM.
IT'S FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THAT HIS RACE SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE BILL.
CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
FOR DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLLING TIED
ABOUT EYES FORTY THREE. KNOWS
EIGHTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WHERE IT FILE ITEM ONE
OF SEVEN AB TWENTY SEVEN.
SIXTY THREE.
BY MISTER O'DONNELL CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY THREE BY SOME REMEMBER
O'DONNELL AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE ENGLISH LIKE WHICH
EDUCATION. MISTER O'DONNELL
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
THREE REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
TO DEVELOP A STANDARDIZED
PROTOCOL TO HELP TEACHERS
EVALUATE ENGLISH LEARNERS
PROFICIENCY IN ENGLISH FOR USE
IN REVERSE RE CLASSIFICATION.
DECISIONS
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES THE
TEACHERS EVALUATE ENGLISH
LEARNERS PROFICIENCY.
PART OF THE PROCESS TO
RECLASSIFY STUDENTS.
WHY THIS EVALUATION IS HIGHLY
CONSEQUENTIAL FOR STUDENTS
THE STATE HAS NOT PROVIDED
TEACHERS WITH STANDARDIZED TOOLS
FOR MAKING SUCH RECOMMENDATIONS?
AS A RESULT IS THESE EVALUATIONS
ARE INCONSISTENT AND CAN
UNNECESSARILY HOLD STUDENTS BACK
FROM RECLASSIFYING.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY THREE WILL
MEET TEACHERS NEEDS FOR A
STANDARDIZED STANDARDS ALIGNED
PROTOCOL. EVENTUALLY MAKING RE
CLASSIFICATION A MORE CONSISTENT
AND FAIR PROCESS FOR ALL
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA. AYE
ASPIRIN AYE VOTE.
THEY'VE DONNELL MEANING SENIOR
DISCLOSURE BAIT ON THE BILL
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
SARAH VOTE ON.
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE ANTI VOTE AYE SIXTY
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE AWAY TO SEE BE TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY SIX.
BY MISTER BERMAN.
GREGORY. AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY SIX BY SOME A MEMBER
BERMAN AND ACTUALLY THE
RECYCLING MAKING PREPARATION
THEREFORE DECLINED URGENCY THERE
AT TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MISTER BERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE PRESENT AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY SIX A BILL
WHICH WOULD REAUTHORIZE
CALIFORNIA SUCCESSFUL PLASTIC
MARKET DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM.
THE PLASTIC MARKET DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM INCENTIVIZE IS RE USE OF
CALIFORNIA GENERATED RECYCLED
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS.
SUCH AS SODA BOTTLES PRIOR TO
THE ENACTMENT OF THIS INCENTIVE
PROGRAM VIRTUALLY ALL OF THE
PLASTIC COLLECTED FOR RECYCLING
IN CALIFORNIA WAS EXPORTED
OVERSEAS. DURING THE PREVIOUS
AUTHORIZATION THIS INCENTIVE
PROGRAM WAS CREDITED WITH
GROWING AND USE DEMAND FOR
CALIFORNIA GENERATED RECYCLED
PLASTIC AND SUPPORTING NEW
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES AND JOBS
IN THE PROCESS. OUT RESPECTFULLY
RISK REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
FAMOUS BERMAN SEEN NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE BILL CLUB CLUB
MOREAU. I'M.
RESIGNED VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TELL ABOUT ICE FIFTY
NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM ONE OF
NINE FILE ITEM ONE TEN.
IS AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY TWO
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MEDINA AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
THE PEOPLE INSTRUCTION. MR
MEDINA. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS TODAY I PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY TWO.
A BILL THAT WILL ADD A CHORUS OF
ETHNIC STUDIES.
TO BE A HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION
REQUIREMENT
BEGINNING IN THE SCHOOL YEAR
TWENTY.
THREE.
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
I THINK WE HAVE BEEN.
FORTUNATE ON THIS FLOOR. TO
BEEN ABLE TO HEAR THE STORIES
WHETHER IT BE DURING BLACK
HISTORY MONTH.
OR LATINO. HERITAGE
A WEEK.
OR API.
.
RECOGNITION TO HEAR A FULL STORY
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE UNITED
STATES.
BUT I THINK UNFORTUNATELY AS A
HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER FOR MANY
YEARS THAT HAS NOT BEEN THE THE
CASE FOR OUR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
SO ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY TWO WOULD DO WHAT MANY
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND OTHER STATES
HAVE ALREADY DONE AND THAT IS TO
MAKE ETHNIC STUDIES A HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION REQUIREMENT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
EGGMAN SPIN DOCTOR WEBER.
YES MISTER SPEAKER I RISE AS A
CO AUTHOR TO THIS PARTICULAR
BILL TO AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY
TWO. IT IS PROBABLY TIME FOR US
IN CALIFORNIA TO RECOGNIZE THAT
OUR EDUCATIONAL PRESENTATION OF
MATERIAL WITH THIS HISTORY OR
LITERATURE IS INADEQUATE FOR THE
NATURE OF THE STATE THAT WE HAVE.
IN THE WORLD IN WHICH WE LIVE.
WE OFTEN TALK ABOUT THE TIME
WHEN WE'D LOVE TO GET TO A POINT
WHERE WE DON'T NEED A BLACK
HISTORY MONTH OR IT WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH OR A LATINO
HISTORY MONTH. WHERE WE FOCUS
ONLY ON THAT TIME ON THE
DESTRUCTIVE THE STUDY OF THOSE
INDIVIDUAL GROUPS THAT WILL ONLY
HAPPEN WHEN WE TAKE THE FIRST
STEP IN THAT IS BY REQUIRING
FIRST OF ALL? THAT ALL OF OUR
CHILDREN LEARN ABOUT ETHNIC
STUDIES AND THEN EMPOWERING ARE
ALSO EDUCATORS WITHIN TO
INCORPORATE THAT MATERIAL INTO
THE REGULAR CURRICULUM SO THAT
WE NO LONGER HAVE TO SPECIALIZE
FOR SPERM CERTAIN MONTHS OF
TIMES OUR PERIODS. THIS TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA TO MOVE FORWARD AS I
SAID THIS IS A VERY DIVERSE
STATE AND WE NEED TO HAVE A
CURRICULUM THAT IS REFLECTIVE OF
THE STATE IN THE PEOPLE IN WHICH
WE LIVE. WOULD NOW BOMBARDED
OBVIOUSLY WITH A LOT OF
OPPOSITION IN THE LARGER SOCIETY
WE SEE THE INCREASE IN HATE
CRIME IN STEREO TYPES AND ALL
THOSE THINGS. HAVE A TENDENCY TO
WEAKEN US MUCH MORE THAN
STRENGTHEN US GIVING OUR
STUDENTS OF KNOWLEDGE THEY NEED
ABOUT OTHER FOLKS IN THE WORLD
AND IN TERMS OF ETHNIC STUDIES.
EMPOWERS THEM AGAINST THE
NEGATIVE INFORMATION THAT THEY
GET FROM THE MEDIA AND FROM
OTHERS WHO HAVE VERY CLOSE MINES.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO MOVE FORWARD
WOULD VERY DIVERSE STATE AND WE
NEED TO HAVE A CURRICULUM THAT
REFLECTS THAT AND THIS IS THE
FIRST STEP IN A BILL TO HELP
HOPEFULLY MAKE IT. SO THAT ALL
OF OUR MATERIAL IS ADEQUATELY
INTEGRATED AND WOOD ON THE
HISTORY AND CULTURE OF EVERYONE
WHO LIVES IN CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT AYE VOTES
AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY TWO.
THEY DUCKED WEBER MISTER BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AS CHAIR OF THE ASIA
PACIFIC PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AND PROUD TO
AN AUTHOR OF THIS BILL I RISE IN
SUPPORT. OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY TWO THE BENEFITS OF
ETHNIC STUDIES CAN BE MEASURED.
MULTIPLE STUDIES SHOW THAT WHEN
STUDENTS OF COLOR LEARN MORE
ABOUT RACE
RACISM AND CULTURAL IDENTITY
THEY RAISE THEIR GRADES AND
THEIR GRADUATION RATES AND ARE
MORE LIKELY TO ATTEND COLLEGE.
AFTER GROWING UP IN YOUR FORMING
YOUR VIEWS ABOUT THE WORLD IN
ABOUT YOURSELF IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT.
SEE YOUR COMMUNITIES SUCCESSES
AND HISTORY REPRESENTED IN A WAY
THAT IS COMPLETE. THAT IS FAIR
AND THAT IS ACCURATE THAT
CREATES INSPIRATION.
AND EMPOWERS THE NEXT GENERATION.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO ME THAT MY OWN
CHILDREN AND ALL HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE A
MEANINGFUL OPPORTUNITY. TO LEARN
MORE ABOUT THE HISTORY AND
CONTRIBUTIONS
OF ALL OF OUR DIVERSE GROUPS
THAT CONTRIBUTED SIGNIFICANTLY
TO OUR STATE. TO OUR COUNTRY
INTO OUR WORLD I THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA FOR AUTHORING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL TO ESTABLISH AN
ETHNIC STUDIES CURRICULUM AT ALL
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOLS.
I RESPECTFULLY URGE AYE VOTE.
HE WAS BONTA DOCTOR CHOI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THEN THROUGH.
I RISE TO SUPPORT ALL OF OCT
TWENTY SEVEN NINE SEVENTY TWO.
ARE MANDATING A HIGH SCHOOL
CURRICULUM OUT TO INCLUDE ETHNIC
STUDIES.
I.
AS MYSELF WESTERN IMMIGRANT. I
FIND THE OUR COUNTRY AS A
COUNTRY OF WHITE IMMIGRATION AND
THEN ALSO PARTICULARLY. A
CALIFORNIA OUT WE HAVE. A MORE
AUTHORITY INTEGRATED A SERIES ON
LOS ANGELES AND THEN EVEN MY
CITY US CITY EVER IRVINE.
SEVENTY FIVE DIFFERENT NOW ON.
LANGUAGES ARE SPOKEN AND HOMES
AND THAT WE ARE.
.
ENCOURAGE OUR STUDENTS TO
UNDERSTAND.
A DIFFERENT CULTURES AND THE
WITHOUT TEACHING.
AT THE OF FOR VULNERABLE AGE
SENSITIVE AGE.
THIS IS ON NECESSARY EDUCATION
FOR THEM TO DEVELOP.
THE UNDERSTANDING OF DIFFERENT
CULTURES AND THEN ALSO DEVELOP
WITH SENSITIVITY TO DEFINE OUR
CULTURES. AS
STONE YOU URGE YOU I'VE WORKED.
THEY GET CHOI SAY NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. I'M SORRY
MISTER GALLAGHER.
MEMBERS OF THE ONE WE RECOGNISE
PLEASE RECOGNIZE YOU PLEASE
RAISE YOUR MICROPHONES DURING
DEBATE MISTER GALLAGHER. OUT
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
.
MY COLLEAGUE GUY FROM SAN
BERNADINO SERVER SIDE COUNTY
SORRY.
.
WE'D WE SHARE A PASSION FOR
HISTORY AND.
AS SO AND NOT LIE I AM I AM
SUPPORTIVE OF THE IDEA OF
INCREASING THE AMOUNT.
OF.
OF OF HISTORY THAT IS TAUGHT IN
OUR HIGH SCHOOLS THAT'S I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT.
.
WHAT I THINK WHAT I WOULD LIKE
TO WORK ON WITH THE AUTHOR IS
YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW I THINK
DEFINING IT AS AS PURELY IN
ETHNIC STUDIES?
YOU IT'S A VERY DEFINED FIELD OF
STUDY.
AND I AND I THINK IT MAYBE EVEN
BROADLY IN THAT YOU KNOW TO. WE
DO DO CALIFORNIA HISTORY IN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL BUT I THINK.
WE NEED TO TEACH OF A BROADER.
SUBJECT OF CALIFORNIA HISTORY IN
OF ALL THE. THE ETHNIC PEOPLES
AND CULTURES.
.
THAT HAVE INFLUENCE CALIFORNIA
HISTORY.
I'M ITS I'D LIKE TO SEE MAYBE
THIS BROAD. SO THAT.
THERE WOULD BE MORE FLEXIBILITY
AMONGST THE DIFFERENT DISTRICTS
TO TEACH.
AND MAYBE EVEN MORE TO FOCUS IN
ON THE LOCAL.
HISTORY.
OF DIFFERENT PARTS OF CALIFORNIA
YEAH WE KNOW THAT EACH OF OUR
LOCALITIES.
WE HAVE AND.
YOU KNOW DIFFERENT LOCAL HISTORY
THAT I THINK IS IMPORTANT.
AND SO.
I AGREE WITH THE SPIRIT OF THIS
LEGISLATION.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT. MAY
MORE BROADENED IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE HAVE THAT WE CONTINUE.
WHEN YOU HEAR OF OF STUDENTS
GRADUATING FROM HIGH SCHOOL
WITHOUT HAVING.
.
NIELSEN VERY VITAL INFORMATION
ABOUT THEIR HISTORY AND ABOUT
HOW.
OUR STATE OUR NATION AND OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES CAME TO BE.
THAT'S DISCONCERTING AND AND SO
I SHARE THAT MOTIVATION.
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS
MOVIE. MORE BROADLY.
BROADENED OUT YOU KNOW AS IT
MOVES OVER TO THE SENATE.
SURE THURMOND YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES ARE RISING SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY TWO.
AS WE OFTEN SAY.
I HISTORY IS OFTEN VIEWED
THROUGH THE EYES OF THE BEHOLDER.
AND IN THAT RESPECT HISTORY HAS
OFTEN BEEN PROVIDED.
IN WAYS THAT AS MY COLLEAGUE
HAS SAID SHOULD BE BROADER. UP
THIS BILL MOVES IN THE DIRECTION
TO ACTUALLY CREATE THE KIND OF
WRITING THAT I THINK WE NEED TO
HAVE.
TO HELP ALL STUDENTS SEE HOW.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE THEIR
ANCESTORS HAVE MADE
CONTRIBUTIONS
I TO THE STATE. ARM WHETHER THEY
BE AFRICAN AMERICAN LATINO ASIAN
OR FROM OTHER GROUPS NATIVE
AMERICAN AND OTHERS. THAT WE
SHOULD PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR STUDENTS FROM THOSE GROUPS
TO SEE THOSE CONTRIBUTIONS
BUT ALLOW STUDENTS FROM ALL
BACKGROUNDS TO ALSO SEE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT HAVE.
CONTRIBUTED TO OUR BROADER
SOCIETY THIS IS A. BILL THAT'S
MOVING IN A GREAT DIRECTION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON BEHALF OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY TWO.
MISS MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND I
DON'T DISAGREE THAT ETHNIC
STUDIES CAN BE.
A A HELPFUL COURSE FOR STUDENTS
TO TAKE BUT LET'S NOT LOSE SIGHT
OF THE FACT THAT.
A LARGE NUMBER OF OUR COLLEGE
STUDENTS HAVE TO TAKE REMEDIAL
MATH.
IN REMEDIAL ENGLISH
WE HAVE A VERY LARGE SEGMENT OF
OUR BLACK POPULATION CRISPUS
BIGGER BOYS.
WHO BY A CERTAIN AGE IN THEIR
EDUCATIONAL CAREER? CAN'T READ
AND WRITE AT THE SAME LEVEL AS
THEIR AS THEIR WHITE
COUNTERPARTS.
I THINK MORE OF A FOCUS ON THE
ESSENTIALS THE BASICS.
FOR STUDENTS IS WHERE THE FOCUS
SHOULD BE OF WE'RE GOING TO
INCREASE FUNDING FOR THAT.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE A GOOD IDEA TO
ME BUT TO CONTINUE TO ADD THESE
COURSES THAT ARE REQUIRED THAT
ARE NOT GOING TO.
.
THERE IS NOT GOING TO ADVANCE
THEIR.
ABILITY TO.
TO GET A JOB OR TO GET INTO
COLLEGE ORDER START THEIR OWN
BUSINESS LATER THIS IT'S HELPFUL
IT'S INTERESTING IT'S
ENCOURAGINGIT'S GOOD FOR ONE.
TO NO ONE'S BACKGROUND AND WENT
HISTORY BUT THERE ARE SO MANY
OTHER ESSENTIAL IS THAT WE NEED
TO FOCUS ON THAT I THINK
EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM IF YOU
READ THE REPORTS. WOULD AGREE
THAT. WE ARE FAILING OUR
STUDENTS.
IN SO MANY WAYS SO IT'S NOT TO
DISCOUNT.
ON THE EFFORTS OF THIS BILL BUT
I THINK.
LET'S PLACE IMPORTANCE WHERE IT
SHOULD BE.
THANK YOU.
MISTER SANTIAGO.
I THINK YOUR SPEAKER KNOW WE
HEARD A LOT ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE.
OF EDUCATION TODAY.
BUT BUT WHAT ALL SAY ABOUT A
PEOPLE'S HISTORY.
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT.
THAT A THAT A PEOPLE IS EMPOWER.
NOW YOU MAY THINK THAT OR FOR
THOSE OF THOUGHT THAT ETHNIC
STUDIES ARE LESS IMPORTANT.
THEN OTHER STUDIES.
LOOK I TOOK TO CONDUCT STUDIES.
AND I WAS VERY PROUD OF IT.
AND IT TAUGHT ME ABOUT MY
PEOPLE'S HISTORY AND THEY GAVE
ME A PASSION FOR WHAT I WANTED
TO DO IN LIFE.
SO SOMETIMES I MIGHT ARGUE.
THAT THE OTHER COURSE WORK IS
IMPORTANT.
AND IT IS.
BUT I MIGHT ARGUE.
THAT THESE KIND OF COURSES.
ARE EQUALLY AS IMPORTANT OR MORE
ON POINT.
THE EMPOWERMENT OF OUR COMMUNITY
BECAUSE WE'VE GOT THAT. DEVELOP
THE SORT OF PEOPLE.
WHO ARE GOING TO BE IN POSITIONS
OF POWER?
WHO WILL CARRY OUT POLICIES?
BE IT IN THE CORPORATE WORLD.
OR IF THE GOVERNMENT.
OR LOCAL MUNICIPALITY.
WHO HAVE THAT SCENE DRIVE AND
ENERGY
NOW?
THERE ARE THOSE WHO HAVE
MENTIONED WE SHOULD BROADEN THE
BILL WE SHOULD DO THINGS OUR
LOCAL. I. PIE WOULD DISAGREE SO
CARRY OWN BILL.
PASS IT TO THE LEGISLATURE.
WHAT I WOULD ENCOURAGE ON THAT?
AND AS WE AS A REFERENCE TO THE
OTHER COURSES THAT ARE IMPORTANT.
WE CARE THOSE BILLS TO.
JOIN US IN IN HELPING TO FUND
EDUCATION BETTER.
JOIN US IN HELPING TO WHAT LIFT
OUR COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE THERE ARE REAL IMPORTANT.
HISTORICAL LESSONS.
AND AND AND ACTIONS THAT TOOK
PLACE.
AS TO WHY SOME COMMUNITIES ARE
THE WAY THEY ARE TODAY.
AND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
STAND.
THE DISTRICT I REPRESENT.
DOES NOT HAVE POOR LATINOS
BECAUSE THEY JUST ALL MOVED IT
OUT AREA.
WE DON'T HAVE LITTLE TOKYO
BECAUSE IT'S JUST AS THERE WE
DON'T HAVE CHINA TOWN ABOVE ME.
ABOVE MY DISTRICT JUST BECAUSE
SIMPLY PEOPLE WANTED TO MOVE
THERE.
THERE IS A HISTORICAL
SIGNIFICANCE.
AND MUCH OF IT WAS ABOUT A
PRUSSIAN.
IF YOU CANNOT UNDERSTAND THE
PEOPLE WHO WAS OPPRESSED.
AND IF YOUR CULTURE WAS NOT
OPPRESSED.
GOD BLESS YOU.
BUT MINE WAS AND IT WAS
IMPORTANT FOR ME TO LEARN ABOUT
IT.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT MOTIVATED ME
TO BE HERE TODAY TOUGH FIGHT FOR
THE BILL DOES VERY AND JUSTICES.
AND WE CANNOT FORGET HIM. AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO FIGHT BUT HE'S
KIND OF COURSE OR.
COURSES
AND UNLESS YOU UNDERSTAND.
RICE THEN TODAY.
I CAN UNDERSTAND HOW IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR YOU TO ACCEPT OR
EMBRACE.
BUT THESE THAT THIS SORT OF
CURRICULUM IS IMPORTANT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MISTER HARPER YOUR RECOMMENDS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS.
ARISES. VIA SPEAKER.
THERE IS A HIERARCHY OF WHAT'S
IMPORTANT WITH EDUCATION.
THE MOST FUNDAMENTAL. AND
IMPORTANT SUBJECTS.
SUBJECTS WE ARE FALLING BEHIND
IN.
HEARING CALIFORNIA.
AND NEED TO DEVELOP MORE FOCUS
NOT LAST.
MATHEMATICS.
AND READING.
RIDING.
SPEAKING.
AN ENGLISH.
WHICH IS THE COMMON MEDIAN A CAR
MEDIUM OF COMMERCE
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY. IS THE
COMMON MEDIUM.
OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
BEING ABLE TO COMMUNICATE.
BEING ABLE UNDERSTAND
MATHEMATICS.
ARE ABSOLUTELY MORE CRITICAL.
AND I'M SORRY.
BUT WE NEED HAD MORE FOCUS ON.
I AGREE WITH MORE FUNDING AND
MORE PRIORITY. AND WILL REFORM
IN EDUCATION.
SO IT WEAKENED HAVE IMPROVEMENT
IN RESULTS ON THE SUBJECT.
FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE.
WE DO INDEED NEED MORE RESOURCES.
BUT LET'S NOT LOSE OUR FOCUS.
SOME SUBJECTS ARE MORE IMPORTANT
THAN OTHERS.
AND LET'S REALIZE THAT FOR THE
SUCCESS OF OUR STUDENTS.
FOR THE SUCCESS OF THE NEXT
GENERATION.
FOR THE SUCCESS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
MISTER EDUARDO GARCIA YOUR
RECKONING THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I AM FEEL
COMPELLED TO RISE AND SPEAK.
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY TWO.
AS A PROUD.
.
DEGREE HOLDER OF. BOTH A NATIVE
AMERICAN STUDIES AND CHICANO
STUDIES
I CAN TELL YOU FIRSTHAND HOW
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND VALUABLE.
THOSE PARTICULAR.
STUDIES
HAVE SERVED ME. VERY MY TIME IN
PUBLIC SERVICE AND SO ONE OF THE
COMMENTS WAS. THAT
YOU KNOW WE SHIP BE PREPARING
OUR STUDENTS FOR BETTER JOBS.
AND
JEAN THEM.
ABOUT THE WORLD IN AND MAKING
SURE THAT THEY ARE WELL ROUNDED.
AND THE DECISIONS
BY THOSE WHO SIT ON. BOARDS AND
OTHER TYPES OF CORPORATIONS THAT
THEY TO UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR
VARIOUS PERSPECTIVES TO BE
BROUGHT TO THE TABLE. AS
DECISIONS ARE BEING MADE AND
REALLY AT THE CORE AND
FUNDAMENTAL.
REALLY TEACHING.
TO ALL THAT IS BEING ABLE TO
OFFER. ETHNIC STUDIES CLASSES TO
YOUNG PEOPLE I CAN SHARE WITH
YOU THAT. WHEN YOU TEACH YOUNG
PEOPLE.
ABOUT THEIR HISTORY ABOUT THEIR
CULTURE. IT STRENGTHENS THEIR
IDENTITY AND IT ALSO GIVES THEM
A SENSE OF EMPOWERMENT.
AND PURPOSE.
IN THE PAST THAT THEY DECIDE TO
TAKE IRRESPECTIVE OF WHAT TYPE
OF JOB THEY MAY DECIDE TO TAKE.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT IN MY
COMMUNITY.
YOU HAVE.
THAT PROMISE YOUTH.
THEN YOU PUT ON BEFORE.
STRUCTURES TO LEARN ABOUT
CHICANO STUDIES.
AND IT CHANGES.
THEY'RE THINKING.
AND IT GIVES THEM A SENSE OF
DIRECTION AND PRIDE THAT TAKES
HIM TO SUCCEED AS OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM OAKLAND MENTIONED THAT IT
IS PROVEN FACT THAT WHEN YOU
TEACH THESE CLASSES.
IT IMPROVES THE QUALITY OF
LEARNING AND EDUCATION THAT
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE RECEIVE.
AS A FORMER MAYOR OF THE CITY OF
COACHELLA WE HAD FOUR. TRIBES
WITHIN OUR JURISDICTION.
MY UNDERSTANDING.
AND KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT IT MEANS
TO BE A SOVEREIGN NATION.
VIA THE TEACHINGS THAT I
RECEIVED THAT UC RIVERSIDE
ETHNIC STUDIES.
HELP ME FACILITATE
SOME VERY DIFFICULT
CONVERSATIONS BUT UNDERSTANDING.
THAT IT WAS ABOUT MUTUAL RESPECT.
AND THAT THE TRIBES HISTORICALLY.
HAD BEEN LIKE TO.
SHE DID TO AND IN MANY WAYS.
HER.
BY OUR OWN GOVERNMENT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA HERE IN THIS COUNTRY
AND SO WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING.
THAT HISTORY PERHAPS I WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO HAVE A
SUCCESSFUL PRODUCTIVE
RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES IN MY COMMUNITY
SO I WANT JUST TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
IN IN MY COMMENTS THAT.
THESE TEACHINGS THESE CLASSES
ARE OF EXTREME SIGNIFICANCE.
A TEACHING EVERYONE.
TO EMBRACE AND TO RESPECT THE
DIFFERENCES THAT WE HAVE.
AND I TRULY BELIEVE THAT AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY TWO.
SETS THE TONE FOR EVERY HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATE. TO MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
RIVAL.
MISS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN TWO.
I HAVE HEARD THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES AND I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR GROUPS.
WHO ARE GOING TO HIGH SCHOOL TO
LEARN ABOUT THEIR OWN CULTURE?
IT IS EQUALLY IMPORTANT FOR
GROUPS TO LEARN ABOUT SOMEONE
ELSE'S CULTURE.
AND WHY IS THAT.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU DON'T DO THAT.
THEN YOU FAIL TO SEE. OTHER
PEOPLE.
AND WHEN YOU DON'T SEE ASKS.
YOU ERASE SASS.
AND I CERTAINLY DON'T THINK THAT
THIS BODY.
ISN'T THE HABITS.
OF WANTING TO ERASE CULTURES AND
DIVERSE CITY.
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT ON AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN.
THANKS YOU FOR THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION MEMBERS SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEE RECOGNITION MR
MEDINA YOU MAY CLOSE ON THE ITEM.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
LET ME THANK ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES FROM BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE. WHO STOOD?
UP TO DISCUSS WHAT I THINK IS A
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
I BEGAN MY EDUCATION.
IN THE MID NINETEEN FIFTIES.
AT A TIME WHERE I WAS INVISIBLE
IN THE CURRICULUM.
CALIFORNIA.
I DID NOT SEE MYSELF REFLECTED.
IN THE READERS OR IN THE
CURRICULUM THAT I WAS TAUGHT.
WHEN I WENT TO COLLEGE I WAS
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN A
LOT OF THINGS THAT I DID NOT
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN
ABOUT.
THAT AS A A YOUNG PERSON.
I LEARNED ABOUT THE WALKOUTS OF
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT THAT WE
CELEBRATED HERE ON THIS FLOOR.
AND THE IMPACT THAT THOSE WALK
OUTS IN EAST LA HAD ON EDUCATION.
AND HOW THAT THOSE WALKOUTS
CHANGED EDUCATION.
I LEARNED THAT IN NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT STUDENTS AT SAN FRANCISCO
STATE.
DEMONSTRATED
FOR DAYS WEEKS EVEN MONTHS
TO HAVE A CURRICULUM THAT
REFLECTED ALL STUDENTS.
AND A HAVE FACULTY THAT
REFLECTED THEM AS WELL.
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY AS A
TEACHER.
TEACH ETHNIC STUDIES AND CHICANO
STUDIES.
AND A WEEK DOES NOT PASS WHEN I
GO HOME TO RIVERSIDE THAT
STUDENTS COME BACK. AND TELL ME
THANK YOU MR MEDINA FOR THE
CLASSES THAT YOU TAUGHT FOR WHAT
YOU TAUGHT US.
AND I CAN TELL YOU WHY.
IF THERE IS A HIERARCHY IN
EDUCATION.
WHICH I DON'T DISAGREE THAT
THERE IS.
AT THE BEGINNING OF THAT
HIERARCHY STUDENTS MUST SEE
THEMSELVES.
IN WHAT THEY ARE TAUGHT.
IF THEY DO NOT SEE THEMSELVES
AND WHAT THEY ARE TAUGHT THEY
FEEL THAT EDUCATION.
IS MEANINGLESS.
SO AS WE STAND HERE AND DEBATE.
PERFORMANCE
PERFORMANCE OF ALL THE DIFFERENT
GROUPS.
AND EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS I WOULD ARGUE THAT. AT
THE OUTSET.
THAT CURRICULA MS INCLUDE THEM.
BUT IT'S BEEN FIFTY YEARS
SINCE THOSE DEMONSTRATIONS
AT SAN FRANCISCO STATE AND STILL
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WHAT NEEDS TO BE INCLUDED ALL
PEOPLE'S HISTORY AND CULTURES
HAVE NOT BEEN INCLUDED?
I THINK THAT.
THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT I
ENCOURAGE YOU ALL TO PLEASE VOTE
YES
ON TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY TWO.
THANK YOU MR MEDINA WITHOUT
CLERK LOVE IN THE ROLE ON.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
AYE AYES FORTY EIGHT NOSE ALIVE
AND THAT MEASURE PASSES
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MEMBERS JUST A
PROGRESS UPDATE WE HAVE
DISPENSED WITH. ABOUT FIFTY
SEVEN BILLS TODAY.
OUR GOAL IS HOPEFULLY TWO
HUNDRED.
TODAY.
SO IF WE CAN MOVE THINGS ALONG
BE CONCISE AND I REMARKS AND
ONLY SPEAK WHEN WE FEEL LIKE IT
IS ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY WE NEED
TO SPEAK. AT A REALLY HELP US
MOVE THINGS ALONG THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING IN FILE
ORDER TO ITEM ONE ELEVEN AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE OUT OF
CLERK PLEASE READ THAT SOME
LEGAL TWENTY SEVEN SEVEN.
CALLER AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
ACTUAL COSMETICS
SO MEMBER KALRA YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE REQUIRE
MANUFACTURERS LIST INGREDIENTS.
ON THE LABEL IS A PROFESSIONAL
COSMETIC PRODUCTS IN THE SAME
MANNER AS REQUIRED A RETAIL
COSMETIC PRODUCTS IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE OPEN INFORMATION TO
CONSUMERS. SALON WORKERS IN THE
GENERAL PUBLIC WHILE RETAIL
BECAUSE MAKES ARE SOLD TO THE
PUBLIC ISTOCK CONSUMPTION.
PROFESSIONAL COSMETIC PRODUCTS
ARE USED BY SALON BROKERS FOR
UPWARDS OF EIGHT HOURS PER DAY
RESULTING IN MANY CASES OF ACUTE
DISAPPEAR. HEALTH SYMPTOMS AB
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE ALLOWS FOR
STANDARDIZATION ACROSS ALL
COSMETIC LABELING AND PROMOTES
HEALTHIER WORKPLACES FOR SALON
WORKERS WHO ARE PREDOMINANTLY
WOMEN OF COLOR OF THE
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND MAJOR INDUSTRY CORPORATIONS.
SUCH AS YOU KNOW LEVER I RESPECT
THE ASPIRIN AYE VOTE.
SOME NEVER WALDRON YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I SUPPORTED THIS BILL
LAST YEAR AND I STAND TO SUPPORT
IT AGAIN THIS YEAR. JUST REALLY
QUICKLY SOME NUMBERS. THIS ALL
THERE ARE ABOUT FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND BUSINESSES LICENSED.
BY THE BBC TO PROVIDE NAIL HAIR
BARBER OTHER BEAUTY SERVICES
OVER A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND LICENSE MANICURISTS IN
THE STATE. THREE HUNDRED
FOURTEEN THOUSAND THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED COSMETOLOGIST LICENSE
THIS BILL WILL PUT HELP PROTECT
THEIR HEALTH. URGENT AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MADAME
PRECLUDES OPEN THE ROLE. ON
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
BENEFIT PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
TALLY THE VOTES.
I FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES MOVING TO ITEM
ONE TWELVE AB TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY MEADOW HER PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY BY SOME THE MEMBER IRWIN
AND ACTUALLY THE VETERANS THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY WOULD
ESTABLISH AN OFFICE OF INTERNAL
AUDITS OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS
AND A CHIEF AUDITOR TO LEAD THAT
DEPARTMENT THE CHIEF AUDITOR
WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE TO THE
SECRETARY FOR CONDUCTING AUDITS
AND INVESTIGATIONS OF THE
DEPARTMENT TO INCREASE
EFFICIENCY. IMPROVE OPERATIONS
AND REDUCE FRAUD WASTE AND ABUSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MEADOW QUICKLY IS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ADEQUATE PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW THE VOTES.
I FIFTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM ONE THIRTEEN PASS AND
RETAIN WE HAVE DEALT WITH ITEM
ONE FOURTEEN MOVING TO ITEM ONE
FIFTEEN AB TWENTY.
PAST TEMPER ITEM ONE FIFTEEN
PASS TEMPORARILY ITEM ONE
SIXTEEN AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTEEN.
METAPHOR PLEASE READ AT SOME
LEVEL TWENTY EIGHT THIRTEEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN AND
ACTUALLY TO EMERGENCY SERVICES
SOME MEMBER WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTEEN WHICH
WOULD CODIFY. VERBATIM THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT
CREATED THE CALIFORNIA
CYBERSECURITY INTEGRATION CENTER.
THIS BILL IS INTENDED TO GIVE
THE GOVERNOR ANOTHER CHANCE TO
EVALUATE HIS VISION FOR THE
CALCIUM SICK BEFORE HE LEAVES
OFFICE CYBERSECURITY WILL
UNFORTUNATELY BE A CONTINUING
THREAT FACTOR FOR CALIFORNIA
JUST AS MENACING AS FIRES
EARTHQUAKES AND FLOODS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING THEIR REQUEST
TO SPEAK MEDICAL QUIZ OPEN THE
ROLL-ON
MEMBERS WILL.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE HIS IRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TELLING THE BOATS EYES
FIFTY NINE KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM ONE SEVENTEEN AND ONE
EIGHTEEN PASS TEMPORARILY MOVING
TO ITEM ONE NINETEEN EIGHTY BE
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY FIVE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
YOU MAN THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
I RISE TODAY PRESENT AB TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE EXCUSE ME I BEG YOUR
PARDON. MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
S. UNABLE TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
FIVE BY FAMILY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY A
DEBT COLLECTION OF BUYING.
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO RESENT
AB TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WHICH WE
CLOSE A LOOPHOLE IN A ROSENTHAL
FAIR DEBT COLLECTION PRACTICES
ACT IN THE FAIR DEBT BUYING
PRACTICES THAT. SPECIFICALLY
JUST BILL WOULD ADD A NEW
DEFINITION FOR NON CONSENSUAL
OBLIGATIONS TO PAY WHICH
INCLUDES DEBTS ARISING FROM
TOWING AND STORING CHARGES.
UNPAID PARKING PENALTIES AND
PASSED TO RESIDENTIAL RENT.
CURRENTLY INDIVIDUALS WITH THE
TYPES OF DEATHS ARE NOT
PROTECTED FROM UNSCRUPULOUS DEBT
COLLECTORS USING DECEITFUL OR
ABUSIVE COLLECTION TACTIC.
BUILD THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT DUE TO
ASSEMBLY POLICY COMMITTEES THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AND HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTE MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THREE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK ADEQUATE PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MEDICARE PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
ON TELLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM ONE TWENTY. PASS
TEMPORARILY.
MOVING TO ITEM ONE TWENTY ONE AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY THREE ABOUT A
PARK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
THREE BY SOME A MEMBER GLORIA
AND ACTUALLY A MENTAL HEALTH
MAKING A PREPARATION THERE FOR.
I'M SORRY WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY ON ITEM ONE TWENTY
ONE.
MOVING BACK IN ORDER TO ITEM ONE
TWENTY AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY
ONE MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY ONE BY SOME A MEMBER
LIMON AND ACTUALLY ENERGY.
SOME METAL AMONG YOUR RECOGNIZED
THINK HUMANA SPEAKER AB TWENTY
EIGHT THIRTY ONE REQUIRES THAT
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION IN CONSULTATION WITH
THE OFFICE OF SMALL BUSINESS
ADVOCATES.
ENSURE THAT ADEQUATE MARKETING
AND OUTREACH ARE UNDERTAKEN TO
ENABLE SMALL BUSINESS CUSTOMERS
TO BETTER PARTICIPATE IN ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS.
IS THE EXISTING LAW PERMITS
SURCHARGES ON BILLS OF
ELECTRICITY AND GAS.
FOR CUSTOMERS THE PURPOSE OF
FUNDING INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY
ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS
HOWEVER A SMALL BUSINESSES
DESPITE PAIN INTO EXISTING
ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS
THROUGH ELECTRICITY AND GAS
RATES. PARTICIPATE MINIMALLY AND
ENERGY CONSERVATION PRACTICE
OFTEN DUE TO A LACK OF AWARENESS
AND LIMITED RESOURCES. AB TWENTY
THIRTY ONE SIX TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE BY ENSURING THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES HAVE GREATER
AWARENESS OF THE AND ACCESS TO
EXISTING ENTER ENERGY EFFICIENCY
PRACTICES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN A REQUEST TO
SPEAK METACARPALS OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES.
I SIXTY NO ONE THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM ONE TWENTY TO PASS
TEMPORARILY MOVING TO ITEM ONE
TWENTY THREE AB TWENTY EIGHT
FIFTY MATTER QUICKLY STREET
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
BY SOME THE MEMBER RUBIO AND
ACTUALLY TO HEALTH FACILITIES.
SOME MEMBER RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BELT
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY A BILL WHICH
WOULD AUTHORIZE THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. TO APPROVE THE
REQUIRED SIXTY HOURS OF
CLASSROOM TRAINING FOR CERTIFIED
NURSING ASSISTANTS
TO BE OFFERED THROUGH ONLINE OR
DISTANCE LEARNING CLASSES.
CALIFORNIA'S SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES ARE FACING WORKFORCE.
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE
WITH OVER FOURTEEN MILLION
PEOPLE AND MEDI CAL AN ELEVEN
HUNDRED CALIFORNIANS TURNING
SIXTY FIVE YEARS. OLD EVERYDAY
THERE MUST BE AN ATTRACTIVE AND
SUSTAINABLE. WORKFORCE IN PLACE
IN ORDER TO CARE FOR OUR OUR
AGING POPULATION
THIS BILL WILL HELP ADDRESS THE
CALIFORNIA'S SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES WORKFORCE SHORTAGE.
BY MODERNIZING THE CLASSROOM
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS TO BECOME
A CEO NAME.
GIVEN THE CONVENIENCE AND
EFFICIENCY OF ONLINE COURSEWORK
ALLOWING POTENTIAL CMA'S
THE OPTION OF PURSUING THIS
PORTION OF THEIR CERTIFICATION
ONLINE IS A COMMON SENSE
APPROACH TOWARD TOWARDS.
MODERNIZING THE CERTIFICATION
PROCESS AND ENCOURAGING MORE
PEOPLE TO GET INTO THE FIELD.
AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD IN
MODERNIZING THE PROCESS TO
BECOME A CERTIFIED NURSING
ASSISTANT.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO A DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE METACARPALS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS BOTH THE DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MEDICAL PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING THE VOTES EYES FIFTY SIX
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION MOVING BACK IN
FILE ORDER TO ITEM THIRTY THREE.
AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY EIGHT MADAM
HER PLEASE READ.
AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRO AND
ACTUALLY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER GROW YOUR
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
EIGHT STATES WITH THAT ONE A
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
ATTEMPTS TO CONSOLIDATE AUTHORED
CONTROLLER AND TREASURER TAX
COLLECTOR OFFICERS THE MOVE MUST
BE APPROVED BY A VOTE OF THE
PEOPLE. AND THE VOTERS WILL
DECIDE IF WILL BE APPOINTED OR
ELECTED POSITION.
THE BILL DOES NOT IMPACT FIVE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
SPECIFIED IN EXISTING LAW
THEY'RE CURRENTLY CONSOLIDATING
THESE OFFICES AN ELECTED
POSITION.
THE BILL ENSURES INDEPENDENCE OF
THESE OFFICERS CHARGED WITH
MANAGING TAXPAYER DOLLARS WITH
INTEGRITY PROFESSIONALISM AND
IMPARTIALITY THANK YOU I ASKED
WE ARE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MADAM CLERK WAS OPEN
THE RUN. ON MEMBERS VOTE YOU
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
NOT A QUICKLY IS CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING NOW BACK IN FILE ORDER TO
ITEM ONE TWENTY FOUR AB TWENTY
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE MINUTE QUICKLY
THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE BY SELLING MEMBER BRO AND
ACTUALLY DID TAXATION.
SOME MEMBER GROW YOUR RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY FIVE WILL
EXPEDITE BUSINESS TAX REFUNDS AS
A RESULT OF AN OPERATING LOSS.
THIS IS A WIN FOR BUSINESSES AND
OFTEN EXPERIENCE LOSS DURING THE
FIRST YEAR IN OPERATION.
IT'S ALSO WHEN FOR THE STATE
BECAUSE A STATESMAN HOLDING ON
TO THESE ARE RETURNS RESULTING
IN MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
INTEREST BEING CHARGED TO
TAXPAYERS. AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE IS SUPPORTED BY A COALITION
A TAXPAYER ADVOCATES BUSINESS
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE THE.
THANK YOU SING NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK METAPHOR QUIZ OPEN THEIR
OWN. NUMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE?
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM ONE TWENTY FIVE PASS
TEMPORARILY MOVING TO ITEM ONE
TWENTY SIX AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
EIGHT MADAM HER PLEASE READ. AT
SOME LEVEL TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
EIGHT BY FAMILY MEMBERS SANTIAGO
AND ACTUALLY THE TRIAL COURTS
THANK YOU A SUMMER SANTIAGO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MEN'S BIGGER TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY PROVIDES A LAW CLERK.
IS A PROVIDES A LOT OF THE LA
COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT EMPLOYEE
IF YEAR SHE IS EMPLOYED FOR MORE
THAN A HUNDRED.
IN EIGHTY DAYS.
THIS PRACTICE OF LABELING A
EMPLOYEES AS LIMITED TERM VERSUS
TEMPER IS INTENTIONAL AND
CIRCUMVENT EXISTING LAW AND
SIMPLY UNFAIR.
I SUSPECT WE ASK AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE NOT A PART PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TELLING THE VOTES EYES
FIFTH FORTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY THE
MEASURE PASSES
.
ITEM OF ONE TWENTY SEVEN PASS
AND RETAIN MOVING TO ITEM ONE
TWENTY EIGHT AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY SEVEN MATTER QUICKLY
THREE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE HOUSING.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN
AMENDS THE STATE'S MIGRANT
HOUSING PROGRAM TO GIVE EACH
COUNTIES OPERATING AGENCY
GREATER DECISION MAKING POWER.
TODAY WE HAVE MANY MORE WOMEN
WORKING IN THE FIELDS WE HAVE
MANY FAMILIES LOOKING FOR PLACES
TO LIVE IN OUR STATE HOUSING
CENTERS.
THERE IS NO ONE SIZE FITS ALL
SOLUTION.
AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN
WILL UPDATE OUR A FIFTY YEAR OLD
STATE FARMERS FARMWORKERS CENTER
PROGRAM TO EMPOWER LOCAL HOUSING
AUTHORITIES TO UTILIZE RESOURCES.
TAILORED TO THE NEEDS OF OUR
FARMWORKERS.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AM
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM OF ONE TWENTY
NINE AB TWENTY NINE OH EIGHT
METAPHOR PLEASE READ. THAT SOME
EVIL TWENTY NINE OH EIGHT BY
SOME A MEMBER BERMAN AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE TIRE RECYCLING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY NINE OH A A BILL WHICH
WOULD HELP CREATE A MARKET FOR
THE. FORTY FOUR MILLION USED
TIRES THAT CALIFORNIANS GENERATE
EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
ILLEGALLY DUMPED TIRES POSE A
SIGNIFICANT COST TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN THE STATE. LARGE
ABANDONED TIRE PILES HAVE
RESULTED IN WEEKS LONG FIRES AND
THE OVERALL RECYCLING RATE HAS
GONE DOWN THE LAST FOUR YEARS.
IN ORDER TO SUBSTANTIALLY
INCREASE TIRE RECYCLING AB
TWENTY NINE OH WE WILL CREATE
THE TIRE RECYCLING INCENTIVE
PROGRAM. EMPLOYING A PROVEN
MODEL OF PERFORMANCE BASED
INCENTIVE FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE
USE OF RUBBERIZED PAVEMENT AND
OTHER CONSUMER PRODUCTS MADE
FROM USED TIRES.
TO FUND THIS NEW PROGRAM TOWER
CYCLE WOULD SPEND DOWN SURPLUS
DOLLARS IN THE CALIFORNIA TIRE
RECYCLING MANAGEMENT FUND WHICH
IS UNDER UTILIZE MONEY THAT
SHOULD BE USE FOR THIS TYPE OF
PROGRAM. IT SHOULD BE AN SHOULD
BE SPENTFASTER THAN IT
CURRENTLY IS.
ONCE THE SURPLUS IS DRAWN DOWN
THE BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE A FEW
TO COVER CAL RECYCLES COSTS OF
REGULATING WASTE TIRES.
COLLEAGUES THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THAT TIRE RECYCLING IN
CALIFORNIA IS NOT GENERATING THE
RESULTS THAT WE NEED TO END THIS
INCENTIVE WILL HELP ESTABLISH. A
MARKET FOR USED TIRE DERIVED
PRODUCTS EVER QUIT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
ON AB TWENTY NINE ALWAYS.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER FRAZIER YOUR
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. OF COLLEAGUES IN IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN I DID A SIMILAR
BILL WINTEL RECYCLE HAD ABOUT A
FIFTY FOUR MILLION DOLLAR
SURPLUS IN THIS ACCOUNT. AND OUR
BILL WAS TO EXPEDITE THE THE
USAGE OF THIS MONEY TO GET THIS
OUT INTO THE PAVEMENT. CAN YOU
IMAGINE DURING THE RECESSION
THAT THAT'S THIS AGENCY HELD ON
TO FIFTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
WHEN WE'RE CONSTRAINED WITH
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS.
AND NOW HERE WE ARE AGAIN AND
THE COUNT IS ACTUALLY LARGER
THAN WHEN WE DID THE BILL. NOT
VAST ARE ACCOUNTABILITY CHAIR TO
LOOK INTO AGENCIES THAT DON'T
RESPOND TO THE BILLS THAT WE PUT
OUT.
AND ASKING THEM TO DO WHAT'S
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE WANTS.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING I AM A CO AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL. BUT I THINK THAT WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO THE
PEOPLE THAT WE REPRESENT THE ONE
WE REQUIRE THE AGENCY TO RESPOND.
TO A BILL THIS PUT IN STATUE.
AND THEN THEY SAY THAT IS UNDER
SUBSCRIBE BUT THEIR MARKETING
POLICY IS ABSOLUTELY.
REPREHENSIBLE WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE MORE ACTION WITH THESE
AGENCIES TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
GO OUT AND DO WHAT WE INTEND
THEM TO DO. WITH THAT'LL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL BUT I'LL BE
WATCHING TELL RECYCLE VERY
CLOSELY.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MADAM CLERK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
TIRED OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MISTER BERMAN WHO.
SINCE NUMBER COLLEAGUES ON THE
FORM OF THE CALL THANKS
TO BERMAN MOVES THE CALL
.
MOVING AND FILE ORDER TO ITEM
ONE THIRTY AB TWENTY NINE TEN
MINUTE QUICKLY ST.
SOME LEGAL TWENTY NINE TEN BY
SOME THE MEMBER WOULD AND
ACTUALLY NEED TO TELECOMMUTE.
THANK YOU A SOME NEVER WOULD YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THE DEVASTATING
FIRES THAT RAVAGED NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE STATE IN THE CP
YOU SEE A FOCUS HEAVILY ON THE
UTILITIES RESPONSE TO THE
MASSIVE DESTRUCTION.
HOWEVER LITTLE IS KNOWN ABOUT
THE IMPACT THESE NATURAL
DISASTERS HAVE ON
TELECOMMUNICATIONS NETWORKS AND
HOW TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES
HAVE RESPONDED.
WHILE WE AGREE THAT THE CPUC HAS
THE AUTHORITY TO COLLECT THE
INFORMATION SPECIFIED IN THE
BILL THAT CPUC IS NOT REQUIRED
TO PURSUE SUCH A REPORT. TODAY
THE CPC CPUC HAS NEVER PRODUCED
SUCH A REPORT BEEN LEFT IN THE
DARK WHEN IT COMES TO UNDERSTAND
THE TECHNOLOGY THAT MAY BE USED
TO REBUILD INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
NORTH BAY. WHERE THE COMPANIES
HAVE PUT TEMPORARY FIXES IN
PLACE OR INSTEAD INVESTED IN
PERMANENT UPGRADES?
WITHOUT THIS INFORMATION HERE'S
NO WAY TO ENSURE THAT RESIDENTS
WILL HAVE THE SAME OR IMPROVED
ACCESS TO RELIABLE NETWORK.
OCTOBER TENTH THE HUMBLE COUNTY
SHERIFF DECLARED A LOCAL
EMERGENCY MY DISTRICT DUE TO A
WIDESPREAD PHONE SERVICE
FAILURES CAUSED BY THE NORTH BAY
FIRES.
THE OUTAGES
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND GOVERNMENT PRIVATE
AGENCIES TO PROVIDE ESSENTIAL
PUBLIC SERVICES.
AB TWENTY NINE TEN WOULD FOR
REQUIRE THE PETE CPUC TO REPORT
TO THE APPROPRIATE POLICY
COMMITTEE OF THE LEGISLATURE.
THE IMPACT OF A NATURAL DISASTER
ON THE STATE'S COMMUNICATIONS
TELLING THAT TO COME
TELECOMMUNICATIONS NETWORK. AND
RESPONSE OF TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPANY.
AT THAT AS TIME PASSES IT'S
LIKELY THAT A DAMAGED OR
DESTROYED NETWORK INFRASTRUCTURE
WILL BE REPLACED THEIR STRONG
PUBLIC INTEREST ENSURING THAT
NEWER EQUIPMENT RESULTS IN
IMPROVED OR MORE AND MORE
RESILIENT SERVICES.
THE BILL WOULD NOT REQUIRE
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES TO
DEVELOP INFORMATION WE HARMFUL
TO SECURITY SUCH AS TO
DISCLOSURE OF ADDRESSES A
PROPOSED NETWORK FACILITY
LOCATIONS. OR AN ITEMIZED LIST
OF. EQUIPMENT DEPLOYED.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON.
ON EVERY ALL MEMBERS VOTE YOU
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
SOMEONE THERE WOULD.
MISTER WOOD REQUESTS THAT WE
MOVE THE CALL.
MOVING NOW TO IDEA ONE THIRTY
ONE HAS BEEN DISPENSED WITH
MOVING TO ITEM ONE THIRTY TWO AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTEEN. MADAM
QUICKLY THREE.
ASSEMBLY MULTIPLANE AND FIFTEEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CABALLERO AND
OTHERS NATURALLY TO WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT.
A SUMMER MCCARTY OR YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
PERCENT AB TWENTY NINE FIFTEEN.
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD.
TO CONVENE LOCAL DEVELOPMENT
BOARDS TO DEVELOP A MEMORANDUM
OF UNDERSTANDING TO COORDINATE.
MUTUAL AID ASSISTANCE IN
DISASTER RELIEF EFFORTS.
THIS WOULD ALLOW LOCAL BOARDS TO
ASSIST REGIONS DAMAGE AND
DEVASTATED BY NATURAL DISASTER
BY SENDING STAFF AND RESOURCES
JUST TO ASSIST IN OUTREACH AS
WELL AS BUSINESS AND CLIENT
SERVICES.
AS CALIFORNIA HAS SEEN FROM
RECENT FIRES FLOODS AND MUD
SLIDES THERE IS AN URGENT NEED
TO HELP BUSINESSES AND FAMILIES
RECOVER AND TO HELP WORKERS WHO
ARE DISPLACED. BECAUSE OF A
DISASTER.
AB TWENTY NINE FIFTEEN AS IT
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPRT IN
POLICY COMMITTEES HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS RECEIVED NO
NO VOTES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS BOTH
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
HIGHS FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
ITEMS ONE THIRTY THREE AND ONE
THIRTY FOUR PASS TEMPORARILY
ITEM ONE THIRTY FIVE PASS AND
RETAIN MOVING OUT ITEM ONE
THIRTY SIX AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY
FOUR MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE THIRTY
FOUR BY SOME THE MEMBER MARK
STONE AND OTHERS ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC HEALTH. THINK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I MEMBERS WITH THAT
CONAGRA DECISION BEING FINALIZED.
THE PAIN COMPANIES HAVING BEEN
FOUND LIABLE THE TEN
JURISDICTIONS. WHO BENEFITTED
FROM WINNING THAT LAWSUIT NOW
NEED TO GO OUT AND WE'RE
INSPECTS? BUILDINGS AND GET THEM
OR GET THE LEAD PAINT REMEDIATED
FROM THOSE BUILDINGS. THIS BILL
WILL FACILITATE. LEAD PAINT AND
LET INSPECTORS BEING ABLE TO. BE
CERTIFIED THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IN ORDER TO GET
THE MONEY SPENT PRODUCES AN OPT
IN PROGRAM THAT ALLOWS WORKING
WITH THE HEALTH DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND THE COUNTIES
TO ENSURE THAT THAT THE
INSPECTORS DO GET CERTIFIED SO
THAT THE MONEY CAN GET SPENT AND
THE LEAD PAINT CAN GET
REMEDIATED I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTES.
THANK YOU SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE NOT A PARK WAS OPEN THE
ROLE. MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
MR SOME OF THE CALL.
AND THE.
MOVING NOW BACK IN THE FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION TO ITEM ONE
THIRTY FOUR AB TWENTY NINE
THIRTY MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY NINE THIRTY
BY SOME A MEMBER SANTIAGO AND
ACTUALLY THE TENNESSEE.
THANK YOU WITH SOME MEMBER
SANTIAGO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MAN SPEAKER AB TWENTY
NINE THIRTY EXTEND THE SUNSET
AND TOLD TWENTY TWENTY FOUR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA UNLAWFUL DETAINER
PILOT PROGRAM.
A PROGRAM HAS BEEN IN EXISTENCE
IN THE CITY LOS ANGELES ARE
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT AND
SINCE BEEN HAD HAS BEEN
AUTHORIZED IN. TWO THOUSAND NINE
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN.
I WOULD COLLEAGUES TO EXTENDING
THE PROGRAM AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AND THERE'S
NO OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MATTER QUICKLY IS OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM ONE THIRTY SEVEN PASS
TEMPORARILY ON MOVING OUT ITEM
ONE THIRTY EIGHT AB TWENTY NINE
FIFTY THREE MADAM COURT PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE
FIFTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LIMON AND ACTUALLY CONSUMER
LOANS THINK U. S. SOME MEMBERS
AMONG YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY THREE WILL
BRING MUCH NEEDED CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS TO ONE SEGMENT OF A
IMPORTANT SPACE.
UPON ACCEPTING MY ROLE AS CHAIR
OF THE BANKING COMMITTEE I'VE
HEARD COMMON REFRAIN FROM FELLOW
MEMBERS CONSUMER ADVOCATES
REGULATORS LENDERS AND THE MEDIA
THAT SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE DONE
ABOUT SMALL DOLLAR CONSUMER
LOANS IN CALIFORNIA.
UNDER TITLE LOANS REQUIRE
CONSUMER TO PLEDGE THEIR VEHICLE
AS COLLATERAL ON THE LOAN
POLICING AT RISK ONE OF THEIR
MOST VALUABLE ASSETS AND OFTEN
THEIR PRIMARY MODE OF
TRANSPORTATION TO WORK TO SCHOOL
AND ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE.
UNFORTUNATELY TOO MANY CONSUMERS
WHO TAKE OUT A TITLE LOAN HAVE
THEIR CARS REPOSSESSED WHEN THEY
ARE UNABLE TO MAKE SCHEDULED
LOAN PAYMENTS.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND CARS REPOSSESSED
COMPARED TO A HUNDRED AND EIGHT
LOANS ORIGINATED. INDICATING
THAT NEARLY ONE IN FIVE TITLE
NAM BUYERS HAVE THEIR CAR
REPOSSESSED.
I AM A STRONG BELIEVER IN THE
VALUE OF CREDIT MARKETS
AND I DO NOT WANT TO ELIMINATE A
BUSINESS THAT PROVIDE. AN
ESSENTIAL SERVICE TO CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS
I ALSO BELIEVE THAT HEALTHY
CREDIT MARKETS ARE BUILT UPON
THE FOUNDATION OF SOUND
UNDERWRITING OF A BORROWS
ABILITY TO PAY.
IF THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD I AM
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH INDUSTRY IN GOOD FAITH AND
CONSIDER THAT THE OPPORTUNITIES
TO CONSIDER THE FOLLOWING.
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF RATE CAPS CONSIDER
ALTERNATIVE UNDERWRITING
LANGUAGE. IMPROVE REPOSSESSION
PRACTICES WHILE ENSURING THOSE
WHO DO NOT QUALIFY FOR AND
SECURED LOANS HAVE ACCESS TO
CREDIT AND INCREASE INCREASING
CONSUMER PROTECTION.
TO I RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN AYE
VOTES.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY THREE WE OFTEN
HEAR THE PHRASE SLIPPERY SLOPE
ON THIS FLOOR WE.
HEARD ABOUT.
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT
TIMES TODAY AS A MATTER OF FACT.
I CAN'T THINK OF ANYTHING MORE
SLIPPERY THAN DOWN WORLDS
DOWNWARD SPIRAL THE TRAPS TOO
MANY LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
WHO HAVE BEEN VICTIMIZED BY
PREDATORY LENDING?
BECAUSE.
RATES ARE TOO HIGH ANTI LOAN
CITIES CALIFORNIANS NOT ONLY
LOSE THEIR CARS.
BUT ALSO THEIR JOBS AND THEIR
ABILITY TO PAY THEIR BILLS.
WE NEED TO ENSURE ACCESS TO
CREDIT.
WE NEED TO ENSURE RESPONDENTS
RESPONSIBLE LENDING PRACTICE
PRACTICES.
AB TWENTY NINE FIFTIES THREE
STRIKES THAT BALANCE I ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THINK YOU SEE NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MADAM CLERK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
QUIRK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES.
AYE AYES FORTY THREE KNOWS ONE
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM ONE THIRTY NINE PASS
TEMPORARILY MOVING TO ITEM ONE
FORTY AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY SIX
ADEQUATE PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY SIX BY FAMILY MEMBER
QUIRK AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
HEALTH. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY SIX
DIRECT THE DEPARTMENT OF.
PUBLIC HELPED COORDINATE WITH
APPROPRIATE STATE AGENCIES.
ON DATA REGARDING COMPLIANCE
WITH CHILDHOOD LEAD LEAD TESTING.
MY COMMITTEE HELD AN OVERSIGHT
HEARING IN FEBRUARY TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE COMPLIANCE RATE.
ATTESTING CHILDREN FOR LEAD
EXPOSURE.
DATA WAS DIFFICULT COMPLETELY
WIPED CAME COMPLIANCE LEVELS
WERE DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE.
FURTHER WE DIDN'T WE BELIEVE
THAT COMPLIANCE IS LOW. HOWEVER
WE DON'T KNOW WHY.
SO AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY SIX
WILL MANDATE COLLABORATION AND
PARTICIPATION SO WE CAN GET
BETTER INFORMATION ON HOW WELL
OR HOW POORLY. WE ARE TESTING
CHILDREN AT RISK
FOR LEAD POISONING.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY UNDERSTAND
WHY
APPLIANCES NOT BETTER.
THIS BILL WAS HAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SEEING NO
REQUEST TO SPEAK MADAM CLERK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND HOW THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY SIX NOW ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM ONE FORTY ONE PASS
TEMPORARILY MOVING TO ITEM ONE
FORTY TWO AB TWENTY NINE NINETY
TWO MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE NINETY
TWO BY SOME REMEMBER DALY AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE PEACE
OFFICER TRAINING THANK YOU SO
MEMBER DALY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
COMMISSION ON POLICE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING.
A GREAT A COMPREHENSIVE TRAINING
COURSE FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS FOCUSING ON HOW TO
RESPOND TO CHILD VICTIMS.
COMMERCIAL SEXUAL EXPLOITATION.
THIS TRAINING WILL HELP INCREASE
THE IDENTIFICATION AND REPORTING
OF CHILD VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION REMOVE CHILDREN
FROM ABUSE DISAPPEAR SITUATIONS
AND CONNECT HIM OR HER. TO THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED IN ORDER TO
RECOVER AND LEAD ACTIVE
FULFILLING LIVES I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO REQUEST TO SPEAK
MEDICAL PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE YOU DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
ICE FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEMS ONE FORTY THREE ONE FORTY
FOUR AND ONE FORTY FIVE PASS
TEMPORARILY MOVING TO ITEM ONE
FORTY SIX A. B. THIRTY SIXTY
EIGHT MATTER QUICKLY THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY SIXTY EIGHT
BY FAMILY MEMBER DALY AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
THANK YOU SO MEMBER DALY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS THIS BILL
STRENGTHENS THE INDEPENDENCE AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF COUNTY AUDITOR
CONTROLLERS.
BY ESTABLISHING NECESSARY
SAFEGUARDS TO REMOVE CONCERNS
REGARDING ANY POTENTIAL
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST.
THROUGH THIS BILL AUDITOR
CONTROLLERS WILL HAVE THE
ABILITY TO THOROUGHLY EVALUATE
THE FINANCIAL DECISIONS AND
SPENDING WITHIN THEIR RESPECTIVE
COUNTIES FREE FROM MANY FEAR AND
INTIMIDATION OR CONFLICTS OF. OF
INTEREST.
BY THOSE WHO THEY ARE EXAMINING.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SING A REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY SEVEN AT NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM ONE FORTY SEVEN
E. B. THIRTY SEVENTY SIX MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ. AT SOME REAL
THIRTY SEVENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE CHILD WELFARE
THINK YOU A SUMMARY AS YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS A. B. THIRTY
SEVENTY SIX PROVIDES MUCH NEEDED
ASSISTANCE.
THE TRIBES AND THEIR MEMBERS IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
ADEQUATELY REPRESENTED IN CHILD.
TRIBAL WELFARE CASES.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
CONGRESS PASSED REQUIRE THE
INDIAN CHILD WELFARE ACT
TO PROTECT THE INTEREST OF
TRIBAL CHILDREN TO PROMOTE
STABILITY. AND SECURITY FOR
TRIBES AND THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS.
HOWEVER STATE COURTS AND COUNTY
AGENCIES CONTINUE TO ILLUSTRATE
OUR MAJOR LACK
APPLIANCE WITH EQUAL.
WELL PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE THE
MAJOR CONCERNS PERSIST REGARDING
EQUAL COMPLIANCE.
AND HOW IT WAS.
PROCEEDINGS ARE CONDUCTED.
THE COMPLIANCE.
COMPLIANCE TASK FORCE WAS FORMED
WHICH REPORTED TO TURN THE
GENERAL AND FOUND THAT MANY
TRIBES. DO NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES SUFFICIENT TO RETAIN
LEGAL COUNSEL LEAVING TRIBES.
AS THE SOLE ON REPRESENTED PARTY
IN CHILD WELFARE CASES WERE
EQUAL APPLIES.
BY PASSING A B. THIRTY SEVENTY
SIX
A GRANT WILL BE PUT IN PLACE
WHICH CAN HELP FINANCIALLY
SUPPORT TRIBES. AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND EQUAL CASES BY
FINANCING ADEQUATE COUNSEL TO
HELP SUPPORT THEM. THIS WILL NOT
ONLY STOP YOU BORN AMOUNT OF
APPEALS.
WHICH HAVE BACKLOGGED OUR COURT
SYSTEM BUT ALSO ACTIVELY HELP
STOP THE TEARING APART OF TRIBAL
CHILDREN FROM THEIR FAMILIES.
AND UNNECESSARILY PLACING THEM
IN FOSTER CARE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
I AM ONE FORTY EIGHT A. B.
THIRTY ONE FIFTEEN MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ. SOME LEGAL THIRTY
ONE FIFTEEN BY SOMETHING MEMBER
GIPSON AND ACTUALLY THE COUNTY
JAILS THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
ONE FIFTEEN WHICH SEEKS TO
EDUCATE THOSE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED IN COUNTY JAILS
ABOUT VOTER REGISTRATION AND
VOTERS RIGHTS TO HELP THEM. FEEL
MORE CONNECTED TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
AND ENCOURAGE THEM TO GET
INVOLVED IN CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
CALIFORNIA INCARCERATION IS OVER
EIGHTY THOUSAND PEOPLE IN ITS
JAILS AND MORE THAN HALF. OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN
CONVICTED OR NOT SENTENCE.
THIS IS A LARGE A LARGE
COMMUNITY THAT HISTORICALLY BEEN
EXCLUDED FROM PARTICIPATING IN
THIS PROCESS. THIS PROGRAM.
WOULD INCLUDE BUT NOT BE LIMITED
TO VOTER REGISTRATION VOTERS'
RIGHTS ASSISTING THEM TO READ.
THOUGHT THE VOTER REGISTRATION
FORM AND RETURN IT BACK TO THE
ELECTION OFFICIAL I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I VOTED THIRTY ONE
FIFTEEN.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER BAKER YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SEEN A REQUEST TO
SPEAK ADEQUATE PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO IS HIRED TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MISTER GIBSON MOVES A CALL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION MOVING BACK
AND FILE ORDER TO ITEM ONE FORTY
FIVE EIGHT B.. THIRTY SIXTY ONE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY SIXTY ONE
BY SOME A MEMBER GLORIA AND
ACTUALLY DIDN'T SERGEANTS
DOUBTLESS BEEN.
THANK YOU.
THE SUMMER GLORIA YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER A. B. THIRTY SIXTY ONE
ACQUIRE MISSILES THERAPY
ESTABLISHMENTS TO REGISTER WITH
THEIR COUNTIES AS A CONDITION OF
OPERATION ORDER BETTER
COORDINATE. ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS
TO COMBAT HUMAN TRAFFICKING A
WITH THE STATE AND COUNTY IN
CITIES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING THEIR REQUEST
TO SPEAK METACARPALS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MEDICARE PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES. EYES
FORTY SEVEN KNOWS TO.
WE ARE BACK AND PILE ORDER TO
ITEM ONE FORTY NINE E. B. THIRTY
ONE TWENTY MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE TWENTY
BY SOME A MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AND EXPLAIN CHILD
SEXUAL ASSAULT THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY WOULD
EXTEND THE CIVIL STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS FOR VICTIMS OF
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ASSAULT FROM
THE AGE OF TWENTY SIX TO THE AGE
OF FORTY.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF DAMAGES RECOVERABLE IN
INSTANCES WHERE THERE WAS A
COVER UP WHICH LED TO FURTHER
ABUSE. AND ALLOW FOR A VERY
SHORT WINDOW FOR PAST CLAIMS
WHICH HAVE SLIPPED THROUGH THE
CRACKS.
SOME OF YOU TALK TO ME ABOUT THE
SPELLING AND WE REFERRED TO IT
LOOSELY IS THE CATHOLIC CHURCH
BILL.
BUT REALITY THIS ISN'T THE
CATHOLIC CHURCH BILL IT MIGHT
HAVE BEEN IN TWO THOUSAND TWO
WHEN IT WAS FIRST INTRODUCED.
BUT SINCE THEN WE'VE LEARNED A
LOT.
IN IT SHOULD SCARE US HOW MUCH
WE'VE LEARNED.
THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT THE CHURCH
THIS IS ABOUT HUNDREDS OF YOUNG
ATHLETES ON OUR OLYMPIC TEAMS
WHO ARE SUBJECTED TO SEXUAL
ABUSE DESPITE EVIDENCE.
THAT'S EXECUTIVE THE TOP
OFFICIALS KNEW OF THE PREDATORY
BEHAVIOR IT'S ABOUT STUDENTS AT
OUR SCHOOLS WHO'VE BEEN SEXUALLY
ABUSED BY TEACHERS AND COACHES
IT.
ALL WITH A HISTORY A VERY
COMPLAINTS AGAINST THEM.
SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE THE BECAUSE
SOMEBODY IS IN THEIR MID
TWENTIES STILL HAVE THAT READY
TO PURSUE A STRESSFUL AND RETRY
MATAI THE LEGAL RECOURSE THAT WE
TELL THEM. THEY CAN ONLY PURSUE
CIVIL REMEDIES IF THEY CAN PROVE
THAT THEY HAD REPRESSED MEMORIES
OR SOMEHOW DIDN'T KNOW THEIR
ABUSE WAS AFFECTING THEM.
THIS DOESN'T ONLY DENY A VICTIMS
JUSTICE
BUT GIVEN THE EVIDENCE OF HOW
LONG IT CAN TAKE FOR VICTIMS OF
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL THOUGHTS COME
FORWARD. NOT EXPANDING THE
STATUE OF LIMITATIONS ALLOW
THESE PERPETRATORS OF ABUSE
THESE PERVERTS.
TO CONTINUE TO ABUSE OTHER
VICTIMS AND PREY ON CHILDREN
WHILE WE TURNED A BRIGHT LINE
AYE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU THE SOME MEMBER KEVIN
YEAR OF YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY
ONE I THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN DIEGO. FOR AUTHORING THIS
BILL ONE OF MY CONSTITUENTS
ROBERT MET WITH ME EARLIER THIS
YEAR AND HE SHARED HIS PERSONAL
STORY.
TO CLEAR DO CLEARLY DEMONSTRATED
THE INJUSTICE AND THE DANGER
CREATED BY THE TWO THOUSAND NINE
PROSPECTIVE ONLY AMENDMENT TO
THE GOVERNMENT CODE.
HE OUT ROBERT JOIN THE LOCAL
POLICE DEPARTMENT EXPLORER
PROGRAM IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWO
WHEN HE WAS A HIGH SCHOOL
FRESHMAN. AND THERE HE WAS ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE IN RIGHT ALONG
WITH WITH SOME POLICE OFFICERS
THE RIDE ALONGS OFTEN MADE A
STOP AT THE NOT LOCAL NINE ONE
ONE CENTER AND DURING ONE OF
THOSE STOP HE WAS INTRODUCED TO
A LOCAL GROUP LEADER IN AN
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICE.
SPECIALIST
PROCESS THE NINE ELEVEN CALLS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
THIS SPECIALIST WAS ABLE TO
BEFRIEND ROBERT AND TO GROOMING
FOR SEXUAL ABUSE WHICH IN HE
ENTERED FOR YEARS.
DURING THIS TIME HE CONFIDED TO
A MEMBER OF THE DEPARTMENT ABOUT
THE ABUSE BUT IT WASN'T TAKEN
SERIOUSLY.
BECAUSE OF THE ABUSE ENDED
BEFORE JANUARY FIRST OF TWO
THOUSAND NINE ROBERT WAS FACED
WITH A SIX MONTH CLAIM PERIOD IN
WHICH IT WAS OBLIGATED TO NOTIFY
THE AUTHORITIES OF THE ABUSE ARE
HIS CLAIM WOULD FOR EVER BE LOST.
THIS IS AN UNREASONABLE BURDEN
TO PLACE ON ANY CHILDHOOD SEXUAL
ABUSE SURVIVORS THIS ARBITRARY
TIME LIMIT NOW PREVENTS HIM FROM
SEEKING JUDGE JUSTICE. AND I ASK
THAT YOU SUPPORT A. B. THIRTY
ONE TWENTY IN HIS NAME.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY ONE TWENTY.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT WE SHOULD
KNOW THE EXTENT.
OF THE PROBLEM AND IF IN FACT.
THERE ARE VERY FEW CASES TO BE
DEALT WITH.
THAT SHOULD COME TO LIGHT.
IF IN FACT THESE KICK THESE
CASES STILL REMAIN.
BOB HOPE BALMER. VOLUMINOUS
RATHER.
.
THEY WE NEED TO KNOW THAT AS
WELL AND IS A SIMPLE BILL IS
IMPORTANT BILL AND I WOULD
RECOMMEND YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU AND SPEAKER ALSO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
THIS IS A REAL PROBLEM OUR
SOCIETY NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED.
I'M HOPEFUL AND GRATEFUL THAT
THE AUTHOR WILL CONTINUES TO
WORK WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS AND
IT CONTINUES TO TO LOOK AT THE
ISSUE A RETROACTIVITY.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU ALL DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE HAVING CEASED MADAM CLERK
WAS OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
RULE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
AYE AYES FORTY ONE IT KNOWS
THREE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM ONE FIFTY A. B.
THIRTY ONE TWENTY NINE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY ONE TWENTY NINE BY SOME
THE MEMBER RUBIO AND ACTUALLY TO
FIREARMS
SOME MEMBER RUBIO YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER TODAY
I'D LIKE TO PRESENT A. B. THIRTY
ONE TWENTY NINE A BILL TO
ENHANCE PUBLIC SAFETY BY KEEPING
GUNS OUT OF THE HANDS OF THOSE
ALREADY PROHIBITED FROM HAVING
THEM.
IN LIGHT OF THE MOST RECENT MASS
SHOOTINGS THE NATIONAL SPOTLIGHT
HAS FOCUSED ON GUNS GUN LAWS.
AND THEIR IMPACT ON SOCIETY A.
B. THIRTY ONE TWENTY NINE ALIGNS
WITH FEDERAL LAW BY IMPOSING A
LIFETIME BAN ON THE POSSESSION
OF A FIREARM FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN CONVICTED OF A MISDEMEANOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OFFENSE.
THIS IS ONE OF THE RARE
INSTANCES WHERE CALIFORNIA'S GUN
LAWS GUN LAW IS MORE LENIENT
THAN FEDERAL LAW.
MEMBERS WE'RE NOT CREATING A NEW
CLASS OF PROHIBITED PERSONS NOT
OWNING A FIREARM.
BUT MERELY HELPING KEEP GUNS OUT
OF THE ANDS OF THOSE ALREADY
PROHIBITED FROM HAVING THEM.
CURRENT STATE LAW IS AN ADEQUATE
TO FULLY PROTECT SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
ACCORDING TO THE ALLEY COUNTY
DA'S OFFICE.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
EIGHTY FOUR POINT NINE PERCENT
OF THE FELONY FIREARM CASES.
THAT THE FAMILY VIOLENCE
DIVISION FILED THE DEFENDANT HAD
A PRIOR MISDEMEANOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CONVICTION.
LET ME SAY THAT AGAIN EIGHTY
FOUR POINT NINE PERCENT
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
OF THE FELONY FIREARM CASES THAT
THE FAMILY VIOLENCE THE VISION
FILE THAT THE DEFENDANT HAD A
PRIOR MISDEMEANOR. DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CONVICTION.
ABUSED WOMEN ARE FIVE TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO BE KILLED IF THEIR
ABUSER OWNS A FIREARM.
AND THE METHOD VIOLENCE ASSAULT
INVOLVING A GUN ARE TWELVE TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO END IN DEATH.
THEN ASSAULTS WITH OTHER WEAPONS
OR PHYSICAL HARM.
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
COALITION AGAINST DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS ONE OF THE
MOST CHRONICALLY UNDER REPORTED
CRIMES.
ONLY TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF ALL
PHYSICAL ASSAULTS PERPETRATED
AGAINST FEMALES BY THEIR
PARTNERS ARE REPORTED TO THE
POLICE.
ONLY TWENTY FIVE PERCENT
REPORTED.
LET ALONE ARRESTS
PROSECUTIONS AND CONVICTIONS
THIS MEANS THAT SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT GO UNDER ON REPORTED.
THERE IS A VERY REAL CONNECTION
BETWEEN PAST DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND A PROPENSITY TO FUTURE
VIOLENCE INCLUDING MASS
SHOOTINGS.
TRAGICALLY CHILDREN ARE THE MOST
COMMON VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC MASS
SHOOTINGS.
WHILE THERE ARE NO GOVERNMENT
STATISTICS ON HOW MANY CHILDREN
ARE KILLED IN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SITUATIONS.
THE HUB HUFFINGTONPOST FOUND
THAT CHILDREN UNDER SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLD YEARS OLD MADE UP THE
LARGEST GROUP OF VICTIMS IN THE
STUDY.
AND WHILE WE SIT HERE AND
DISCUSS THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
MISDEMEANOR OFFENSE NEARLY THREE
US WOMEN EVERY DAY ARE KILLED BY
AN INTIMATE PARTNER AND NEARLY
FIFTY PERCENT. OF THOSE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CRIMES GO UNREPORTED.
THE FEDERAL BUREAU OF JUSTICE
STATISTICS SAYS AN AVERAGE OF
SEVEN HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
THOUSAND INSTANCES OF NONFATAL
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
WERE REPORTED TO POLICE ANNUALLY
OVER THE PAST DECADE AND FIVE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND
INSTANCES WHERE I'M REPORTED.
FOR THE MEMBERS WHO QUESTIONS
WHY SINGLE OUT THE MESS THAT
VIOLENCE.
WELL I HOPE I WAS ABLE TO SHED
LIGHT ON NOT ONLY THE DATA. BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF LIVES THAT HAVE
BEEN LOST OR AFFECTED BY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ABUSE
INVOLVING A FIREARM.
THANK YOU AND EVERY RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU A SOME MEMBER COMPOUND.
OF YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I.
.
JUST RISE TO URGE THOUGHTFULNESS
IN.
.
YOUR VOTE ON THIS BILL.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
THERE IS A NON NEGOTIABLE IN
FACT I'M A VICTIM A SURVIVOR OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND I KNOW
WHAT.
THAT CAN FEEL LIKE AND LOOK LIKE.
BUT POSSESSION.
THERE IS A VERY LOW THRESHOLD
FOR POSSESSION IN OUR PENAL CODE.
AND I JUST WANT TO SHARE WITH
YOU TWO EXAMPLES.
YOU COULD BE IN A CAR WITH A
FRIEND.
AND NOT KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT WHAT
IS IN THAT CAR.
AND YOU COULD GET STOPPED.
AND IF THE POLICE FIND.
A FIREARM IN THAT CAR.
POSSESSION IS CONNECTED TO YOU.
YOU COULD BE WITH A FRIEND.
GOING TO A. FIRING RANGE
YOUR FRIEND COULD NOT HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY.
TO PURCHASE BULLETS COULD NOT
HAVE THE RIGHT ID.
AND YOU COULD PURCHASE THEM FOR
THE FRIEND AND NEVER GOING TO
THE RANGE AND SHOOT.
BUT YOU HAVE A RECEIPT
AND IF YOU GET STOPPED.
YOU ARE IN POSSESSION.
SO I URGE SOME THOUGHTFULNESS IN
YOUR VOTE ON THIS BILL AND IF IT
DOES PASS I CERTAINLY HOPE THAT
THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL WILL
TAKE THESE ISSUES INTO
CONSIDERATION AS IT MOVES
FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER
YOUR RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MA'AM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I BRIEFLY STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE AND VERY
PLEASED THAT OUR COLLEAGUES
BRINGING IT FORWARD. THE AND
RESPECTFULLY THE SCENARIOS THAT
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT FORTH TO YOU
IT WOULD BE ILLEGAL.
ILLEGAL UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW FOR
A PROSECUTOR TO PROSECUTE
SOMEBODY FOR DOING THAT.
AND SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE IN THEORY
THAT MAY SOUND LIKE A PROBLEM IN
FACT.
SCRUPULOUS PROSECUTORS WILL NOT
DO WHAT YOU JUST HEARD.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE
THIS BILL IS VERY VERY MUCH
UNNECESSARY BILL. AND I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT IN FAVOR OF GOOD
POLICY AND NOT A NO VOTE BASED
ON. A HYPOTHETICAL THAT IS
ILLEGAL UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW
THINK YOU.
THANK YOU SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE IS ALL I'M
I BEG YOUR PARDON DOCTOR QUIRK
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
YEAH ARM IT'S ALREADY THERE'S
ALREADY A TEN YEAR PROHIBITION.
FOR OWNING A GUN IF IT'S A
MISDEMEANOR.
OUR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
VIOLATION.
I THINK THAT'S A GOOD LONG TIME.
ALL I COULD BE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL IF SOMEONE WHO HAD
HAVE A LONG RECORD IN IF YOU
WANT TO CHANGE FROM TEN YEARS TO
TWENTY. I COULD DO THAT ALONG
CLEAR RECORD WOULD THEN BE
EXONERATED AND ABLE TO EXERCISE
ALL THEIR CIVIL RIGHTS.
I JUST THINK THAT A LIFETIME BAN
IS TOO MUCH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BELINDA'S YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
.
WE'VE WE'VE HANDED DISCUSSION
ABOUT THIS THE AUTHOR AND I AND
AND I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO AND I THINK
YOUR INTENTIONS ARE CHEN ARE
GENUINE.
.
BUT THERE ARE FEW ISSUES SOME
SUMMER HE BROUGHT UP BY SOME OF
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS BUT I
SPOKE WITH MY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE THIS MORNING
ABOUT THIS BILL.
IN THEY SAID DIET.
YOU KNOW YOU COULD HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE.
THERE IS A CONVICTION FOR
MISDEMEANOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN
A SITUATION WHERE A HUSBAND AND
WIFE ARE BOYFRIEND AND GUARDINO
WHATEVER.
.
ONE THINKS THE OTHER IS CHEATING
ON THEM.
THEY GET INTO A FIGHT.
SHE HITS HIM THROW SOMETHING OUT
M. WHATEVER IT GOES TO COURT SHE
CAN BE. AN AND THERE ARE MANY
TIMES ARE THAT HAPPENS WHERE HE
OR SHE IS CONVICTED OF
MISDEMEANOR.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
SO DOES THAT PERSON DESERVED TO
HAVE A LIFETIME BAN. FOR OWNING
A FIREARM BECAUSE OF SOMETHING
LIKE THAT THERE ARE SOME THINGS
THAT FALL INTO THIS AREA THAT I
THINK.
MOST OF US WOULD AGREE PROBABLY
SHOULDN'T RESULT IN A LIFETIME
BAN THERE ARE SOME CERTAINLY
THAT DO BUT WE ARE LUMPING
EVERYONE INTO THE SAME CATEGORY
WHICH I THINK IS AN UNFAIR WAY
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE THERE'S
PROBABLY SOME WAYS. THIS COULD
BILL COULD BE TIGHTENED UP A
LITTLE BIT BUT I ALSO WOULD
CAUTION YOU.
IN MAKING SUCH A SWEEPING
CHANGE LIKE THIS BECAUSE YOU ARE
GOING TO BE.
ENTRAPPING A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
THIS LAW THAT DESERVE NOT TO BE
IN THEIR THINK YOU.
THANK YOU I SEE NO FURTHER
REQUEST TO SPEAK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I JUST POINT TO SAY THAT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS NO RACE.
ETHNICITY CLASS OR GENDER IT
IMPACTS EVERY COMMUNITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND I STAND HERE
TODAY WITH SURVIVORS. UP OF
DOMESTIC FROM DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
WITH EVERY COMMUNITY AND I ASK
YOUR SUPPORT. OF THIS IS ALSO
CODIFYING THE FEDERAL LAW THAT
ALREADY IMPOSES A LIFETIME BANS
ó CALIFORNIA FOR SOME REASON
IT IS NOT IN LINE WITH FEDERAL
LAW WHICH. IS SURPRISING TO ME
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S USUALLY THE
WILL OF THE BUT LEADING.
STATE IN ISSUES LIKE THIS SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU BENEFIT PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE
.
THIS RUBIO.
IT'S RUBIO MOVES A CALL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE ARE MOVING.
BACK TO ITEM ONE TWENTY FIVE AB
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY FIVE METAPHOR
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY FIVE BY FAMILY
MEMBER DAVID CHIU AND ACTUALLY A
TRANSPORTATION.
THANK YOU SOME MEMBER TO YOUR
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY FIVE AS A DISTRICT
BILL TO ALLOW THE SAN FRANCISCO
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
TO UTILIZE MANAGE LANES. TO
ALLEVIATE CONGESTION ON THE I
TWO EIGHTY AND U. S. WANNA ONE
QUARTERS WHICH RUNS THROUGH SAN
FRANCISCO CONNECTS TO SAN MATEO
AND SANTA CLARA COUNTIES.
THE BAY AREA SUFFERING AND
INTENSE CONGESTION CRISIS LAST
YEAR BARRIER RESIDENTS CITING
GRIDLOCK FOR ALMOST EIGHTY HOURS
ON TOP OF THEIR ALREADY AWFUL
COMMUTES. MANAGE LANES
INCENTIVIZE CARPOOLING TRANSIT
USE AND PASSENGER EFFICIENCY
WITHOUT ADDING MORE CARS TO THE
ROAD. THEY ALREADY EXIST IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND SAN MATEO
COUNTIES CURRENTLY PERFORMING
ENVIRONMENTAL EVALUATIONS
UNFORTUNATELY OUR CITY DOES NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE THE ABILITY. TO
IMPLEMENT MANAGE EXPRESS LANES
ON THE QUARTERS I MENTION
DESPITE EXISTING AUTHORITY IN
OUR NEIGHBORING COUNTIES
I WOULD FORTY CONTINUING EFFORTS
WAS STAKEHOLDERS THROUGHOUT THE
BAY AREA. AS THIS BILL
PROGRESSES THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK BRUNEI
BOAT.
THANK YOU.
SINGLE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE
BUT A QUIRK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE ON TELLY THE VOTES EYES
FORTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY ONE THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE ARE MOVING
TO ITEM ONE FORTY ONE AB TWENTY
NINE SEVENTY NINE MADAM FIRST
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY NINE BY SOME A MEMBER
BURKE AND ACTUALLY THE CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
THINKING AS SPEAKER ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY NINE SEVENTY NINE
ESTABLISHES THE STATE SEAL OF
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PATHWAY COMPLETION.
TO RECOGNIZE HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES WHO ATTAINED A HIGH
LEVEL OF KNOWLEDGE IN
PROFICIENCY IN A CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PATHWAYS. CT
PREPARE STUDENTS FOR THE WORLD
OF WORK BY INTRODUCING THEM TO
WORKPLACE COMPETENCIES AND MAKES
ACADEMIC CONTENT ACCESSIBLE TO
STUDENTS PROVIDING IT IN A HANDS
ON CONTEXT.
ALONG THE WAY STUDENTS DEVELOP
CAREER RELEVANT REAL WORLD
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY SKILLS
ACTUALLY BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD
CONTINUE TO PUSH IT TO ENSURE
GRADUATES ARE BOTH COLLEGE AND
CAREER READY. THE MESSENGER ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GAIN THE SKILLS
NECESSARY TO OBTAIN A JOB
PROVIDES ECONOMIC SECURITY FOR
THEIR FAMILIES AND WE MUST
SUPPORT A STRONG AND GROWING
MIDDLE CLASS A BETWEEN NINE
SEVENTY NINE. RECOGNIZE THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF GRADUATE TO
COMPLETE A CT PATHWAY BY
AWARDING THEM A STATE SEAL OF
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PATHWAY COMPLETION ON THEIR
DIPLOMA ASPECT WHERE QUESTION I.
THANK YOU SEEING THEIR REQUEST
TO SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MEDICARE PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I SIXTY TWO NO ZERO.
WE ARE MOVING BACK IN FILE ORDER
TO ITEM ONE FIFTY ONE AB THIRTY
ONE THIRTY SIX MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE THIRTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL
AN ACT RELATING TO SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL YOUR
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB THIRTY
ONE THIRTY SIX OVERRIDE MUCH
NEEDED FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE
EDUCATION. OF OUR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES.
THIS BILL EQUALIZES SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING RATES PROVIDES
FUNDING FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
PRESCHOOL SERVICES
AND PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR HIGHER
COSTS PLACEMENTS.
OUR STUDENTS WITH EXCEPTIONAL
NEEDS DESERVE A HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATION WHICH ALLOWS THEM TO
REACH
THEREFORE POTENTIAL.
THE CALIFORNIA SYSTEM OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION FINANCE IS AN EQUAL
AND SIMPLY AN ADQUATE.
ALL THE ADJUSTMENTS IN THIS BILL
ARE COMMON SENSE INVESTMENTS IN
FAIRNESS AND EQUALITY FOR OUR
VALUED STUDENTS AYE ASPIRIN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU WITH SOME CUNNINGHAM
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT AND I THINK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR LONG BEACH
FOR CARRYING THIS. IMPORTANT
MEASURE IF YOU SPENT SOME TIME
ON A LOCAL SCHOOL BOARD. OR
YOU'RE IN CONTACT WITH YOUR
EDUCATION PROFESSIONALS YOU KNOW
THAT SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING
AS IT.
IN DIRE NEED IN CALIFORNIA I
THINK THIS BILL THE POSITIVE
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AYE URGENT
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER IS THE CHAIR OF
THE SELECT COMMITTEE FOR THE
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED IN CALIFORNIA. I
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL
IN FIGHTING FOR MORE RESOURCES
FOR OUR UNDERSERVED POPULATION
OF THE SPECIAL NEEDS POPULATION
IN THE EDUCATION SECTOR WE CAN
DO ALL. WE CAN ONE APPEAR WE'VE
GOT TO SUPPORT THIS POPULATION
WHO'S BEEN CUT DRAMATICALLY OVER
THIS THE THROUGH THE RECESSIONS
AND NEVER BEEN RESTORED SO I.
URGE YOU VER MUCH DO WELL. TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE AS A GROUP. OF
MOVING FORWARD TO SUPPORT THIS
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THURMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES ARE RISE SAID AT MY
VOICE IN SUPPORT A. B. THIRTY
ONE THIRTY SIX AM PROUD TO BE TO
AN AUTHOR. I LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FROM LONG BEACH REYES
LEADERSHIP HERE.
AS YOU'VE HEARD THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION IS BEEN UNDERFUNDED A
FOR DECADES AND IT HAS FORCED
MANY OF OUR FAMILIES.
TO GO WITHOUT MUCH NEEDED
SERVICES OF FOR THEIR STUDENTS
IN EVERY STUDENT DESERVES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN.
REGARDLESS OF THE WAY IN WHICH
THEY LEARN THIS IS A GREAT STEP
TO MOVE FORWARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL OF OUR KIDS GET THE
CHANCE TO LEARN INCLUDING OUR
STUDENTS.
SPECIAL NEEDS TO RESPECT WE ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE FOR AB THIRTY ONE
THIRTY SIX.
THANK YOU ALL DISCUSSION HAVING
CEASED METACARPALS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
BENEFIT PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY THREE
KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM ONE FIFTY TWO A. B. THIRTY
ONE THIRTY SEVEN METAPHOR PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE THIRTY
SEVEN BY SOMETHING NUMBER
RODRIGUEZ AND ACTUALLY THE STATE
PROPERTY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE RICE
PRESENT AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY
SEVEN. THIS IS THE DISTRICT BILL
WHICH WILL ELIMINATE AN
UNNECESSARY DEED RESTRICTION ON
THE EAST COUNTY FIRE TRAINING
CENTER LOCATED CITY POMONA. SO
THAT THE CITY MAY SELL THE
PROPERTY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SING A REQUEST TO
SPEAK NOT APART PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
MEDICARE PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM ONE FIFTY THREE
A. B. THIRTY ONE FORTY ONE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ. AT SOME LEVEL
THIRTY ONE FORTY ONE BUT THE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS AND ACTUALLY TO THE
BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER LOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS
IS THE EXTENSION OF THE BUREAU
OF AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CLERK WAS OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS PRODUCE HIGHER TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLER PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO.
MOVING TO ITEM ONE OF FIFTY FOUR
A. B. THIRTY ONE FORTY TWO
METAPHOR PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY ONE FORTY TWO BUT
THE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS AND ACTUALLY THE
HEALING ARTS MOVIE BACK TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BEEN A SECURE MEMBERS
THIS IS THE SECOND OF. COMMITTEE
BILL WITH RESPECT TO THE
EXTENSION OF ACUPUNCTURE BUT IN
RESPECT WE ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS BOTH
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND HOW THE VOTES I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM ONE FIFTY FIVE A.
B. THIRTY ONE FORTY FOUR MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY ONE FORTY FOUR BUT THE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS AND ACTUALLY TO
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AND YOU VERY MUCH IT
REMEMBERS THE CIVIC CENTER FOR
THE PROFESSIONAL FINISH HERE IS
BUREAU RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM ONE FIFTY SIX A.
B. THIRTY ONE FORTY FIVE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ. SOME LEGAL
THIRTY ONE FORTY FIVE BY SOME
THE MEMBER SALAS AND ACTUALLY
STATE EMPLOYEES MAKING A
PREPARATION THEREFORE. THINK U.
S. SOME MEMBERS SALAS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THINK ABOUT OF
SPEAKER MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY ONE FORTY FIVE WOULD
ALLOW SPECIFIED STATE EMPLOYEES
PAY INTO THE STATE DISABILITY
INSURANCE PROGRAM. IN ORDER TO
ALLOW THESE WORKERS TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR BENEFITS RESPECT WE
ASK FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU SEEING
A DISCUSSION OR DEBATE METAPHOR
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND HOW THE VOTES.
I SIXTY TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM ONE FIFTY SEVEN A. B.
THIRTY ONE SEVENTY NINE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY ONE SEVENTY NINE BY SOME
A MEMBER SALAS AND OTHERS AND
EXPLAIN STATE GOVERNMENT THANK
YOU SO MEMBER SALAS YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THINK ABOUT OF SPEAKER MEMBERS
A. B. THIRTY ONE SEVENTY NINE
WOULD LOWER FROM FIVE PERCENT TO
THREE PERCENT THE THRESHOLD
WHICH.
STATED THE SIERRA REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE LANGUAGE ACCESS SERVICES
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE METALCORE PLEASE OPEN THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
AND A QUICK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM ONE FIFTY EIGHT
A. B. THIRTY ONE EIGHTY SIX
MADAM PURPLISH READ. AT SOME
LEVEL THIRTY ONE EIGHTY SIX BY
SOME A MEMBER MEDINA AND
ACTUALLY PUBLIC POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION
THANK YOU SO MEMBER MEDINA YOU
MAY. I YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
A. B. THIRTY ONE EIGHTY SIX WILL
REMOVE THE SUNSET DAY AND PUBLIC
CONTRACT CODE. ALLOWING THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
USE BEST VALUE PROCUREMENT.
METHODOLOGY INDEFINITELY.
RATHER THEN HAVING TO SELECT THE
LOWEST COST BITTER THE BEST
VALUE PROCUREMENT METHODOLOGY.
ALLOWS CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND UC TO CONSIDER NON
COST FACTORS.
EQUALITY EXPERIENCE AND LIFE
CYCLE COSTS WHEN SELECTING
VENDORS.
CURRENT LAW AUTHORIZE THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND UC. TO USE BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT METHODOLOGY ON A
PILOT BASIS FOR FIVE YEARS.
THE LA HAUTE RECOGNIZE THAT YOU
SEE MADE A REASONABLE USE OF
BEST VALUE PROCUREMENT AND
RECOMMENDED THAT THEY BE ALLOWED
TO CONTINUE.
CHOOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SO
MEMBER BAKER YOUR RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AND DOWN WITH THE AYE VERY
GREATLY RESPECT ARE GOOD CHAIR
OF HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE
ENJOY WORKING ON MANY ISSUES
THIS IS AN AREA WHERE WE'VE
DISAGREED AND I DO URGE. A NO
VOTE ON THIS BECAUSE NOW IS
EXACTLY THE TIME WE SHOULD KEEP
SUNSET PROVISIONS PARTICULARLY
ON YOU SEE.
I GIVE THEM ANOTHER FIVE YEAR
SUNSET PROVISION THEY HAVE A OUR
MOST RECENT TRACK RECORD OF
NEEDED TO IMPLEMENT NOT ONLY THE
AUDITOR'S REPORT FROM LAST YEAR
AND THE AUDITOR'S REPORT FROM
THE YEAR PRIOR. BUT OTHER BUDGET
CONTROLS AND BEST PRACTICES I
THINK.
AT IF WE WERE ABLE TO HAVE A A
BILL THAT DID NOT.
INCLUDE YOU SEE AND KEPT THE
SUNSET FOR THEM THAT MIGHT BE A
GOOD OPTION BUT I HOPE THAT WE
CAN MAKE THAT KIND OF CHANGE AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THAT
INSTEAD. AND I THINK THE THE
CHAIR FROM HIGHER EDUCATION FOR.
THE GOOD PARTNERSHIP WE HAVE ON
SO MANY OTHER BILLS THANK YOU
RESPECTFULLY VERY RESPECTFULLY A
NO VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR COLLEAGUES WE DID A
BILL THAT ARE CREATED OF BEST
VALUE PROCUREMENT PROCESS FOR
CALTRANS. IN IT HAS BEEN AN
EXCEPTIONAL PROGRAM THAT GAVE
THEM THE ABILITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY WERE GETTING THE BEST
VALUE OF THEIR PURCHASES.
THIS IS SOMETHING IT'S A TOOL
FOR PROCUREMENT THAT WORKS
THROUGHOUT.
INDUSTRY AND WE SHOULD. EMBRACE
A GOING FORWARD AND I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THIS OF
MY COLLEAGUE. FROM RIVERSIDE
THEN THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
THANK YOU SEEING NO FURTHER
REQUEST TO SPEAK SOME MEMBER
MEDINA WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
BUT THANK YOU TO BOTH MY
COLLEAGUES FOR US SPEAKING ON
THE ISSUE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM COURT PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON
ALL MEMBERS WHO WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
BUT APART PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
AYE AYES FORTY FOUR NO SEVENTEEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM ONE FIFTY NINE AB
THIRTY ONE NINETY THREE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ AS
UNABLE THIRTY ONE NINETY THREE
BY SOME A MEMBER CHAD OTHERS
ACTUALLY TO INFORMATION SECURITY.
THANK YOU AS A MEMBER CHAO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER AB
THIRTY ONE NINETY THREE
ADDRESSES AN ISSUE THAT WAS
BROUGHT UP. IN A JOINT OVERSIGHT
HEARING ON CYBERSECURITY IN
FEBRUARY.
THE BILL SEEKS TO ENSURE THAT
THE OFFICE OF INFORMATION
SECURITY OR A WHY S. WITHIN C.
D. T..
OBTAIN A COMPLETE PICTURE OF THE
INFORMATION SECURITY IN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
CURRENTLY THE LEGISLATURE HAS
CHARGED Y. US WITH DUTIES OVER
STATE AGENCIES IN THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH IN ONE PART OF THE STATUE.
BUT IN THE VERY NEXT PART OF
THAT SAME STATUE ONLY CERTAIN
STATE ENTITIES THAT REPORT
DIRECTLY TO THE GOVERNOR ARE
REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH THE O.
I. S. ISSUE STANDARDS. POLICIES
PROCEDURES INCIDENT NOTIFICATION
FILING REQUIREMENTS AND REPORTS
THIS BILL AB THIRTY ONE NINETY
THREE REMOVES ANY AMBIGUITY AND
THE LAW AND CLEARLY STATES THAT
ALL STATE AGENCIES MUST COMPLY
WITH WHY S. ISSUE INFORMATION
SECURITY REQUIREMENTS.
WE GOT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU SEEING UP I'M SORRY.
SOME MEMBER IRWIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AS A JOINT AUTHOR OF AB THIRTY
ONE NINETY THREE I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
TODAY.
THE MATURITY OF OUR STATE THE
GOVERNMENT CYBERSECURITY HAS
SEEN GREAT GROWTH IN RECENT
YEARS THIS GROWTH IS DUE TO THE
LOSS OF THIS LEGISLATURE PASSED.
THE UPDATE OF REQUIREMENTS BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY IN
RESPONSE TO THESE LAWS AND THE
CONTINUED EFFORT OF OUR IT
PROFESSIONALS WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY.
TO REACH OUR GOALS AS MY
COLLEAGUE STATEMENTS STATED THAT
THERE IS A DISAGREEMENT OVER
VARYING DEFINITIONS OF THE
GOVERNMENT CODE SOME STATE
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS HAVE
DECLINED TO FOLLOW OUR REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS.
THIS PREVENTS US FROM ENSURING
THAT WE ARE PROTECTING THE
ENTIRE STATE NETWORK WE ARE ONLY
AS STRONG AS OUR WEAKEST LINK.
A. B. THIRTY ONE NINETY THREE
WILL MAKE CLEAR THAT CALIFORNIA
INFORMATION SECURITY
REQUIREMENTS APPLY TO ALL OF
STATE GOVERNMENT.
I. URGE YOUR AYE VOTE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU SOME NUMBER OBERNOLTE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED BY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I RISE AS A JOINT
AUTHOR OF THE B. THIRTY ONE
NINETY THREE. INFORMATION
SECURITY IS A CRITICAL ISSUE FOR
STATE GOVERNMENT AND IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE HOLD ALL STATE
AGENCIES TO THE SAME STANDARDS.
AYE URGENT AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO FURTHER
REQUEST TO SPEAK MEDICARE PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
SENATE CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM ONE SIXTY AB
THIRTY TWO OH FIVE MATTER
QUICKLY THREE. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY TWO A FIVE BY SOME
REMEMBER O'DONNELL AND ACTUALLY
THE SCHOOL FACILITIES THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL YOUR
RECOGNIZED.
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AS A
CLASSROOM TEACHERS THAT HAS
PARTICIPATED IN MANY SCHOOL
LOCKDOWNS.
I CAN ATTEST TO THE NEED FOR A
TEACHER TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO
LOCK A CLASSROOM DOOR FROM THE
INSIDE. AS THIS CAN SAVE LIVES.
FOLLOWING THE COLUMBINE COLORADO
SHOOTING IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE
OR THIRTEEN STUDENTS AND A
TEACHER WERE KILLED. THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED A BILL THAT
REQUIRES ALL NEW SCHOOLS THAT'S
NEW SCHOOLS TO HAVE LOCKS THAT
LOCK FROM THE INSIDE.
THE MAJORITY OF OUR SCHOOLS
HOWEVER ARE OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OLD. THIS MEANS THAT IS
LIKELY THAT MOST OF OUR
CLASSROOM DOORS DO NOT LOCK FROM
THE INSIDE.
IN TWENTY TWELVE TWENTY SIX
STUDENTS AND EDUCATORS WERE
KILLED AT SANDY HOOK ELEMENTARY
IN CONNECTICUT.
A NUMBER OF THEM WERE SHOT AND
CLASSROOMS THAT COULD ONLY BE
LOCKED FROM THE OUTSIDE.
ONE OF THE MAIN RECOMMENDATIONS
OF A COMMISSION FORMED AFTER THE
INCIDENT WAS CHANGE THE LOCKS
ALLOW THOSE DOORS TO LOCK FROM
THE INSIDE.
THE RECENT TRAGEDIES THAT
MARJORIE STONEMAN DOUGLAS HIGH
SCHOOL IN FLORIDA AND SANTA FE
HIGH SCHOOL IN TEXAS.
REMIND US THAT OUR WORK IS NOT
DONE.
AB THIRTY TO ALL FIVE REQUIRES
MODERNIZATION PROJECTS SEEKING
STATE BOND FUNDS TO INCLUDE IN
THOSE PROJECTS.
LOCKS ON CLASSROOM DOORS THAT
CAN BE LOCKED FROM THE INSIDE.
AS A TEACHER AND A PARENT.
I TAKE STUDENT SECURITY VERY
SERIOUSLY AND I KNOW YOU DO AS
WELL.
LET'S ENSURE THAT OUR STUDENTS
TEACHERS AND ALL SCHOOL STAFF
ARE ABLE TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
WHETHER THEY ARE IN A NEW SCHOOL.
OR AN OLDER SCHOOL.
I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
ICE FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. ITEM ONE SIXTY
ONE HAS BEEN DISPENSED WITH ITEM
ONE SIXTY TO PASS AND RETAIN
ITEM ONE SIXTY THREE PASS
TEMPORARILY. WIND OF ONE SIXTY
FOUR HAS BEEN DISPENSED WITH
MOVING TO ITEM ONE SIXTY FIVE A.
B. THIRTY TWO THIRTY THREE ABOUT
A CLERK PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY TWO THIRTY THREE BY
SIGN OVER KILEY AND ACTUALLY THE
PEOPLE ASSESSMENT.
SOME MEMBER KILEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THINK ABOUT A SPEAKER THIS BILL
STATUTORILY RECOGNIZES THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DASHBOARD AND
ALLOWS THE LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCY TO USE THE SAT TEST OR
OTHER FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED WITH
ELEVEN ASSESSMENT. AS A LOCAL
ACADEMIC INDICATOR ON THE
DASHBOARD NOW THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL DASHBOARD WAS DEVELOPED
BY THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION
WITH THE STATED PURPOSE OF
UPDATING AND IMPROVING
TRANSPARENCY. AND SCHOOL
ACCOUNTABILITY.
FOR PUBLIC SCHOOLS ACROSS THE
STATE ARE THIS BILL WILL GIVE
PARENTS A TOOL TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS FOR THEIR CHILD'S
EDUCATION.
THE STATE APPROVES A NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED HIGH SCHOOL
ASSESSMENT RALLY IS TO
ADMINISTER IN LIEU OF THE
EXISTING STATEWIDE ASSESSMENT AS
PERMITTED BY FEDERAL LAW AT THE
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED SAT AND ACT
TEST OR USING COLLEGE ADMISSIONS.
AND THIS BILL SIMPLY AUTHORIZES
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO USE THOSE
TESTS
AS A VOCAL PERFORMANCE METRIC
WHEN ADMINISTERED ALL GRADE
ELEVEN STUDENTS
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL WAS
UNANIMOUS IN BOTH THE. EDUCATION
AND APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEES
AND I ASK YOUR ABA.
THANK YOU SEEING A REQUEST TO
SPEAK MATTER QUICKLY IS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
HIGHS FIFTY NINE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM ONE SIXTY SIX AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOUR MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY THIRTY FOUR BY FAMILY
MEMBER CALDERON AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE TAXATION TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
SO MEMBER CALDERON YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY FOUR WILL EXTEND THE
SUCCESSFUL CALIFORNIA FILM AND
TELEVISION PRODUCTION TAX CREDIT.
FEW INDUSTRIES ARE MORE
INDELIBLY TIED TO A LOCATION IN
THE UNIT ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY
IS THE CALIFORNIA.
THIS INDUSTRY CREATES HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF GOOD PAYING
MIDDLE CLASS JOBS AND BILLIONS
AND ECONOMIC IT ACTIVITY
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA EACH YEAR.
CALIFORNIA'S REPUTATION AS THE
HOME OF FILM AND TELL TV DRIVE
MUCH OF THE TOURISM OUR STATE
SEES AS WELL. UNFORTUNATELY
SINCE LATE NINETEEN NINETIES
OTHER STATES AND COUNTRIES OF
LORD PRODUCTION OUT OF
CALIFORNIA A GENEROUS TAX BREAKS.
IN AN EFFORT TO COMBAT
PRODUCTION FLIGHT THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED THE
CALIFORNIA FILM AND TELEVISION
TAX CREDIT PROGRAM TWO THOUSAND
NINE. WE'VE IMPROVED UPON THAT
PROGRAM OVER THE YEARS WITH EACH
EXTENSION OF THE INCENTIVE THE
CURRENT PROGRAM SOME SENSE INTO
YEARS ON JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY. DUE TO THE COMPLEXITY OF
THE MOTION PICTURE AND
TELEVISION PRODUCTION DECISIONS
REGARDING SHOOT LOCATIONS ARM
OFF MADE OFTEN A YEAR OR MORE IN
ADVANCE.
MOTION PICTURE TELEVISION
PRODUCTIONS NEED THE CERTAINTY
OF THE CALIFORNIA FILM AND
TELEVISION. TAX CREDIT PROGRAM
IN ORDER TO CONSIDER
CALIFORNIA'S LOCATION IN THEIR
PRODUCTION PLANNING.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOUR WILL
EXTEND THE EXISTING PROGRAM WAS
SEVEN PROVEN SAYS WELL FOR
ANOTHER FIVE YEARS AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY FOUR WILL CONTINUE TO
RESTORE CALIFORNIA'S COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGE FOR FILM AND TV
PRODUCTION. AND TO BRING BACK
JOBS TO CALIFORNIA THUS ENSURING
THAT THIS VIBRANT FOUND DASCHLE
INDUSTRY REMAINS A PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S LEGACY.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON THIS BILL AND THINK THE MANY
JOINT AUTHORS ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU A SOME MEMBER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ACOSTA YOUR RECOGNIZE.
WELL THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOUR THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL I IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT FOR MY DISTRICT HOW WE
CALL OURSELVES HOLLYWOOD NORTH.
HOW WE HAVE MANY MOVIE RANCHES
AND PRODUCTION STUDIOS?
AND WHAT'S ALSO IMPORTANT IS THE
FACT THAT WE CAN HELP KEEP
CALIFORNIA VERY COMPETITIVE. I
LIKE TO SEE THIS EXPANDED OTHER
INDUSTRIES BUT THIS INDUSTRY. IN
PARTICULAR HOUSE ITS ROOTS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS IS THAT IT CREATES A
LOT OF JOBS AND A LOT OF
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY. IN THE REGION
AND I HIGHLY SUPPORT AB ONE
SEVEN THREE FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK U. S. SOMEWHERE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THE MINISTRY CAN MEMBERS.
.
YOU KNOW I I AM SUPPORTIVE OF A
TAX CREDIT THAT HELP SUPPORT
BUSINESS.
AYE BUT AT THIS TIME I DON'T
THINK I CAN BE SUPPORTIVE OF
FOCUSING ON ONE INDUSTRY IN THIS
STATE. WHEN AT THE SAME TIME WE
PASS LAWS AND LEGISLATION TO
MAKE IT VERY HARD TO DO.
BUSINESS IN OTHER SECTORS
INCLUDING A MANUFACTURING.
IN AGRICULTURE.
AND MANY OTHER SECTORS OF THIS
ECONOMY THAT ARE STRUGGLING
RIGHT NOW THEY DON'T GET.
A TAX CREDIT BENEFIT.
AND ALSO AT A TIME WHEN.
WE FAIL TO PASS TAX CREDITS THAT
WOULD HELP PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES GET HIRED.
I HAD A MEASURE MYSELF THAT
WOULD HAVE DONE THAT.
IT WAS KILLED.
NOT SO I WAS AT THE TIME WERE
HURTING OTHER INDUSTRIES.
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD. YOU
KNOW.
TARGET ONE SPECIFIC INDUSTRY IN
THIS STATE. AND GIVE THEM THE
BENEFIT OF A TAX CREDIT WE'RE
NOT DOING THE SAME FOR A WHOLE
LOT OTHER INDUSTRIES IN THE
STATE I DON'T THINK WE CAN IN
GOOD CONSCIENCE DO THAT. AND
ESPECIALLY WE WON'T EXTEND THE
SAME COURTESY. TO THE DISABILITY
THEN THE DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED.
COMMUNITY. WHO ALSO IS IN NEED
OF OF OF HELP AND SUPPORT? IN
THIS STATE SO FOR THOSE REASONS
I CAN'T SUPPORT THIS TODAY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES OF THE JOINT AUTHORS
ON THIS BILL THE CHAIR OF THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER.
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
FOUR. I DON'T THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP IN HIS
PARTNERSHIP LEAD AUTHOR. OUR
MAJORITY LEADER CALIFORNIA'S
INTERNATIONALLY RECOGNIZED FOR
OUR FILM AND ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY AND THIS MEASURE WILL
HELP TO PRESERVE THAT REPUTATION
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY IT'LL
PROTECT TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIA JOBS.
BUT AS WE VOTE TO EXTEND THE
FILM TAX CREDIT PROGRAM IT'S
CRITICAL THAT FILMS TELEVISION
SHOWS AND OUR WORKFORCE.
BOTH ON AND OFF THE SCREEN
REFLECTED ADVERSITY OF OUR STATE
IT'S REALLY INTERESTING THIS
TIME BECAUSE WE WERE JUST
MEETING WITH. OUT MAGGIE Q. API
ACTRESS THE FIRST ASIAN AMERICAN
LEAD IN A BROADCAST DRAMA.
WHICH JUST OCCURRED IN TWENTY
TEN ARE TRAGICALLY WAIT WAIT TO
RECENTLY AND SHE SHARED HER OWN
PASSION ABOUT THE NEED TO
INCREASE DIVERSITY.
IN FILM WHEN IT COMES TO THE
ONSCREEN REPRESENTATION OF ASIAN
AMERICANS IT'S COMMON TO SEE
WHITE ACTORS AND ACTRESSES TAKE
THE PLACE OF TRADITIONAL. ASIAN
ROLES HOLLYWOOD IS DOING BETTER
BUT IT IS STILL FALLING SHORT.
THERE ARE MANY EXAMPLES OF THIS
I IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA WITH
THEIR ACTORS AND ACTRESSES AND I
KNOW MY COLLEAGUES ON THE MEMBER
AYE CHU WELL.
SAY MORE ABOUT THAT BEHIND THE
SCENES IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
TO HAVE DIVERSE WRITERS
PRODUCERS AND DIRECTORS SO THEY
CAN SHARE THEIR STORY AND THE
STORIES OF ASIAN AMERICANS IN A
WAY THAT ONLY THEY COULD.
IN SHORT DIVERSITY MATTERS.
THE FILM INDUSTRY SHOULD RESPECT
AND REFLECT THE DIVERSE CITY OF
OUR STATE.
THE API CAUCUS IS ENCOURAGED BY
THE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR LEAD AUTHOR AND
APPRECIATE HIS WILLINGNESS TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS WE EXPECT
THOSE CONCERNS TO BE ADDRESSED
AND KNOW THAT THEY WELL AS AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOUR. MOVES
FORWARD WERE PLEASED THAT THIS
YEAR ABOVE THE LINE DIVERSITY
PROVISIONS WILL BE INCLUDED IN
THE CALIFORNIA FILM TAX CREDIT
LAW. FOR THE FIRST TIME I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOUR.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID
CHIU YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
COLLEAGUES TO ME FIRST START BY
EXPRESSING MY HISTORIC SUPPORT
FOR THIS FILM TAX CREDIT. UP
BEFORE HE CAME TO THE ASSEMBLY I
FIRST MET THE MAJORITY LEADER A
NUMBER OF YOU. ARE SUPPORTING
THE ORIGINAL FILM TAX CREDIT IN
PART BECAUSE MY DISTRICT HAS
SOME OF THE MOST A FILM BUSINESS
AND NORTHERN CALIFORNIA OR USED
TO. AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THIS
CONTINUE.
THAT BEING SAID LET ME EXPRESS
SOME OF MY INITIAL AMBIVALENCE
AROUND THIS TAX CREDIT.
BECAUSE AS MY COLLEAGUE THE
CHAIR OF THE API CAUCUS JUST
MENTION. THE FACT IS
HOLLYWOOD DOES NOT REFLECT THE
DIVERSITY OF OUR STATE.
OR A COUNTRY.
OR THE WORLD.
THIS FILM TAX CREDIT NEEDS TO
HELP TO MOVE THAT NEEDLE.
AS CALIFORNIA IS MAJORITY
MINORITY STATE AS UNITED STATES
IS BECOMING A MINORITY MAJORITY
COUNTRY.
HOLLYWOOD HAS BEEN WOEFULLY
BEHIND.
WHEN IT COMES TO.
THE INVOLVEMENT OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS LATINOS.
LGBT WOMAN AND OTHERS BOTH BELOW
THE LINE AN ABOVE THE LINE WHEN
IT COMES TO ACTORS WRITERS
DIRECTORS AND PRODUCERS.
HOW TO TAKE A MOMENT AND SPEAK
ABOUT HOW I'VE EXPERIENCES AS AN
ASIAN AMERICAN?
GROWING UP.
MY ASIAN AMERICAN ROLE MODEL WAS
LONG DUCK DONG IN SIXTEEN
CANDLES.
CHILDREN TODAY WATCH THE
DEPICTION OF HANS IN TWO BROKE
GIRLS.
SOUTH ASIANS WATCH THE DEPICTION
OF OP WHO IN THE SIMPSON'S.
WHEN I TALK TO MY ASIAN AMERICAN
ACTORS AND ACTRESSES FRIENDS
THEY TALK ABOUT THE FACT. THAT
THEY OFTEN ONLY GET TO.
INTERVIEW FOR ROLES INVOLVING
THE FIVE JEEZ.
THEY GET TO INTERVIEW FOR PARTS
INVOLVING KOOKS
GEEKS
GANGSTERS GEISHAS AND KUNG FU
MASTERS.
WHY IS IT THAT TWENTY YEARS
AFTER MARGARET SHOW IN ALL
AMERICAN GIRL? ARE WE STILL
WAITING FOR API'S TO BE CAST AS
LEADS IN A SITCOM OR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AFTER JOY LUCK CLUB ARE WE
WAITING FOR ASIAN AMERICANS. TO
BE CASTING LEADS IN A MOVIE.
THE NIGHT MY SON WAS BORN.
ON THE OSCARS.
THEY'VE.
SOME MEMORABLE AND AS FOR WHAT
REASON DO ARISE.
POINT OF ORDER MADAM SPEAKER
WHILE I APPRECIATE WHAT THE
SPEAKER HAS TO SAY DON'T THINK
THAT IS SPEAKING TO THE MERITS
OF THE BILL.
MISTER CHIU CAN YOU PLEASE TRY
AND ACCESS TO THE BILL THE NEXUS
IS WHY I AS AN ASIAN AMERICAN
WOULD HOPE THAT THIS FILM TAX
CREDIT DOES MORE TO MOVE. THE
DIVERSITY OF THE HOLLYWOOD
INDUSTRY.
WITH THAT ELECT TO CONTINUE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE NIGHT MY
SON WAS BORN ON THE OSCAR STAGE
THERE WERE THREE YOUNG ASIAN
CHILDREN WHO WERE BROUGHT ON
THAT STAGE. AND THEY WERE
STEREOTYPED IN FRONT OF AN
INTERNATIONAL AUDIENCE.
LAST YEAR IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN ON HWY FIVE THOUGH THE
ASIAN LEADS QUIT BECAUSE THEY
WERE PAID UNEQUAL SALARIES TO
THEIR WHITE COLLEAGUES.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
IT WAS A YEAR OF WHITEWASHING
WHEN YOU HAD ACTOR AND ACTRESSES
THAT DEPICTED ASIAN ROLES WERE
NOT ASIAN.
THIS IS BROADER THAN THE
EXPERIENCE OF API'S IN HOLLYWOOD.
IT'S ABOUT OSKAR SO WHITE.
IT'S ABOUT HOLLYWOOD SO WHITE
IT'S ABOUT THE ME TOO MOVEMENT
AND HARVEY WEINSTEIN.
THIS IS THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
ANOTHER MEMORABLE AND AS FOR
WHAT REASON DO YOU RIDE MADAM
SPEAKER POINT OF ORDER THIS HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE TIME
CREDIT BILL THAT IS BEFORE US.
WE NEED TO MOVEMENT.
WELL WHO IS BEING CAST IN LEAD
ROLES AND WHAT ETHNIC BACKGROUND
THEY COME FROM HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE TAX CREDIT BILL THAT IS
BEFORE US WHICH IS NOT FOR. LEAD
ROLES AS IT WAS EXPLAINED TO ME
BY THE SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL
DOES FOR BELOW THE LINE ACTORS
NOT LEAD ROLE AS IT HAS NOTHING
TO DO I APPRECIATE WE JUST SAY.
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE BILL.
IS MELENDEZ I BELIEVE YOUR POINT
IS WELL TAKEN I WILL ASK MISTER
CHIU TO PLEASE CONTINUE BUT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS. THAT YOUR
COMMENTS REFER SPECIFICALLY TO
THE BILL WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
THERE ARE PROVISIONS IN THIS
BILL.
THAT FOR THE FIRST TIME DO
ADDRESS DIVERSITY BELOW THE LINE.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND THE COALITION. A THAT WORKED
ON THIS AND I ALSO A ONE I THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR HIS COMMITMENT TO
WORK ON LANGUAGE TO ENSURE FOR
THE FIRST TIME. THERE IS
LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS DIVERSITY
ABOVE THE LINE AT LEAST TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE HOLLYWOOD IS
AND HOW WE MOVE THIS FOR. THAT
WAS IMPORTANT FOR MY SUPPORT AND
THAT WAS WHAT I WANTED TO CONVEY.
SO THAT BEING SAID I KNOW THE
LANGUAGE IS NOT SETTLED BUT I DO
TRUST THE MAJORITY LEADER OF THE
AUTHOR THIS BILL TO WORK ON THIS
AS WE MOVE FORWARD. THIS IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE HOW THE WORLD.
UNDERSTANDS.
HOW'RE COMMUNITIES ARE DEPICTED
DEPENDS ON WHAT HOLLYWOOD DOES
IN THE DECISIONS THAT ARE MADE.
AND WITHOUT I AM GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY BUT I
VERY MUCH HOPE.
THAT AS THIS BILL GETS CLOSER
TO COMPLETION OF THAT IT DOES
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES AND WILL
CERTAINLY BE MONITORING THIS.
BOTH WITH THIS BILL AND IN THE
FUTURE. WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY ASK
RED ONES AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THURMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MA'AM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOUR AND I
THINK OUR MAJORITY LEADER FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP HERE.
OBVIOUSLY IDEA AYE LINE MYSELF
WITH THE COMMENTS OF THOSE WHO
WANT TO SEE MORE DIVERSITY.
IN HOLLYWOOD AND I APPRECIATE
THAT THE AUTHORS TAKEN MEASURES
TO ADDRESS THAT. AYE I THINK
SIMPLY.
UP BEYOND THAT WE SHOULD FOCUS
ON THE JOB CREATION
OPPORTUNITIES THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR REVENUE INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND TO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE
MANY BUSINESSES THAT SUPPLY.
THIS INDUSTRY.
THAT IMPACT EVERY COMMUNITY IN
OUR STATE I WOULD LOVE TO GO TO
SAY THAT THE CITY OF RICHMOND IS
HOLLYWOOD NORTH OR WEST OF IT
BUT IT'S NOT.
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
THAT THERE ARE BUSINESSES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT SUPPLY
THIS S. SECTOR ON THE MORE JOBS
CREATED. THE MULTIPLIER EFFECT
TAKES EFFECT MORE DOLLARS ARE
SPENT AND I APPRECIATE. THAT
THIS ITERATION OF THE TAX CREDIT
EMPHASIZES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EMPLOY THOSE WHO WORK ON IN THE
INDUSTRY AND NOT JUST. IN FRONT
OF THE CAMERA BUT BEHIND THE
CAMERA AND IN OTHER SECTORS OF
OF TECHNICAL OPPORTUNITIES OF
FOR MANY ON BEHALF OF ALL THE
STATE IN IN IN AND I HOPE THAT
MY COLLEAGUES WILL NOT LET. ANY
FEELINGS ABOUT ANY PREVIOUS TAX
CREDIT THAT WASN'T SUPPORTED
STOP THEM FROM VOTING FOR THIS.
THE QUESTION SHOULD BE WHATEVER
IN MY BELIEF WHENEVER. A TAX
CREDIT IS BEFORE US WE SHOULD
ASK OURSELVES A SIMPLE QUESTION.
IS A TAX CREDIT WARRANTED
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO HELP TO
CREATE JOBS IN OUR SECTOR IS
CLEARLY A TAX CREDIT THAT WILL
HELP TO CREATE JOBS RETAIN JOBS
IN SUPPORT OF VERY STRONG ROBUST.
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY I RESPECT WE
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER HARPER
YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS. AYE AFTER
WATCHING THE THE EXCHANGE
BETWEEN THE MEMBER FROM MY SAN
FRANCISCO AND THE MEMBER FROM
RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
I THINK IT UNDERSCORES THE
DANGER I IN TERMS OF TREADING
INTO THIS. INTO THIS FEAR.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT GOVERNMENT
FUNDING.
IN GOVERNMENT EXPENDITURE OR
GOVERNMENT CREDITS.
IN THIS AREA.
PACIFIC WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AN
INDUSTRY.
WHICH IS
IN THE REALM OF ART.
AN IS IN THE REALM OF CULTURE.
AND SO THE QUESTION BECOMES.
FOR AN INDUSTRY TO RECEIVE A
MASSIVE TAX CREDIT LIKE THIS.
SHOULD THEY BE PUSHED
WITH THE HEAVY HAND OF
GOVERNMENT ON THEIR CONTENT IN
ORDER TO GET THE CASH.
I THINK WE TRIED AND A VERY VERY.
SERVING TERRITORY HERE.
WHERE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE MAY
BE INSERTING IT'S POLITICS
IT'S CULTURAL PRIORITIES?
INTO THE CONTENT.
OF ARTWORK
OF CULTURAL PIECES.
THAT'S WHY I THINK THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE NOT GET
INVOLVED IN THIS SPHERE. AND
THAT WE SHOULD BE INTERESTED IN
MAKING SURE THE CALIFORNIA IS AN
OVERALL GOOD PLACE TO DO
BUSINESS FOR ALL BUSINESSES
ACROSS THE BOARD WHETHER IT'S
OUR TAXATION RATE. OUR LABOR
LAWS ARE REGULATION AND ALL THE
OTHER THINGS THAT MAKE IT A
CHALLENGE TO DO BUSINESS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. LET'S MAKE
CALIFORNIA MORE BUSINESS
FRIENDLY OVERALL RATHER THAN
TRYING TO GET INVOLVED IN
PICKING LOSERS. TRYING TO CHOOSE
WHOSE IN LEADING PARTS WHO IS IN
MINOR PARTS IN WHO IS AN BACKING
PARTS IN FILM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR FOR
CONSIDERATION I URGE A NO VOTE
ON THIS BILL.
I THINK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY FOUR AND I WANT TO THANK
OF THE LEAD AUTHOR AS WELL AS.
CHAIR DAYPACK AUTISM MAYBE I
CAUCUS COLLEAGUES FOR REALLY
STARTING A VERY IMPORTANT
DIALOGUE.
THAT WILL ULTIMATELY I BELIEVE
THE END UP WITH VERY POSITIVE
RESULTS BECOMES A DIVERSITY. OF
IN HOLLYWOOD YOU KNOW I GREW UP
HERE IN CALIFORNIA I NEVER
IMAGINED I'D BE THE FIRST INDIAN
AMERICAN TO SERVE IN THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE. BUT I'LL
TELL YOU THAT WHEN I GREW UP THE
ONLY TIMES I SAW ANY DEPICTION
OF ANYONE TO LOOK LIKE ME THAT
ANY SENSE ADAPT WAS IN BOLLYWOOD.
WHEN I LOOKED IN HOLLYWOOD BUT
THAT WAS THE BIG SCREEN OR ON
TELEVISION OF. UNC PEOPLE LOOK
LIKE ME AND IF YOU DID I DON'T
THINK I'D BE VERY PROUD OF WHAT
YOU SAW.
AND SO THIS CONVERSATION IS LONG
OVERDUE.
AND I'M SO GRATEFUL THAT WE'RE
HAVING OPPORTUNITY ESPECIALLY AT
THIS MOMENT. ABA WHEN NOT JUST
DIVERSITY BUT STORIES BEING TOLD
REFLECTING WHO WE ARE AS
CALIFORNIANS AND AS AMERICANS
AND YES WHEN WE DO GIVE
RESOURCES OR WHETHER STATE WE
RESOURCES OTHERWISE THERE IS
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT COMES WITH
THAT. THERE'S ACCOUNTABILITY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE RESOURCES
ARE BEING USED IN A MANNER THAT
REFLECTS OUR BEST VALUES
REFLECTS WHO WE ARE. AND SO I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE THAT
SPOKEN IN FAVOR OF THE BILL BUT
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR.
FOR EXPRESSING HIS GREAT
WILLINGNESS TO WORK MUCH THE API
CAUCUS BUT WITH OTHER MINORITY
CAUCUSES AS WELL AS THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS TO MAKE SURE. THAT AS WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THIS
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA THAT WE
DO SO IT WITH HER UP THOUGH THE
MINDSET THAT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE REPRESENTS THE BEST OF WHO
WE ARE. AND I ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE AS WAS REFERENCE
EARLIER BY API CAUCUS CHAIR
MAGGIE Q. WHO IS IT WITH US A IN
THE GALLERY AS A TRAILBLAZER AS
SOMEONE THAT REALLY HAS LED THIS
FIGHT ON THE GROUND BEFORE IT
REALLY CAME TO PROMINENCE. THAT
WE STAND A REALLY A FOLLOWING
HER PATH TO MAKE SURE THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN SET THE. EXAMPLE%
OF FOR THE REST THE NATION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALTER
AND YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IS A
MADAM SPEAKER. I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL I DID SEE IT. OUR
ARTS AND ENTERTAINMENT COMMITTEE.
OF.
FOR MY LIFE PHONE HONEST WORK AS
A POLITICIAN I ACTUALLY WORK FOR
NBC SPORTS IN NEW YORK. AND THEN
I MOVED OUT TO CALIFORNIA IT'S A
SUNNY BURBANK A WORK IN THE
CABLE TV INDUSTRY.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE NOT
ONLY DOES IT HELP THE INDUSTRY
THERE'S SO MANY ANCILLARY BEEN
THAT BUSINESSES THAT BENEFIT
FROM ALL THE FOOD VENDORS AND
RESTAURANTS THE A CAR RENTALS
AND TRUCK RENTALS ALL THE
EQUIPMENT AND SUPPLIES OF GOING
THERE WITH. ALL OF THOSE JOBS
ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE INDUSTRIES A
BENEFIT FROM IT AS WELL AS TAX
REVENUE TO CALIFORNIA SO WE MORE
THAN MAKE UP WHAT'S GIVEN OUT AS
FAR AS THE BENEFIT.
THOUGH AS WE KNOW AS WE SAW
WITH THE HARVEY WEINSTEIN ISSUES
WITH SEXUAL HARASSMENT THE
INDUSTRY THAT'S ANOTHER ONE OF
THOSE INDUSTRIES THAT'S BEEN
IMPACTED. SO THAT'S ONE OF THE
THE REASONS THAT'S INCLUDED IN
THIS BILL SO I I STRONGLY URGE
AN AYE. AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
FOUR. PARTICULARLY THE
PROVISIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED AS IT RELATES TO
DIVERSIFYING.
THE FILM INDUSTRY YOU SEE YOU
KNOW I AM A STRONG BELIEVER THAT
YOU KNOW THE DEPICTIONS THAT WE
SEE ON TV. MOST OF THE TIMES OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE A WRONG
STORIES ARE BEING TOLD THE FACT
IS THAT.
WE'RE NOT.
TOTALS IN FILMS AND.
OTHER CHARACTERS THAT. ARE NOT
DEPICTING OF OUR COMMUNITIES WE
WE ARE DOCTORS EMERGENCY ROOM
DOCTORS
ASTRONAUTS
A P. H. D.'S WHO TEACH ETHNIC
STUDIES AT UNIVERSITIES I MEAN
WE. HAVE A DIVERSE GROUP OF
PROFESSIONALS THAT SHOULD BE
REFLECTED IN FILM BUT I I I RISE
PACIFIC THE. BECAUSE OF A
COMMENT THAT WAS MADE THAT WE
SHOULD EXTEND THE SAME. POLICY
COURTESY TO OTHER AREAS LET ME
REMIND EVERYONE THAT THROUGH THE.
HISTORIC BIPARTISAN.
EXTENSION OF THE NATIONAL YOU
WATCH CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM.
THE MANUFACTURING.
INDUSTRIES THE RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT.
COMMUNITY RECEIVED A.
GOOD.
TAX EXEMPTION AS A RESULT OF
THAT POLICY IN EFFECT YOU DON'T
BELIEVE ME ASK THEM.
HOW BIG AN GOOD OF A POLICY THAT
WAS AYE I DO WANT TO JUST SAY
THOUGH THAT? YOU KNOW OUR TAX
INCENTIVES
SHOULD BE TARGETED.
AND FOCUSED IN REGIONS OF THE
STATE.
THAT NEED THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND SO
I GO AGAIN RIGHT IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOUR AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR IN THE REST OF
THE STAKEHOLDERS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH REAL QUICK I
JUST WANT TO ADD MY VOICE AS A
MEMBER AND AP I CAUCUS YOU KNOW.
I HAVE A LOT OF FAMILY IN HAWAII
AND AND.
IT'S JUST NOT SEEING ANY ASIANS
REPRESENT AND A WHOLE Y. IS JUST
RIDICULOUS ANYONE'S EVER BEEN A
WHOLE Y. KNOWS THAT. THE WHOLE
AYE FIVE OH AYE DOES NOT READ
THE CALF TO THAT REPRESENT VOID
THE REALITY OF HOLE AYE IF WE'RE
GONNA.
SUPPORT OUR OUR FILM AND
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY AS I WILL
DO AND AS I'VE ALWAYS DONE THEN
I WANT TO MAKE SURE TO THE TAX
CREDITS OR GO TO SUPPORT.
REPRESENTATION TELLING OUR
STORIES DIVERSITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MELENDEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I AM SO
I'VE HEARD A LOT OF CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW GIVING A TAX CREDIT IS
GOING TO SOMEHOW MAGICALLY. MAKE
HOLLYWOOD MORE DIVERSE I DON'T
KNOW HOW THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
I DON'T SEE THAT IN THE BILL IF
IT DOES THAT'S GREAT. MY BIGGER
CONCERN IS THAT THE WHOLE REASON
THAT MY WHISTLEBLOWER BILL WAS
PASSED THIS YEAR WAS BECAUSE OF
THE MEAT TO MOVEMENT THAT BROKE.
AND IT MADE EVERYBODY FACE THE
ISSUE.
HOLLYWOOD STARTED THIS.
SO NOW WE ARE CONTEMPLATING
GIVING A TAX CREDIT TO AN
INDUSTRY THAT HAS A HABIT.
OF ALLOWING WOMEN TO BE
MISTREATED HAS A HABIT OF
ALLOWING WOMEN OF COLOR TO BE
MISTREATED. OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN SO WHAT I WANT TO
KNOW BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
CONVERSATIONS WHICH IS GREAT BUT
I WANT TO HEAR FROM THE AUTHOR
IF I MAY. WHAT ASSURANCES ARE
GOING TO BE PUT INTO THIS BILL
SO THAT WE CAN FEEL CONFIDENT
THAT WE ARE NOT SUBSIDIZING MORE
BAD BEHAVIOR BECAUSE I KNOW IT'S
NOT THE BILL RIGHT NOW? I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN DISCUSSION ABOUT IT
AND I KNOW THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
TALK ABOUT.
IT'S ALL ABOUT IT'S ALL BELOW
THE LINE PEOPLE IT'S NOT THE
STARS IT'S NOT THE PRODUCERS
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT THE
MONEY'S GOING TO BUT GUESS WHAT.
IF YOU CAN SAVE MONEY AT THE
BELOW THE LINE LEVEL YOU'RE ALSO
SAVING MONEY AT THE ABOVE THE
LINE LEVEL BECAUSE YOU HAVE MORE
WITH WHICH TO WORK. SAID THIS IS
NOT THIS ISN'T IT IN A SILO THAT
THEY'RE THAT THEY'RE WORKING IN
I'M SO I JUST WANT TO HEAR FROM
THE AUTHOR OF YOU COULD ADDRESS
THAT BECAUSE I HAVE.
GREAT CONCERN WITH GIVING A TAX
CREDIT TO AN INDUSTRY THAT NOT
ONLY.
EVERY OPPORTUNITY THEY HAVE THE
SAFETY UP IN AND.
SPEAK OUT AGAINST THE BAO EARS
THAT I STAND FOR BUT ALSO THE
VALUES THAT THIS BODY STANDS FOR
GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE CONTINUE
TO VOTE. FOR LEGISLATION THAT
PROTECTS WOMEN THAT PROTECTS
PEOPLE OF COLOR. SEPARATE I MEAN
ALL OF THESE THINGS SO.
IF YOU DON'T MIND.
ALL DISCUSSION AND DEBATE HAVING
CEASED. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND I
AND I THINK EVERYBODY FOR THEIR
COMMENTS AND YOU KNOW I'VE SPENT
A LOT OF TIME.
WORKING ON THE ISSUES OF
DIVERSITY WORKING ON THE ISSUES
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT SPECIFIC TO
SEXUAL HARASSMENT APPLICANTS
WILL HAVE TO PROVIDE THEIR
WRITTEN POLICY AGAINST UNLAWFUL
HARASSMENT. INCLUDING PROCEDURES
FOR REPORTING INVESTIGATING
ALLEGATIONS AS WELL AS IDENTIFY
A POINT PERSON FOR EACH
PRODUCTIONS THAT WAS RESPONSIBLE
FOR RECEIVING HIS REPORTS SO
THAT WE CAN MANAGE AND HAVE A
POINT PERSON HAVE SOME TYPE OF
POLICY PUT IN PLACE. FOR THOSE
THAT ARE APPLYING FOR THIS FILM
TAX CREDIT SO THAT PEOPLE IF
THEY'RE BEING ABUSED OR THEY'RE
BEING HARASSED HAVE SOMEWHERE TO
GO AND THEIR SPECIFIC POLICY PUT
IN PLACE. TO ALLOW THEM THE
ABILITY TO KNOW THAT THEY HAVE
THE RIGHT TO SAY SOMETHING IN
AND WHEN THEY SAY SOMETHING THAT
SOME IS GOING TO BE DONE ABOUT
IT. WITH REGARDS TO I DIVERSITY
IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
THAT WE THAT WE.
MAKE SURE THESE THESE PROJECTS
ARE REPRESENTATIVE OF OUR
DIVERSE CULTURE.
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY IN ANY AND
AND AND EVERYWHERE ALSO RIGHT
NOW WE'RE WORKING WITH ALL OF
THE. THE THAT CAUCUS IS EH API
CAUCUS LATINO CAUCUS AS WELL AS
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN CAUCUS
BLACK CAUCUS ON THE ISSUES OF
DIVERSITY AND WHAT WE CAN DO. A
TO MAKE SURE WE ENCOURAGE THESE
PRODUCTIONS ITEM TO AT LEAST
REPORT ARE ABOVE THE LINE ON
WHAT THEY THE PRODUCTIONS IN
TERMS OF THE WRITERS. THE ACTORS
AND EVERYBODY ELSE THAT'S
INVOLVED THESE PROJECTS WHAT
THAT IVERSITY BROKE BREAKDOWN
IS AND TO DEVELOP SOME POLICIES
ARE PROGRAMS WHICH BY THE WAY A
LOT OF THESE COMPANIES ALREADY
HAVE PROGRAMS TO INCLUDING TO
INCREASE DIVERSITY. TO DEVELOP A
PROGRAM AS WELL AS DEVELOP ONE
IF THEY DON'T HAVE TO DO TO
MAINTAIN A PROGRAMMER DEVELOP A
PROGRAM THAT ALREADY HAVE ONE
AND THEN REPORT THAT INFORMATION
TO THE CALIFORNIA FILM TAX
CREDIT. SO THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CAN THEN TAKE THAT INFORMATION
AND PROPERLY MAKE AN ASSESSMENT
ON WHAT THEY'RE DOING TO
INCREASE DIVERSITY IN PRODUCTION
ARE BUT THIS IS A PROUD. A
PROGRAM THAT WE'VE THAT WE
PASSED.
SEVERAL YEARS AND IT BENEFITS A
LOT OF COMMUNITIES OF BENEFITS A
LOT OF PEOPLE WE CANNOT FORGET
THAT THE BELOW THE LINE.
THE WE KEEP FAMILIES TOGETHER
BY MAKING SURE THEY'RE NOT
HAVING TO GO TO OTHER STATES
THAT HAVE PRODUCTION TAX CREDITS
DON'T HAVE TO LEAVE THE COUNTRY
HOW WE'RE GOING TO DO SOMETHING
FOR OUR MUSICIANS. ABOUT ARE THE
ONES THAT BRING OUT HEART AND
SOUL TO THESE PRODUCTIONS ARE
THROUGH THE MUSIC MAKING SURE
THAT THEIR JOBS ARE GOING TO BE
INCLUDED IN THIS PROGRAM BECAUSE
WE CARE ABOUT THOSE JOBS. ARE
BUT THIS IS A GOOD PROGRAM IT'S
A HUGE BENEFIT TO CALIFORNIAN
INDUSTRY THAT IS HOME GROWN HERE
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
NOW I ONE POINT TIME. WE WERE IN
THE PRISON WE ARE IN THE
POSITION OF LOSING.
BUT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO SAVE IT
THROUGH THIS PROGRAM WERE ALWAYS
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THIS PROGRAM IT'S ALWAYS GONNA
BE A WORK IN PROGRESS TO INCLUDE
MODE MORE IVERSE CITY. MORE
INCLUSIVENESS AND MORE
PROTECTIONS OFFICE ABOUT THOSE.
THAT ARE WORKING ON THESE
PRODUCTIONS DON'T FEEL LIKE THEY
CAN BE HARASSED OR ARE IN A
POSITION TO BE HARASSING THAT
THERE'S NOTHING IN IT THAT'S
GOING TO BE DONE ABOUT IT. SO
WORKING HARD IT'S ALWAYS
CONTINUING TO BE A WORK IN
PROGRESS BUT WE'RE GETTING CLOSE
AND SOME OF THE LANGUAGE ARE BUT
I APPRECIATE ALL THE COMMENTS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM QUICKLY IS OPEN
THEIR OWN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
OKAY MY MY KIDS
.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
FIVE KNOWS TO
MEASURE PASSED.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE ARE MOVING
BACK AND FILE ORDER TO ITEM
THIRTY FIVE AB TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
SOME LEGAL TWENTY THIRTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN AND
ACTUALLY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
SOME MEMBER MULLIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER SINCE
THE ENACTMENT OF THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AUTHORITIES LAW. VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS OF ASK FOR CLEAN UP
LANGUAGE TO ENSURE THAT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AUTHORITIES
AND TAX INCREMENT FINANCING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CAN BE
PROPERLY IMPLEMENTED AB TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE PROVIDES CLARITY. TO
TAXING ENTITIES AND LOCAL
AUDITOR CONTROLLERS ON HOW TO
ADDRESS COMPLEXITIES IN THE
LOCAL PROPERTY TAX INCREMENT
FRAMEWORK. IS A TECHNICAL CLEAN
UP BILL WHICH WILL MAKE IT
EASIER FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
CREATE AND USE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AUTHORITIES AND I ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING THEIR REQUEST
TO SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE.
MEMBERS.
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
RULING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FORTY FOUR NO NINETEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING WITHOUT OBJECTION TO ITEM
THIRTY NINE AB TWENTY FIVE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED GREAT I JUST WANT TO
UPDATE MEMBERS THAT.
WE HAVE PASSED NINETY BILLS
FIVE ARE STILL ON CALL AS A
THREE FORTY FIVE PM.
I WAS STILL TRYING TO GET THAT
TWO HUNDRED MARK SO.
AGAIN I LEVEL THE OTHER TALKING
BUT IF WE CAN GET MOVIN AT
APPRECIATE IT.
MEMBERS MOVING TO ITEM THIRTY
NINE EIGHTY TWO.
FORTY
AND FOR PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE FORTY
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN AND
ACTUALLY TO ELECTIONS.
THANK YOU A SUMMER MULLIN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THEY YOU MANNIX MADAM SPEAKER
BRIEFLY AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY SIX
TO ENSURE THAT PUBLIC FACILITIES
REMAIN AVAILABLE FOR USE AS
VOTES CENTERS THIS IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT AS IMPLEMENTATION OF
SP FOUR FIFTY.
THE CALIFORNIA VOTERS CHOICE ACT
BEGINS IS HERE IN MULTIPLE
COUNTIES INCLUDING MINE SAN
MATEO.
WELL IF YOU'RE LOCATIONS WILL BE
NEEDED ON ELECTION DAY ITSELF
THE NUMBER OF LOCATIONS THEY DID
DURING THE EARLY VOTING PERIOD
IS SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED UNDER.
SP FOUR FIFTY PUBLIC FACILITIES
INCLUDING SCHOOLS LIBRARIES
COMMUNITY CENTERS AND CITY HALLS
ARE IDEAL LOCATIONS FOR VOTES
CENTERS THEY'RE EQUIPPED WITH
INTERNET AND WIFI THEIR
ACCESSIBLE AND VOTERS ARE
GENERALLY FAMILIAR. WITH WHERE
THEY ARE LOCATED IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
TWENTY FIVE FORTY WILL PROVIDE
ELECTIONS OF MINISTERS OF MORE
RESOURCES AND ULTIMATELY MAKE
CERTAIN THAT VOTERS HAVE ACCESS
TO VOTE CENTERS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND I ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MATTER QUICKLY IS OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
RULING TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM EIGHTY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY TWO MADAM QUICKLY THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
TWO BY SOME A MEMBER MULLIN AND
OTHERS AND I TO LINK HOUSING.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER MULLIN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED MEN THINK ABOUT
US BIGGER TOGGLING BACK TO
HOUSING AB TWENTY FIVE SIX TWO
GRANTS THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AUTHORITY TO ADJUST
INTEREST RATES ON LOANS. COUPLED
WITH AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS.
UTILIZING FEDERAL LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDITS WHEN NEEDED
TO MAKE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS FEASIBLE WHILE HCD
CURRENTLY HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
REDUCE THE INTEREST RATE ON SOME
LOANS AND INCREASE THE RATE ON
CERTAIN OTHERS. THIS BILL WOULD
GIVE EIGHT CD BROAD AUTHORITY TO
INCREASE OR DECREASE THE
INTREST RATE ON ANY EIGHT CD
LOAN WHEN NEEDED TO HELP MAKE
PROJECTS PENCIL OUT. LOCAL
PUBLIC AGENCIES HAVE BEEN
ADJUSTING THEIR INTEREST RATES
IN THE SITUATIONS FOR YEARS THIS
FLEXIBILITY IS ALSO NEEDED AT
THE STATE LEVEL AND I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
WRONG. I MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES. EYES
FORTY FIVE KNOWS EIGHTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES MOVING WITHOUT
OBJECTION TO ITEM ONE OH TO AB
TWENTY SEVEN OH SEVEN MADAM
CLERK FISHERIES.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY SEVEN A
SEVEN BY SOME A MEMBER MULLIN
AND ACTUALLY TO VOTERS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER FINALLY AB TWENTY
SEVEN OH SEVEN SEEKS TO PROVIDE
VOTERS WITH AN ONLINE DATABASE
WHERE THEY CAN EASILY FIND
CONTACT INFORMATION FOR. FOR
EACH OF THEIR FEDERAL STATE
LOCAL REPRESENTATIVES IN PUBLIC
OFFICE.
CURRENTLY VOTERS MUST REVIEW
MULTIPLE LAYERS OF GOVERNMENT
WEBSITES IN ORDER TO OBTAIN A
COMPLETE LIST OF THEIR ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES TWENTY SEVEN OH
SEVEN WILL FACILITATE CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT FOR VOTE VOTERS BY
PROVIDING A CENTRALIZED LOCATION.
WHERE ESSENTIAL INFORMATION
REGARDING EACH OF THEIR ELECTED
OFFICIALS IS RETURNED THEM UPON
ENTERING THEIR ADDRESS THANK YOU
AND I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE?
THANK YOU SEEN THAT NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MADAM CLERK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL ON ITEM NUMBER ONE
FORTY EIGHT AB THIRTY ONE
FIFTEEN.
BUT A QUICKLY IS.
OPEN THE ROLE.
.
HOPE WILL POST
MISTER GIBSON WITH A CALL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING BACK TO ITEM.
ONE EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY THREE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY THREE BY SOME A MEMBER
NAZARIAN AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
THE CRIME.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER HIS
AREA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. AB
TWENTY TWENTY THREE ENSURES THAT
A. CONVICTS SERVE THEIR FULL
SENTENCES BY ADDING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND SPECIFICITY
CIVIC INSTANCES OF RAPE TO THE
LIST OF VIOLENT CRIMES.
AB TWENTY TWENTY THREE EXPANDS
THE TYPES OF RAPE INCLUDED ON
THE LIST OF VIOLENT CRIMES FOR
THOSE SITUATIONS WHERE A VICTIM
IS UNABLE TO GIVE CONSENT SUCH
AS BEING IN A STATE OF
UNCONSCIOUSNESS OR INTOXICATION.
SERIOUSNESS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AND RAPE SHOULD REQUIRE.
THAT A PUNISHMENT FIT THE CRIME.
SINCE THE PASSING OF PROP FIFTY
SEVEN THE PERPETRATORS OF THESE
CRIMES WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
EARLY PAROLE. AB TWENTY TWENTY
THREE SIR STRENGTHENS THE
PURPOSE OF PROP FIFTY SEVEN
WHICH WAS INTENDED TO ALLOW NON
VIOLENT REHABILITATED OFFENDERS.
ELIGIBILITY FOR EARLY RELEASE
AND NOT PERPETRATORS OF VIOLENT
ACTS
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I'M PROUD TO BE JOINT AUTHOR ON
AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY THREE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW DIFFERENT
FORMS OF RAPE ARE NOT CONSIDERED
VIOLENT FELONIES.
THIS BILL ENSURES AT THESE ACTS
OUR CLASSIFIED AS VIOLENT CRIMES.
AND THAT THE PERPETRATORS SERVE
THEIR TIME. AB TWENTY TWENTY
THREE ENSURES THE VICTIMS
RECEIVE THE JUSTICE THEY DESERVE
ARE ALSO RESPECT RESTAURANT AYE
VOTE. ON AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
THREE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER
YOUR RECOGNIZED METAL SPEAKER
MEMBERS CURRENTLY CALIFORNIALAW
DOES NOT RECOGNIZE THE CLAIMS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING RAPE OF AN
UNCONSCIOUS PERSON. RATE OF IN
TOSCA PERSON OR RAPE OF A
MENTALLY HANDICAPPED PERSON IS
VIOLENT.
ONCE CONVICTED FOR ONE OF THESE
CRIMES AND SINS TO PRISON THE
PERPETRATORS ELIGIBLE FOR EARLY
RELEASE. UNDER THE CURRENT LAW.
PERSONS CONVICTED THESE CRIMES
OR SOME OF THE WORST PREDATORS
IN OUR SOCIETY AND SHOULD NOT
RECEIVE ANY SPECIAL CREDITS THAT
ALLOW THEM TO GET OUT OF PRISON
EARLY.
IT'S KIND OF VIOLENT KNOWS
CONVICTS OF THEM DESERVE TO
FULFILL THEIR FULL SENTENCE
THE VICTIM DESERVE FULL JUSTICE.
I RESPECTFULLY URGE DRIVE VOTE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I GUESS
THIS IS THE DAY OF TALKING ABOUT
SEX AND GUNS WHICH ARE ALWAYS
TOUGH ISSUES.
I DO WANT TO SHARE THAT SEX
CRIMES ARE ONE OF THE FEW AREAS
IN THIS PENAL CODE. THAT COME
WITH STACKABLE CONSECUTIVE
SENTENCES WHICH MEANS YOU CAN BE
A SENTENCE ONE ON TOP OF THE
OTHER. THE SAME PERSON FOR THE
SAME INSTANCE.
IN FACT THE PENAL CODE IS RICH.
IN WAYS TO PROSECUTE SEX CRIMES.
IF THIS IS IN RESPONSE AND I
KNOW THAT I'M NEW TO AGREE JUST
ACTIONS THAT FOLKS IN THE PAST
HAVE DONE.
I HAVE TO SAY.
THEY WERE NOT NOT PROSECUTED AND
NOT JAILED BECAUSE THIS LAW WAS
NOT ON THE BOOKS.
THEY WERE NOT PROSECUTED AND NOT
JAILED BECAUSE OF THEIR
PRIVILEGE.
ALL THIS WILL DO WILL
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT THOSE
WHO ARE ALREADY
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT
PROSECUTORS HAVE SO MANY TOOLS
AT THEIR DISPOSAL RIGHT NOW TO
PROSECUTE THOSE WHO SHOULD BE
CONVICTED OF SEX CRIMES.
A NO VOTE ON THIS BILL IS NOT.
BEING SOFT ON CRIME IT IS BEING
COMMITTED. TO OUR CIVIL
LIBERTIES I RESPECTFULLY URGE A
NO VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU.
I.
DISAGREE WITH THE STATEMENT THAT
PEOPLE SHOULD NOT BE ELIGIBLE
FOR PAROLE.
PAROLE IS NOT AUTOMATIC.
PAROLE HAPPENS BECAUSE PEOPLE
HAVE CHANGED THEIR LIVES.
WE SHOULD GIVE PEOPLE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CHANGE OUR LIVES.
AND TO GET OUT.
AND LEAD PRODUCTIVE LIVES.
THESE CRIMES ALREADY SEVERELY
PUNISHED.
IT IS TIME TO REALIZE.
THAT LOCK THEM UP AND THROW AWAY
THE KEY IS NOT THE ANSWER
REDUCING RECIDIVISM.
GIVING PEOPLE SERVICES.
GETTING PEOPLE.
TO ACCEPT THAT THEY MADE A
MISTAKE AND TO TURN THEIR LIVES
AROUND IS WHAT MATTERS AND THE
INCENTIVE OF GETTING OUT ON
PAROLE.
WILL AND CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE
TAKING THAT AWAY WILL NOT HELP
US THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALLEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
AND ON THE SIMPLY FLOOR I'M
SHOCKED BY SOMETHING YOU FOR THE
POLITICIANS IS SERVING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE LET
ME JUST BE VERY CLEAR. YOU JUST
HEARD FROM TWO.
ELECTED OFFICIALS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT ARE TRYING TO DEFEND.
SEXUAL PREDATORS THEY'RE GUILTY
OF THE FOLLOWING CRIMES.
RAPE SPOUSAL RAPE SODOMY ORAL
COPULATION AND SEXUAL
PENETRATION BY A FOREIGN OBJECT
WITH THOSE CRIMES INVOLVE THE
VICTIM WE CANNOT GIVE VALID
CONSENT TO SEXUAL ACTIVITY DUE
TO DISABILITY OR MENTAL
DISABILITY WHERE THE VICTIM
CANNOT CONSENT DUE TO BEING
DRUGGED OR INTOXICATED. OR THE
VICTIM CANNOT GIVE CONSENT DUE
TO BEING UNCONSCIOUS IT ALL A A.
IT EVEN ADDS.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING TO THIS LIST
LISTEN.
THE ONLY PERSON THAT WOULD BE IN
FAVOR.
OF THIS LAW NOT PASSING.
I'D PROBABLY BE.
SOMETHING LIKE BILL COSBY.
IT SHOULD NOT BE ANY OF THE
MEMBERS OF THIS FOR IT IS
SHOCKING THAT ANYONE WOULD NOT
VOTE YES ON THIS THIS BILL. IS
PHENOMENAL THESE CRIMES ARE
ATROCIOUS ANYBODY THAT IS
AGAINST THIS BILL IS TRULY
AGAINST JUSTICE IN CALIFORNIA.
VOTE VOTE I.
DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MADAM SPEAKER I WASN'T GOING TO
SAY ANYTHING.
SINCE WARY ONE OF THE GREAT
EXAMPLES OF PEOPLE WHO SHOULD BE
PROSECUTED I WOULD SAY DONALD
TRUMP. BUT ASIDE FROM ALL OF
THAT WHO ALSO WHO HAS YET TO BE
TRIED FOR ALL THE COUNTY HAS
ACTUALLY SAID HE DID IT. AGAINST
WOMEN ALSO YOU KNOW.
WE BOTH WE LOOK AT THAT ALONE
WE SEE THE INCONSISTENCY IN THE
SYSTEM THAT EXIST.
THE TERM WHO GETS PROSECUTED WHO
DOES NOT GET PROSECUTED. THIS IS
A DIFFICULT BILL.
AND I CITY AND WANDERED CUANDO
ABOUT IT MAINLY BECAUSE ONCE
AGAIN. WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE
THESE PROBLEMS IN THE QUICKEST
AND FASTEST WAY THAT WE THINK WE
CAN.
NO WE JUST SPENT.
MUCH TIME BILLS HAVE BEEN IN
THIS BUILDING FOR THE LAST.
THREE OR FOUR YEARS AND THOSE OF
YOU WHO KNOW NOW.
RECOGNIZING THAT WE HAVE SPENT
TWENTY YEARS OR MORE STACKING
CRIMES ON TOP OF CRIMES ON TOP
OF CRIMES SPECIFYING THINGS WITH
ITS CRACK COCAINE WITH ITS SEX
TRAFFICKING. A WHAT WOULD ITS
GANG LIST UP IN VIOLENCE AND SO
FORTH AND SO ON AND PILING THESE
BEINGS ON TO MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR FOLKS TO RECLAIM
THEIR LIVES.
AND WHAT WE'VE DONE IS THE OVER
THE YEARS AS WE HAVE MADE AN
OVERCROWDED PRISON SYSTEM.
WELL WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND PEOPLE IN PRISON
WE START WITH TWENTY WOMEN WENT
TO HUNT IN EIGHTY.
WE'RE NOW BACK DOUBTS ABOUT ONE
FORTY AND WE STILL HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE STILL HAVE THE LARGEST
PRISON SYSTEM IN THE WORLD. YET
WE DON'T HAVE ANY MORE SAFER
ENVIRONMENT IN THE STATE THAN
ANY OF THE STATE.
AND SO IT'S INTERESTING TO ME AS
I LISTEN TO THIS AND WE KEEP
ADDING THESE ENHANCEMENTS ADDING
THESE ADDITIONAL THINGS TO THE
LIST.
THAT WE ALREADY HAVE THE ABILITY
TO PROSECUTE PEOPLE FOR RIGHT
NOW AND WE DO.
IT BOTHERS ME THAT WE HAVE NOT
LEARNED FROM THE PAST.
BUT WE CONTINUE TO MAKE THE SAME
MISTAKE OVER AND OVER AGAIN BIDE
ONCE AGAIN FOCUSING ON A
SPECIFIC CRIME CREATING MORE
DIFFICULTY IN WHAT TIME FOR
PEOPLE TO SPEND IN PRISON. AND
THEN WILL STAND BACK AND SAY ALL
MY GOD WE HAD TO HAVE ANOTHER
BILLION DOLLARS TO OUR PRISON
BUDGET WHICH TAKES A BILLION OUT
OF OUR SCHOOLS. AND NOW WE HAVE
THIS HIGH RECIDIVISM RATE
BECAUSE WERE OVERCROWDED AND WE
CAN'T DO ANYTHING TO HELP PEOPLE
RECLAIM THEIR LIVES.
SO WE HAVE DONE WE WE TAKE ONE
STEP FORWARD AND THEN FOUR STEPS
BACK.
WE WAS WITH FAILED TO LISTEN TO
WHAT THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
HAS SAID ABOUT THEIR OWN PRISON
SYSTEM WHEN THEY PASSED THE
PROPOSITION. AND WE A COSTLY
WORKING WHAT TO DO WHAT TO
REBUILD A HUGE PRISON SYSTEM
AGAIN. THAT MAKES IS NO SAFER
THAN WE WERE BEFORE.
AND WE CAN SIT AND TALK ABOUT
AND DO ALL THE SCARE TACTICS IN
THE WORLD ABOUT HOW HORRIBLE
IT'S GOING TO BE AND WHO'S GOING
TO GET OUT OF HOW WE'RE GOING TO
BE PROTECTED. WITHOUT REALIZING
THAT WE FELT NO SAFER WITH A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN PRISON THEN WE FEEL
RIGHT NOW TODAY. IT'S I CAUTION
YOU AS I LOOK AT THIS BECAUSE
IT'S NOT THAT THOSE WHO WILL BE
MAY VOTE AGAINST THIS ARE IN
FAVOR OF RAPISTS AND SO FORTH
AND SO ON. WHAT WE OUGHT TO BE
LOOKING CAREFULLY AT WHERE WE
HAVE BEEN?
AND WHERE YOU WANT TO GO.
WE SHOULD LEARN FROM MY HISTORY
AND PEOPLE WHO DON'T LEARN FROM
THEIR HISTORY ARE DOOMED TO MAKE
THE SAME MISTAKES OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
AND SO WHAT IT SOUNDS GOOD TO
JUMP ON THIS.
I WANT TO CAUTION YOU ESTA WHAT
ROAD WE'RE GOING DOWN AND WHERE
WE HAVE BEEN AND WHERE WE THINK
WE TAKE PRIDE ABOUT WHERE WE'RE
GOING. INSTEAD OF UNRAVELING
EVERYTHING SO QUICKLY AND MAKING
OURSELVES BACK WHERE WE STARTED.
WITH NOT JUST THE LARGEST PRISON
SYSTEM IN THE WORLD BUT THE MOST
RIDICULOUSLY LARGEST PRISON
SYSTEM IN THE WORLD. I URGE YOU
TO CAREFULLY THINK ABOUT THIS
BILL I URGE YOU TO TAKE SOME
TIME PROBABLY OTE AGAINST IT OR
NOT VOTE AT ALL AND WANTED TO
GIVE.
FOLKS MORE TIME TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT WE'RE DOING AND NOT SIMPLY
RUSH IN BECAUSE THE PUBLIC IS
WATCHING US AND WE DON'T WANT TO
SEEM TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF RAPISTS.
I DON'T THINK ANYONE IN THIS
FLOOR IS SUPPORTIVE OF RAPIST.
NONE OF US ARE.
AND AND WHETHER IT'S SOMEBODY WE
KNOW JUST OF A DISTANCE IS NOT
IT'S A VIOLENT ACT AGAINST A
WOMAN AND SOMETIMES AGAINST MAN.
WE'RE NOT SUPPORTIVE OF A BUT
THIS IS NOT THE SOLUTION AND
WE'VE DISCOVERED THAT YEAR AFTER
YEAR AFTER YEAR AND WILL
CONTINUE TO MAKE THE SAME
MISTAKE AGAIN WHAT. THE MEDIA
ATTENTION I'M NOT SURE BECAUSE
I'M NOT RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR BUT
I DO KNOW ONE THING THAT WE HAVE
BEEN HERE BEFORE. AND WE SHOULD
NOT GO THERE AGAIN IF WE ARE
SMART.
SEEING NO FURTHER REQUEST TO
SPEAK ASSEMBLY MEMBER HIS AREA
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES I
WOULD THINK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO BE AN
OPPOSING SIDES WITH SOMEONE THAT
I RESPECT SO MUCH SO FROM. TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO I
ALWAYS.
HE JUROR DICE AND I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE WHERE YOU'RE COMING
FROM ON THIS.
AND WE HAVE TAKEN GREAT STRIDES
AND FOR EVERYONE HERE IF YOU
WERE TO LOOK AT MY VOTING RECORD
I THINK YOU'D BE AWARE OF WHERE
I'VE STOOD. ON MOST OF THESE
ISSUES WHICH IS RIGHT ALONG
WHERE YOU HAVE BEEN.
BUT.
THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
MISTAKEN IT WAS AN OVERSIGHT BY
THE ADMINISTRATION WHEN PROP
FIFTY SEVEN WAS BEING PUSHED A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO.
AND MY GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM
POMONA.
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE THROUGH
LEGISLATION LAST YEAR IT WAS
HELD IN APPROPRIATIONS BECAUSE
THERE WAS AN ATTEMPT
POTENTIALLY TO TRY TO FIX IT.
WHEN THE COURTS THIS YEAR
EARLIER RULED AND ALLOWED FOR
MANY PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO BE
PAROLED EARLIER BY THE WAY THIS
BILL DOES NOT DO ANYTHING TO
PAROLE YOU
STILL. ARE ABLE TO GET PAROLED.
IT A LOT IT INSURES THAT A
SELECT FEW AREAS OF RAPE SODOMY.
OF ORAL COPULATION AND VARIOUS
OTHER AREAS WHICH IF YOU. WERE
TO ADD COMMUTE OF LEE.
DO NOT.
DO NOT CONTRIBUTE TO A GREAT
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
CURRENTLY IN JAIL. BUT ON
PRINCIPLE. NEED TO SERVE THEIR
TIME.
SO AS MUCH AS I VALUE THE
ARGUMENTS THAT WERE MADE AGAINST.
UP BY BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO LET'S ALSO NOT ALLOWED
THIS ISSUE. TO BE HOSTAGE TO
OTHER SCORES THAT ARE BEING
SETTLED THIS IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO IN SUPPORTING THIS BILL
RIGHT NOW AND TO FIX SOMETHING.
THAT WAS UNFORTUNATELY. NOT
ADDRESSED WELL AND PROP FIFTY
SEVEN WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK VERY AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM HER PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TELLING THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY SEVEN KNOWS THREE THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING NOW BACK IN FILE ORDER.
TWO ITEM OF ONE SIXTY SEVEN AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN FORTY
THREE BY FAMILY MEMBERS
O'DONNELL AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL YOUR RECOGNIZED.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE
ESTABLISHES ONGOING FUNDING FOR
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS IN OUR K.. TWELVE
SCHOOLS
AT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
PER YEAR WITH A ONE TO ONE LOCAL
MATCH REQUIREMENT.
CTE VOCATIONAL EDUCATION IS
CRITICAL FOR STUDENTS AND THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY.
CURRENCY T. FUNDING STREAMS
EXPIRE THIS YEAR.
WE NEED TO MAINTAIN THE STRONG
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS SUPPORTED IN THE
PAST
AND TO BUILD ON THAT INVESTMENT
BY HER RIDING STABLE ONGOING
FUNDING.
TO K. TWELVE SCHOOLS FOR CAREER
TECHNICAL VOCATIONAL EDUCATION.
THIS BILL HAS STRONG BY PORTIS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND SUPPORTED
BY A WIDE RANGE OF BUSINESS
LABOR AND EDUCATION ORGANIZATION.
AYE ASPIRIN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
THREE. WHICH I AM CO AUTHORING
WE OWE IT TO OUR YOUTH TO ENSURE
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION HIGH SCHOOL.
BLACK WOMEN I WAS IN SCHOOL WE
CALL THE VOCATIONAL ED.
I TOOK WOOD WORKING ANOTHER SHOP
CLASSES THIS TRAINING GOT ME
INTO IT A CARPENTRY
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM RIGHT
AFTER GRADUATION.
I WENT ON TO BUILD A SUCCESSFUL
CAREER AS A CONTRACTOR.
NOW I'M A MEMBER OF THIS BODY.
LIKE ME NOT EVERY STUDENTS GOING
TO COLLEGE
IN CASE YOU HAVEN'T NOTICED
COLLEGE HAS BECOME QUITE
EXPENSIVE.
RIGHT NOW EMPLOYERS CAN'T FIND
ENOUGH QUALIFIED PEOPLE TO FILL
HIGH PAYING TECHNICAL JOBS.
THESE JOBS RANGE FROM COMPUTER
CODING TO BUILDING TRADES.
AND IN MANY CASES THE PEOPLE IN
THESE CAREERS EARN MORE THAN
COLLEGE GRADUATES.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE WILL
ALLOW STUDENTS TO TRAIN FOR
THESE CAREERS WHILE STILL IN
HIGH SCHOOL.
WE HAVE MANY OPTIONS TO HELP
COLLEGE BOUND STUDENTS TO
SUCCEED WE MUST DO THE SAME FOR
STUDENTS WHO ARE COLLEGE BOUND.
AND WE CAN DO THAT WITH AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE THANK YOU
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
RIVAL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. MEMBERS
I'M PROUD OF THE BIPARTISAN WORK
WE'VE DONE A SUPPORT FREE
TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
IN THE COMING YEARS OVER FIVE
MILLION. BABY BOOMERS WILL
RETIRE ON THE SKILLED TRADES
THERE'S TREMENDOUS DEMAND IN
THAT AREA.
AND THEREFORE THERE IS
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR
KIDS.
AND BY SUPPORTING THIS BILL
TODAY YOU SUPPORT THOSE KIDS YOU
GIVE OPPORTUNITY TO THEM SO THEY
CAN GET EXPOSURE.
TO A SKILL SET THAT THEY CAN USE
TO PROVIDE FOOD FOR THEIR
FAMILIES AND MAKE IT A GREAT
LIFT.
I CAN THINK OF NO BETTER VOTE TO
CAST TODAY.
IT'S BILLS RIGHT FOR CALIFORNIA
IT'S RIGHT FOR EDUCATION.
IT'S RIGHT FOR OUR KIDS.
I URGE MY BOAT THANK YOU.
THINK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
THURMOND YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE.
I'M PROUD TO BE A JOINT AUTHOR I
WOULD ECHO THE SENTIMENTS THAT
YOU'VE HEARD TODAY FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WE TALK ALL THE TIME.
ABOUT CREATING COLLEGE AND
CAREER PATHWAYS.
THIS BILL REALLY CREATES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY MOVE ON
THOSE PATHWAYS IN TO HELP. OUR
STUDENTS TO BE AWARE OF SOME OF
THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE AWARE
FOR THEM. YOU SEEN IN RECENT
REPORTS THAT IN MANY SECTORS WE
CANNOT FILL THE JOBS IN THOSE
SECTORS THAT SOMETIMES IT'S IN
CONSTRUCTION SOMETIMES IT'S
ENCODING.
OFTEN IT TECHNOLOGY A THESE
OPPORTUNITIES TO CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION ENSURE THAT
OUR STUDENTS LEARN EARLY ABOUT
WHAT THOSE OPPORTUNITIES ARE
THAT THEY GET HANDS ON
EXPERIENCE IS LIKE INTERNSHIPS.
AND OTHER OPPORTUNITIES TO ALLOW
THEM TO BE ON A PATHWAY TO A
GREAT CAREER THAT WILL SERVE
THEIR COMMUNITIES SERVE THEIR
FAMILIES AND SERVE THEIR SUCCESS.
ON BEHALF OF OUR STUDENTS IN OUR
FUTURE WORKFORCE.
I URGE AYE VOTE FOR AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE.
THANK YOU ALL DEBATE AND
DISCUSSION HAVING CEASED MADAM
CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
FIVE AT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM ONE SIXTY EIGHT
EIGHTY SEVEN TEAMS.
SIXTY TWO MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
SOME LEGAL SEVENTEEN SIXTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER STEINORTH AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE STATE
PARKS
THANK YOU SO MEMBERS TIME WITH
YOUR RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I'M I ASK
YOUR INDULGENCE THIS WILL BE MY
LAST BILL THE PRESENT.
OFTEN IT CAN BE VERY ROUGH FOR
PET OWNERS TO FIGURE OUT WHERE
THEY CAN TAKE THEIR PETS IN
STATE PARKS.
I WENT ONLINE TO FIND WERE PETS
ARE ALLOWED IN STATE PARKS AND
IT WAS IMPOSSIBLE TO FAX ANY
INFORMATION.
YOU WOULD HAVE TO WORK YOUR TAIL
OFF TO DETERMINE WHERE YOU COULD
TAKE A DOG FOR A HIKE.
BY REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT OF
PARKS AND RECREATION TO RETRIEVE
INFORMATION ON WHERE PETS ARE
ALLOWED IN EACH STATE PARKING
COMPILED INTO A COMPREHENSIVE
ONLINE LIST. AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
TWO WILL ENABLE MORE PET OWNERS
TO ENJOY OUR STATE PARKS
I WOULD HOW WOULD YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT BUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTES.
THE MIST I DON'T.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLUB
CLUB MOREAU.
ON MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL. CLOSER ROLE TALENTED
BUT I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
RICHARD PASSING TEMPORARILY AND
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY NINE.
FILE IEM ONE SEVENTY.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY BY MR
MAIENSCHEIN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
BY FAMILY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
HEALTH. MISMATCH I THANK YOU OUT
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
ANIMALS INCLUDING OUR PETS CAN
CARRY DANGEROUS DISEASES
INCLUDING RABIES TAPEWORM WINE
DISEASE AS WELL. AS A NUMBER OF
OTHER VIRUSES SOME OF THESE
DISEASES CAN EVEN BE TRANSFERRED
TO HUMANS AS REPORTED BY THE US
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
PREVENTION A RECENT EXAMPLE OF
SUCH AN OUTBREAK IS A BACTERIAL
INFECTION. THAT IS NOW AFFECTED
PEOPLE IN SEVENTEEN STATES
THIS OUTBREAK HAS BEEN
PARTICULARLY DANGEROUS DUE TO
THE FACT THAT THE STRAIN IS
RESISTANT.
TO NUMEROUS COMMON ANTIBIOTICS
TYPICALLY USED TO TREAT THE
VIRUS WHILE THE CURRENT OUTBREAK
CONTINUES TO SPREAD THE EXISTING
SCOPE OF THE DEPARTMENT'S
AUTHORITY WOULD NOT ENSURE THAT
PETS LIKE TO THE OUTBREAK OR NOT.
IMPORTED INTO THE STATE GIVEN
THE PREVALENCE OF MULTI STATE
TRANSACTIONS IN THE DANGEROUS
NATURE OF ANIMAL BORNE DISEASE
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY WILL EXPAND
THE DEPARTMENT'S AUTHORITY. TO
BETTER PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ALLOW IT TO INVESTIGATE AN ISSUE
AN ORDER PROHIBITING IMPORTATION
OF DOGS OR CATS AFFECTED BY
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE OUTBREAK
INTO THE STATE. THINKING I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I'VE UP.
THEY RAISE MAIENSCHEIN SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CORPORAL PLURAL.
.
SARAH VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
THERE THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FIFTY EIGHT.
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTY ONE IS AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FOUR CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE FOSTER CARE. THIS
MAIENSCHEIN YOU MAKE AN OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THE
CURRENT CALIFORNIA FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM RESULTS IN TOO MANY
CHILDREN BEING MOVED FROM HOME
TO HOME FAR TOO FREQUENTLY. WHEN
CHILDREN UNDERGO MULTIPLE
PLACEMENTS THEY ARE LIKELY TO
EXPERIENCE SEVERE TRAUMA.
STUDIES SHOW A MAJOR REASON FOR
FAMILIES TO REQUEST REMOVAL OF
FOSTER CHILDREN FROM THEIR HOMES
IS DUE TO INSUFFICIENT
COMMUNICATION AND SUPPORT FROM
THE CHILD'S CASE WORKER. AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FOUR WILL
ESTABLISH A TWO YEAR PILOT
PROGRAM PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT TO FOSTER AND KINSHIP
CAREGIVERS VIA POST PLACEMENT
COACHING. THIS PILOT PROJECT
WILL HELP FOSTER YOUTH OBTAIN A
PERMANENT FAMILY AND AVOID MANY
NEGATIVE OUTCOMES BY PROVIDING
RESOURCE FAMILIES WITH THE
NECESSARY INFORMATION AND TOOLS
TO ENSURE THE SUCCESS OF THE
PERMANENT SITUATION. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND
I'VE.
THEY WISH MAIENSCHEIN SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CORPORATE
ROLL-ON. VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE SARAH VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE WHAT I SIXTY ONE
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTY TO PASS RETAIN.
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY THREE.
IS AB EIGHT YOU KNOW ONE
CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN ó ONE
BUY SOMETHING MEMBER NAZARIAN
AND ACTUALLY TO NEWBORNS.
MR HIS AREA. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER A AB T. NO ONE WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO ESTABLISH A
COMMISSION WHICH WOULD REVIEW
AND PROVIDE. RECOMMENDATIONS
TISSUE SURROUNDING EXPOSURE TO
CYTOMEGALOVIRUS.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS CMV CMB IS
THE MOST COMMON INFECTIOUS
BECAUSE OF BIRTH DEFECTS IN THE
U. S. IMPACTING ONE IN TWO
HUNDRED INFANTS EACH YEAR. IT
CAN LEAD TO HEARING LOSS VISION
LOSS CAESAR SEIZURES.
DEVELOPMENTAL AND MOTOR DELAY
AND OTHER LONG TERM HEALTH
PROBLEMS.
AS A BIG PROBLEM AS CMB IS
UNFORTUNATE ONLY NINE PERCENT OF
THE POPULATION EVEN KNOWS ABOUT
IT.
OVER THE PAST FEW MONTHS WE'VE
ENGAGED IN MEANINGFUL
CONVERSATIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS
IN THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY ON HOW
TO MAKE THIS COMMISSION MOST
EFFECTIVE. THROUGH THIS BILL
CALIFORNIA WILL GATHER
INFORMATION WHICH CAN BE USED TO
COMBAT THE SERIOUS VIRUS.
THE BILL REPRESENTS A FIRST AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN CALIFORNIA TO
JOIN A NATIONAL TREND WORKING TO
ADDRESS CMB.
THIS BILL RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY EMISSIONS AREA SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
COR CLUB IN THE WRONG. ON
MEMBERS.
ROSARIO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AND ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
ICE FIFTY THREE NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY FOUR.
IT'S A. B..
EIGHTEEN FIFTY EIGHT COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON
AND OTHERS AND I ACTUALLY MISSED
DUE TO FINANCIAL AID. WHICH
CALDERON. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT REQUIRES ALL
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES IN
CALIFORNIA USE THE US DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION'S FINANCIAL AID
SHOPPING SHEET. WHEN
COMMUNICATING FINANCIALLY
PACKAGES TO STUDENTS.
CURRENTLY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
MANDATES ALL INSTITUTIONS USES
SHOPPING SHEET WHEN
COMMUNICATING FINANCIAL AID TO
VETERANS.
THIS MASTER SIMPLY EXPANDS THIS
MANDATE TO ALL STUDENTS THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND HAS RECEIVED ANY NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
NAMES CALDERON.
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CLERK LIBERAL. I'M.
THESE ARE ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE ROLE TIES OUT
EYES FIFTY NINE THERE WAS ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONCE EVERY FIVE IS AB.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY BY MISSILE AMONG
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN SIXTY BY
SOME REMEMBER LIMON AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE.
THIS ALONE. THINK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
REMOVES THE SUNSET ON THE ORAL
CHEMOTHERAPY.
CHEMOTHERAPY FAIRNESS ACT AND
MAKE SURE THAT THE CANCER
PATIENTS CAN'T AFFORD THEIR
TREATMENT. BEFORE THE PASSAGE OF
AB TWO NINETEEN CANCER PATIENTS
HAD TO PAY THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
OUT OF POCKETS FOR THEIR ORAL
CHEMOTHERAPY IS BECAUSE IT WAS A
DRUG BENEFIT. AS OPPOSED TO IV
TREATMENTS.
BECAUSE IT WAS AN ORAL BUT IF AS
OPPOSED TO IV TREATMENTS.
WHICH ARE A MEDICAL BENEFITS.
BECAUSE OF THE ORAL CHEMOTHERAPY
FAIRNESS ACT CANCER PATIENTS CAN
WORK WITH DOCTORS TO FIND THE
MEDICATION THAT BEST SUITS THEIR
NEEDS.
THE OTHER BENEFITS OF ORAL
CHEMOTHERAPY IS THAT THEY CAN BE
TARGETED TO SEE.
TARGETED OR SMART THERAPY
HELPING LOWER EMPLOYEE ABSENTEE
AND ABSENTEEISM AND COST AND
INCREASES SURVIVORSHIP.
THIS CLIMB PROVES THE QUALITY OF
LIFE FOR CANCER PATIENTS AND
PROVIDES GREATER ACCESS TO LIFE
SAVING TREATMENT. WE MUST
PROTECT THE SAUCER THAT CANCER
PATIENTS DO NOT HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN THE COST OF TREATMENT
AND THEIR QUALITY OF LIFE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THING THIS AMONG SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLUB CLUB IN
THE ROLE.
HOMEOWNERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF THEM.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I FIFTY
KNOWS FOR. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY SIX IS AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE.
HARPER REACHED ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE BY SOME A
MEMBER POTS AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE TERTRE SCHOOLS
ISSUE BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
ONE WOULD ENSURE THAT ALL LOW
INCOME PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOLS
STUDENTS LIKE ALL OTHER LOW
INCOME TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO AT LEAST
ONE FREE OR REDUCED PRICE MEAL.
EACH SCHOOL DAY DESPITE
ATTENDING PUBLIC SCHOOLS MORE
THAN EIGHTY THOUSAND LOW INCOME
STUDENTS ATTEND A CHARTER SCHOOL
WITHOUT ACCESS TO FREE. AND
REDUCED MEALS
RESEARCH AND COMMON SENSE TELL
US THAT CHILDREN MUST BE WELL
NOURISHED IN ORDER TO LEARN GROW
AND ACHIEVE THEIR FULL POTENTIAL.
SCHOOL MEAL SUPPORT THE ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT AND FUNDAMENTAL WELL
BEING OF ALL STUDENTS
PARTICULARLY LOW INCOME STUDENTS
WHO MAY BE ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE
TO THE HARMFUL EFFECTS OF
POVERTY. AND HUNGER CALIFORNIA
SHOULD NOT MAKE HUNGER A SCHOOL
CHOICE ACCESS TO MEALS TO BE
AVAILABLE TO ALL STUDENTS
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THE
ATTENDED TRADITIONAL PUBLIC
SCHOOL. OR A PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOL.
COLLEAGUES THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
AND A BROAD COALITION OF ANTI
HUNGER ORGANIZATIONS PUBLIC
EDUCATION STAKEHOLDERS
CHILDREN'S WELFARE ADVOCATES AND
CHARTER SCHOOL CHAMPIONS ALL
SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THEY RESPONDED SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN. A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE YOUR OWN TIME
ABOUT ICE FORTY THREE NO'S
FOURTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN THIS AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN BY SOME A MEMBER LIMON AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY DIVERGENCES
SERVICES. MISSILE LOAD. THANK
YOU SPEAKER AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN REQUIRES NATURAL DISASTER
RELATED EMERGENCY COMMUNICATIONS
TO INCLUDE CLEAR TRANSLATION FOR
THE MOST COMMONLY SPOKEN
LANGUAGE OTHER THAN ENGLISH WITH
FORTY FOUR PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIANS OVER THE AGE OF
FIVE THE SPEAKING A LANGUAGE
OTHER THAN ENGLISH AT HOME. IT
IS VITALTHAT EMERGENCY
COMMUNICATIONS ARE MADE
AVAILABLE IN LANGUAGES OTHER
THAN ENGLISH.
COMMUNITIES IN THE DISTRICT THAT
I REPRESENT EXPERIENCE FIRSTHAND
THE IMPACT OF EXCLUSIVE
EMERGENCY COMMUNICATION DURING
THE DEVASTATING THOMAS FIRE.
DURING THE INITIAL DAYS OF THE
THOMAS FIRE THERE AND
UNDERSTANDABLY COMMUNICATION
GAPS.
SCHEDULED EMERGENCY UPDATES AND
OTHER LANGUAGE TOOK OVER A WEEK
TO PROVIDE FROM THE DATE THE
FIRE INITIALLY STARTED THIS LEFT
MANY COMMUNITY MEMBERS FEELING
AND SAFE AND UNSURE WHETHER TO
EVACUATE. THE COMMUNICATION
NEEDS OF INDIVIDUALS TO SPEAK A
LANGUAGE OTHER THAN ENGLISH ARE
NOT SUFFICIENTLY BEING
INCORPORATED INTO EMERGENCY
PLANS.
THE OVERSIGHT PLACES A HEALTH
AND SAFETY RISK FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING FIRST
RESPONDERS.
TODAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THEY'VE IS AMONG SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
OR CULTURAL.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE ANTI ABOUT EYES
FIFTY FIVE.
KNOWS THREE. THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEMS ONE SEVENTY.
EIGHT IN ONE SEVENTY NINE PASS
RETAIN WORK FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY.
AB NINETEEN NINETEEN DOCTOR
WOULD.
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN NINETEEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT IN
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO PRICE
GOUGING.
THAT WOULD. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THE NORTH BAY
FIRES LAST YEAR DESTROYED OVER
EIGHT THOUSAND HOMES INCLUDING.
OVER THREE THOUSAND IN MY HOME
CITY OF SANTA ROSA. THOUSANDS OF
MY CONSTITUENTS LOST THEIR HOMES
IN ONE NIGHT.
THIS NIGHTMARE SCENARIO TOOK
WHAT WAS ALREADY A DIFFICULT
HOUSING MARKET AND MADE IT INTO
A CRISIS.
CURRENT LAW PREVENTS THE COST OF
ANY GOOD OR SERVICE INCLUDING
HOUSING FROM BEING RAISED MORE
THAN TEN PERCENT DURING TO
DECLARE DISASTER.
UNFORTUNATELY UNSCRUPULOUS
LANDLORDS AND VACATION RENTAL
HOUSE HAVE MANAGED TO SKIRT
THESE PROTECTIONS ARE NOW TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THOSE WHO LOST
EVERYTHING.
IN LESS THAN A WEEK THE MEDIAN
RENTAL RATE CINEMA COUNTY JUMPED
BY OVER THIRTY FIVE PERCENT AND
THERE WERE DOZENS OF EXAMPLES
OPPOSE BEING OFFER FOR MORE THAN
DOUBLE THE PRE DISASTER PRICE OF
SIMILAR HOMES.
THIS HAPPENED BECAUSE EXISTING
LAW DOES NOT PROVIDE A METHOD
FOR DETERMINING THE BASEMENT OF
A HOME THAT WAS NOT ON THE
RENTAL MARKET PRIOR TO THE
DISASTER.
AS A RESULT HOMEOWNERS WHO HAD A
SECOND HOME IN THE AREA HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO PUT ON THEIR HOME
ON THE MARKET FOR WHATEVER PRICE
THEY DEEM THAT.
AB NINETEEN NINETEEN CLOSES THE
NEW RENTAL LOOPHOLE IN EXISTING
LAW BY DEFINING BASE RENT AS A
HUNDRED SIXTY PERCENT OF THE OF
THE HIDE FAIR MARKET PRICE.
THIS DEFINITION
CLUB RIDES A CLEARLY DEFINED
NUMBER FOR BOTH LANDLORDS AND
TENANTS TO ENSURE EVERYONE IS
PLAYING BY THE RULES AND NOBODY
IS EXPLOITING THESE TERRIBLE
DISASTERS.
AS BILL HAS HAD NO OPPOSITION
ENJOYS PRIVATE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
VIDAK WOULD SAY NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON BONUS OUR VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE YOUR OWN TIME
ABOUT AYE AYES FORTY FIVE. KNOWS
FIVE THAT MEASURE PASSES
MARRIAGE WHEN I GO BACK TO FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTY NINE.
THIS IS AB NINETEEN SIXTEEN.
BY MISTER COOPER.
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN SIXTEEN
BY SOME MEMBER COOPER AND
EXPLAIN THE CIVIL SERVICE.
MISTER COOPER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB NINETEEN SIXTEEN WILL HELP
CLOSE THE GENDER AND ETHNICITY
PAY GAP IN THE REPRESENTATION OF
WOMEN AND MINORITIES IN STATE
CIVIL SERVICE. CLASSIFICATIONS
RACIAL ETHNIC PILLSBURY'S REMAIN
ISSUE AFRICAN AMERICAN HISPANIC
WOMEN EARN JUST SIXTY FOUR AND
FORTY FOUR CENTS RESPECTIVELY
FOR EVERY DOLLAR A WHITE MAN
EARNS DISLEY. AFRICAN AMERICAN
MEN AND SEVEN FIVE PERCENT OF
THE AVERAGE SALARY.
LET MEN. BABIES NINETEEN SIXTEEN
REQUIRE STATE AGENCY DEPARTMENTS
THE PAY DETAILED REPORT ON
GENDER AND ETHNICITY WAGE
DISPARITY AND THE OTHER
REPRESENTATION OF WOMEN AND
MINORITIES.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL REQUIRE
EACH DEPARTMENT REPRESENT.
EXCUSE ME.
EXCUSE ME ANY COMMENTS.
THIS YOUR.
NOT A PLAN FOR EVERY TWO YEARS
TO THE APPROPRIATE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE INCLUDES AN
INFORMATION REGARDING THE
AGENCY'S PROGRESS. FOR RATES
PARITY ANY DETAILED TIME LINE
FOR MEETING THE GOAL OF WEIGHTS
PARITY AND RECRUITING ATTRACTING
AND RETAINING WOMEN AND
MINORITIES.
MEMBERS THIS BILL WILL HOLD A
PUBLIC IT IS THE COUNTABLE ISSUE
THAT WOMEN AND MINORITIES ARE
PAY FAIRLY THERE QUICKLY ALSO
WORKING TOWARDS ADDRESSING AND
REPRESENTATION. OF MINORITIES IN
STATE CIVIL SERVICE PUBLICATIONS
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE.
AMOS GOVERNMENTS MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM I
HAVE A QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR IF
I MAY WITHOUT OBJECTED DO THESE
REQUIREMENTS ALSO APPLY TO THE
STATE LEGISLATURE.
YES CITY THEY DO THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS YES ARE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
WE'LL TAKE THAT AS THE CLOSE.
CLICK LIBERAL.
WE IS OUR VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIED BUT I FIFTY TWO.
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY ONE.
IS AB NINETEEN TWENTY ONE.
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE BY SOME A
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AND OTHERS
NATURALLY AND CAL WORKS MR
MAIENSCHEIN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS CURRENT LAW
PROVIDES TEMPORARY HOUSING
ASSISTANCE TO HOMELESS FAMILIES
RECEIVING AID THROUGH THE COW
WORKS PROGRAM FOR UP TO SIXTEEN
CONSECUTIVE NIGHTS. IN A HOTEL
MOTEL OR COMMERCIAL
ESTABLISHMENT.
BECAUSE THERE HOUSING ASSESSMENT
CAPS AT SIXTEEN CONSECUTIVE DAYS
A BREAK IN ASSISTANCE
INADVERTENTLY PUNISHES FAMILIES.
VACATE THEIR TEMPORARY LODGINGS
FOR JUST ONE DAY AB NINETEEN
TWENTY ONE WILL REMOVE THE
REQUIREMENT FOR THE SIXTEEN DAYS.
BEING CONSECUTIVE AND LET
ELIMINATE THE DISINCENTIVE TO
REFUSE OR INTERRUPT TEMPORARY
HOUSING ASSISTANCE ALLOWING THE
FAMILY TO USE THE VOUCHERS
DURING THEIR ENTIRE PERIOD OF
HOMELESSNESS. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THINGS MAIENSCHEIN SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CLUB THE
ROLE I AM.
SARAH VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
HIGHER TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE HIS AIRBOAT.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
ICE FIFTY NINE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
PASS RETAIN A FILE AND ONE
EIGHTY TWO.
WHAT FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY THREE?
AB NINETEEN THIRTY THREE
CORPORATE.
AT SOME LEVEL NINETEEN THIRTY
THREE BY SOME THE MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AND OTHERS AND THAT
TOO IN THE GREENHOUSE GASES.
WHICH MAIENSCHEIN YOU MAKE AN
OPEN THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS THE CALIFORNIA
GLOBAL WARMING SOLUTIONS ACT OF
TWO THOUSAND SIX REQUIRED THE
STATE AIR RESOURCES BOARD. TO
REDUCE THE STATEWIDE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS LIMIT TO NINETEEN
NINETY LEVELS BY THE YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY AND ENSURE THAT STATEWIDE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
OUR REDUCE TO AT LEAST FORTY
PERCENT BELOW THE NINETEEN
NINETY LEVEL BY TWENTY THIRTY
ALTHOUGH THESE GOALS ARE
ACHIEVABLE UNNECESSARY
CALIFORNIA LACKS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO MEET THIS
DEMAND. AMY NINETEEN THIRTY
THREE WILL HELP ACCOMPLISH HIS
GOALS BY CLARIFYING THAT FUNDING
APPROPRIATED FROM THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO IMPROVE WASTE
DIVERSION AND RECYCLING WILL
INCLUDE FOOD RESCUE WASTE
PREVENTION AND ORGANIC. WASTE
RECYCLING THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST I'VE.
NEIGHBORS MAIENSCHEIN SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLARK LOOKED THE WRONG. I'M.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE RURAL COUNTY
THAT I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS GOING TO MOVE BACK TO
THE PRIOR ITEM. IT'S FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY TWO.
AB NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN TWENTY
SEVEN BY SOME A MEMBER BONTA AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO FIREARMS.
MISTER BONTA THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES WITH
AMENDMENTS MADE IN
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AB
NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO STUDY OPTIONS TO
ALLOW PEOPLE. TO REGISTER
THEMSELVES ON A LIST OR DATABASE
THAT PROHIBIT THE PERSON FROM
BEING ABLE TO PURCHASE A FIREARM
AND REPORT ITS RECOMMENDATIONS
TO THE LEGISLATURE BY TWENTY
TWENTY.
FIREARMS OF THE MOST LETHAL AND
MOST COMMON METHOD OF SUICIDE
MORE PEOPLE WHO DIE BY SUICIDE
USE A FIREARM THAT ALL OTHER
METHODS COMBINED IF THIS
PROPOSAL WILL ULTIMATELY ALLOW
PEOPLE AT RISK. FOR SUICIDE TO
HAVE THE OPTION TO PRESENT
THEMSELVES TO PREVENT THEMSELVES
FROM BUYING A FIREARM DURING A
SUICIDAL CRISIS WITH A BEAT
NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN WE CAN
GIVE INDIVIDUALS AT RISK OF
SUICIDE. THE TOOLS TO BE
PROACTIVE AND SAVE THEIR OWN
LIVES I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THE IMAGE BONTA SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK LIBERAL.
FOR.
SARAH VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE VOTE
ICE FIFTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY FOUR IS AB
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE. CORKERY AT
SOME LEGAL NINETEEN FORTY FIVE
BY SOME A MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
GREENHOUSE GASES. MISTER GARCIA.
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES A.
B. NINETEEN FORTY FIVE IS A BILL
TO REFORM THE APPLICATION
PROCESS FOR THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND. DOES FOR
SPECIFIC THINGS THE FIRST IS
EXPANDING THE LIST OF CO
BENEFITS.
THE A RESOURCE THAT IS BOARD HAS
BEEN DEVELOPING TO ENSURE THAT
ALL THIS CAPTURES ALL OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES.
WE HAVE TO LINE THESE
INVESTMENTS WITH OUR COMMUNITY
AND SAY PRIORITIES. SECOND IS
DIRECTING AIR RESOURCES BOARD TO
WORK WITH AGENCIES TO ENSURE
COMMUNITIES IDENTIFIED FOR
MISSION REDUCTIONS.
THROUGH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AB
SIX OR SEVEN ARE GIVING
PREFERENCE TO RESOURCES.
THE THIRD ARE ALLOWING. THE
BORDER REGIONS TO INCLUDE TAKE
TIME POPULATIONS IN THEIR
APPLICATIONS
IT'S AN AVERAGE OF ALMOST TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE CROSS
THE BORDER TO CALIFORNIA EVERY
DAY.
WHICH HAS HUGE EMISSION IMPACTS
THAT CANNOT BE ADDRESSED IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH.
DHEA MEXICO.
AGENCIES AND FINALLY AIR
RESOURCES BOARD TO START
TRACKING APPLICATIONS RECEIVED
FOR FUNDING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CAN UNDERSTAND WHERE THERE'S
UNMET FUNDING NEEDS
AND BARRIERS TO ACCESSING THE
FUNDING. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISS GARCIA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
COR FLIPPED THE ROLL-ON HOME
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. HIS IRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE TIE ABOUT
ICE FORTY SEVEN KNOWS FIVE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
VIOLATE THEM. ONE EIGHTY FIVE.
IS AB NINETEEN FIFTY ONE.
CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN
FIFTY ONE 9
OTHERS AND APPEALING TO PEOPLE
SUSPENSE.
MISTER O'DONNELL MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB NINETEEN FIFTY
ONE WILL INCREASE THE PATHWAY TO
COLLEGE BY PROVIDING ELEVENTH
GRADE STUDENTS.
FREE ACCESS TO OUR. COLLEGE EXAM.
CURRENTLY STUDENTS IN GRADES
THREE THROUGH EIGHT AND THEN
ELEVENTH ARE REQUIRED TO TAKE
THE SMARTER BALANCED ASSESSMENT
THE S. BACK.
TEST AGAIN THE STATE REQUIRED
TESTS.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO ADMINISTER A
COLLEGE ENTRANCE EXAM.
SUCH AS THE EIGHT SAT OR ACT
INSTEAD OF THE STATE REQUIRED
ASSESSMENT
DURING THAT ELEVENTH GRADE YEAR.
THE ALTERNATIVE ASSESSMENT WILL
BE OFFERED DURING THE SCHOOL DAY
AT NO COST.
STUDENTS.
THE BILL REQUIRES THE ASSESSMENT
TO BE ALIGNED TO THE STATE
STANDARDS MEET FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS AND ENSURE THAT
ACCOMMODATIONS.
ARE PROVIDED.
NEARLY FOUR DISC FORTY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA ARE ALREADY
GIVING THE SAT OR THE ACT DURING
THE SCHOOL DAY.
THIS BILL WILL REDUCE THE AMOUNT
OF TESTING AND GIVE STUDENTS AND
TEACHERS MORE TIME FOR
INSTRUCTION.
ELEVENTH GRADE IS A BUSY YEAR.
STUDENTS ARE NOT ONLY TAKING THE
STATE REQUIRED TESTS BUT ALSO
OFTEN AP TESTS AND IT ALSO
COLLEGE AND HIS COLLEGE ENTRANCE
EXAMS AS WELL.
STUDENTS TAKE THE SAT.
OR THE ACT SERIOUSLY BECAUSE IT
IS MEANING FULL TO THEM MORE
MEANINGFUL QUITE FRANKLY THEN
THE ASPECT HAS.
THE SAT OR ACT WOULD BE MORE
USEFUL TO TEACHERS AS WELL.
THE SMARTER BALANCED ASSESSMENT
IS THAT PASSED.
THE SAT OR ACT IS AN ASSESSMENT
TO HELP STUDENT HELP ADDRESS
GAPS IN STUDENTS AND STUDENT
LEARNING. THE PSA TIKI ANY GIVEN
DURING THE BEGINNING IN THE
ELEVENTH GRADE YEARS AND
TEACHERS CAN MONITOR PROGRESS
OVER THOSE YEARS.
THE SAT AND THE ACT ART
ASSESSMENT.
THE S. BACK AS A TASS
ASSESSMENTS HELP A CLOSED
TREATMENT GAPS.
ARE MERELY A TEST JUST HELPS
IDENTIFY THEM.
THERE'S BEEN A QUESTION ABOUT
ACCOMMODATIONS THERE WILL BE
ACCOMMODATIONS.
WITH THIS TEST JUST AS THERE ARE
TODAY.
FOR THE ASPECT THE
ACCOMMODATIONS WILL BE DIFFERENT
BECAUSE THE ASPECTS GIVEN ON A
COMPUTER THIS IS A DIFFERENT
TYPE OF TEST BUT AGAIN. THERE
WILL BE ACCOMMODATIONS OTHER
STATES SUCH AS CONNECTICUT
DELAWARE AND MICHIGAN HAVE
RECEIVED APPROVAL TO ADMINISTER
THE SAT. AND ACT IN PLACE
ALTHOUGH THE ELEVEN AND PLACE OF
THE STATE EXAM FOR ELEVENTH
GRADE STUDENTS.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT EXPANDING
ACCESS TO COLLEGE.
IT IS ABOUT EQUITY AN
OPPORTUNITY I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
MAKING SURE NOT ALL SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE.
PALMER'S VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT ICE WOULD
YOU NINE KNOW ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY SIX.
A. B. NINETEEN SIXTY ONE.
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY WILL NINETEEN SIXTY ONE
BY SOME THE MEMBER CHOI AND
ACTUALLY INTO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. DOCTOR CHOI.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND THE
MEMBERS.
AB I NINETEEN SIXTY ONE IS A
SIMPLE MEASURE TO INCREASE OUR
FINANCE OUR TRANSPARENCY WHEN
COLLEGE CAMPUSES IN CALIFORNIA.
UNDER. THIS BILL UNIVERSITIES SO
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO A SEPARATE
THE COSTS OF A CAMPUS PROVIDED
TO ME AND PLANS. AND THE HOSTING
PLANS SO ON THEIR CAMPUS
WEBSITES AND THE LITERATURE.
THIS YEAR AT INVESTING OF
CALIFORNIA IRVINE.
THE CURRENT COSTS OF WAR REMAIN
BOARD. IN ON NOW ON CAMPUS
TRIP BROUGH OCCUPANCY ROOM WITH
A MEDIA PLAN POROUS AND YOU AND
THE THIRTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS.
WHILE A LARGE MAJORITY OF THE
SCORES ARE GOING NOT DONE THIS
THE.
.
AS SEPARATE TO COST SO FOR ROOM
AND BOARD OF ON THEIR WEBSITES.
IT IS TAUGHT ESTIMATED THAT
DON'T MEET PLANS SO CAN
SOMETIMES BE UP ASSESS THAT HAS
SO.
HALF OF THE COSTS OF OF THE
PORTER CHARGE
OVER REMAIN BORDEAUX FOR ONE
YEAR.
CALIFORNIA SUPERA SIR AND OF
STUDENTS
DESERVE TO HAVE WELL ALL OF THE
FACTS AVAILABLE TO THEM SO THAT
THEY CAN. MAKE THE MOST OF
FISCALLY SOUND THE DECISION FOR
THE OF FAMILY. AB NINETEEN SIXTY
ONE MAKES THIS A REALITY I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
I GOT A CHOICE SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
OUR CLUB THE ROLL-ON.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON THE RESOURCES
THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARAB THOUGH.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TYPE WHAT
I FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
VIOLATE THEM WHEN EIGHTY EIGHT
IS AB NINETEEN NINETY TWO.
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY WILL NINETEEN NINETY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER KANSEN CHU
AND ACTUALLY AND CAL WORKS.
MISTER CHIU.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
NINETEEN NINETY TWO THIS A BILL.
TO HELP FAMILIES RECEIVING CALL
WORK BENEFITS
TO COMPLY WITH A HUMAN LIVES
ATION REQUIREMENT. CURRENTLY
FAMILY RECEIVE HELP WORK
BENEFITS ARE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
PROOF OF IMMUNIZATIONS FOR
CHILDREN AGE FIVE. AND UNDER
WHICH ALL PROVED THEIR BENEFIT
ARE REDUCED BY HUNDRED THIRTY
DOLLARS FOR MONTHS.
THIS IS A LOT OF MONEY FOR THOSE
FAMILIES.
AND DISPEL INSTEAD OF AND
PENALIZE THOSE FAMILIES A. B..
NINETEEN NINETY TWO WERE HELP
PROVIDE RESOURCES INCLUDING
TRANSPORTATION FOR THOSE
FAMILIES TO OBTAIN THE NECESSARY
OF VACCINATION FOR THEIR
CHILDREN. I URGE FOR EUROPE AYE
VOTE.
FAMOUS SHOES SENIORS I'M SORRY
MISTER LACKEY.
YEAH QUESTIONS IN THE OFFICE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION IS A RELIGIOUS
EXEMPTION AVAILABLE IN THIS
AMENDED BILL.
BUT THIS BILL WOULD COMPLY WITH
THE CURRENT LAW DO WE KNOW WHO
OUR PERSONAL. OF BELIEVE
EXEMPTION.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION I'M
SORRY MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
THANK YOU I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY.
GIVEN THE QUESTION THAT THERE
IS NO RELIGIOUS EXEMPTION.
FOR IMMUNIZATIONS IN THE STATE
ANYMORE THERE'S NO PERSONAL
BELIEF EXEMPTIONS WE CLEAN THAT
UP. I'M I GUESS TWO YEARS AGO
NOW SO THIS BILL WITH THE CLEAN
UP LANGUAGE JUST CONFORMS TO
STATE LAW WHICH MEANS IF THERE
IS A MEDICAL NECESSITY TO NOT BE
IMMUNIZED. THEN THEN THE CHILD
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE BUT OTHERWISE
I'M WE NO LONGER HAVE PERSONAL
BELIEF EXEMPTIONS IN STATE
OPERATING IONISATION SO THAT'S
WHY IT READS THAT WAY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MISTER CHIU YOU MAKE
CLOTHES IF YOU WISH.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHARIA
URGE FOR YA.
LOCAL UP THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
THESE ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLLING TIE OF ICE FORTY
THREE.
KNOWS TEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY NINE IS AB
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT. BY MISTER
RODRIGUEZ.
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT BY SOME
REMEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND ACTUALLY
THE CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES.
IT'S RODRIGUEZ.
SPEAKER MEMBERS
AND TWENTY SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA
SAW OVER TWO THOUSAND OPIATE
OVERDOSE DEATHS AND NEARLY FOUR
THOUSAND EMERGE ROOM VISITS FOR
OPEN ORG OVERDOSES.
AB NINETEEN NINETY IT WILL
REQUIRE EVERY HEALTH CARE
PRACTITIONER AUTHORIZED
PRESCRIBE OPIATES TO ADOPT A SAY
PRESCRIBING POLICY.
THE GOAL OF REDUCING UNNECESSARY
UP YOUR PRESCRIPTIONS.
SAY PRESCRIBING PARTICLES WOULD
NOT APPLY TO PATIENTS WITH
CHRONIC PAIN.
CANCERS SICKLE CELL ANEMIA OR IN
NEED OF HOSPICE PALLIATIVE CARE
OR END OF LIFE CARE.
THIS BILL IS THE RESULT OF
COLLABORATIVE WORK WITH THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY THAT GIVES
PROVIDERS THE FLEXIBILITY CREATE
POLICY THAT WORKS.
FOR WORK FOR THEM WHILE GETTING
STANDARDS TO ACHIEVE AN OVERALL
REDUCTION AND UP YOUR
PRESCRIPTIONS
ARE STRUCK ME OUT FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THINGS RODRIGUEZ SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE BILL.
OUR CLUB RURAL.
MEMBERS VOTE.
ROSARIO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
WORK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR OWN TIED ABOUT I
SIXTY FIVE.
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE NINETY IS AB TWO
THOUSAND FIVE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THOUSAND AND
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO
AND ACTUALLY THE CHILD ABUSE
REPORTING.
MR SANTIAGO.
FIGURES A SPEAKER AB TWO
THOUSAND FIVE WOULD ALLOW LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S ABILITY TO REPORT
CASES OF CHILD ABUSE AND SEVERE
NEGLECTED THE DOJ'S TELL W.
CENTRAL INDEX DATABASE WHILE
MAINTAINING PERSONAL RIGHTS.
TO DO PROCESS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS SANTIAGO SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL THE
ROLE.
I'M FUNDS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR OWN TIME ABOUT I
SIXTY FOUR. NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY ONE IS TWO
THOUSAND SIX
BY DR EGGMAN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THOUSAND AND
SIX BY SOME A MEMBER EGGMAN AND
OTHERS AND I PLAINTIFF HICKEY LA
AIR POLLUTION. DOCTORING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AB TWO ZERO
ZERO SIX WOULD CRITICIZE
STATEWIDE AGRICULTURAL VANPOOL
PROGRAM.
DIVIDE AGRICULTURE WORKERS WITH
A CLEAN AND RELIABLE
TRANSPORTATION TO WORK. A AS A
FIFTH LARGE ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
PART OF OUR LARGE ECONOMY IS
THROUGH OUR AGRICULTURAL.
WORKERS A IT'S ONLY FAIR AND
RIGHT TO GIVE THEM RELIABLE WAYS
TO GET TO WORK AS WELL AS
CUTTING DOWN ON GREENHOUSE GAS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS BIPARTISAN BILL
WITH NO OPPOSITION.
DECORATING AND SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE QUIRK LOCAL
ROLL-ON TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE VOTE
AYE SIXTY THREE NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY TWO.
IS AB TWENTY TWENTY TWO BY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY TWENTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KANSEN CHU
AND ATLANTA PEOPLE HEALTH.
MISTER KEW.
BUT CERTAIN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB TWENTY TWENTY TWO
REQUIRED THERE WILL BE ONE OR
MORE MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
ALL ALL KATE THROUGH TWELVE
CAMPUSES.
AND IT STRUCK ESTABLISH A RATIO
OF ONE MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS HER EVERY SIX
HUNDRED STUDENTS.
SPECIFICALLY THE SPELLBOOK PLAYS
AN ADDITIONAL TWO THOUSAND NEW
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ON
SCHOOL CAMPUSES.
AND WILL DIRECT SCHOOL TO
UTILIZE MEDI CAL REIMBURSEMENT
AND DIRECT FUNDS FROM THE
PROPOSITION SIX
FOR A POUND APPROPRIATION.
MENTAL HEALTH BUT MENTAL
WELLNESS IS DIRECTLY LINKED TO
THE ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT.
GRADUATION RATE BEHAVE VERY WE
HABER AND DO PREVENTION ALL.
ABSENCE.
GOOD SUSPENSION ADDRESS WELL AS
THE OTHERS.
THERE'S SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
AND KEEPING KIDS OUT OF TROUBLE.
EXPERTS HAVE IDENTIFIED SCHOOLS
AT ESTHER BASS PLACE TO PROVIDE
TIMELY AND ACCURATE OF ALL S. IS
TO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
RIGHT NOW OVER SEVENTY PERCENT
HEALTH NEEDS NEVER RECEIVED
TREAT TREATMENT.
AND THIS NUMBER FOR CHILDREN IN
POVERTY AND WAS NOT SPEAKING IT
NINE ENGLISH SPEAKING PREFERENCE
JUST NUMBER JUMPED TO OVER
EIGHTY PERCENT.
INVESTING EARLY IN THE CHURCH
KITS MENTAL WELLNESS
IT'S CRITICAL TO PROVIDING THE
BEST OPPORTUNITY. FOR THEIR
HEALTH AND HER SUCCESS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THEY WISH TO SAY NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
HER CLOAK NARAL.
ZARA VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE TALLY VOTE I SIX FOUR
KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSED.
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEMS ONE
NINETY THREE ONE NINETY FOUR
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
ONE
FIVE.
WHERE FILE ITEM ONE NINETY SIX
AB TWENTY?
THIRTY FOUR BY MISTER KALRA
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THIRTY FOUR
BY SOME REMEMBER KALRA ACCOLADE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
STIR KALRA YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS AN
EFFORT TO BETTER IDENTIFY AND
PREVENT CASES HUMAN TRAFFICKING
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THIRTY FOUR
ACQUIRES MASS TRANSIT ON PLEASE.
TO UNDERGO HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AWARENESS TRAINING BY GENERATE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE REQUIRES
TRAINING GUIDELINES TO DEVELOP
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE A
YEAR PRIOR.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF REPORTED HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CASES IN THE COUNTRY
AND MANY HUMAN TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS ARE HIDDEN IN PLAIN
SIGHT. ALONG OUR STATES
TRANSPORTATION ROUTES.
AB TWENTY THIRTY FOUR QUIPS
THOSE TRANSIT OPERATORS AND
EMPLOYEES ON THE FRONTLINE OF
DEFENSE WITH THE PROPER TRAINING
ON THE SCIENCE HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
BY DOING SO SUSPECTED ACTS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING CAN BE
PROPERLY REPORTED AND IF NEEDED
ACTED UPON BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
PREVENT FURTHER HARM TO THE
VICTIM.
THIS IS BEEN PROVEN TO BE VERY
EFFECTIVE FOR THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY VALLEY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY IN MY DISTRICT ONE IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN. IT
INITIATED ITS OWN HUMAN
TRAFFICKING EMPLOYEE TRAINING
PROGRAM AND WITHIN WEEKS A BUS
OPERATOR ACTION IDENTIFIED A
VICTIM OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
BECAUSE OF THAT TRAINING.
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY NUMBER
OF ANTI HUMAN TRAFFICKING
ORGANIZATIONS PUBLIC IT WAS KALRA SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON.
WHO IS OUR VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE THOUGH?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLLING TIED
ABOUT AYE SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY A FILE ITEM.
ONE NINETY SEVEN.
WE'LL TAKE UP FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY EIGHT. AB TWENTY FORTY
ONE. BY MISS CABALLERO CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FORTY ONE BY SOME REMEMBER
CABALLERO ANOTHER PERSON THAT
RELATE TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
IT'S COMING OUT.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
FORTY ONE WHICH URGES THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA REGENTS
TO REQUIRE THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA INVESTMENTS GROUP.
TO LAUNCH AN EMERGING MANAGERS
PROGRAM AND ADOPT POLICIES THAT
PROMOTE DIVERSE HIRING PRACTICES
INTERNALLY AND AT PARTNER
COMPANIES DIVERSITY IS IMPORTANT
FOR INVESTMENT FINANCIAL
PERFORMANCE AND FOR DIMINISHING
INVESTMENT RISKS.
BECAUSE DIVERSITY DRIVES BETTER
CORPORATE PERFORMANCE.
THIS IS.
YOU SEE INVESTMENT SISTER
ENTITIES WITH DECADES OF
INVESTMENT MANAGEMENT EXPERIENCE
CALPERS AND CAL STICKERS USE
THIS MODEL SUCCESSFULLY EACH HAS
BEEN IN THE VANGUARD FOSTERING.
CORPORATE DIVERSITY FOR FEMALE
AND UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY
BUSINESS FOUNDERS AND SPONSORING
EMERGING EMERGING MANAGER
PROGRAMS MANAGERS WHOSE
PERFORMANCE EXCEEDS THE FUNDS
AVERAGE RETURN. WITH AB TWENTY
FORTY ONE YOU SEE INVESTMENTS
WILL MIMIC THE EMERGING FUND
MANAGER PROGRAMS.
CALPERS IN CASTERS AND REPORT TO
THE LEDGE LEGISLATURE ON THAT
EFFORT CREATING NEW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FEMALE AND
MORE MINORITY INVESTMENT
MANAGERS RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THINK OF IS BECAUSE WE ARE MISS
RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TO THE ESTABLISHED POWER PROUD
CO AUTHOR OF AB TWENTY FORTY ONE
WHICH WILL HELP INCREASE
INTENTIONAL INVESTMENTS.
BY THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
TO PROMOTE DIVERSITY.
OUR STATE IS STRONG BECAUSE OF
IT BECAUSE OF ITS DIVERSITY AND
IS AS A IS OUR UNIVERSITY SYSTEM.
OUR STATE IS STRONG BECAUSE OF
ITS.
BY THE UC INTENTIONALLY VESTING
IN ITS PARTNER FIRMS WHICH HAVE
MANAGEMENT AND PARTNER POSITIONS
AS OUR DIVERSE IS OUR STATE.
THE YOU SEE IN THE STATE AS A
WHOLE BENEFIT IN THE LONG TERM
IT IS FOR THESE REASONS I ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
NAME IS REYES SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
MS COMPANY ARE YOU MAY CLOSE IF
YOU WISH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
KRIKALEV LAUREL.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLAND HOW THE VOTE.
EYES FORTY FIVE NO SEVENTEEN
THAT MEASURE PASSED
.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE TO
FOLLOW ON TWO HUNDRED.
AB TWENTY FIFTY I MISS CABALLERO
CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY FIFTY BY SOME
REMEMBER CABALLERO AN ACCOLADE
TO SMALL SYSTEM WATER
AUTHORITIES IS COMING YEAR YOU
MAY GET OPEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY FIFTY. THE SMALL SYSTEM
WATER AUTHORITY ACTIVE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN.
RECENTLY THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
IDENTIFIED OVER THREE HUNDRED
WATER SYSTEMS THAT CHRONICALLY
SERB CONTAMINATED DRINKING WATER
OR FAILED TO PROVIDE A RELIABLE
WATER SERVICE TO OVER ONE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS. MOSTLY IN
RURAL CALIFORNIA.
IN THE WEALTHIEST STATE. IN THE
WEALTHIEST NATION ON THE PLANET
THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
AB TWENTY FIFTY ADDRESSES THIS
PROBLEM BY GRANTING THE STATE
BOARD THE AUTHORITY TO
CONSOLIDATE THESE FOUGHT FAILING
WATER SYSTEMS.
TRADITIONAL CONSOLIDATIONS RELY
ON A BORDERING LARGER HOST
AGENCY TO ABSORB THE FAILING
SYSTEM.
THIS BILL PROVIDES AN
ALTERNATIVE ALTER ALTERNATE
SOLUTION BY MERGING SMALL NON
COMPLAINT WATER SYSTEMS INTO A
LARGER MOTOR MORE ROBUST PUBLIC
WATER SYSTEM THAT COULD TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF IMPROVED.
ECONOMIES OF SCALE STREAMLINED
MANAGERIAL FUNCTIONS AND ENHANCE
FINANCIAL CAPACITY.
THE MERGE SYSTEMS WILL HAVE WILL
BE FORMED. AS INDEPENDENT
SPECIAL DISTRICTS AND PROVIDED
WITH NEW INTERNAL AND EXTERNAL
FINANCING OPPORTUNITIES AND
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY INCLUDING
AN ELECTED BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
THIS WILL LEAD TO MORE
SUSTAINABLE WATER SYSTEMS WHICH
CAN EFFECTIVELY DELIVER SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
AB TWENTY FIFTY PROVIDES A
VALUABLE TOOL SO WE CAN ENSURE
ALL CALIFORNIANS DRINK. COOK AND
BATHED IN SAFE WATER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS CABALLERO SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK CLUB ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TIED TO THEM ICE FORTY THREE.
KNOWS FOURTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
I WAS WE'RE GOING TO PASS RETAIN%
ON FILE ITEMS TO A ONE.
AND TO GO TO THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM TO A THREE.
AB TWENTY SIXTY ONE.
BY MISTER FRAZIER CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIXTY ONE
BY SOME MEMBER FRAZIER OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE TO VEHICLES.
MISTER FRAZIER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM PROUD
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY SIXTY ONE
THE CLEAN TRUCK DEPLOYMENT ACT
WHICH AIMS TO CREATE A MORE
EQUAL PLAYING FIELD FOR EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES IN. THE TRUCKING
INDUSTRY BY ALLOWING ZERO
MISSION AND NEAR ZERO MISSION
TRUCKS TO HAVE THE SAME CARRYING
CAPACITY IS DIESEL TRUCKS.
THIS BILL SPONSORED BY CAL START
THE NATURAL GAS VEHICLE
COALITION IN THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY DISPOSAL ASSOCIATION.
AND IS SUPPORTED BY COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR AGRICULTURAL
GROUPS AND SEVERAL AIR QUALITY
DISTRICTS
AS BILL HAS A.
RECEIVE NO OPPOSITION AND
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST RIVAL.
THINK WAS FRAZIER SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN ROLL-ON.
DESIRE THOUGH ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE OWN TIED ABOUT I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM TOOL
FOR. AB TWENTY SIXTY FOUR BY
MISTER GLORIA.
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIXTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA AND
OTHERS AND ACCOLADES WATER.
MISTER GLORIA. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB TWENTY SIXTY FOUR
WOULD INSURE INTO INTEGRATED
REGIONAL WATER MANAGEMENT
PROCESS HE'S A WORKABLE FOR
SMALL DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THINGS GLORIA SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
CLICK LIBERAL. ON MEMBERS.
IS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WAS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TIME BUT I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM TO A FIVE IS AB TWENTY
EIGHTY THREE BY MISTER COOLEY.
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHTY
THREE BY SOME MEMBER COOLEY AN
ACCOLADE THE FAUCET YOU. MISTER
COOLEY.
COLLEAGUES AND PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY THREE DO YOU.
SPILL RELATES TO STRENGTHENING
SERVICES TO FOSTER YOUTH WHO
EXPERIENCE.
DRAMATIC CIRCUMSTANCES.
FIRST
FOR A TRUCK FOSTER YOUTH IN THAT
CATEGORY. SERVICES WHICH YOU
NEED ARE MORE VARIED AND THEY
NEED TO BE INTEGRATED
COORDINATED THE BILL STRENGTH
THAT I RICHARD AYE VOTE.
IT WAS COOLEY SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
QUIRK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
USER VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE WAS
THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE RURAL TYPE BUT I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TWO OH SIX IS AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN BY DR
QUIRK.
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN BY SOME REMEMBER
QUIRK ACTUALLY TO LEAD.
DOCTOR QUIRK.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN.
DIRECTS THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCE CONTROL.
TO CONDUCT A LITERATURE REVIEW
ON THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT OF
LEAD FISHING TACKLE.
SEVERAL STATES HAVE BANNED THE
USE OF SMALL LEAD FISHING TACKLE
AFTER STUDIES FOUND CONCLUSIVELY.
THAT THESE PRODUCTS HAD
POPULATION LEVEL HARMON
WATERFALL.
OTHER STUDIES HAVE INDICATED LED.
HAS THAT HUNDREDS OF TONS OF
LEAD MAY BE LOST EACH YEAR AND
TACKLE. SOME OF WHICH MAY
DISSOLVE IN THE WATER WAYS AS IT
IS DEPOSITED.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE THAT DATA FOR
CALIFORNIA WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE EFFECTS WOULD BE.
OUR SAID THIS REPORT RELEASED
UNDER THE.
RELEASED UNDER THIS BILL WILL
SYNTHESIZE
THE BEST SCIENCE AVAILABLE ON
THIS SUBJECT.
AND THE EFFORTS OF OTHER STATES
TO REGULATE THESE PRODUCTS.
ARMS WITH THIS INFORMATION AND
THE BEST SCIENCE AVAILABLE WE
CAN MAKE BETTER DECISIONS ABOUT
WHAT IS RIGHT.
THE CALIFORNIA
I REQUEST YOU ARRIVE VOTE.
THEY DON'T QUIRK.
I SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE QUIRK
LOVELY ROLL-ON
ALL MEMBERS VOTER SARAH VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY
FOUR KNOWS NINE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TWO OR SEVEN IS AB
TWENTY EIGHT OH FIVE AMATEUR
BIGELOW.
CLERK WILL BE.
SO MANY ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT OH FIVE BEISEL BEAVERBROOK
ALONE OTHERS NOT RELATE TO WHILE
PICKS.
SHE BIGELOW.
THANK YOU MEMBERS AND MISTER
SPEAKER.
GOSH.
THE DAY'S GOING BY AND WE'RE ALL
DOING FINE
SO IS TAKE A DEEP BREATH.
I'M HIGH HAS ALLOWED TO RISE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY EIGHT OH FIVE
WHICH UPDATES THE MANAGEMENT OF
WILD PIGS.
I'M NOT GOING TO BORE YOU WITH
THE DETAILS BEFORE YOU.
BUT IT IS A COMPROMISE BETWEEN A
BROAD HEARD.
A STAKEHOLDERS.
I THOUGHT THIS BILL WOULD MOVE
OFF THE FLOOR WHEN PIGS FLY. BUT
EVEN BLIND PIGS FAR A BRIGHT
PINK WILL FIND.
AN ACORN.
I'M COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AS AS MAJOR MOVES.
THROUGH THE PROCESS BUT THIS
ISSUE HAS BEEN HOG WILD FOR
YEARS.
MEMBERS.
WAKE UP AND SMELL THE BACON AND
PLEASE VOTE I I'LL BE HAPPY AS A
PIG IN MUD.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AND THIS IS NOT UP CORPORAL
PROJECT THE CIVIC.
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
QUITE LIBERAL.
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE TO DESIRED OF
THEM.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY ONE.
KNOWS ONE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WORD FILE ITEM NUMBER TO
AWAIT.
AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETEEN.
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
NINETEEN BY SOME REMEMBER HOLDEN
THAT RELATE TO EMPLOYMENT.
MISTER HOLD.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
NINETEEN REQUEST THE UNIVERSE
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY. THE
BUNCH CENTER FOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDIES AT UCLA.
TO CONDUCT A BI ANNUAL STUDY ON
THE DIVERSITY OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS AND EMPLOYEES OF
CALIFORNIA HIGH TECHNOLOGY
COMPANIES.
THE REPORT WILL INCLUDE PROGRAMS
AND BEST PRACTICES THAT SEEK TO
DIVERSIFY THE TECHNOLOGY
WORKFORCE.
AT THE TOP SEVENTY FIVE
COMPANIES IN SILICON VALLEY
VALLEY ONLY THREE PERCENT. OF
EMPLOYEES OR BLACK
ACCORDING TO THE EQUAL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY
COMMISSION.
ANY DISCUSSION ABOUT DIVERSITY
DIVERSE HIRING AND SILICON
VALLEY INEVITABLY COMES BACK AND
BECOMES A DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
PIPELINE.
DESPITE SIXTY FIVE PERCENT
INCREASE AMONG LATINO STUDENTS
AND A FIFTY PERCENT INCREASE
AMONG BLACK STUDENTS FOR STEM
DEGREES.
HOWEVER OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
UNDER UTILIZED AND UNDER
EMPLOYED ACCORDING TO THE TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN NATIONAL
SCIENCE FOUNDATION FINDINGS.
AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETEEN WILL
EXPLORE THE DIVERSITY PROGRAMS
AND HIRING PRACTICES THAT EXIST
THROUGH AN ACADEMIC LENDS TO
CREATE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW TO ADDRESS THE LACK OF
DIVERSITY. AND SILICON VALLEY.
THIS BILL WILL ALSO HELP US
DETERMINE WHAT IS NEEDED TO
INCREASE DIVERSE HIRING IN THE
FASTEST GROWING INDUSTRY. TO
ENSURE ALL COMMUNITIES ARE
CONSIDERED FOR THESE REASONS I
ASK FOR YOUR.
I THINK THIS HOLDEN SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CORP CLUB THE
ROLE.
HIS ARE A VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT ABOUT.
CLERK WELL CLOSER ROLE TALLY
VOTE.
AYE AYES FORTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TWO ONE NINE.
IS AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY BY MR
MCCARTY.
OPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY WISELY MEMBER RICARDIAN
ACCOLADES SCHOOL ACCOUNTABILITY.
THIS MCCARTY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THIS BUILDS UPON OUR
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FOR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IN THE LOCAL CONTROL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLANS AND.
ESSENTIALLY THIS MEASURE
REQUIRES OURS SUPERINTENDENT
PUBLIC CONSTRUCTION TO CONVENE A
TECHNICAL DESIGN GROUP. AT TO
DEVELOP CRITERIA FOR AN
IMPROVING OUR SCHOOL CLIMATE
SURVEYS AS WELL AS IMPROVING.
COMMUNING GAZE MET IN THE AL
CAPP PROCESS
THANK YOU.
CONGRESS REGARDING SEEING THEIR
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CARP LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IS THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIME
ABOUT I SIXTY FIVE. NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TO.
MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
PROGRESS UPDATE.
IT'S NOW FIVE O'CLOCK.
WE'VE DONE A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
BILLS.
HOPEFULLY ANOTHER SEVENTY TO GO
BEFORE WE LEAVE YOU TONIGHT.%
WE CAN DO IT.
SKIP DO IT.
THAT WAS A MIXED RESPONSE MISTER
CALDERON.
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM TO TEN
AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY.
CLERK WILL.
COOPERATE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT THIRTY BY SIMPLY MARIA'S
AN ACCOLADE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES.
THIS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY
WOULD REQUIRE COUNTIES.
TO DEVELOP A HIRING PREFERENCE
PROGRAM.
FOR DISADVANTAGED GROUPS WHEN
HIRING FOR INTERNSHIPS.
STUDENT ASSISTANT POSITIONS.
FOR THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL
DISADVANTAGED GROUPS WILL
INCLUDE BUT NOT BE LIMITED TO
HOMELESS YOUTH FORMERLY
INCARCERATED YOUTH AND FOSTER
YOUTH.
OLDER AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
ARE LESS LIKELY TO BE EMPLOYED
THAN THEIR PEERS IN THE GENERAL
POPULATION.
NATIONAL LEAGUE CLOSE TO THIRTY
THOUSAND FOSTER YOUTH WILL AGE
OUT OF CARE EVERY YEAR WILL HAVE
TO BE SELF SUFFICIENT.
PROVIDING INTERNSHIPS AND
STUDENT ASSISTANT POSITIONS PAR
MOST AT RISK YOUTH. CAN HELP
THEM TRANSITION TO MEANINGFUL
EMPLOYMENT AND CAN ALSO HELP
THEM DEVELOPMENT DEVELOP.
SKILLS NECESSARY TO SUCCEED IN
THE WORKPLACE AND ENSURE LASTING
ECONOMIC SELF SUFFICIENCY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THINGS RACINO DISCUSSION BAKER
BLOOM THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
SARAH TO VOTE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE RURAL TIED TO VOTE. I
FORTY FOUR NOTES TWENTY.
THAT MEASURE PASSES WORD FILE
ITEM TO ELEVEN AB TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY TWO BY MISTER DALLI
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ITALIAN OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO
RECYCLING.
SHELLY.
THE MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY
IMPRISONING AB TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY TWO REALLY TO ELECTRIC
VEHICLE LITHIUM ION BATTERY THE
RECYCLING AND REUSE.
THEIR APPROXIMATE FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND THAT TRICK
VEHICLES ON CALIFORNIA ROADS
CURRENTLY AND THAT NUMBER IS
EXPECTED.
TO CLIMB TO WELL OVER FOUR
MILLION BY TWENTY THIRTY UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S NEW PLAN. MEMBERS
THAT'S A LOT OF BATTERIES.
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THE END OF
LIFE ISSUES BEFORE WE HAVE
ANOTHER EXCITE. A SITUATION ON
OUR HANDS.
I'M SIMPLY ASKING FOR A PLAN AB
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY TWO WILL
TELL US THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCE CONTROL CAL RECYCLE.
THEIR RESOURCES BOARD AND OTHERS
TO IDENTIFY APPROACHES FOR THE
RE USE AND RECYCLING OF ELECTRIC
LITHIUM ION BATTERIES AND REPORT
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE. BY
TWENTY TWENTY THIS IS A COMMON
SENSE APPROACH.
YOU PROBABLY PLANNED FOR THE END
OF LIFE PROCESS FOR THESE
ELECTRICAL.
VEHICLE BATTERIES
AND WITH ANY LUCK WILL PREVENT
ANOTHER HAZARDOUS WASTE DISASTER
IN CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS TELLING.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
LOGAN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
SORRY TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE A ROLL TIDE BUT
I SIXTY FIVE. NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WERE
GOING TO MOVE BACK IN THE FILE
TO FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY NINE
THAT'S A. B..
TWENTY NINE SIXTY THREE BY
MISTER KALRA.
THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY NINE SIXTY THREE BY SOME
REMEMBER KALRA OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE TO EMPLOYMENT.
MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS FOR
THE OPTION TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
NINE SIXTY THREE TODAY AB TWENTY
NINE SIXTY THREE. REQUIRE THE
CALVARY DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH REPORT TO CAL OSHA
INSTANCES OF ELEVATED LEVELS OF
LEAD IN WORKERS BUT.
THIS BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE ANY
PINE CITATIONS FROM INSPECTIONS
BY CAL OSHA TO BE PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE ON AN ANNUAL BASIS.
DID ARRIVE THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT HAS REAL THAT EVERY
YEAR IN CALIFORNIA THERE
HUNDREDS PERHAPS EVEN THOUSANDS
OF WORKERS WERE KNOWN TO HAVE
SERIOUS LEVELS OF LEAD IN THEIR
BLOOD.
ONCE NOTIFIED THE PROBLEM I SEE
THE P. H. CAL OSHA IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR FOLLOWING UP OF
THESE CASES HOWEVER THERE'S
OFTEN A DISCONNECT ABOUT WARNING
THE AFFECTED WORKERS OR
ADDRESSING THE EXPOSURE.
EXPOSURE PROBLEM THE WORK SITE
EVEN ONE EMPLOYERS SUPPORT HIGH
LEAD LEVELS. BLOOD LEVELS A CDP
AGE.
AS WE ALL KNOW THAT. CAN HAPPEN
ALL FOUND IN PERMANENT ADVERSE
HEALTH EFFECTS IN BOTH CHILDREN
AND ADULTS AT VERY HIGH LEVELS
LEAD POISONING CAN BE FATAL.
THE CDC STATES THAT NO SAFE
BLOOD LEVEL. OF BLOOD LEAD LEVEL
EXISTS.
THE LEAD INSPECTION BACKSIDE
PLANT WAS CONDUCTED TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT WHILE CPT CP DID WAS AWARE
OF NUMEROUS LEAD POISON WORKERS.
IT WAS UNTIL TWENTY FIFTEEN THE
PLANT WAS PERMANENTLY CLOSE WITH
ORDER THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
UNFORTUNATELY A PLATE APPEARS
THAT MORE AGGRESSIVE STATE
ACTION BY STATE AGENCIES COULD
HAVE RESOLVED THE ISSUE MORE
RAPIDLY. THEREBY SAVING HUNDREDS
OF WORKERS FROM EXPOSURE TO THIS
TOXIC METAL. A BETWEEN AYE SIXTY
THREE WOULD IMPROVE HOW PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS ARE MADE AWARE
OF AND HANDLE CASES A LEAD
POISONING AMONG WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT WOULD PREVENT
REPEATED INCIDENTS OF LEAD
POISONING WORKPLACES
UP WITH THAT IR ARREST WITH
RESPECT WE ASK FOR MY BOOK.
THERE WAS KALRA SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
I'M CLOSER TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE
MISTER KALRA.
MOVES TO CALL.
MEMBERS BACK AND FILE ORDER.
FILE ITEM TO TWELVE.
IS AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY SIX BY
MR GLORIA CLERK WILL READ.
SO MEMBER ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT THIRTY SIX VICE WILL BE
ROBERT LOWER ANOTHER SATELLITE
TRIBAL AFFAIRS.
MISTER GLORIA.
THEY CAN MISTER SPEAKER I BRING
BEFORE YOU A BILL THIS AFTERNOON
THAT IS NEAR AND DEAR TO MY
HEART AS AN ROLL TRIBAL MEMBER.
AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY SIX SEEKS
TO FINALLY PUT AN END TO A
DECADES LONG CONVERSATION THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN HAVING
WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. ABOUT NATIVE
AMERICAN ARTIFACTS AND HUMAN
REMAINS.
THAT.
I WILL IN CAPS LEE THE DECADES
LONG CONVERSATION TODAY FOR THE
SAKE OF TIME BUT I WOULD SAY
THAT A BEAT THE TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY SIX HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I'M PROUD TO
SAY THAT THE ENTIRE MEMBERSHIP
IN THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER AD AND
ARTS COMMITTEES HAVE JOINED ME
AS CO AUTHORS. LET'S PASS THIS
BILL AND ONCE AND FOR ALL
CONCLUDE THIS CONVERSATION ABOUT
THE PROPER DISPOSITION OF
RELATIVES OF SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
NAY WAS GLORIA SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. UPS ARE.
SORRY MISS WALDRON MISTER
MICROPHONE MISS WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER.
REALLY BRIEFLY.
.
THIS BILL DOES RIGHT OR WRONG
THAT'S BEEN ONGOING FOR A LONG
TIME AS A MATTER OF FACT.
.
A NUMBER OF THE REMAINS OF OUR
NATIVE AMERICAN.
FAMILY MEMBERS HAVE BEEN IN
BOXES WITH DUST ON THEM AND
THAT'S NOT A VERY.
RESPECTFUL WAY. TO.
.
TREAT OUR NATIVE AMERICAN SAWYER
URGENT IVEL.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE?
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL CLOSE WRONG TIME
ABOUT AYE SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WANT TO MOVE BACK IN THE
FILE TO FILE ITEM.
FORTY FOUR. BY MISTER MURATSUCHI.
THIS IS AB SEVENTEEN.
SEVENTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE BY SOME MEMBER MURATSUCHI
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE THE STATE
LANDS.
MISTER MURATSUCHI THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MEMBERS.
THIS BILL FIX TO PROTECT ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST PRECIOUS
RESOURCES.
OUR BEAUTIFUL COASTLINE.
FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS
CALIFORNIANS HAD A BIPARTISAN.
COMMITMENT TO PROTECT OUR COAST
FROM OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING.
SIXTY NINE PERCENT.
ACCORDING THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE SIXTY NINE PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIA VOTERS.
OPPOSE OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING.
BUT THAT LONG SANDY BIPARTISAN
COMMITMENT IS BEING THREATENED.
BY PRESIDENT TRUMP WHEN YOU
ANNOUNCE IN JANUARY OF THIS YEAR
THAT HE WANTS TO REOPEN.
NEW OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING LEASES
UP THE COAST TO CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING SIX.
NEW LEASES UP THE COAST TO
CALIFORNIA.
THIS NOT ONLY THREATENS
OUR BEAUTIFUL COASTLINE.
BUT ALSO OUR MULTI TRILLION
DOLLAR.
COASTAL ECONOMY MULTI DOLLAR
BECAUSE ECONOMY.
FORTY FOUR POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN GDP EACH YEAR.
WHICH ALSO EMPLOYS ALMOST HALF A
MILLION PEOPLE.
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED.
NOT ONLY A TOP PRIORITY BILL.
FOR THE ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY.
BUT IT'S ALSO SUPPORTED BY LABOR
SEIU CALIFORNIA LEGAL CALIFORNIA
CITIES.
SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN AND
MANY MANY OTHERS.
I ASK FOR A AYE VOTE.
THEY WITH MURATSUCHI MS THEM ON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
PROUD TO STAND.
WE SET OF THE CHAIR OF ASSEMBLY.
NATURAL RESOURCES AS A JOINT
AUTHOR OF ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE.
THE LEGISLATURE RECENTLY PASSED
A BIPARTISAN ASSEMBLY JOINT
RESOLUTION EXPRESSING OUR STRONG
AN UNEQUIVOCAL OPPOSITION TO THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION STRAPLINE
TO OPEN UP. ALL THREE REGIONS OF
THE CALIFORNIA'S COAST TO
OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS LEASING.
TO DATE WE TAKEN IMPORTANT STEPS
TO PUT THAT RESOLUTION INTO
ACTION.
FOR NEARLY THREE DECADES WE HAVE
HAD A BIPARTISAN AGREEMENT THAT
WE WOULD NOT EXPAND OIL DRILLING
OFF THE CAP OFF CALIFORNIA'S
COAST.
I URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT
AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE AND
STAND STRONG AGAINST THE IDEA.
OF EXPANDING OFFSHORE OIL.
THE AIM IS AMONG MISTER OUR.
THIS IS.
YET ANOTHER FRONT EVERY SINGLE
CALIFORNIA'S CITIZEN THIS IS YET
ANOTHER ACTION. BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE TO
TAKE AWAY YOUR ABILITY TO USE
YOUR OWN NATURAL RESOURCES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE OIL
AND GAS IN CALIFORNIA BELONGS TO
EVERY SINGLE CALIFORNIA'S
CITIZEN EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THE
THIRTY NINE MILLION PEOPLE IN
THIS STATE. ALL IN THIS STATE
THIS IS OUR LAND WE ARE THE
CITIZENS OF THIS STATE.
THIS IS OUR OIL AND GAS
TODAY CALIFORNIA IMPORTS OVER
SEVENTY PERCENT OF OUR ENERGY
NEEDS EVERY SINGLE YEAR. THINK
ABOUT THE SEVENTY PERCENT OF OUR
DOLLARS GOES TO OTHER STATES AND
OTHER COUNTRIES WHEN WE COULD
NOT ONLY BE ENERGY SELF
SUFFICIENT WE COULD BEAT NET
ENERGY EXPORTERS. THIS WOULD
LOWER EVERY SINGLE CALIFORNIANS
GASOLINE BILLS IT WOULD LOWER
THEIR ELECTRICITY BILLS LOWER
THEIR UTILITY BILLS AND YES IT
WOULD BRING MANUFACTURING JOBS
BACK TO CALIFORNIA. BY LOWERING
THE MOST BASIC COST OUR ENERGY
COSTS IN CALIFORNIA THIS BILL.
TRIES TO TAKE YET ANOTHER PIECE
OF CALIFORNIA AWAY FROM
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS I URGE A NO
VOTE I URGE EVERY CALIFORNIA
CITIZEN TO ADVOCATE FOR THEIR
FULL USE OF ALL OF OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES. THINK ABOUT IT LAYS
THE GENTLEMAN THIS IS OUR STATE
THIS IS OUR LAND.
IT BELONGS TO US VOTE NOW.
SURE HARPER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I THINK THE DISCUSSION ON THIS
ISSUE HAS BEEN MISLEADING
BECAUSE THE ISSUES THAT WE HAVE
REGARDING OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING.
ARE TO PARK.
STATE JURISDICTION IS WITHIN
THREE MILES OF THE COAST LINE
AND NOBODY'S DEBATING HERE
WHETHER OR NOT TO HAVE ANY
EXPANDED OIL PRODUCTION OR ANY
NEW PLATFORMS WITHIN THAT AREA.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I AM
VERY PERFECTLY CLEAR I'M IN
OPPOSITION TO ANY NEW PLATFORMS.
WITHIN OUR STATE WATERS
I'M ALSO VERY AWARE THAT THERE'S
NOT INTEREST I ESPECIALLY IN
ORANGE COUNTY AREA AYE IN HAVING
NEW NEW NEW PLATFORMS IT'S JUST
NOT THERE BECAUSE THE OIL. FIELD
IN THE AREA HAS BEEN PUMP FOR
ABOUT ONE HUNDRED YEARS AND IT
ALREADY HAS THE A BILL BUT.
FOLKS WHO ARE OR PRODUCING WELL
ALREADY HAVE THE ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO GET TO THE OIL AYE THAT
IS WITHIN THE AREA.
WHAT'S IT
QUESTION HERE IS NOT THE STATE
WATERS
IT'S ABOUT THE FEDERAL WATERS
AND WHETHER THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO TRY TO
BLOCK.
TRANSPORTATION OF ANY NEW
PRODUCTION FROM FEDERAL WATERS
WHICH I WOULD ARGUE ISA
VIOLATION OF INTERSTATE COMMERCE
WITHIN OUR COUNTRY.
WE'RE NOT HERE TO JUST SIMPLY
BLOCKED THIS IS LIKE SAYING THAT
YOU CAN HAVE.
ANY OIL LOW ON OIL CARS ON A
RAILROAD COMING THROUGH A
CERTAIN PART OF CALIFORNIA. I
THIS IS JUST SIMPLY BLOCKING
COMMERCE THROUGH THE STATE
WATERS.
FEDERAL WATERS ARE A QUESTION
FOR CONGRESS.
AND THAT'S JUST SIMPLY WORD IS
YOU WANT TO RUN FOR CONGRESS IN
DETERMINE WHAT'SIN THE WHAT'S A
DRILLED IN THE FEDERAL RODDERS
THAT IS YOUR CHOICE TO BE ABLE
TO DO SO IN ANY PARTICULAR
ELECTION YEAR. BUT IN TERMS OF
STATE WATERS THAT'S NOT WHAT
THIS AFFECTS
I URGE A NO VOTE BECAUSE. I
THINK THAT WE SHOULD NOT BE
VIOLATING THAT INTERSTATE
COMMERCE THEY SHOULD BE ALLOWED
TO BE ABLE TO FLOW. FROM THE
FEDERAL WATERS ON TO THE
MAINLAND THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
I URGE A NO VOTE.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MISTER MERCY SHE MAY.
CLOSE IF YOU WISH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN.
ASKED TO.
THE COMMENTS RAISED BY MY TO.
COLLEAGUES FROM ORANGE COUNTY.
SIXTY NINE PERCENT.
IT'S A LOT OF CALIFORNIA VOTERS.
AS TO THE.
CALIFORNIA'S RIGHT TO PROTECT
OUR OWN COASTLINE.
I AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM.
HUNTINGTON BEACH.
THAT THE.
THE TRUMP PROPOSAL IS TALKING
ABOUT WHETHER TO ALLOW ANY NEW.
OFFSHORE DRILLING IN FEDERAL
WATERS THE CALIFORNIA HAS A
RIGHT TO PROTECT OUR COASTLINE
IN CALIFORNIA HAS THE RIGHT. IN
FACT THE DUTY AND THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO.
CONTROL WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
STATE WATERS SO THIS BILL. IS
DESIGNED TO.
PROHIBIT ANY NEW OIL RIGS OR ANY
NEW INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT WOULD SUPPORT ANY NEW
OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING.
THE.
BUILDING TRADES ARE NEUTRAL ON
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT IS NOT.
GOING TO AFFECT ANY EXISTING.
OFFSHORE OIL DEVELOPMENT.
AND WITH THAT CLARIFICATION ASK
FOR AYE VOTE.
THING IS MURATSUCHI WITH THAT
CORPS CORPORAL.
ON THIS VOTE.
ZARA VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
MR MURATSUCHI.
BUT THE CALL MISTER MURATSUCHI
MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS I GOTTA MOVE BRIEFLY TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
MISTER COOPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR A POINT OF CLARIFICATION.
BUT MISTER SPEAKER EARLIER MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LAKE ELSINORE ASK
ME A QUESTION ON AB NINETEEN
SIXTEEN. INVOLVING PAY EQUITY
FOR STATE CIVIL SERVICE
EMPLOYEES I MISSPOKE I WAS WRONG
THE LEGISLATURE IS NOT INCLUDED.
SO FOR THAT CLARIFIES IT THANK
YOU.
HARPER NO.
MEMBERS BACK ON THE FILE.
IN FOLLOWER MEMBERS WE ARE AT
FILE ITEM TO THIRTEEN.
THAT IS AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
ONE BY MISTER GRAYSON HARPER
RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
ONE BY SIMPLY BUT GRAYSON
ACCOLADE OF TRANSPORTATION.
GRAYSON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT FIFTY ONE AUTHORIZES
CITIES WITHIN THE BAY AREA'S
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT TRAFFIC SIGNAL
OPTIMIZATION PLANS. TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GASES SHORTEN TRAVEL
TIMES AND CONSERVE FUEL USE FOR
AUTOMOBILES.
SEVERAL RECENT STUDIES BY
CALTRANS UC DAVIS AND THE
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE HAVE CONCLUDED THAT
TRAFFIC SIGNAL OPTIMIZATION
TECHNOLOGY HAS BEEN PROVEN TO
REDUCE TRAFFIC CONGESTION AND
VEHICLE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
FOR THE MORE. THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
IMPLEMENTED A VERY SUCCESSFUL
TRAFFIC LIGHT SYNCHRONIZATION
EFFORT BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT THAT WAS FUNDED BY PROP
ONE BE FUNDS. AB TWENTY EIGHT
FIFTY ONE HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES AND IS
ALSO SUPPORTED BY TRIPOLI
AUTOMOBILE CLUBS IN NORTHERN AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR THESE
REASONS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
MISS WALDRON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER OF I
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND THE COUPLE
YEARS AGO I HAD A BE FOURTEEN
FORTY SEVEN. WHICH ACTUALLY
ALLOWS A.
A GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION FUND
TO PAY FOR SUCH PROJECTS SO
HIGHER TONIGHT.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON.
MISTER FRAZIER MISTER SPEAKER IS
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE THROUGH
OUR WORK WITH SP ONE LAST YEAR
WE. OF APPROPRIATED MONEY TO THE
UC SYSTEMS WHICH WE'VE ASKED
THEM TO START THIS PROCESS
PROCESS ALSO FIRST MARKS
LEGALIZATION THIS IS JUST
ANOTHER GREAT STEP OF GETTING
THE BALL ROLLING AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S EFFORTS.
NAMES FRAZIER WITHOUT.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
THOSE ARE LITTLE MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL.
CLOSE AROUND HIGH VOTE I SEVENTY
NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO LIFT THE CALL ON
MISTER GIBSON'S ITEM THIS WAS
FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY EIGHT. A. B. THIRTY
ONE FIFTEEN.
MCCORKLE POSTS. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER WISH TO VOTE ON
VOTE WHO WISH TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROWLAND HIGH ABOUT EYES
FORTY TWO KNOWS TWENTY SIX.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS BACK IN FILE ORDER
.
MEMBERS I PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL.
ON FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY SIX AB
TWENTY NINE THIRTY FOUR BY
MISTER STONE THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WISH TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTER WHICH TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE WRONG TIED ABOUT AYE AYES
FORTY SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
AND WE WILL ALSO LIVE THE CALL
ON FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY.
AB TWENTY NINE TEN BY DOCTOR
WOULD THE CLERK
POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO WISH TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLLING TIED ABOUT ICE
FORTY FOUR KNOWS TWENTY TWO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
KIM MEMBERS WE ARE. BACK ON THE
FILE.
MR SALAS WILL BE TAKING UP FILE
ITEM TO FOURTEEN AB TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTY ONE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
ONE BY SOME WOMEN WERE SALAS AN
ACCOLADE TO MEDI CAL. MISTER
SALAS.
THANK YOU IS SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY ONE WOULD
ALLOW THE USE OF TELEHEALTH
SERVICES FOR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS.
PROVIDED BY A LICENSED
PRACTITIONER TO BE REIMBURSED
FOR COVERED SERVICES THROUGH
MEDICARE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR DIAMOND.
THEY WISH A SALAS SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK LIBERAL. MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER THE SIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WELL.
CLOSER ROLL INTO ABOUT AYE SIXTY
ONE KNOWS.
ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WHERE FILE ITEM TO
FIFTEEN.
AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY FOUR BY MS
LIMON.
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY FOUR BY SO
MEMORABLY MOMENT ACCOLADE ACOSTA
RESOURCES.
MISLIM ON.
THANK YOU AND MISTER SPEAKER
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
FOUR REQUIRES THE LEAD GROUP
BELIEVE NATURAL RESOURCES FOR
STEVE TO INVITE THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION OR SAN
FRANCISCO BAY CONCERT
CONSERVATION AND DEVELOPMENT
COMMISSION.
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE NATURAL
RESOURCE DAMAGE ASSESSMENT
PROCESS AFTER AN OIL SPILL THE
IMPACTS ARE COAST.
OIL SPILLS ALONG OUR COAST ARE
STILL HAPPENING AND THE RECENTLY
PROPOSED FEDERAL PLAN.
TO EXPAND STRENGTH STRENGTHENS
THE CASE FOR TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
FOUR WE MUST ENSURE THAT DAMAGES
CAUSED BY OIL SPILLS ARE
EVALUATED RECOVERED AND RESTORED.
TO THEIR FULLEST POTENTIAL I
HAVE WORKED WITH THE OPPOSITION
AND IMPACTED AGENCIES AND HAVE
REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION FOR THE
BILL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS THE MOST.
PRESSURE DEBATE.
COUPLE OF THE ROLE I AM.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ON TYPE OF IT EYES FIFTY
EIGHT KNOWS ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM TO
SIXTEEN AB TWENTY EIGHT.
SEVENTY TWO BY MISS CARILLO.
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO ACCOLADE
TO IN HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES.
THIS CARILLO.
YOU THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO A BILL THAT WOULD
ALLOW THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
TO PROVIDE JUSTLY DESERVE
COMPENSATION FOR PROVIDERS OF IN
HOME SUPPORT SERVICES OR AYE H.
ASSESS.
WHO ALSO TRAIN THEIR PEERS
CURRENTLY THE CALIFORNIA I JUST
THAT'S PROGRAM SERVES OVER FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
RECIPIENTS WITH THE HELP OF OVER
FOUR HUNDRED AND SIX?
THOUSAND PROVIDERS
CALIFORNIA CAN EXPECT AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
PROVIDERS TO BE ENROLLED IN THE
PROGRAM BY THE END OF THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
FISCAL YEAR WHICH MEANS
PROVIDERS WILL NEED TO BE WELL
TRAINED IN ORDER TO ASSIST THOSE
THEY CARE FOR AND PRESERVE THEIR
DIGNITY. PROVIDERS TEND TO OUR
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS IN
THEIR HOMES AND HAVE LITTLE TO
NO WAY TO LEARN OR OBTAIN. ONE
ON ONE GUIDANCE THAT WOULD HELP
THEM KEEP UP WITH THE TRAINING
STANDARDS.
THIS BILL WOULD ENSURE THAT I
JUST HAS WORKERS WHO TAKE TIME
TO TRAIN EXPAND AND ENHANCE THIS
WORKFORCE WILL BE JUSTLY
COMPENSATED FOR THEIR TIME AND
FOR THEIR EFFORTS. AB TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY TWO WILL PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED ASSISTANCE IN
ADDRESSING THE CARE CRISIS IN
OUR STATE ESPECIALLY IN THE
LIGHT OF OUR AGING POPULATION.
AS WELL AS THE OVERALL RETENTION
CHALLENGES EXPERIENCE BY THIS
VITAL WORK FORCE THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY AYE JUSTICE WORKERS
WHO DO THE JOB. ON A DAY TO DAY
BASIS AND HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN.
SUPPORT AND ZERO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THINKING IS CREEL SAY NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CORPORAL OF THE ROLE. I'M.
WHO OUR OF VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF
THIS OUT OF VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ROLLING TIME
ABOUT AYE AYES FORTY FIVE. KNOWS
TWELVE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE ITEM TO
EIGHTEEN.
THAT'S AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY
TWO BY DOCTOR QUIRK.
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AN ACCOLADE
THE PAST CONTROL.
DOCTOR PARK.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY TWO
ESTABLISHES IN STATURE.
THE CALIFORNIA MOSQUITO
SURVEILLANCE RESEARCH PROGRAM TO
WOULD BE ADMINISTERED. BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH.
SKEETER SURVEILLANCE IS CRUCIAL
FOR TRACKING ELIMINATING AND
PREVENTING.
SPREAD OF MOSQUITOES IN THE
DISEASE THEY CARRY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE ARRIVAL OF.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLERK CORPORAL. MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO GO.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE VOTE AYE
SIXTY TWO. NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TO NINETEEN IS AB
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY THREE BY
MISS WALDRON CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY A NINETY
THREE BY SO MEMBER WALDRON
AYKROYD HEALTHCARE COVERAGE.
MISS WALDRON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY THREE.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE.
THAT'S A BURP ALSO KNOWN AS THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFITS
REVIEW PROGRAM TO CONSIDER A
LONGER OUTLOOK EVALUATION.
FOR A PERIOD OF UP TO TO FISCAL
YEARS OF.
HEALTH OUTCOMES.
LIMITING SAVINGS AND COST
ESTIMATES TO A TWELVE MONTH
PERIOD DOES NOT ACCURATELY
REFLECT
THE BENEFITS.
OR IMPACTS OF THE COVER THERAPY
FOR EXAMPLE INITIAL COSTS OF
HIGHER TIER DRUGS OR THERAPIES
MAYES SHOW SUBSTANTIAL SAVINGS
MANIFESTED. AFTER A TWELVE MONTH
ESTIMATE.
YEAH INCLUDING LOWER
HOSPITALIZATION RATES PREVENTION
OF ALL ORGAN TRANSPLANTS AND MAY
RESULT IN BETTER QUALITY OF LIFE
AND HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR THE
PATIENT UP LOWER COSTS IN THE
LONG RUN.
LEVELING THE PLAYING FAILED
FIELD FOR A LOW INCOME PATIENTS
IN MEDICO.
AFFORDING THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ACCESS LIFESAVING THERAPIES
SOONER IS A GOAL OF MAYBE TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY THREE. PRIOR TO
ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON SENA
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION ON
THE ITEM
CLERK WILL. OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
IS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSER ROLE ENTIRE
VOTE I SEE
STEVE NINE. KNOWS ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSESFILE ITEM TO
TWENTY IS AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY
BY MR FUHRMAN CORPORATE RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE SIXTY
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER AFFIRMATIVE
ACCOLADES CHILDCARE DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES.
MR THURMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES ARE RICE PRESENT AB
TWENTY NINE SIXTY THIS IS A BILL
THAT SEEKS TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
CALIFORNIANS ACCESS CHILD CARE.
IT RECOGNIZES THAT CHILD CARE
SERVICES ARE OFTEN SPREAD OUT
AND DIFFICULT TO FIND IN THERE
IN DIFFERENT LOCATIONS SO THE
BILL PROPOSES TO CREATE AN
ONLINE PORTAL. THAT WILL BECOME
THE ONE STOP SHOPPING A RESOURCE
FOR FINDING INFORMATION FOR
FAMILY SEEKING CHILDCARE
RESOURCES THE BILL HAS FEDERAL
FUNDING ALREADY ACQUIRED THAT TO
COVER THE COSTS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE FOR AB TWENTY
NINE SIX.
DAVIS THURMOND SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE QUIRK LOCAL ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
MISSOURI TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR OWN TIED ABOUT I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM TO TWENTY ONE
IS AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY ONE BY
MISTER O'DONNELL.
CARPOOL READ. SOME PEOPLE TWENTY
NINE SIXTY ONEBY SOME LIBERAL
DONALD OTHERS AN ACCOLADE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. MISTER O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
PLEASED TO RESENT AB TWENTY NINE
SIXTY ONE.
WHICH REQUIRES LOCAL EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AGENCIES TO
REPORT AMBULANCE PATIENT OFF
LOAD TIME. DATA TO THE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS AN
ISSUE OFTEN REFERRED TO AS WALL
TIME.
OR THE TIME IT TAKES AMBULANCES
PARAMEDICS TO OFFLOAD ENTRANCE
FOR PATIENTS TO LOCAL EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS.
DELAYS IN THE OFFLOAD PROCESS
NOT ONLY JEOPARDIZE THE PATIENT
UNDER DIRECT CARE COULD PREVENT
CRITICAL EMERGENCY RESPONSE
PROFESSIONALS FROM RE ENTERING
THE FIELD. AND HELPING OTHERS IN
NEED.
COLLECTING STANDARDIZE STATEWIDE
DATA WILL GIVE US THE
INFORMATION NEEDED TO REDUCE OR
EVEN ELIMINATE.
OFFLOAD DELAY AYE ASPIRIN AYE
VOTE.
THEY WHICH HAVE DONALD SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OF A MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YES ARISES
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY
ONE I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FROM LONG BEACH FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD. IT IS A HUGE ISSUE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS. PUBLIC SAFETY
ESPECIALLY FOR FIRST RESPONDERS
IS IMPACTED WHEN THEY'RE.
WAITING HOSPITALS FOR UP TO
SEVERAL HOURS AT A TIME FOR MANY
REASONS SO WITHOUT. OUR RESPECT
ROWS DRIVE VOTE ON AB TWENTY
NINE SIXTY ONE THINKING.
IN THIS RODRIGUEZ AND WITHOUT.
QUIRK LIBERAL. I'M.
ZARA VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE THE ROLE IN
THAI ABOUT AYE SIXTY FIVE NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM TO
TWENTY THREE.
THAT IS AB.
TWENTY NINE EIGHTY EIGHT BY DR
WEBER.
CORPOREAL. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINE EIGHTY EIGHT BY SOME
REMEMBER WEBER ACCOLADE TO
EVIDENCE.
DOCTOR WEBER MISTER SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS OF I RISE TO PRESENT TO
YOU AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY EIGHT
THE CRIMINAL EVIDENCE A BILL. OF
THE CORNERSTONE OF HONEST A
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IS TO
PROTECT THE INNOCENT IT CURRENT
LAWS ALLOW FOR THE DESTRUCTION
OF TRIAL EXHIBITS AFTER THE
INITIAL APPEAL. LONG BEFORE ALL
POST CONVICTION LITIGATION IS
COMPLETE.
THE NUMBER OF EXONERATION THE
PAST SEVERAL SEVERAL DECADES.
DEMONSTRATE THAT WRONGFUL
CONVICTIONS CAN HAPPEN THE
EFFORT TO REMEDY WRONGFUL
CONVICTIONS AND AFFIRM BALLOT
CONVICTIONS IS VITAL TO ENSURE
JUSTICE AND PUBLIC CONFIDENCE.
AB TWENTY NINE ABA WILL MAKE
CERTAIN ACCORD EXHIBITS ARE
RETAINED ITS COOL TO BE IN THE
COURTS CONTROLLED IN THE MOST
SERIOUS CASES FOR THE LIMP OF
EXONERATION. INCARCERATIONS ME
INTEGRITY OF OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM DEMANDS WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO EXONERATE THOSE
WERE WRONGFULLY CONVICTED. AND
AFFIRM THE CONVICTION OF THOSE
WHO ARE GUILTY THE ONLY WAY TO
ENSURE THIS IS TO PRESERVE TRIAL
EXHIBIT SO THEY ARE SUBJECT TO
EGGS REEXAMINATION. THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA.
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
ACLU AND THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
OFFICE OF OF DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
AND SEVERAL OTHER ATTORNEY
ASSOCIATIONS THERE ARE NOT
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE BOTH TWENTY NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
LOVE THE ROLE.
I'M VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO GO.
CLARK WELL CLOSE TO ROLL AND
TALLY ABOUT AYE SIXTY FIVE NO
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE FILE I'M TO TWENTY
FOUR AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY NINE
CORKERY. ASSUME IT'LL TWENTY
NINE EIGHTY NINE BY SIMPLY RIVER
FLOOR AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO
VEHICLES MISTER FLORA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY
NINE WHICH WOULD CREATE A CLEAR
DEFINITION FOR STAND UP ELECTRIC
SCOOTERS IN THE STATE VEHICLE
CODE.
ESTABLISHING RULES OR
REGULATIONS NEW MODE OF
TRANSPORTATION AB TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY NINE. CREATE A BASELINE
LEGAL FRAMEWORK FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO BUILD.
UPON DEPENDING ON THE CIRCUIT
REGULATORY NEEDS OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
AS A STATE WE NEED TO PROVIDE
CLEAR AND SAY AND SAFE.
I'M SORRY PROVIDE WE NEED TO
PROVIDE CLARITY AND SAFETY
REGULATIONS FOR WRITERS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT WELL CREATING SPACE
FOR CITIES TO REGULATE STANDUP
SCOOTERS AS THEY SEE FIT RESPECT
LAST RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISS FLORA SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
COR CLUB THE ROLL-ON.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSER ROLE TALIBAN
AYE SIXTY NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
I BELIEVE WE'RE DISPENSED WITH
FILE ON TWO TWENTY FIVE.
WE'RE FILE ITEM TO TWENTY SIX.
AB THREE THOUSAND SIX BY MR
STONE.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THOUSAND SIX
BISON REMEMBER MARK STONE RELATE
TO CHILD WELFARE.
MISTER STONE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS IF A CHILD
PROTECTIVE SERVICE WORKERS
SHOWED UP AT A HOME.
AND DIDN'T SPEAK SPANISH AND THE
OCCUPANTS SPOKE SPANISH.
WE WOULD EXPECT THAT THAT.
CHILD PROTECTIVE SERVICE WORKER
WOULD GO TO GREAT LENGTHS TO
UNDERSTAND THE FAMILY DYNAMIC
AND BRING ALONG AN INTERPRETER.
THAT'S A MATTER OF CIVIL RIGHTS
IT'S A MATTER OF OF RIGHTS OF
OUR CONSTITUENTS. THE SAME IS
NOT TRUE HOWEVER FOR A FAMILY
WHERE SOMEONE IS DEAF AND HARD
OF HEARING.
IN FACT WE KNOW OF CASES WHERE
CHILDREN GET REMOVED OR A
SOMETHING IS MADE OF CHILD ABUSE
BECAUSE THERE IS NOT VERBAL
COMMUNICATION IN THE HOUSE. AND
IS MERELY BECAUSE ONE OF THE
MEMBERS IS DEAF AND HARD OF
HEARING INCLUDING FAMILIES WHO.
ARE ADAPTED AMERICAN SIGN
LANGUAGE WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
IT.
PROVIDES A AT THE STATE LEVEL A
DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING
COORDINATOR. AND ENSURES THAT
EACH COUNTY HAS A DEFINITE ART
OF HEARING COORDINATOR TO MAKE
SURE THAT EACH COUNTY HAS THE
APPROPRIATE RESOURCES EDUCATION
AND PROCESSES TO BE ABLE TO DEAL
WITH ALL OF THESE FAMILIES.
WHO MAY OR?
BE.
MAY BE SUBJECT TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A DEAF OR HARD
OF HEARING MEMBER IS A MATTER OF
CIVIL RIGHTS THIS IS A MATTER OF
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. AND
ENSURING THAT THE COUNTY
FUNCTIONS ARE ABLE TO WORK WITH
THEM ASSESSED THE SITUATION
APPROPRIATELY AND ENSURE THAT
THE APPROPRIATE ACTION HAPPENS
WITH THAT FAMILY. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTES.
THANK YOU MISTER STONE SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
PART LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE AROUND TIED
ABOUT EYES FIFTY NINE KNOWS.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK IN THE FILE.
TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM NUMBER
FORTY FIVE.
THAT IS HE BE EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO
BY MISTER SANTIAGO.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO AND
OTHERS IN THAT RELATE TO
IMMIGRATION AND MAKING
APPROPRIATION AFFORD TO CLEAR
ABUSE OF ZERO TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
MISTER SANTIAGO THINGS SPEAKER I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT ON A. B. EIGHTEEN SIXTY
TWO WHICH ARE APPROPRIATE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. AND OR TO PRY
IMMIGRATION SERVICES AYE TO
INDIVIDUALS OR CURRENTLY OR
FORMALLY RECIPIENTS OF THE
FEDERAL TEMPORARY PROTECTED
STATUS PROGRAM.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS SANTIAGO.
SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
RIGHT STRUCTURAL.
STRUCTURAL.
MS CARILLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
APOLOGIES FOR THAT. UP MEMBERS I
RISE TO CO PRESENT AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY TWO A MEASURE THAT WOULD
PROVIDE LEGAL ASSISTANCE ONE
NEARLY VULNERABLE SECTOR OF OUR
IMMIGRANT POPULATION WHO HAVE
LOST.
THEIR TEMPORARY PROTECTED STATUS
KNOWN AS TPS AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LOS ANGELES THAT THIS BILL
BUILT ON CURRENT EFFORTS TO
ASSIST MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY
THAT HAVE BEEN STRIPPED OF THE
PROTECTION AND MADE VULNERABLE.
FOR THE REMOVAL FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN DECADES TPS RECIPIENT
RECIPIENT FROM ALL SALVADOR
NICARAGUA HAITI AND OTHER
COUNTRIES ARE INCLUDED IN THIS
GROUP.
EARLIER THIS YEAR WE HAD A FEW
TPS RECIPIENTS VISIT OUR
CHAMBERS AND AFTERWARDS THEY
SHARED HEARTBREAKING STORIES
WITH ME AND OTHERS. ABOUT THEIR
UNCERTAINTY AND THEIR FEAR OF
HAVING LOST THEIR LEGAL STATUS
THEY FOLLOWED ALL OF THE
REQUIREMENTS THIS COUNTRY SET ON
THEM AND TRUSTED THAT IF THEY
WORK HARD AND PLAY BY THE RULES
THAT WOULD GET. TO RAISE THEIR
CHILDREN IN A SAFE AND WELCOMING
COUNTRY BUT ARE NOW LEFT WITH
ONLY A FEW OPTIONS TO STAY HERE.
AS AN IMMIGRANT FROM A SOLID OR
I FEEL IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
RECOGNIZE OUR COMMUNITIES
POTENTIAL.
AND AS THE STATE AND ANOTHER
STATE RESPOND TO THEIR CONCERNS
THESE DEPORTATIONS WILL COST OUR
STATE THOUSANDS. WITH LAW BY LAW
ABIDING HARDWORKING RESIDENTS TO
CONTRIBUTE MILLIONS TO OUR
ECONOMY.
IT'D BE S. RECIPIENTS PAY TAXES
ON HOMES AND START THEIR OWN
BUSINESS ACROSS OUR STATE
PARTICULARLY IN MY DISTRICT AND
SURROUNDING ALLEY COMMUNITIES
TIP YES RECIPIENTS ARE ALSO
PARENTS TO CHILDREN. WHO ARE
AMERICAN CITIZENS SAID AND IF
THEY ARE FORCED TO LEAVE?
THOUSANDS MORE FAMILIES WILL BE
TORN APART IN RESPONSE TO THE
SENSELESS AND A TPS IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO SAFEGUARD
AFFECTED CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS BY
OFFERING QUALIFIED LEGAL
SERVICES. TO HELP THEM AND
ADVISE THEM THIS BILL WILL MAKE
SURE ARC ARE COMMITTED NONPROFIT
PARTNERS HAVE THE FUNDING TO
UNDERTAKE THIS TASK AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR ABOUT.
THEY'VE IS CARILLO.
SEEING.
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
SURE SANTIAGO YOU MAY CLOSE IF
YOU WISH.
THANK YOU FOR SPEAKER I
APPRECIATE AN AYE VOTE UP FROM
THE MEMBERSHIP.
I THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
HERE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE PROVIDE. A SERVICES FOR THOSE
IMMIGRANTS UNDER TPS RESPECT
WHEN THAT'S RIVAL.
WITH THAT CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
S. TAKES FIFTY FOUR.
S. TAKES FIFTY FOUR ON THE
URGENCY ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE
THE ROLE AND TALENT ABOUT EYES
FIFTY SIX KNOWS FOURTEEN ON THE
URGENCY. EYES FIFTY SIX KNOWS
FOURTEEN ON THE BILL THAT
MEASURE PASS.
MEMBERS BACK IN FILE ORDER YOUR
PAST SEEING AND RETAINING ON
FILE ITEM TO TWENTY SEVEN.
WORD FILE ITEM TO TWENTY EIGHT
AB THIRTY TWENTY ONE BY MISTER
LEVINE FOR CORPORATE.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTY TWENTY ONE BY
SOME REMEMBER LEVINE ANOTHER
PERSON THAT LINK TO FARM ANIMALS
MAKING APPROPRIATION ARE FOR.
THIS SHOW LEVINE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
WHETHER YOU LIKE THEM SCRAMBLED
OR FRIED YOU'LL GET ON CAGE FREE
BY TWENTY TWENTY FOUR WITH THIS
BILL. AND I WANT TO SAY THAT WE
ARE GOING TO BE INCORPORATING
NATIONAL CAGE FREE STANDARDS SO
THAT WE AND AS WE STAGGER THIS
IMPLEMENTATION WILL MAKE SURE
THAT PRICE STAY LOW. JOBS REMAIN
BUT WE ALSO TREAT ANIMALS AWAY
THAT WE SHOULD THESE TYPES OF
BILLS DON'T HAPPEN ON THEIR OWN
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES
FROM RIVERSIDE IN BAKERSFIELD.
FOR WORKING WITH ME ON THIS
ISSUE AYE ASTRAEA AYE VOTE.
A RICH THE VEIN.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CARP LOEBNER ALL.
ON MEMBERS.
IS THERE A VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
THREE KNOWS TO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE FILE ITEM TO TWENTY NINE
AB THIRTY EIGHTY.
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY EIGHTY BY
SOME REMEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER
AN ACCOLADE TO EMPLOYMENT.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. I WANT
TO LEGISLATURE HAS PASSED SOME
OF THE STRONGEST WORKER
PROTECTIONS IN THE COUNTRY
AGAINST SEXUAL HARASSMENT. PAY
INEQUITY DISCRIMINATION BASED ON
RACE RACE SEXUAL ORIENTATION OR
ABILITY AND AGREE JUST LABOR
VIOLATIONS LIKE WAGE THEFT
HOWEVER THOSE LAWS ARE WORTHLESS
IF THEY CANNOT BE ENFORCED IN
COURT OR BY STATE AGENCY BECAUSE
AN EMPLOYER HAS FORCED THEIR
WORKERS TO SIGN AWAY THEIR
RIGHTS. IN AN ARBITRATION
AGREEMENT.
MANDATING THAT EMPLOYEES GO TO
ARBITRATION IS A PRACTICE WHICH
ALLOWS COMPANIES TO FORCE
EMPLOYEE COMPLAINTS INTO
SECRETIVE HEARINGS WHICH HIDES
LABOR VIOLATIONS FROM THE PUBLIC.
SILENCE HIS VICTIMS WITH NON
DISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS AND OFTEN
PROTECTS SERIAL OFFENDERS.
ARBITRATION TO BE A HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE DISPUTE RESOLUTION
METHOD WHEN EVERYBODY CHOOSES TO
ENTER IT VOLUNTARILY. THIS IS
WHY A. B. THIRTY EIGHTY DOES NOT
PROHIBIT EMPLOYERS FROM USING
ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS TO SOLVE.
OR RESOLVE WORKPLACE DISPUTES
INSTEAD IT SIMPLY REQUIRES
EMPLOYEES CHOOSE TO SIGN SUCH
AGREEMENTS AND THAT'S NOT CAN
DID CONTINGENT UPON THEM GETTING
A JOB.
AB THIRTY EIGHTY ALSO DOES NOT
RENDER ANY EXISTING ARBITRATION
AGREEMENT UNENFORCEABLE.
AS AN ADDITIONAL PROTECTION A.
B. THIRTY EIGHTY ENSURES A
WORKER INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS
NOT PROHIBITED FROM DISCLOSING
ANY INSTANCE OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT. THAT THEY SUFFER OR
DISCOVER IN THE WORKPLACE IN
ORDER PURSUE OR KEEP A JOB IN
EMPLOYMENT BENEFITS.
THIS IS A PRIORITY WOMEN'S
CAUCUS BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
WITH YOUR KILEY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I THE
PROPONENTS WOULD HAVE YOU
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL WILL
SOMEHOW HELP I TO ADDRESS THE
EXTREMELY SERIOUS PROBLEM. OF
SEXUALHARASSMENT AND OTHER
WORKPLACE MISCONDUCT
I IT DOES NO SUCH THING.
WHAT THE BILL REALLY DOES IS
PUSH FOR A LONG STANDING
PREEXISTING POLITICAL AGENDA?
DESIGNED TO FINANCIALLY BENEFIT
ONE GROUP AT THE EXPENSE OF
WORKERS.
AND VICTIMS.
THE BILL'S GOAL IS TAKE MORE AND
MORE CASES AWAY FROM THE FORUM
OF ARBITRATION.
WHERE VICTIMS CAN RECEIVE
COMPENSATION MORE QUICKLY?
WITH A LOWER LEGAL COSTS
AND WITH GREATER FLEXIBILITY AND
MOVE THOSE CASES
INTO ARE ALREADY OVERWHELMED
COURTS.
WHERE PROCEEDINGS ARE MORE
PROTRACTED AND THOUGHTS BEES FOR
LAWYERS ARE OF COURSE MUCH
MUCH HIGHER?
THIS BILL IS NOT LIMITED TO
SEXUAL HARASSMENT CLAIMS BUT.
SWEEPS IN ALL CLAIMS UNDER THE
FLARE FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING ACT AND THE LABOR CODE.
IT ALSO DOES NOT GIVE.
WORKERS ANY NEW SUBSTANTIVE
RIGHTS BUT SIMPLY CHANGES THE
FORUM IN WHICH CLAIMS WILL BE
ADJUDICATED.
THIS MEANS THAT IF YOU'RE A
VICTIM OF DISCRIMINATION BASED
ON AGE DISABILITY FAMILY CARE
STATUS SACKS ARE OF YOUR VICTIM
OF RETALIATION OR YES SEXUAL
HARASSMENT. YOUR ONLY OPTION
FORGETTING JUSTICE
WILL BE LITIGATION.
NOW SEVERAL STUDIES HAVE SHOWN.
THIS IS NOT A REALISTIC OPTION.
FOR LOW WAGE EMPLOYEES.
WHO MAY NOT BE ABLE TO AFFORD A
LAWYER?
WHO MAY NOT BE ABLE TO AFFORD TO
WAIT YEARS?
IN ORDER TO RECEIVE COMPENSATION
WHO MAY WORK MULTIPLE JOBS AND
NOT HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY IN
ORDER TO PROSECUTE A YEARS LONG
CIVIL ACTION AS ONE ARTICLE IN
THE UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN LAW
REVIEW PUT IT. THE VAST MAJORITY
OF ORDINARY LOWER AND MIDDLE
INCOME EMPLOYEES CANNOT GET
ACCESS TO THE COURTS TO
VINDICATE THEIR CONTRACTUAL OR
STATUTORY RIGHTS
THERE ARE ONLY PRACTICAL HOPE IS
THE GENERALLY CHEAPER. FASTER
AND MORE INFORMAL PROCESS
OF ARBITRATION.
NUMEROUS STUDIES ALSO SHOW. THAT
EMPLOYEES GENERALLY WIN THE SAME
PERCENTAGE OF CASES IN
ARBITRATION.
IF NOT MORE.
NOW TO BE FAIR THERE IS SOME
CONFLICTING DATA ON THIS POINT I
GOVERNOR BROWN FOR HIS PART IN
VETOING A SIMILAR BILL. A FEW
YEARS AGO SAID THIS
THE EVIDENCE ON ACTUAL OUTCOMES
AN ARBITRATION VERSES LITIGATION
IS CONFLICTING AND UNCLEAR. WITH
SOME STUDIES SHOWING EMPLOYEES
RECEIVING MORE IN ARBITRATION
WHILE OTHER STUDIES SHOW THE
OPPOSITE BUT EVEN IF IT'S A WASH.
ARBITRATION IS STILL VASTLY
PREFERABLE FOR THE VAST MAJORITY
OF EMPLOYEES
BECAUSE MORAL BE ABLE GET ACCESS
TO IT.
THEY'RE POSSIBLY MUCH LOWER THAN
BE ABLE TO KEEP MORE OF THEIR
AWARD RATHER THAN GOING TO
ATTORNEYS AND THEY'LL GET THE
REWARDS MORE QUICKLY. AND WITH
GREATER FINALLY.
FOR THOSE REASONS THIS BILL WILL
DO GREAT DAMAGE.
TO WORKERS
AND TO VICTIMS BY LIMITING THEIR
ACCESS.
TO JUSTICE BUT PERHAPS WORST OF
ALL.
THE BILL ALSO MAKES VICTIMS IN
SOME CASES THE LESS LIKELY TO
COME FORWARD.
FOR THOSE WHO WOULD PREFER THE
CONFIDENTIALITY OFFERED BY
ARBITRATION I WOULD NOT RATHER
NOT HAVE TO TALK ABOUT THEIR
EXPERIENCES. IN OPEN COURT OVER
POTENTIALLY SEVERAL YEARS.
IN ANY CASE THIS BILL IS
OBVIOUSLY PREEMPTED BY THE
FEDERAL ARBITRATION ACT IT'S NOT
EVEN CLOSE JUST LIKE A BILL THIS
LEGISLATURE PASSED IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN.
PURPORTING TO LIMIT ARBITRATION
WAS JUST STRUCK DOWN BY
CALIFORNIA APPELLATE COURT THIS
YEAR BUT IN THE MEANTIME IN THE
YEARS IN WHICH THE BILL IS IN
LEGAL THEM LEGAL LIMBO. IT'LL
CAUSE GREAT HARM TO WORKERS TO
VICTIMS AND OUR STATE AS A WHOLE
I URGE A NO VOTE.
DOCTOR WEBER. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MISTER SPEAKER UP. THIS GIVES ME
AN MEMBERS.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF ALL A B.
THIRTY EIGHTY AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS IS NOT A.
PROEHL NORD ANTI ARBITRATION
BILL. THIS IS REALLY ABOUT
CHOICE THAT PEOPLE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO CHOOSE IF THEY WANT TO
ENGAGE IN ARBITRATION.
IT SHOULD NOT BE FORCED UPON YOU
AS A CONDITION OF EMPLOYMENT BUT
IF YOU WANNA TAKE THIS JOB YOU
MUST SIGN THIS ARBITRATION
AGREEMENT IN ADVANCE.
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO THAT IF
YOU WANT TO SIGN THE ARBITRATION
AGREEMENT. AND SO WHEN WE START
TALKING ABOUT IS GOING TO BE
FASTER AND CHEAPER AND SO FORTH
AND SO ON MAYBE IT WILL BE AND
IF IT IS A CHOICE THAT YOU MAKE.
WHICH YOU SHOULD NOT BE FORCED
TO SIGN IT IN ORDER TO GET A JOB
AND THAT'S THE THING THAT'S
IMPORTANT YOU TALK ABOUT DENIAL
OF JUSTICE THAT IS THE DENIAL OF
JUSTICE IN ITSELF IF I CAN'T
CHOOSE. WHETHER I WANT TO GO TO
COURT OF ARBITRATION BECAUSE I'M
FORCED TO SIGN ARBITRATION
AGREEMENTS IN ADVANCE THEM THAT
BASICALLY DENIES MY RIGHT TO GO
TO COURT AND TO HAVE WHATEVER
FORM OF JUSTICE IN LITIGATION
THAT OCCURS.
IT SHOULD ALSO BE NOTED THAT
PEOPLE IN ARBITRATION ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO FOLLOW THE LAW. AND
MANY OF YOU DON'T KNOW MAY NOT
KNOW THAT BUT IF THEY ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO FOLLOW THE LAW WHEN
YOU DEAL WITH ARBITRATORS. I
KNOW BECAUSE I WANT TO
ARBITRATION ONCE I'LL NEVER GO
AGAIN BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT
REQUIRED TO FOLLOW THE LAW AND
THE AND THEREFORE YOU BASICALLY
MAKE A DECISION AS TO WHAT YOU
THINK IS BEST THE ARBITRATOR
DOES.
IT IS NOT ALWAYS THE BEST FORM
OF GOVERNMENT YES IT IS FAST
IT'S QUICK BUT YOU DON'T ALWAYS
GET THE JUSTICE THAT YOU WANT.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY THIS BILL
IS NOT ABOUT HOW HORRIBLE
ARBITRATION IS HOW WONDERFUL
ARBITRATION IS THIS IS SAYS THAT
I SHOULD BE ABLE TO CHOOSE IF I
WANT TO GO TO ARBITRATION. ARE
NOT AND THAT SHOULD BE THE
CHOICE OF THE INDIVIDUALS AND
NOT SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
DECIDED THAT THEY MUST DO IN
ORDER TO OBTAIN A JOB. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT
FOR A BI THIRTY EIGHTY BECAUSE
THIS REALLY ABOUT CHOICE MUCH
MORE THAN EITHER ONE OF THE
OTHER CHOICES THAT OF THEIR.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER MISTER
HARPER.
MR IN SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I WANT TO KNOW THAT I'M HEARING
A LOT OF GREAT.
REASONS WHY A.
SOMEONE SHOULD NOT BE FORCED TO
PAY INTO A UNION.
AS A CONDITION.
OF HAVING A JOB.
THAT WAS A.
I'M SORRY MS WEBB DOCTOR WEBER
STAGE POINT OF ORDER.
YES I WANTED CLARIFICATION ON ON
WHAT HE WAS TALKING ABOUT.
WELL WE'RE NOT GOING INTO BACK
OKAY I WAS JUST CURIOUS OUTBREAK
HOW IT RELATED TO THE.
THANK YOU TO WHOEVER WILL.
LOOK FOR ANY OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION SEEING AND
HEARING NINE.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU MAY
CLOSE. I JUST WANNA.
TO RESPOND TO TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM.
SOMEWHERE NORTH OF ME FRESNO.
AND IN SAY THIS THERE IS NOTHING
IN THIS BILL. THAT WOULD NOT
ALLOW SOMEBODY TO SEEK
ARBITRATION.
AND IF THIS BELIEF AS THE
OPPONENTS WOULD HAVE IT THAT
ARBITRATION IS SO GOOD FOR
WORKERS ESPECIALLY LOW WAGE
WORKERS THEY WILL STILL HAVE
THAT AS AN OPTION.
TO RESOLVE A DISPUTE AT WORK BUT
THAT HAVE OTHER OPTIONS TO. THEY
CAN GO TO THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
WHAT YOU DON'T NEED AN ATTORNEY
FOR BECAUSE UNDER ARBITRATION
YOU CAN'T DO THAT UNDER FORCE
ARBITRATION. THEY COULD GO TO
COURT ESPECIALLY IF THERE WERE
MORE THAN ONE OF THEM THAT THIS
WAS HAPPENING TO.
BUT WHAT WE KNOW IS THIS
ARBITRATION HAS BEEN A TOOL. FOR
EMPLOYERS TO KEEP A SECRET
SERIAL OFFENDERS WHEN IT COMES
TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT WHEN IT
COMES TO SEXUAL ASSAULT. THEY
REQUIRE PEOPLE THE SIGN AND DA'S
THAT'S WHY PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO STAY ON THE JOB CONTINUALLY
HARASSED SEEN WOMEN TIME AND
TIME AGAIN WITHOUT ANYONE
KNOWING IT.
BECAUSE IT'S A SECRET PROCESS.
IT'S BEEN ABLE IT'S USED TO
SHIELD.
HARASSERS
THIS ISN'T A PARTISAN ISSUE MANY
OF YOU KNOW GRETCHEN CARLSON
FROM FOX AND FRIENDS CAME OUT I
DON'T THINK WE'RE IN THE SAME
IDEOLOGICAL SPEAR. SUSAN ABOUT
UNIONS THIS IS ABOUT MAKING SURE.
EVERY WORKER HAS A MARKET PLACE
OF REMEDIES AVAILABLE IF THEY'RE
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST ON THE JOB
IF THEY'RE SALTED IF THEY'RE
HARASSED IF THEIR WAGES ARE
STRONG IF THEY HAVE PAY
INEQUITIES. AND THIS IS A BILL
WHOSE TIME HAS COME.
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS HAS
RECOGNIZED THIS AS A PRIORITY
LEGISLATION FOR DEALING WITH
SEXUAL HARASSMENT ISSUES IN THE
WORKPLACE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
AND WITHOUT THE CAR PULL UP THE
ROLE. MEMBERS.
IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLAND HOW ABOUT AYE AYES
FORTY THREE KNOWS NINETEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS REMOVED BACK IN THE FILE
TO FILE ITEM ONE FORTY THREE A.
B..
THIRTY TEN FIVE MS LIMON.
KERKORIAN.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TEN BY SOME
WOMEN LIMON ACCOLADE TO DEFERRED
DEPOSIT TRANSACTIONS.
MS MS LOW MOAN.
WE CAN PASS TEMPORARILY.
OR WE CAN WAIT FOR YOUR FOLDER
TO ARRIVE AT YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU JURY WHERE AND MEMBERS.
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT DATA THERE
WERE OVER ELEVEN MILLION AT PT
LOANS FOR A TOTAL OF OVER THREE
BILLION.
IN TWENTY
STEEN.
THE CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE IS
THAT SOME OF THESE SOME OF THESE
ARE THE MOST EXPENSIVE LOANS
AVAILABLE ON THE MARKET. WITH AN
AVERAGE APR TWO BARS OF THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO PERCENT.
THIS BILL BEGINS TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM BY STRENGTHENING ONE OF
THE ONE LOAN AT A TIME LEADING
POLICY THAT IS CURRENTLY IN
PLACE.
IT DOESN'T IS BY.
ENSURING THAT BIRD HAS ANOTHER
PAYDAY LOAN THAT DOESN'T THE BAR
THAT HAS ANOTHER PAYDAY LOAN OUT
WITH ANOTHER LENDER IS NOT ABLE
TO GET A SECOND ONE.
THE BILL ALSO CREATES A DATABASE
THAT LENDERS TO REFER TO TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE NOT
VIOLATING THE ONE LOAN AT A TIME
POLICY.
SEVERAL OF MY CALL OF COLLEAGUES
WERE CONCERNED WITH THE SECURITY
AND PRIVACY ISSUES SO WE TOOK
SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS IN THE
PRIVACY COMMITTEE NEARING THE
DATA COLLECTION TO. ONLY THE
MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS NEEDED TO
MAKE THE PROGRAM WORK.
THIS IS ONE WAY TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM. AND MANY MEMBERS ARE.
STOPPING INAPPROPRIATE LENDING
FROM CREATING NEW PATHWAY TAXES
FOR REASONABLE ON PRODUCTS IS AN
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT BUT
DIFFICULT TASK I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THING IS AMONG.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CORPORAL. MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO IS OUR VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
MS THEM ON
MISS THEM ALL OF THE COSTS.
S. THEM ALMOST CALL.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK.
IN FILE ORDER.
OR RETURN TO FILE ORDER I SHOULD
SAY.
PAST RETAIN ON FILE ITEM TO
THIRTY. OR FILE ITEM TO THIRTY
ONE.
AB THIRTY EIGHTY TWO BY THIS
GONZALEZ FLETCHER THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY EIGHTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER INACCURATE PUBLIC
SOCIAL SERVICES
AS GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU MAY
OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS CARE FOR
SOME OF OUR COMMUNITY'S MOST
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS YET THEY
AREN'T ACCOUNTED FOR IN MOST OF
THE HARD FOUGHT LAWS THAT
PROTECT WORKERS AGAINST SEXUAL
HARASSMENT. ARE IHS AS PROGRAM
LACKS EVEN THE BASIC PROTOCOLS
TO ADDRESS WORK FOR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT STATEWIDE THERE'S NO
FORMAL MECHANISM THE PROGRAM FOR
WORKERS TO REPORT. RESOLVE OR
PREVENT THE RECURRENCE OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
WITHOUT ANY STANDARD PROCEDURES
HE'S VULNERABLE WORKERS ARE
SENSUALLY EXPECTED TO ENDORSE
SOME DEGREE OF IN DIGNITY AS A
PART OF THEIR EMPLOYMENT.
AB THIRTY EIGHTY TWO ADDRESSES
THIS ISSUE BY DIRECTING THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
DID DEVELOP UNIFORM SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PROCEDURES. AND
PROTECTIONS FOR IHS THAT'S
WORKERS.
THIS PROCESS INCLUDES A
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS
DEVELOP A CONTINUING PROGRAM
SEXUAL HARASSMENT EDUCATION FOR
PROVIDERS AND RECIPIENTS.
PROCEDURES TO ENSURE PROVIDERS
ARE COMPENSATED APPROPRIATE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT CASES AND
PROTECTIONS AGAINST RETALIATION
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE OF.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLERK LIBERAL. MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DECIDED VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL.
ON A COUPLE OF ITEMS FIRST WHAT
IS FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR.
AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE BY
MISTER MURATSUCHI.
CARPOOL POST.
OUR MEMBERS VOTER WISH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE. MENTALITY THE
VOTE.
I FORTY FOUR KNOWS TWENTY FOUR
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
AND WE'RE ALSO GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
NINE THAT'S AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY
THREE BY MISTER KALRA THE CLERK
WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE WRONG TIED ABOUT ICE FORTY
ONE KNOWS TWENTY SEVEN.
THAT MEASURE HOUSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO. TAKE UP
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE FORTY FOUR.
BY MISTER LOWE THIS IS FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY FOUR.
AB THIRTY EIGHTEEN.
THE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY WILL BREATHE OUT A TEAM
BY SOME REMEMBER LOW AND ACT
LIKE A PUBLIC CONTRACTS.
MR LOVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS A. B. THIRTY
EIGHTEEN INCREASE IS COMPLIANCE
WITH SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE RULES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR BREVITY MISS
LOVE. SCENE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ON
MEMBERS.
THE SIDE OF THE ROAD ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF THOSE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR OWN TALENT OF OWN
FORTY FIVE KNOWS NINETEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
BACK IN FILE ORDER.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM TO. THIRTY
TWO. AB THIRTY EIGHTY FIVE FIVE
MISTER CALDERON TO CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY FIVE BY
SOME REMEMBER CALDERON ACCOLADE
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES MISTER
CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER A. B.
THIRTY EIGHTY FIVE WILL
INCENTIVIZE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
EITHER PURSUE A HOMELESS
EMPLOYMENT FLORA PROGRAM OF
THEIR OWN OR EXPAND ON EXISTING.
THIS BILL CREATES A NEW
BEGINNINGS CALIFORNIA PROGRAM
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT WHICH WILL FUNCTION
AS A GRANT PROGRAM WHEREIN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MAY APPLY FOR
MATCHING FUNDS TO IMPLEMENT AN
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM FOR HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS.
IN ORDER TO QUALIFY THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HOMELESS EMPLOYMENT
PROGRAM MUST MEET CERTAIN
CRITERIA INCLUDING AN HOURLY
WAGE OF AT LEAST A MINUTE
MINIMUM WAGE AND CONNECTING
PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS. WITH OTHER
SERVICES AND RESOURCES THIS BILL
SEEKS TO OFFER ANOTHER TOOL TO
HELP. THE HOMELESS CITIZENS OF
OUR STATE BY CONNECTING THEM
WITH THE SERVICES THEY NEED
WHILE OFFERING THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ACHIEVE THE SELF
CONFIDENCE THAT OFTEN COMES WITH
THE JOB WELL DONE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON THE SUPPORT.
BIG WAS CALLED AROUND SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CAR CLUB THE ROLL-ON ARE TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTERS HAD A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS HIGHER TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ON TIED ABOUT AYEAYES
FORTY THREE NOTES TWENTY.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS OR FILE ITEM TO THIRTY
THREE. A. B. THIRTY EIGHTY NINE
BY MR FUHRMAN THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY EIGHTY NINE
BY SOME REMEMBER THURMAN
ACCOLADE THE STUDENT FINANCIALLY.
MISTER THEREMIN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE PRESENT AB THIRTY
EIGHTY NINE THIS BILL SEEKS TO
HELP MORE OF OUR FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH. BE ABLE TO GO TO COLLEGE
IT EXPANDS THE JP GRANT WHICH IS
A. FINANCIAL AID PROGRAM THAT
EMANCIPATED FOSTER YOUTH CAN USE
TO GO TO COLLEGE BUT EXPANDS THE
AIDS A. CEILING.
TO TWENTY SIX IT MOVES IT FROM
AGE TWENTY TWO TYPICALLY MANY OF
OUR YOUTH.
WHO ARE LEADING FOSTER CARE
DON'T LEARN ABOUT THIS?
BENEFIT UNTIL.
THEY WERE OLDER THAN TWENTY TWO
AND THIS WRECK DEFIES THAT TO
ENSURE THAT YOUTH.
WHO LEAVE FOSTER CARE WILL HAVE
ALL THE TIME THEY NEED TO USE
THIS BENEFIT TO BE ABLE TO GO TO
COLLEGE? ONE FINAL NOTE THIS
BILL WAS WRITTEN BY YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO THEMSELVES HAVE EXPERIENCE
OF FOSTER CARE.
THEY ARE ADVOCATES A GREAT
PROGRAM CALLED JOURNEY HOUSE AND
OUT ON THEIR BEHALF IN. AND THE
THOUSANDS OF YOUNG PEOPLE OUR
STATE WHO HAVE BEEN IN FOSTER
CARE AYE URGE AYE VOTE.
FAMOUS THURMOND SEEN NOTICED
QUESTION OR DEBATE.
QUIRK LIBERAL. I'M.
IT IS OUT OF OUR OWN RESOURCES
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS FOR THIS AREA THOUGH.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROAD TIES BUT I
SIXTY SIX.
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM TO THIRTY FOURS AB
THIRTY NINETY SIX BY MS RUBIO.
KERKORIAN.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY NINETY SIX
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO AN
ACCOLADE SCHOOL ACCOUNTABILITY.
MS RUBIO THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER OF AB THIRTY
NINETY SIX STREAMLINES ACCESS TO
THE SCHOOL ACCOUNTABILITY REPORT
CARD BY MAKING THE INFORMATION
AVAILABLE ONLINE. AND AVAILABLE
TO BE PRINTED IF DESIRED
CURRENTLY SCHOOL AND DISTRICT
LEVEL STAFF ANNUALLY COMPLETES
THE STARK IN ADDITION TO DOZENS
OF OTHER REPORTS REQUIRED FOR
STATE AND FEDERAL PURPOSES.
ABTHIRTY NINETY SIX CREATING
MORE ALIGNED REPORTING SYSTEM
FOR THE STARK AS WELL AS ONE
STOP RESOURCES FOR PARENTS AND
STAKEHOLDERS TO ACCESS
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR SCHOOLS.
WE TOOK AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE INTENDED TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS BY THE ACLU AND PUBLIC
ADVOCATES.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR ABLE.
DAVIS REVEALS SEEN NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ON
MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE CALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO THOUGH.
IT TAKES FIFTY FOR ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM TO THIRTY FIVE IS A B.
THIRTY NINETY SEVEN CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY NINETY
SEVEN BY SIMPLY RIVER SALAS AN
ACCOLADE OF VEHICULAR AIR
POLLUTION.
MISTER SALAS.
THINK RESPECT REMEMBERS AB
THIRTY NINETY SEVEN.
DEAS WITH SMOG CHECK REPORTS
REFLECT WAY ASPIRIN I'VE.
THE RISALA SEEN NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
CLUB CLUB THE ROLL-ON.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THOUGH.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLL TIDE BUT
I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES PASSING
RETAIN ON FILE ITEM TO THIRTY
SIX.
WHERE IT FILE ITEM TO THIRTY
SEVEN?
AB THIRTY ONE EIGHTEEN BY MISTER
DAVID CHIU CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE
EIGHTEEN BY SOME REMEMBER DAVID
CHIU ANOTHER WAS AN ACCOLADE A
SEXUAL ASSAULT. MISTER CHIP.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES A. B. THIRTY ONE
EIGHTEEN WILL ADDRESS THE
BACKLOG OF UNTESTED RAPE KITS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE INJUSTICE OF THE BACKLOG
SHOULD BE OBVIOUS BUT IS WORTH
REPEATING. AFTER THE HORRIFIC
CRIME OF A SEXUAL ASSAULT THE
COLLECTION OF THIS EVIDENCE IS
EXTREMELY INVASIVE AND LASTS
HOURS.
WHEN RATE KITS REMAIN UNTESTED
COLLECTING DUST IN THE BACK OF
POLICE CRIME LABS AND SHERIFF
DEPARTMENTS. VICTIMS SURVIVORS
ARE DENIED JUSTICE
CRIMINALS ROAM FREE AND SOMEONE
WHO IS ACTUALLY INNOCENT COULD
BE DENIED EXONERATION.
WHILE OUR STATUS STARTED TO
ADDRESS THE RAPE KIT BACKLOG
THERE'S SO MUCH LEFT TO DO AND
WE ARE BEHIND OTHER STATES IN
TERMS OF REFORM.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO CONDUCT
AN AUDIT OF ALL UNTESTED RAPE
KITS IN THEIR POSSESSION AND
REPORT THAT DATA TO OUR STATE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. WHO WILL
PROVIDE THAT REPORT BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE?
WE NEED THIS INFORMATION BECAUSE
WE DON'T KNOW THE SIZE OF THE
RAPE KIT BACKLOG IN CALIFORNIA.
WHILE THEY'RE SOME ESTIMATES
THAT IT IS AT LEAST THIRTEEN
THOUSAND.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE ANSWER IS
AND THIS IS NOT HOW THE LARGEST
IN THE COUNTRY SHOULD HANDLE
THIS EVIDENCE.
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
DESERVE JUSTICE THIS BILL IS
RECEIVED STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN ALL COMMITTEES AND
RECEIVE ZERO NO VOTES AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THEY MISS YOU MISS WALDRON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AYE
URGENT AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL
THIS IS BEEN AN ISSUE SINCE I'VE
BEEN IN THE ASSEMBLY GOING ON
SIX YEARS SO IT'S BEEN EVEN
LONGER THAN THAT.
WE NEED TO GET IT RESOLVED.
THEY MISS WALDRON.
SEEING NO OTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
QUIRK GIRL. I'M.
RESERVE VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE.
I SIXTY SIX KNOW ZERO THEM
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE. BAD FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO THIRTY EIGHT.
AB THIRTY ONE NINETEEN BY MISS
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KERKORIAN.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE
NINETEEN BY SOME REMEMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER NOT RELATE TO
THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY REGIONAL
AIRPORT AUTHORITY.
THIS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
THANK YOU THIS IS A LOCAL BILL
AB THIRTY ONE NOT.
THIRTY ONE NINETEEN WOULD CREATE
THE SAN DIEGO INTERNATIONAL
AIRPORT MOBILITY AND
SUSTAINABILITY COMMITTEE TO
EXAMINE ISSUES IMPACTING THE
FUTURE THE AIRPORT THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
I THINK YOU SEEN NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
CLERK LIBERAL.
OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTES.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE ICE FORTY SEVEN KNOW ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TO
THE UNITED C. B. THIRTY ONE
THIRTY DIVERT MISTER BONTA CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE THIRTY
NINE BY SALIBA RIPON TURNED OUT
REALLY THE STATE HIGHWAYS.
MISTER BONTA THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES A. B.
THIRTY ONE THIRTY NINE IS A
DISTRICT BILL. THAT WAY THE CITY
OF OAKLAND BY PROVIDING ANOTHER
TOOL TO ADDRESS THE GROWING
HOMELESS CRISIS THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW THE CITY OF OAKLAND TO
LEASE UP TO TEN. UNUSED PARCELS
BELOW OR NEXT TO STATE FREEWAYS
FOR EMERGENCY SHELTER OR FEEDING
PROGRAMS FOR ONE DOLLAR PER
MONTH
CURRENTLY THERE ARE ONE THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED AND TWO ON SHELTER
HOMELESS PEOPLE IN OAKLAND. BY
PROVIDING AN OPPORTUNITY TO
LEAST CERTAIN CALTRANS PARCELS
FOR EMERGENCY SHELTERS AND
FEEDING PROGRAMS THIS BILL WILL
HELP THE CITY ADDRESS A GROWING.
HOMELESS POPULATION THIS BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
MR MATHIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MEMBERS MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I MUST I RESPECTFULLY RISE IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
LAST YEAR WE PASSED.
A BILL TO ALLOW OUR COLLEAGUES
IN SAN FRANCISCO TO DO THE EXACT
SAME THING.
BUT YEAH THIS YEAR.
I WORK ON A BILL TO ALLOW US TO
DO THIS THE ENTIRE STATE.
THAT.
DIDN'T MAKE IT THROUGH OUR
APPROPRIATIONS SO.
YOU NOT QUITE FRANKLY IT APPEARS
TO ME THAT IT'S GOOD ENOUGH FOR
SAN FRANCISCO.
IT'S GOOD ENOUGH FOR OAKLAND.
BUT IF YOU'RE ANYWHERE ELSE IN
THE STATE IT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH.
WE HAVE A HOMELESS CRISIS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE TALK
ABOUT IT ON A DAILY BASIS.
BUT YEAH.
WHEN IT COMES EVERYWHERE ELSE I
MEAN MEMBERS ARE WE GONNA HAVE
TO PASS LEGISLATION. EVERY YEAR
FOR EVERY SINGLE CITY IN
CALIFORNIA.
ONE AT A TIME.
TO GET MORE HOMELESS SHELTERS
TO GET MORE FOOD PROGRAMS TO GET
THESE RESOURCES WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THE HOMELESS ISSUE.
ARE WE GONNA KEEP PEACE MILLION
IT.
MEMBERS I ASKED FOR NO VOTE
TODAY LET'S GO BACK LET'S OPEN
THIS PROGRAM UP SO IT COVERS THE
ENTIRE STATE.
SEEING NO OTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
SURE BONTA YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THANK
YOU TO MY COLLEAGUE FOR FOR
RAISING THE ISSUE OF.
THE FACT THAT THIS POLICY COULD
POSITIVELY IMPACT OTHER
JURISDICTIONS I I I AGREE WITH
THAT.
AND.
UNFORTUNATE THIS BILL IN ITS
CURRENT FORM IN ITS CURRENT FORM
APPLIES ONLY TO THE CITY OF
OAKLAND I THINK WE SHOULD
CONSIDER GOOD POLICIES AND
EXPAND THEM AS APPROPRIATE OTHER
JURISDICTIONS AS WELL BUT IT ITS
CURRENT FORM THIS BILL APPLIES
TO THE CITY OF OAKLAND IN THE
CITY OF. OAKLAND ONLY ASPECT WE
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
AND WITH THAT.
CLERK WILL THE ROLE.
THESE ARE THE MODAL NUMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE AYE AYES FORTY FIVE.
KNOWS SIXTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
PASS RETAIN ON FILE ITEM TO
FORTY.
WE'RE AT FILE ITEM TWO FORTY ONE
A. B. THIRTY ONE FIFTY THREE BY
MISTER LEVINE.
KERKORIAN.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE FIFTY
THREE BY SOME WEAVERVILLE LEVINE
AND ACT LIKE A STUDENT
FINANCIALLY. MICHELIN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER THIS
BILL ALLOWS FOR STUDENTS TO TAKE
TWO SUMMER SESSIONS.
WITH CAL GRANTS A IN BE OUT YOU
SEE OR IF THEY CHOOSE CSU. AYE
ASPIRIN AYE VOTE.
THEY WRESTLING SCENE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK LIBERAL. MEMBERS.
WHO IS OUR TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO THOUGH?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE TO ROLAND HOW THE VOTE
EYES FIFTY ONE.
NO SIX THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM TO FORTY
TWO. A. B. THIRTY ONE SIXTY
SEVEN BY MISTER O'DONNELL THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE SIXTY
SEVEN BY SOME REMEMBER O'DONNELL
ACCOLADES CHARTER SCHOOLS.
SURE DOLLARS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
THIS BILL CONTINUES THE WORK OF
THE CHARTER AUTHORIZED HER
REGIONAL SUPPORT NETWORK KNOWN
AS CARS NET. BY PROVIDING
FUNDING THROUGH THE BUDGET.
THIS FUNDING WILL ALLOW CARS NET
TO CONTINUE THE MODEL THEY
STARTED WITH TRAININGS AND
CONFERENCES FOR CHARTER
AUTHORIZES
TO IMPROVE THEIR PRACTICE.
CHARTER SCHOOL AUTHORIZES HAVE
VERY FEW RESOURCES FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE
AND SUPPORT OF THEIR CHARTER
AUTHORIZING AN OVERSIGHT WORK.
FEW CHARTER AUTHORIZES HAVE
STAFF THAT IS SOLELY FOCUSED ON
CHARTER SCHOOL AUTHORIZING AN
OVERSIGHT AND MOST AUTHOR RAZORS
ARE SO SMALL THEY DO NOT HAVE
ANY DEDICATED. STAFF TO HANDLE
THESE MATTERS.
SO THIS DOES NOT BENEFIT
CHARTERS NOR DOES IT.
BENEFIT THE AUTHORIZES SURE
DOES NOT EXIST.
THESE AUTHORIZES HAVE RELIED ON
THE ASSISTANCE OF CARS IN IT FOR
THE PAST THREE YEARS.
WELL THE PROGRAM IS FUNDED BY A
FEDERAL GRAND THAT IS NOW
EXPIRED. THE FEDERAL GRANT
FUNDING EXPIRES THIS YEAR AND
WITHOUT STATE RESOURCES CARS
THAT WILL BE LOST AND AUTHORIZES
WILL NOT HAVE A RESOURCE FOR
BEST PRACTICES FOR AUTHORIZING
OVERSIGHT OF CHARTER SCHOOLS
ANSWERING AYE VOTE.
PAYMENTS O'DONNELL SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. I'M
VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE
MR DAHMER'S CALL.
MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM TO FORTY
THREE AB THIRTY ONE SEVENTY SIX
BY MISS WALDRON.
CORPORATE.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTY ONE SEVENTY
SIX BY SOME WOMEN WALDRON
ANOTHER PERSON ACCOLADE TO
INDIAN CHILDREN.
MS WALTERS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB THIRTY ONE SEVENTY
SIX. A MEASURE THAT CHANGES
CALIFORNIA LAW TO COMPLY WITH
THE FEDERAL BUREAU OF INDIAN
AFFAIRS TWENTY SIXTEEN INDIAN
CHILD WELFARE ACT REGULATIONS.
THE INDIAN CHILD WELFARE ACT
KNOWN AS ECWA. WAS ENACTED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT.
WELL GREAT PROGRESS HAS BEEN
MADE HIM PROTECTING NATIVE
AMERICAN CHILDREN.
FROM WHOLESALE SEPARATION FROM
THEIR FAMILIES MORE WORK NEEDS
TO BE DONE. AS A RESULT THE
BUREAU OF INDIAN AFFAIRS
CREATIVE REGULATIONS O ENSURE
THAT ALL INDIAN CHILDREN. ARE
RECEIVING THE SAME PROTECTIONS
ACROSS THE NATION.
AB THIRTY ONE SEVENTY SIX SIMPLY
SEEKS TO CHANGE CALIFORNIA LAW
TO COMPLY WITH EXISTING FEDERAL
REGULATIONS.
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM QUICK LOOK THE ROLE. ON
MEMBERS FOR.
THESE ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERICAL GREAT.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLLER ITALIAN BUT I
SIXTY ONE DOES ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE BACK
IN THE FILE.
TO TAKE UP A COUPLE MISTER BONTA
THOSE ITEMS.
BONTA I THINK WE'LL BEGIN WITH
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY TO. WE MAY
AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY FIVE.
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
FIVE BY SOME THE RIVER BONTA
ACCOLADE <c.green> PARDONS.</c>
MISTER BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
FIVE WOOD. DEPOLITICIZE AND
INCREASE THE TRANSPARENCY IN THE
PARDON AND COMMUTATION PROCESS
IN CALIFORNIA INDIVIDUALS WHO
WERE CONVICTED OF A CRIME. MAY
APPLY FOR A PARDON OR
COMMUTATION IF THEY HAVE
DEMONSTRATED EXEMPLARY BEHAVIOR.
ALTHOUGH THOSE CONVICTED OF
CRIMES MAY SPEND YEARS
REHABILITATING THEMSELVES INTO
PRODUCTIVE LA ABIDING RESIDENTS
IMMIGRANTS ARE FACED WITH THE
RISK OF BEING SENT TO COUNTRIES
WHERE THEY HAVE FEW OR NO TIES.
CURRENTLY THERE IS A LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY IN THE PARDON
PROCESS INDIVIDUALS WHO APPLY
FOR PARDONS DO NOT KNOW IF THE
REQUEST WAS RECEIVED IF IT IS
BEING REVIEWED. AND IF OR WHEN A
DECISION WILL BE MADE.
SINCE THAT SO CALLED TOUGH ON
CRIME POLICIES WERE ENACTED IN
NINETEEN IN THE NINETEEN
NINETIES CALIFORNIA GOVERNORS
HAVE GRANTED VERY FEW PARDONS.
FUTURE GOVERNORS MAY NOT BE AS
WILLING TO GRANT PARDONS
ESPECIALLY IN THEIR FIRST TERM
AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY FIVE AND
CREATE A PANEL TO PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE GOVERNOR.
ON PARDON AND COMPUTATION
REQUESTS.
IT WOULD ESTABLISH A TIMELINE
FOR RECOMMENDATIONS
INCLUDING AN EXPEDITED PROCESS
FOR URGENT PARDON REQUESTS SUCH
AS THOSE WITH PENDING
DEPORTATION ORDERS.
THE PANEL WOULD ALSO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY BUT BY PROVIDING
NOTIFICATIONS TO APPLICANTS WHEN
THEY RECEIVE THE APPLICATION
BEGIN THE INVESTIGATION AND
ISSUE A RECOMMENDATION. WITH A
BETWEEN EIGHT FORTY FIVE.
WILL HAVE INCREASED ACCESS AND
TRANSPARENCY IN THE PARDON
PROCESS THAT HAS A STRONG
COALITION OF TWENTY PLUS
SUPPORTERS AND IT HAS NO
OPPOSITION COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THINGS BONTA SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
LOCAL OF THE ROLE. MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE
MISTER BONTA MOVES TO CALL.
MEMBERS WERE NOW GOING TO MOVE
TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM ONE NINE
SEVEN ONE NINETY SEVEN THIS IS
AB TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN BY MISTER
BONTA.
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THIRTY
SEVEN BY SOME THE RIVER BONTA AN
ACCOLADE HEALING ARTS.
MISTER BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY THIRTY
SEVEN WOULD AUTHORIZE A PHARMACY
TO PROVIDE PHARMACY SERVICES TO
PATIENTS OF SAFETY NET CLINICS.
THROUGH THE USE OF AN AUTOMATED
DRUG DELIVERY SYSTEM BRINGING
THE FULL SERVICES OF A LICENSED
PHARMACY ON SITE TO THE SAFETY
NET CLINIC IN THE FORM OF THE
AUTOMATED DRUG DELIVERY SYSTEM.
WOULD DRAMATICALLY INCREASE THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT PATIENTS WILL
RETRIEVE AND TAKE THEIR
PRESCRIPTION MEDICATIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THE RESPONDENTS SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL FOR THE ROLE. MEMBERS
FOR.
SARA TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE THE ROLE
TALENT OUT I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS BACK IN FILE ORDER.
WE A RAT FILE NUMBER TWO FORTY
FOUR THAT IS AB THIRTY TWO
HUNDRED BY MISTER KALRA.
KERKORIAN.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTY TWO HUNDRED
BY SOME WOMEN RECALL ANOTHER
SNACK RELATED PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES.
MISTER KALRA.
I THINK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS A.
B. THIRTY TWO.
PLUS I S. S. P. GRANTS.
A WHICH ARE THE SOLE SOURCE OF
INCOME FOR ONE POINT THREE
MILLION LOW INCOME SENIORS AND
PEOPLE THAT HE WOULD
DISABILITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
IT HELPS INDIVIDUALS PAY RENT
BUY FOOD PAPER UTILITIES
MEDICINE AND OTHER BASIC
NECESSITIES.
THE CURRENT SI S. B. GRANTS ARE
INADEQUATE FOR A PERSON TO LIVE
ON ESPECIALLY GIVEN CALIFORNIA'S
HIGH COST OF LIVING.
WITHOUT AN INCREASE IN THE S. B.
GRANTS IS INDIVIDUALS WAS
HOMELESSNESS AND BASS HUNGER
WHICH THESE TO POOR HEALTH.
BEFORE AS A SPEAK CUTS WERE
TAKEN IN TWO THOUSAND NINE THE
MAXIMUM GRANT WAS ONE HUNDRED
POINT SIX PERCENT OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL. TO DATE IS EIGHTY
NINE POINT ONE PERCENT
BECAUSE THERE'S NOT BEEN A
RESTORATION OF THE S. P. GRANT
WE'VE ALLOWED OVER ONE MILLION
ELDERLY. AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES IN CALIFORNIA TO
FALL BELOW THE POVERTY LEVEL.
UNLESS THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
ALL THIS BILL DOES NOT RAISE THE
GRANT AMOUNT TO THE POVERTY
LEVEL DOES REINSTATING THE
STATUTE THE ANNUAL COST OF
LIVING INCREASE. WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE I BO.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA THIS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I STAND AS A PROUD
JOINT AUTHORED AB THIRTY TWO
HUNDRED.
ACROSS OUR STATE CALIFORNIANS
ARE STRUGGLING.
HOUSING AND SECURITIES ARE
COMMON FOOD INSECURITY IS EVEN
MORE SO AND THE NUMBERS ARE ONLY
GROWING.
WITH CUTS TO S. A SIGN ESOS P.
ARE ELDERLY AND DISABLED
INDIVIDUALS ARE STRUGGLING THE
MOST.
DURING THE BUDGET HEARING WE
HEARD PERSON AFTER PERSON TELL
HEART WRENCHING STORIES FROM
MOTHERS WORRIED ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN THEY LEAVE BEHIND.
THEIR DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
CHILDREN TO THE ELDERLY WHO
AFTER YEARS OF HARD WORK FIND
MOST OF THEIR FOOD AT THE FOOD
BANK.
WE SIMPLY CANNOT LET THESE
PEOPLE STAND AT CONTINUE TO
STRUGGLE SO WELL BELOW THE
POVERTY LINE.
AB THIRTY TWO HUNDRED
REINSTATING THE COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT WILL POINT BLANK SAVE
LIVES IT IS FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
NAME IS REYES MISTER THURMOND
YOUR RECOMMENDS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
AB THREE TWO ZERO ZERO. I LIKE
THANK THE AUTHOR AND MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP
AND SUPPORT HERE.
.
LET'S INCREASE A COLA HERE LET'S
RECOGNIZE THAT. TOO OFTEN OUR
SENIORS AND PEOPLE LIVING WITH
DISABILITIES.
ARE FORCED TO MAKE A CHOICE
BETWEEN PAYING RENT.
THE WEATHER NOT DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY TO BUY FOOD.
AND WE KNOW THAT THE COST OF
LIVING THROUGHOUT OUR STATE. IS
GREAT BUT LET US SUPPORT OUR
SENIORS ARE IN CALIFORNIA'S THEM
WITH DISABILITIES AND ALLOW THEM
TO LIVE WITH DIGNITY. AND NOT
HAVE TO MAKE THE FALSE CHOICE
CHOOSING BETWEEN PAYING RENT AND
BUYING FOOD I URGE YOU AYE VOTE
FOR A B. THIRTY TWO HUNDRED.
THING WAS STARMAN SCENE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
WHO'S OUT OF A LONG MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THIS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE WRONG TYRONE
EYES FIFTY AYE SIXTY.
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE'VE DISPENSED WITH
FILE ITEM TO FORTY FIVE WE ARE
AT.
FILE ITEM TO FORTY SIX.
THAT IS AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
SEVEN BY DOCTOR WOULD CLERK WILL
READ. SOME PEOPLE TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY SEVEN BY SIMPLY RIVER
WOULD OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE. DOCTOR WHAT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
STATE TO NOT RENEW A MEDI CAL
MANAGED CARE CONTRACT OF FOR
PROFIT HEALTH PLANS THAT ENGAGE
IN ANTI COMPETITIVE COMP CONDUCT.
WORTH THEY ARE NOT SPENDING
ENOUGH ON PATIENT CARE COMPARED
WITH OVERHEAD AND ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS.
THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRES HEALTH
PLANS WITH PREVIOUSLY APPROVE
SERVICE AREAS TO NEGOTIATE WITH
COVER CALIFORNIA TO ENSURE THAT
COUNTIES HAVE MORE CHOICES AND
HEALTH PLAN OPTIONS.
FOR APPROXIMATELY ONE THIRD OF
THE ZIP CODES IN CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS ARE LIMITED TO ONE OR
TWO HEALTH PLANS IN THEIR REGION.
THE LESS COMPETITION OFTEN MEANS
HIGHER PRICES COMPETITIVE
MARKETPLACE IS HELP CONSUMERS BY
ENSURING FAIR PRICES FOR
SERVICES MORE CHOICE AND QUALITY
SERVICES I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
I BO.
THE THAT WOULD SEEM NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ADAM
CLERK OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WAS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TODD ABOUT.
I FORTY FOUR KNOWS TWENTY.
THAT MEASURE PASSES WERE FILE
ITEM TO FORTY SEVEN AB TWENTY
FOUR.
FORTY SEVEN BY MS RANTS THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FOUR FORTY SEVEN BY SOME
MEMORY AS AN ACCOLADE IN LAND
USE THIS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY I AM PROUD TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY SEVEN. A BILL
WHICH ENSURES THAT RESIDENTS OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE INPUT.
ON INDUSTRIAL LIKE LAND USES
BEING PROPOSED IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
THE CORE MESSAGE OF THIS BILL IS
SIMPLE CALIFORNIA SHOULD
PRIORITIZE BRING IN THE MOST
VULNERABLE GROUPS
IN THE STATE TO THE TABLE WHEN
MAKING LOCAL LAND USE DECISIONS.
MEMBERS THAT WE KNOW THAT AREAS
WITHIN OUR MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ARE NOT ONLY
POLLUTED BUT ALSO MAY STRUGGLE
TO BE ENGAGED IN THE TRADITIONAL
SEPA PROCESS. GIVEN BARRIERS IN
PLACE FOR PEOPLE OF LOW INCOME.
THIS BILL REPRESENTS A STEP TO
ENSURE THAT IT WOULD CAN BE A
FEW CONFUSING PROCESS THE VOICES
OF ALL COMMUNITIES ARE HEARD.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO BE CLEAR THAT
AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY SEVEN IS
SIMPLY A NOTICE BILL. THIS
LEGISLATION DOES NOT REALLOCATE
RESOURCES TO CERTAIN REGIONS BUT
RATHER CREATES MEANINGFUL ALL
REACH REQUIREMENTS WITHIN THE
EXISTING SUPER PROCESS.
I'M ALSO PROUD TO SHARE THAT I
HAVE ALSO WORKED EXTENSIVELY
WITH THE COALITION OF OPPOSITION
GROUPS INCLUDING CAL CHAMBER.
WISPA CBI A AND THROUGH THE
NEGOTIATIONS HAVE MOVE THEM TO
NEUTRAL. ON THIS BILL.
MEMBERS AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
SEVEN WILL ENSURE THE CRITICAL
STEPS
ARE TAKEN THROUGH CITICORP.
THROUGH THE SEQUEL PROCESS TO
TRULY ENGAGE COMMUNITIES WHICH
CURRENTLY SHOULDER THE UNDUE
BURDEN TO POLLUTION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
NAME IS REYES.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM.
CLERK OF THE ROLE. ON MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE TIE A
VOTE. EYES FORTY ONE KNOWS
TWENTY FOUR THAT MEASURE BROWN.
MEMBERS WHEN PASS TEMPORARILY
AND FILE ITEM TO FORTY EIGHT
WE'VE DISPENSED WITH.
FALLOUT TWO FOUR NINE.
WILL MOVE TO TAKE UP.
MISTER FLORES FILE ITEM TO FIFTY
AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY ONE.
CORPOREAL.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
ONE BY SO MEMBER FLOOR ANOTHER
PERSON ACRYLATE A CRIMINAL
HISTORY INFORMATION. MISTER
FLORA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY ONE.
WHICH WOULD FULFILL THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ST OUT OF
REQUIRED APARTMENT JUST TO BY
SUBSEQUENT SUBSEQUENT CRIMINAL
HISTORY FOR DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES MEDICALBOARD. THE ALSO
OSTEOPATHIC MEDICAL BOARD FOR
EMPLOYMENT LICENSING AND
CERTIFICATION APPROVING CARE
GIVERS.
AB TWENTY FOUR SIX ONE STILL
THROUGHOUT THE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN STATE OUT OF THE DSS
WHICH DISCOVER THE DSS. AND
OTHER AUTHORIZED ENTITIES WERE
NOT RECEIVING CRITICAL
SUBSEQUENT BACKGROUND CHECK
INFORMATION FROM THE DOJ.
AB TWENTY FOUR SIX ONE WILL MAKE
CERTAIN THAT THE DSS.
AND OTHER AND TIED ENTITIES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT RELY ON THIS
INFORMATION ARE AWARE OF ALL
CRITICAL CRIMINAL.
HISTORY.
RESPECT LAST RIVAL.
NAMES FLORA SEEN NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
CAR CLUB NARAL.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE ANTI VOTE I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
*.
MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM TO FIFTY
ONE AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY BY
MISTER GRAYSON CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY BY SOME REMEMBER GRAYSON
ANOTHER PERSON ACCOLADE TOO
INVASIVE SPECIES
MISTER GRAYSON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT TO YOU
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY.
AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY WILL
FORMALLY ESTABLISHED A
CALIFORNIA INVASIVE SPECIES
COUNCIL AND NBC SPECIES ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. IN ORDER TO ENGAGE IN
DETECTION PREVENTION AND
ERADICATION OF ECONOMICALLY AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY HARMFUL INVASIVE
SPECIES IN CALIFORNIA.
IT GENERATED THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
STAKEHOLDERS CAME TOGETHER FOR
THE INVASION SPEECHES SUMMIT. IT
WAS A COLLABORATIVE.
EVENT AIMED AT REFINING THE
STATE'S APPROACH TO INVASIVE
SPECIES OF CONTROL AND MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR FURTHER
ACTION.
AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY WILL
IMPLEMENT THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THE SUMMIT.
INVASIVE SPECIES DO NOT STOP AT
PROPERTY LINES RECOGNIZE
POLITICAL BOUNDARIES OR
ACKNOWLEDGE INTER AGENCY LINES
OF AUTHORITY COORDINATION IS
THEREFORE ESSENTIAL FOR A
SUCCESSFUL RESPONSE AB TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTY. WILL GIVE
CALIFORNIA AN EFFECTIVE PLATFORM
TO FIGHT AND SPREAD OUT THE
SPREAD OF INVASIVE SPECIES AND
SAFEGUARD OUR UNIQUE
ENVIRONMENTAL HERITAGE THIS BILL
HAS PASSED WITHOUT. WITH.
.
NO VOTES I WITH NO NO VOTES AND
IT ENJOYS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
I WAS A TONGUE TWISTER IT'S BEEN
A LONG DAY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
NAME IS GRAYSON.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT JUST HAPPENED
THERE BUT.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION.
TALK ABOUT THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE RUNS HIGH THAT I SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WHERE FILE ITEM TO FIFTY
TWO AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY FOUR
BY DR QUIRK.
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY FOUR BY
SOME A MEMBER QUIRK AN ACCOLADE
A HAZARDOUS WASTE.
DOCTOR QUIRK. THANK YOU SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY FOUR
AUTHORIZES THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCE CONTROL.
TO EVALUATE AND ADOPT A HUMANE
ALTERNATIVE TO THE CUTE.
OUR AQUATIC TOXICITY TESTS FOR
HAZARDOUS WASTE IDENTIFICATION.
SOME COMPANIES THAT OUR
COMMUNITY THAT ARE COMMITTED TO
CRUELTY FREE PRACTICES CHOOSE
NOT TO USE THE CURRENT TEST.
SO THERE ITEM MUST BE TREATED AS
HAZARDOUS WASTE.
AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY FOUR BIT
PROVIDES A PATH.
TO A HUMANE AND OPTIONAL
ALTERNATIVE
THE CURRENT TESTING AS A RESULT
LEADS TO MORE ACCURATE HAZARDOUS
WASTE DETERMINATION.
THIS SUPPORTED BY SOCIAL
COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION.
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE.
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS COUNCIL
THE U. MAIN SOCIETY.
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION AND IT
HAS HAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I ASK
THE ARRIVAL OF.
THEY GOT QUIRK SEEING THEIR
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
EQUIPMENT ROLL-ON MEMBERS FOR.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE TO THEIR VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL CALL VOTE
I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
FOLLOWING TWO FIFTY THREE IS AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN BY
MISS RUBIO CORPORATION ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN
BY SOME MEMBER RUBIO ANOTHER
PERSON THAT RELATE TO STUDENT
SUPPORT SERVICES.
THIS RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'M
PRESENTING AB TWENTY FOR SEVENTY
SEVEN THAT WILL DESIGNATE A
DREAM RESOURCE LIAISON THAT
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES.
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT EACH YEAR
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
RIGHT GRADUATE FROM CALIFORNIA
HIGH SCHOOLS HOWEVER BECAUSE OF
THE COMPLEXITY IMMIGRATION HIGH
SCHOOLS.
AND COLLEGE PERSONNEL FREQUENTLY
MISGUIDED STUDENTS ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITIES AVAILABLE
RESULTING IN SIGNIFICANT DELAYS
IN THEIR EDUCATIONAL JOURNEY.
TODAY THERE ARE EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS SERVE THE MOST
DIVERSE GROUP OF IMMIGRANT YOUTH.
THAT HAVE VERY DIFFERENT AND
UNIQUE IMMIGRATION BACKGROUNDS
DUE TO THE RESCINDING OF THE
DHAKA AND GPS PROGRAMS.
AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN
ENSURES THAT STUDENTS ARE ABLE
TO TURN TO A TRUSTED SOURCE ON
THE CAMPUS TO RECEIVE ACCURATE
INFORMATION ABOUT OPPORTUNITIES.
AND RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO THEM.
I AM PROUD TO SAY THAT I WAS
BORN IN MEXICO AND CAME TO THE
UNITED STATES. FOR A BETTER
OPPORTUNITY
I KNOW I KNOW FIRST HAND THE
STRUGGLES OF BEING A FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENT AND
TRYING TO NAVIGATE.
COLLEGE ON MY OWN AND THE
OBSTACLES THAT I WOULD SOMETIMES
FACE AS AN IMMIGRANT YOU.
I ASK THE JOIN ME IN EQUIPPING
OUR COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
WITH THE PROPER TOOLS TO BETTER
SERVE THIS UNIQUE STUDENT
POPULATION.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE.
THEY WAS RUBIO SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CARP LOCAL
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY VOTE
EYES FORTY EIGHT KNOWS FOURTEEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM.
TWO FIFTY FOR IS AB TWENTY FIVE
OH FOR BY MR LOW.
THERE FOR FREE ASSUME IT'LL
TWENTY FIVE ALL FOR BY SLIMMER
BELOW AND ACT LIKE A PEACE
OFFICER TRAINING. MR LOW. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THIS IS LGBT AT
DIVERSITY TRAINING FOR MEMBERS
OF POSTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE.
MISTER GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS SPEAKER
MEMBERS AS A FORMER POLICE
OFFICER I THINK IS A GREAT DEAL
I THINK. BECAUSE THEY ARE THE WE
LIVE IN RIGHT NOW THAT WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT UP PLEASE
OFFICES HAVE AS MUCH TRAINING AS
POSSIBLE TO DO ADDRESS. ON THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE THAT EXISTS
RIGHT NOW SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
AN AYE VOTE ON IT TWENTY FIVE
BEFORE I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRING IT FORWARD.
THINGS GIPSON MISTER COOPER I
WAS FOR THE BILL BUT THE BIGGEST
ISSUE REALLY IS POST SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN.
THERE BUDGET HAS DROPPED BY FOR
ALMOST SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS.
AND WITH THE DECLINE IN PENALTY
FEES.
THERE BUDGETS DROPPED BY FORTY
TWO PERCENT AS WITH THE BIGGEST
WE KEEP PUSHING MORE MANDATES ON.
SO RIGHT NOW OBVIOUSLY WITH IT
WITH THE SHOOTINGS AND.
LAW ENFORCEMENT ISSUES
SO WHAT POSES DONE ABLE MAY
FUNDING FOR ACTIVE SHOOTER
RESPONSE TRAINING CULTURAL
DIVERSITY. CRISIS INTERVENTION
USE OF FORCE.
LESS LETHAL WEAPONS CROWD
MANAGEMENT.
THE BILL ME DISABLED MILLIE ILL
ALSO RESOURCES.
MENTAL ILLNESS AWARENESS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HOSTAGE
NEGOTIATIONS
AN OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTINGS.
LEVELS OF POSTED TYPICALLY
REIMBURSE AGENCIES
SO WHEN SOMEONE'S IN TRAINING
THEIR BLOOD BACK FILL THOSE
OFFICERS
SO RIGHT NOW NOT ABLE BACKFILL
OFFICER SO. AUTHORS GO THROUGH
TRAINING EVERY TWO YEARS
TWENTY FOUR HOURS IT'S
PERISHABLE SKILLS THOUGH
SHOOTING DRIVING THINGS LIKE
THAT SO. IT'S IT'S MIND BOGGLING
HOW WE KEEP CUTTING THEM.
DRAMATICALLY AND YET WE EXPECT
AND DO MORE SO YOU WONDER WHY
TRAINED AS A HAPPEN.
BECAUSE THIS.
TO GO FROM YOU KNOW A BUDGET OF.
SEVEN AWAIT SIXTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS.
FOR THIS YEAR FOR THE MAY REVISE.
FORTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS.
CUT.
EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS SO
BASICALLY YOUR SKIN.
BASIC TRAINING
SO THE LIST THAT YOU NEED TO
STEP UP AND DO MORE WITH OF THE
START MR LOW SO THANK YOU BUT WE
NEED MORE DONE.
IF YOU ARE AUTHORS TRAIN
PROPERLY IN IRAQ MAYBE NOT HAVE
SOME OF THE SHOOTINGS HERE. BAD
INCIDENTS HAPPEN BUT RIGHT NOW
THE FUNDING IS HORRIFIC.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MISTER LOW YOU MAY
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FEDERAL.
CLICK LIBERAL. MEMBERS FOR.
DESIRED OF THOUGH ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS THERE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TOWN ABOUT AYE AYES
FORTY NINE THOSE NINETEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TO
PRETTY FIVE IS AB TWENTY FIVE OF
FIVE BY MISTER SANTIAGO CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE OH FIVE BY SOME MEMBER WAS
SANTIAGO AN ACCOLADE TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
MISTER SANTIAGO.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AB TWENTY FIVE
A FIVE WILL LAST THE CSU REPORT
OF LEGISLATURE ON ITS BUDGET AND
PRACTICES SPECIFIC TO IT
SPENDING A STATE FUNDS.
AB TWENTY FIVE A FIVE WOULD
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY IN THE
SPENDING OF STATE FUNDING AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY AT
THIS AT THE SYSTEM LEVEL BY EACH
CAMPUS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOOK.
AMOS SANTIAGO SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
WHO IS THERE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLES HOW THE VOTE AYE
SIXTY ONE.
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TWO FIFTY SIX IS AB
TWENTY FIVE OH SEVEN. CORPOREAL
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE OH
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES
SAWYER ACT LIKE THE COUNTY JAILS.
MISTER JONES SAWYER. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB TWENTY FIVE OH
SEVEN WOULD DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT A BREAST FEEDING
PROGRAM IN COUNTY JAILS FOR
NURSING MOTHERS.
BREAST FEEDING OR PROVIDING
BREAST MILK TO INFANTS IS
STRONGLY SUPPORTED BY EVERY
HEALTH ORGANIZATION AS
BENEFICIAL TO BOTH THE MOTHER
AND HER CHILD FOR CONTAINING
ANTIBODIES TO PROTECT INFANTS
FROM VIRUSES AND ILLICIT
ILLNESSES. EFFORTS STRENGTHENING
THE MOTHER TO CHILD BOND.
SPIKE THE VAST HEALTH BENEFITS
MOST NURSING INMATES ARE UNABLE
TO BREASTFEED OR PROVIDE
BREASTMILK TO THEIR CHILDREN
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF PROGRAMS
AND EQUIPMENT. AB TWENTY FIVE OH
SEVEN WILL ENSURE THAT ALL
MOTHERS EXERCISED THEIR BREAST
FEEDING RIGHT WHETHER THEY ARE
BEING HELD AT THE STATE OR
COUNTY LEVEL. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES MEMBERS
ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO THEM MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TWO FIFTY SEVEN.
IS AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY FOUR BY
MISS AMONG CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
FOUR BY SOME WOMEN REALLY MOMENT
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO PARKS
MISLIM ON.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY FOUR
ESTABLISHES THE OUTDOOR EQUITY
GRANT FUNDING PROGRAM.
DEPARTMENT OF.
PARKS AND RECREATION'S IN ORDER
TO INCREASE THE ABILITY OF THE
UNDERSERVED AND AT RISK
POPULATIONS TO PARTICIPATE IN
OUTDOOR ENVIRONMENTAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS.
IT IS THE GOAL OF THE STATE THAT
ALL THE PEOPLE INCLUDING THOSE
THAT HAVE HISTORICALLY NOT
BENEFIT FROM THESE EXPERIENCES
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
VIGOROUS WOMAN SEEING THEIR
DISCUSSION DEBATE CARP WELCOME
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
WHAT IS THERE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO GO?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSER ROWLAND HIGH
VOTE EYES FORTY EIGHT KNOWS
THIRTEEN THAT. MEASURE PASSES
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM TWO
FIFTY EIGHT.
FILE ITEM TO FIFTY NINE IS AB
TWENTY FIVE.
THIRTY EIGHT BY MS RUBIO.
THE CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FIVE THIRTY EIGHT BY
SIMPLY MEMBER RUBIO ACTUALLY THE
WATER QUALITY.
MISS RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS HIGH RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT WHICH CALLS ON THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
TO DEVELOP FINANCIAL CAPABILITY
ASSESSMENT GUIDELINES
TO BETTER ASSIST LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WHEN DEVELOPING
STORM WATER PERMITS.
CURRENT LAW.
PORTER COLOGNE WATER QUALITY ACT.
PROHIBITS THE THIS CHARGE OF
POLLUTION TO SURFACE WATER
UNLESS THE DISCHARGE.
OBTAINED A PERMIT FROM THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD.
AND AS FOR STORM WATER PERMITS
ARE CRITICAL FOR PROTECTING
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND THE
ENVIRONMENT BUT THEY CAN ALSO
CREATE COSTLY CHALLENGES TO
IMPLEMENT.
ALTHOUGH CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE
DEVELOPING STORM WATER POLLUTION
SCHEDULES MANY REMAIN IN NEED OF
GUIDANCE AND TECHNICAL EXPERTISE
IN ORDER TO DEVELOP ADEQUATE
CONSISTENT AND COST INFORMED
PERMITS.
AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY EIGHT WILL
PROVIDE THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD WITH AN
ADDITIONAL TOOL TO ASSESS THE
COSTS THAT CITIES INCUR. AND ARE
LIKELY TO INCUR WITH STORM WATER
PERMITS.
THIS BILL RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT A POLICY COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
NAME IS RUBIO.
SEEM NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE FOR
GLOBAL THE ROLL-ON
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
A DESIRE TO VOTE ALL OVER
SWEATER DESIRABLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO SARAH TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE THE ROLL TIDE
OUT I SIX YOU KNOW ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM TO SIXTY
AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY FIVE AYE MR
GALLAGHER THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE FORTY
FIVE BY SOME REMEMBER GALLAGHER
ACRYLATE OFFICIAL WILDLIFE.
THE* OUT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY FIVE WILL
STREAMLINE THIS LAKE AND STREAM
THAT ALTERATION AGREEMENT
PROGRAM BY REQUIRING THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
TO ADOPT GENERAL AGREEMENT.
FOR CERTAIN ACTIVITIES THAT FALL
UNDER THE PROGRAM. THIS WILL
ENSURE AN EFFECTIVE PROGRAM
WHILE GIVING MORE OPTIONS TO
APPLICANTS.
I'M COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS BILL. THE
OPPOSITION LISTEN IN THE
ANALYSIS HAS GONE NEUTRAL WITH
THE RECENT AMENDMENTS OUT OF
APPROPRIATIONS IN CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE.
THAT WE WILL TAKE IN THE SENATE
I THINK YOU AND I ASKED HER
ABOUT.
NAMES GALLAGHER SEEN NO
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM CLERK
LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
IS OUR TO VOTE ON MEMBERS WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE TYPE OF ON ICE FIFTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM TO SIXTY ONE
IS AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY ONE
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
ONE BY SOME WEAVERVILLE WOULD
ANOTHER SNACK LABOR FORCE YOU IN
FIRE PREVENTION.
DOCTOR WAIT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS HAVE MADE IT
CLEAR THAT OUR HISTORIC APPROACH
TO FIRE IS INADEQUATE. THE WORLD
IS GETTING WARMER CALIFORNIA'S
FACING LONGER AND DRYER DROUGHTS
AND EVERY YEAR MORE TREES AND
VEGETATION ARE DYING CREATING
MORE AND MORE FUEL.
ACOSTA FIGHTING THESE FIRES IS
ASTOUNDING WE SPENT MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
OUT OF. OUR EMERGENCY FUND IN
FIVE OF THE LAST SIX YEARS
BITING CATASTROPHIC FIRES. OVER
TWO BILLION IN THE LAST THREE
YEARS ENOUGH ALONE.
THE NORTH BAY FIRES IN MY
DISTRICT WITH THE MOST EXPENSIVE
IN MODERN HISTORY.
JUST OVER JUST OVER SIXTY DAYS
LATER THE THOMAS FIRE AGAIN
FUELED BY HIGH WINDS AND BADLY
NEGLECTED WILDLANDS BECAME THE
LARGEST FIRE IN OUR STATE'S
HISTORY.
LET'S MAKE THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN PARTIES IN THE FINAL
WAKEUP CALL. AB TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY ONE AS PART OF THE
SOLUTION.
THE BILL CREATES A JOINT BURNER
PROGRAM WITH CAL FIRE TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO
COLLABORATE WITH PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS. ON PROACTIVE FIRES
IT PROVIDES LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES TO CAL FIRE FOR THE
FOREST HEALTH PROGRAM. IT DRIES
INVESTMENT INTERNATIONAL WORKING
LANCE.
THE BILL HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU KNOW IT WOULDN'T SEEM
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK OPEN ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
THE SENATE VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE?
CLARK WILL. CLOSE AROUND HOWEVER
I SIXTY FIVE.
NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES
FALLEN TO SIXTY TWO.
IS AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY FIVE
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
FIVE BY SOME WOULD MEMBER DAVID
CHIU AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE OF MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION ARE FOR.
CHIU. I MISTER SPEAKER COLLINS
AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY FIVE WILL
IMPROVE AFFORDABILITY FOR LOW TO
MODERATE INCOME CONSUMERS.
PURCHASING INSURANCE THROUGH
COVERED CALIFORNIA.
WHILE THE ACA MADE GREAT STRIDES
TO HELP CONSUMERS AFFORD HEALTH
COVERAGE MUCH MORE NEEDS TO BE
DONE ESPECIALLY IN OUR HIGH COST
STATE.
EVEN WITH AVAILABLE SUBSIDIES
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS UNDER FOUR HUNDRED
PERCENT OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL REMAIN UNINSURED BECAUSE
HEALTH CARE STILL TOO EXPENSIVE
FOR EXAMPLE. A PERSON MAKES
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH
TYPICALLY SPENDS TEN PERCENT OF
HER INCOME ON PREMIUMS.
IMPROVING AFFORDABILITY WILL
INCREASE COVERAGE AND REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF UNINSURED THIS BILL
WILL CAP WHAT PEOPLE PAY ACROSS
THE INCOME SCALE. SO THAT COVER
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS WILL PAY NO
MORE THAN EIGHT PERCENT OF THEIR
INCOME ON THEIR MONTHLY PREMIUMS
FOR FOLKS MAKING FOUR HUNDRED
PERCENT OR BELOW THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL. THIS WILL ENSURE
THE PEOPLE OF ENOUGH ASSISTANCE
TO FOR COVERAGE INSTEAD OF
OPTING OUT OF COVERAGE AND BEING
UNINSURED APPRECIATE THE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THE FAMOUS JUICY NO DISCUSSION
BATES. CLARK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
WE'RE SORRY ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
PARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF IT AS FIFTY
KNOWS FOURTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM TO SIXTY THREE IS AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY EIGHT BY MS
REYES CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
EIGHT BY SOME REVERBERATE AS AN
ACCOLADE THE JAILS.
MS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER NUMBERS
TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU A. B..
TWO FIVE SIX EIGHT WHICH SIMPLY
REQUIRES LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO INQUIRE ABOUT VETERAN STATUS
WHEN A VETERAN HAS BEEN ARRESTED.
IN ORDER TO CONNECT VETERANS
WITH VETERAN TREATMENT COURTS
EARLIER IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
PROCESS.
MANY OF OUR VETERANS AND UP IN
OUR COURT SYSTEM AND STUDIES
REPORT THAT THEY SUFFER FROM A
HIGHER RATE OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DISORDERS.
IN PARTICULAR THE STUDIES ALSO
SHOW THAT INCARCERATED VETERANS
HAVE A HISTORY OF POSTTRAUMATIC
STRESS DISORDER THAT IS DOUBLE
THAT OF CIVILIAN INMATES.
HAVING THIS INFORMATION SOONER
WILL ENABLE COUNCIL TO MAKE IT
EARLIER DETERMINATION ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF VETERAN TREATMENT
COURTS AND WILL ENABLE VETERANS
WHO NEED THEM.
TO BE SEEN BY JUDGES THAT HAVE
PROPER TRAINING. AND CAN BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE ISSUES OF
VETERANS MAY BE DEALING WITH.
THIS BILL ENABLES OUR VETERANS
TO ACCESS PRE TRIAL DIVERSION
PROGRAMS AND GET TREATMENT
EARLIER TO GET THEM BACK ON
THEIR FEET WITH ON THE HONOR
THEY DESERVE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTES.
THEY WAS RENTS.
SEEING NO DISCLOSURE MADE ON THE
ITEM CORP OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
USER TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY VOTE I
SEVENTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS THIS WILL BE THE LAST
ITEM IN FILE ORDER THAT WE TAKE.
FILE ITEM TO SIXTY FOUR AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT BY
MISTER KANSEN
CHIU.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME WE WILL TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KANSEN
CHU AN ACT RELATING TO
MANUFACTURE HOUSING.
MISTER CHIP. SECTOR MISTER
SPEAKER AB PLUNDER FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHT WILL IMPROVE FIRE SAFETY
IN OUR STATES MOBILE HOMES AND
MANUFACTURED HOME COMMUNITY.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL WOULD
IMPROVE THE FIRE NOTIFICATION
AND THAT DISASTER PREPAREDNESS.
FIRST A BILL WILL OBEY STANDARD
TO ENSURE A MOBILE HOME ARE
EQUIPPED WAS STILL LATEST.
TEN YEAR LIFE BATHORY SMOKE
DETECTOR DAD MEET CERTAIN THE
LATEST US STATE FIRE MARSHALL'S
THE STANDARD SECONDLY THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE. THEDISK STATE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
TO TRANSLATE THE HERB PARTS
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS PLAN AND
SAFETY INFORMATION M. BE
AVAILABLE INTO MEDI CAL
THRESHOLD LANGUAGES.
A POUND DAY.
THE RESIDENTS REQUEST.
THIS BILL WAS. THE POTENTIALLY
WAS SAFE LIVE AND WE HAVE LOST
SO MANY LIVE N THIS.
MOBILE HOME PARK.
BECAUSE OF THE STRUCTURE OF TO
THE THE BUILDING AND THE LAY ALL
OF JUST PARKS.
IN O. WILL ASK RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
I THINK IT WAS CHIU SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLICK CLUB THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY VOTE EYES
FORTY SIX KNOWS NINETEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE
HAVE FIVE ITEMS ON CALLED.
I'M PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY THREE THIS IS AB
THIRTY TEN. BY LAW AMONG THE
CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WISH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOUGH.
WISH TO VOTE.
HARTWELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY
ONE KNOWS TWENTY SIX.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL ON MISTER BERMAN'S FILE
ITEM ONE TWENTY NINE THAT'S AB
TWENTY NINE NO EIGHT.
PURPLE POSTS. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHICH TO VOTE.
WELL MEMBERS VOTER WHICH TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE ICE FORTY FOUR KNOWS TWENTY
EIGHT THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY A. B. THIRTY
ONE TWENTY NINE.
LET'S LIFT THE CALL.
PURPLE POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO WISH TO VOTE?
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE ANTI ABOUT ICE FORTY
FIVE KNOWS THIRTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS AND PREPARE TO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY TWO.
THIS IS AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
FIVE BY MISTER BONTA.
CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WISH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WHICH TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER WRONG TIED ABOUT EYES
FORTY FOUR KNOWS TWENTY EIGHT
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
LAST ITEM ON HER TO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM TO FORTY TO AB
THIRTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN BY MISTER
O'DONNELL THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THESE ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK. WILL.
CLOSER AND SALAS ABOUT ICE FORTY
SEVEN THAT KNOWS TWENTY TWO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES MOVING TO
CONSENT CALENDAR DOES ANY MEMBER
WISH TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
THIRTY ONE BY SENATOR NEWMAN
RELATIVE TO COUNSEL APPRECIATION
DAY.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
MEMBERS.
THIS IS CONSENT ALL MEMBERS.
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
THIS IS CONSENT CALENDAR.
CLERK WELL CLOSER ROME TIE ABOUT
I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO.
CLERK WILL READ THE REMAINING
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
THIRTY SIX I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO
AND SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FORTY ONE I SEVENTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO.
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS THURSDAY MAY THIRTY
FIRST FLOOR SESSION AT TEN AM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WE
PASS RETAIN A MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
I WON'T BE ENTERTAINING A MOTION
TO ADJOURN JUST YET
I AM READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN. MISTER FRAZIER MOVES
AND MISS OUR DALLY SECONDS. AT
THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY MAY THIRTY FIRST
AT TEN AM IN THE QUORUM CALLS
LIFTED
.
VOTE CHANGE.
MULLIN.
AB NINETEEN TWELVE.
I TO KNOW.
VOTE CHANGE MULLIN ASSEMBLY GO
NINETEEN TWELVE I TO KNOW.
STEINORTH NINETEEN NINETY TWO I
DUNNO.
STEINORTH SO WE WILL NINETEEN
NINETY TWO I'D TO KNOW.
TING AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY NINE
I TO NOT VOTER.
TING ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY NINE I TO NOT VOTING.
.
FONG AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY ONE
ITEM NO.
FONG ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY ONE I TO KNOW.
WALDRON. AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY A
NO TIME.
WALDRON ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX
TWENTY EIGHT NO TO AYE.
WALDRON A.B. NINETEEN NINETY
TWO. I TO KNOW.
WALDRON ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN
NINETY TWO I'D TO KNOW.
HOLDEN AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY
NINE ITEM NO.
HOLDEN ASSEMBLY RULE TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY NINE I TO KNOW.
LEVINE A. B. NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE I TO KNOW.
LEVINE SOME AGO NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE I'D TO KNOW.
GLORIA AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY FIVE
FROM I TO NOT VOTING.
GLORIA SO WE BILL TWENTY FIVE
FORTY FIVE I TO NOT VOTING.
BIGELOW FILE TWO HUNDRED AB
TWENTY FIFTY NO TO AYE.
BIGELOW SO WE TWENTY FIFTY NOTES
I.
BIGELOW. FILED TO FORTY TWO A.
B. THIRTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN NOTED
NOT VOTING.
BIGELOW ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY ONE
SIXTY SEVEN NO TO NOT VOTING.
CHEN.
A. B. NINETEEN NINETY TWO.
FROM I AM TO KNOW.
CHAIRMAN SO WE WILL NINETEEN
NINETY TWO I'D TO KNOW.
THAT WE BUILD TWENTY TWO
SEVENTEEN FROM AYE TO NON VOTING.
CHEN ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN
SEVENTEEN I TO NOT LOADING.
AND CHEN. SO WE BUILT WE NINE
SIXTY THREE FOR ITEM NO.
CHEN ASSEMBLY RULE THIRTY NINE
SIXTY THREE I TO KNOW THAT
TWENTY NINE SIXTY THREE.
CORRECTION CHEN ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE SIXTY THREE I'D TO
KNOW.
QUIRK SILVA AB TWO NINE SIX FIVE
I TO NOT VOTING.
QUIRK SILVA ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINE SIXTY FIVE I TO NOT VOTING.
STEVEN CHOI ITEM NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY A TYPE A ME IN NINETEEN
NINETY TWO. YES TO NOT VOTED.
CHOI ASSEMBLY GOING NINETEEN
NINETY TWO I TO NOT VOTING.
BONTA AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY ONE
NO TO AYE.
BONTA ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY ONE NO TO AYE
HARPER FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY. AYE TO NOT
VOTING.
HARPER ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE
FORTY I'VE TO NOT VOTING